THE TWENTY NINETEEN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ON THE BUDGET.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO ONCE AGAIN
DOING SOME OF THAT CENTER
NIELSEN SAYS THE MOST IMPORTANT
WORK.
THAT COMES BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE TO AGREE WITH
HIM -- AND WORK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS COME WILL COMPLETE
AGAIN ON DEALS WITH THE UPCOMING
FISCAL YEAR WHICH BEGINS JULY.
ONE AS YOU ALL ARE WELL AWARE
PAINFULLY AWARE AS WE ARE WE
HAVE A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME TO
COMPLETE THIS WORK.
IDEALLY WE'D LIKE TO CLOSE DOWN
BY THE END OF NEXT WEEK.
AND SO WE'RE COMMITTED TO A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS THAT
DEDICATES AN APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF TIME FOR A THOROUGH VETTING
OF THE ISSUES.
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ENTAILS A
GREAT DEAL OF WORK WITHIN A
TIGHT TIME FRAME AND I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY COLLEAGUES FROM
BOTH HOUSES BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE. FOR THE COMMITMENT THAT
YOU'VE MADE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROCESS IN TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BEGIN WITH A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW PROVIDED BY THE LA --
OF EACH HOUSES BUDGET FRAMEWORK
AS COMPARED TO THAT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW --
THAT WE'RE REALLY NOT THAT FAR
APART IN OUR RESPECTIVE VERSES
OF THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
WE'VE ADOPTED SIMILAR REVENUE
ESTIMATES AND I PRIORITIZE
INVESTMENTS IN SIMILAR AREAS.
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
COMBAT IN THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND
CONTINUING TO INCREASE SUPPORT
FOR PROGRAMS.
THAT FRANKLY WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO PLAY CATCH UP ON FROM THE
LAST RECESSION.
IN ADDITION ALL THREE ENTITIES
THE ASSEMBLY SEVENTY
MINISTRATION CONTINUE THE
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET PRACTICES OF
BUILDING RESERVES AT ADDRESSING
DEBTS AND LIABILITIES.
AFTER THE OVERVIEW.
ENTITY OPENING COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL BEGIN
WORK WILL BEGIN TO WORK THROUGH
THE EDUCATION SECTION OF THE
AGENDA.
THE PLAN IS TO MAKE IT AS FAR
FOR THE EDUCATION SECTION AS WE
CAN'T TODAY AND WILL RESUME
TOMORROW AT TEN AM [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
MISTER VICE CHAIR DO YOU HAVE
ANY OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST VERY
BRIEFLY I THINK IT'S ON A GREAT
TO BE A CONFERENCE AGAIN WITH
ALL THE FAMILIAR FACES I THINK
THIS IS OUR OUR VERY EXCITING
TIME OF YEAR WHERE WE GET.
TO PRESENT THE CULMINATION OF
THE MONTHS OF HEARINGS THE
SENATE HAS HAD AS WELL AS THE
MONTHS OF HEARING THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS HAD.
I KNOW THERE'S ALWAYS A LITTLE
BIT OF CONSTERNATION AS WE GO
INTO THE FINAL -- SETTLEMENT OF
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENCES THE BAT
WHEN I'D LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
POINT OUT IS THAT 99% OF THE
BUDGET HAS BEEN DONE.
IT'S BEEN DONE THROUGH NUMEROUS
SUBCOMMITTEES THROUGH HOURS OF
TESTIMONY THROUGH -- THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE OF PUBLIC COMMENT
REALLY COMING FORWARD TO THIS
CAPITAL.
T SHARE THEIR VIEW POINT OF
WHAT THEY BELIEVE WHO ARE STATE
SHOULD BE SPENDING ON I THINK
THIS.
THIS BUDGET THE ALL THREE
PROPOSALS.
SO WE'VE ALREADY AGREE ON REALLY
REFLECT THE SHARED IN PUTTING
THE SHARED VALUES OF THE PEOPLE
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BUT ALSO MORE
POORLY THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO CON.
IN GIVING US FEEDBACK AS TO WHAT
PROGRAMS THAT WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN -- REALLY WHAT
WOULD REALLY IMPROVE THEIR LIFE
WHICH IS ULTIMATELY WHAT THE
GOAL OF THE BUDGET IS TO DO IS
TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
AND AGAIN IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR TO SERVE AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE TO BE
VICE CHAIR OF THIS CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE -- BUT AGAIN MORE
POLICE TO TO REMIND US THAT WE
WILL WE'VE ALREADY AGREED ON HIM
NINETY PLUS PERCENT OF THE
BUDGET.
WE'RE REALLY THIS PART IS THE
PROCESS WHERE WE ARE JUST GOING
THROUGH SOME OF THE DIFFERENCES
AND AGAIN -- BETWEEN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE VERY LITTLE
DIFFERENCES.
IN WITH THE GOVERNOR WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENCES BUT NOT AS MANY
AS WE ARE WE WOULD ANTICIPATE.
SO AGAIN -- LOOKING FOR TWO VERY
ROBUST HEARING I THINK A VERY
VERY TO LIBERTY HEARING AND
EXCITED AGAIN TO GET STARTED.
H. YOU VERY MUCH -- SITTING I
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR PARTNERSHIP
ONCE AGAIN BUT THIS IS OUR
THIRTY THIRD YEAR I APPRECIATE
THAT PARTNERSHIP.
WITH THAT BEFORE WE GET STARTED
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS MITCHELL HERE WARLOCK
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
ROTH YOUR SKINNER HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TING.
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
INVITE -- ARE LESS ALICE MISTER
PADDICK [inaudible]
AND MISTER.
THIS WILL NOTHING TO JOIN US --
SERVICE WOULD OFTEN YOU KNOW
THEIR APPEAR TEASING ME ABOUT
YOU KNOW MY STRUGGLE WITH YOUR
NAME BUT I LANDED IT TODAY DID
NOT.
YOU THAT SENATOR ALL.
THANK YOU YES I GOT MISTER
PETTIT CRIED AS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WELCOME
[inaudible]
YES.
WELL -- GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY I FORWARD TO MY
PARTICIPATION IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
I HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A COPY OF
THIS OVERVIEW HANDOUT.
IN YOUR IN YOUR BINDERS OR
OTHERWISE AVAILABLE TO YOU THERE.
I WAS PLANNING TO WALK THROUGH
THE THE HAND OUT HERE.
BRIEFLY.
BUT FIRST I JUST WANTED TO POINT
OUT THE ROLE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OUR ANALYSTS WILL PARTICIPATE IN
A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE PRIMARILY
TO INTRODUCE THE VARIOUS ISSUES
YOU'LL BE TAKING UP.
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THE KEY
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE PLANS
AND THEN IN SOME BUT NOT ALL OF
THE CASES BUT IN CASES WHERE
THEY HAVE.
AN ANALYTIC BASIS FOR DOING SO
THEY WILL MAKE --
RECOMMENDATIONS THE NEO FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
SO.
THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO DO
BEFORE LAUNCHING INTO THE SLIDES
IS JUST -- PAS.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE REALLY THE VERY
STRONG FINANCIAL POSITION OF THE
STATE AT THIS TIME -- THE STATE
IS IN A VERY HEALTHY FISCAL
POSITION -- WITH -- YOU KNOW
BENEFITING FROM THE CULMINATION
OF SEVERAL YEARS IN A ROW OF
UPWARD REVENUE REVISIONS.
AND THAT'S VERY FAVORABLE
HOWEVER IT'S PROBABLY NOT THE
KIND OF SITUATION THAT IS LIKELY
TO BE RECURRING ON  ONGOING
BASIS INTOTHE FUTURE.
AND THEREFORE.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THINK ABOUT THIS AS
SOMEWHAT OF A RARE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE PREPARING THE STATE
FOR THE FUTURE -- PREPARING THE
STATE TO ACCOMMODATE
UNANTICIPATED COSTS THAT CAN
ARISE.
BOTH FROM ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENTS
BUT ALSO NATURAL DISASTERS OR
OTHER KIND OF EENTS.
AND CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT THERE
IS LIKELY TO BE ANOTHER
RECESSION IN THE FUTURE IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR ANYONE TO PREDICT
EXACTLY WHEN BUT NO MOST MOST
EVERYONE AGREES THAT THERE WILL
BE ANOTHER RECESSION SO.
WITH THAT LET ME TURN TO THE
FIRST PAGE AND HERE.
I WOULD ACTUALLY ECHO SENATOR
MITCHELL'S -- OPENING COMMENTS
IN THAT.
THIS SLIDE COMPARES THE GENERAL
FUND CONDITION UNDER THE THREE
DIFFERENT PLANS AND WHAT YOU
WOULD FIND WHAT WE WHAT THE YOU
KNOW THE POINT I WOULD WANT TO
MAKE HERE IS JUST THAT.
LOOKING AT ALL THREE PLANS YOU
SEE VERY SIMILAR GENERAL FUND
CONDITION AT THAT THE HIGH LEVEL
AT LEAST.
THIS REFLECTS THE ALL THREE
PLANS ADOPTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REVENUE ESTIMATES.
AND ALL THREE PLANS HAVE ADOPTED
THE SAME LEVEL OF PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING AND SO WITH
THOSE TWO VARIABLES IN SYNC.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT AT
LEAST AT A HIGH LEVEL THE BUDGET
CONDITION LOOKS VERY SIMILAR.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES -- STEM FROM FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHOICES THAT
DIFFER AMONG THE THREE DIFFERENT --
PLANS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR'S
REVENUES.
THERE ARE HIGHER REVENUES.
AND THEN THE OTHER THAN THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY PLANS AND
THAT.
PRIMARILY REFLECTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN.
ASSUMES SOME ADDITIONAL REVENUE
FROM THE ADOPTION OF TAX
CONFORMITY MEASURES CONFORMING
THE STATE TAX CODE WITH THE
FEDERAL TAX CODE.
AND THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
PLANS -- DO NOT MAKE THAT
ASSUMPTION UP FRONT.
THE HOWEVER THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY PLANTS GENERATE A
SIMILAR LEVEL OF ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND CAPACITY MORE ON
THE EXPENDITURE SIDE BY ASSUMING
AN EXTENSION OF THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX PACKAGE THEM CO
TAX THAT IS SCHEDULED TO EXPIRE
AT THE END OF THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR.
AND THEN THE OTHER.
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE ON THIS
PAGE THAT I WOULD JUST TRY YOUR
ATTENTION TO IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ENDS WITH A NEARLY
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION.
A SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES RESERVE BALANCE --
WHICH IS MATERIALLY HIGHER THAN
THE OTHER TWO PLANS ON THE PAGE.
SO MOVING TO THE NEXT PAGE I
THINK THAT KIND OF LEADS ME INTO
THE DISCUSSION HERE ABOUT TOTAL
COMPARING TOTAL RESERVE BALANCES.
AND THE WHEN YOU KNOW AGAIN I
THINK I CAN SAY THAT ALL THREE
PLANS HAVE FROM CANNABIS
HISTORIC STANDPOINT ALL THREE
PLAN SHOW VERY HIGH TOTAL
RESERVES AT THE END OF THE
BUDGET YEAR.
SO THAT SAYS THERE'S IN BROAD
TERMS THERE'S AGREEMENT ABOUT
THAT.
ALL THREE PLANS INCLUDE A SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR DEPOSIT
INTO THE SAFETY NET RESERVE.
A WITH THE SENATE ACTUALLY
PUTTING AN ADDITIONAL SIX
HUNDRED MILLION INTO THE SAFETY
NET RESERVE WHICH BRINGS ITS
BALANCE HIGHER THAN THE OTHER
TWO TO ONE POINT FIVE BILLION.
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE AS I WAS
JUST SAYING A MOMENT AGO THE SFE
YOU BALANCE IS NOTABLY HIGHER
THAN THE OTHER TWO PLANS A THREE
POINT SEVEN BILLION.
THAT PROVIDES THE STATE WITH
SOME.
YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL FISCAL
FLEXIBILITY TO CERTAINLY COVER --
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY BUT ALSO
BECAUSE IT'S A TO SERVE A
FLEXIBLE -- RESERVE OTHER TYPES
OF UNANTICIPATED COSTS THAT
COULD ARISE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST MENTION ABOUT THE ASSEMBLY
RESERVES.
IS THAT IT'S THE ONE FIGURE HERE
THAT BRINGS THE TOTAL RESERVE
BALANCE INTO THE LOWER END OF
THE RANGE OF TWENTY TO FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF THAT OUR
OFFICE HAS PREVIOUSLY ESTIMATED.
WOULD BE THE AMOUNT NECESSARY
FOR THE STATE TO WITHSTAND.
THE FFECTS OF A A RECESSION THE
MILD OR MODERATE RECESSION
WITHOUT HAVING TO TAKE SOME
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS LIKE TAX
INCREASES OR SPENDING REDUCTIONS
WERE -- YOU KNOW SOME KIND OF
COST SHIFT MOOD MANEUVER.
SO THE ASSEMBLY PLANT IS NOTABLE
FOR BRINGING TOTAL RESERVES INTO
THAT -- LEVEL THAT WE HAVE SAID
WOULD BE.
HELPFUL AND IN THAT SCENARIO.
MOVING.
TO THE NEXT PAGE -- SO -- FEAR
NOT I WON'T GO THROUGH THIS
ENTIRE SLIGHT IT'S A FULL SLIDE
COVERING.
A LOT OF A LETTER THE MAJOR
PROGRAMMATIC GENERAL FUND
SPENDING CONFERENCE ITEMS AND
THE THE REASON IT'S A FULL SITE
IS REALLY JUST BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO PROVIDE FOR YOU SORT OF A ALL
IN NE PLACE A SUMMARY OF SOME
OF THE MAJOR POLICY ITEMS THAT
YOU'LL BE CARRYING.
IN CONFERENCE AND A BRIEF
DESCRIPTION OF THE KEY
DIFFERENCES IN THE IN THE PLANS --
AND SO IT'S REALLY MORE OF A
REFERENCE FOR YOU.
HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
MENTION A COUPLE THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES TO NOTE -- IN THE
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH AREA THE
SENATE INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING --
FOR STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
PARTNERSHIPS WHICH IS NOT IN
EITHER OF THE OTHER TWO PLANS.
AND THE SENATE PLAN ALSO
INCLUDES -- FUNDING FOR THE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE PACKAGE AND
THE PRISON TO COMMUNITY PIPELINE
PACKAGE SO THOSE ARE DIFFERENCES
THAT YOU'LL BE ADDRESSING IN THE
IN THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
AND ALSO WE DON'T HAVE ON HERE
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS --
AND PROPOSALS.
MOSTLY BECAUSE THESE ARE.
WHAT YOU EAT WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH THAT THERE'S A GENERAL
CONCEPTUALIZATION MEANT ABOUT
THOSE?
AND SO -- AND SOME OF THE
DETAILS WILL BE.
ALSO SORTED OUT IN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE BUT THAT'S WHY THAT'S
NOT ON HERE AND I WANT TO GO AND
GET IT KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU'LL BE
DEALING WITH THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER ISSUE
WHICH HAS -- POTENTIALLY SOME
GENERAL FUND IMPLICATION.
WE DID NOT PUT THAT ON HERE
MOSTLY -- IN THE INTEREST OF A
THE LENGTH OF WHAT WE HAVE ON
THE TABLE.
AND THEN THE OTHER JUST
OBSERVATION I WOULD MAKE IS THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN.
INCLUDES SOME FUNDING THAT WOULD
BE SCHEDULED UNDER HIS MULTI
YEAR PLAN TO SUNSET AFTER A
COUPLE OF YEARS.
THE THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY --
BOTH DO NOT INCLUDE THOSE
SUNSETS IN THEIR PLAN AND
BECAUSE THE FUNDING PERTAINS TO
PROGRAMS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
ONGOING IN NATURE.
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND I HSS --
RATES.
WE ACTUALLY THINK THAT THE
TREATING THEM AS AN ON GOING
RECOGNIZING THE ONGOING COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE PROGRAMS
IS IS MORE -- APPROPRIATE IN THE
IN THE MULTI YEAR PLAN.
SO THEN MOVING TO THE NEXT PAGE.
HERE WE HAVE A SIDE BY SIDE
COMPARISON OF HOW OF THE THREE
PLANS [inaudible]
ROACH.
MAKING SUPPLEMENTAL DEBT AND
LIABILITY PAYMENTS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR.
AND AGAIN ALL THREE PLANS
ALLOCATE SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
TO PAYING DOWN DEBT AND WHY IT
THE STATE'S DEAD IN LIABILITIES --
THING -- IT YOU KNOW I CAN YOU
CAN SEE THIS PEARL OF DRY YOUR
ATTENTION TO SOME KEY
DIFFERENCES AMONG THE THREE
PLANS.
FIRST IS THAT THE GOVERNOR
ACTUALLY PAYS DOWN MORE DEBT
THAN THE OTHER TWO PLANS
PRIMARILY BECAUSE UNDER HIS PLAN
HE MAKES A UP FRONT THREE THREE
BILLION DOLLAR.
SUPPLEMENTAL CONTRIBUTION TO THE
STATE'S CALPERS UNFUNDED
LIABILITY.
AND THE GOVERNOR ALSO INCLUDES
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION.
FOR I'M DOING -- CERTAIN BUDGET.
DEFERRALS THAT THE STATE IS
CONTENT HELD HIS STILL CARRYING
THAT ARE KIND OF A HOLD OVER
FROM THE WRIST.
THE LAST RECESSION.
THE SENATE DIFFERS FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN IN THAT ON AT
LEAST UP FRONT IT INCLUDES --
SMALLER ONE POINT ONE BILLION
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT TO THE
CALPERS.
UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
AND YOU KNOW THERE THERE WOULD
BE -- THERE IS A KIND OF A PLACE
HOLDER FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN
THE FUTURE.
IF IF -- TAX CONFORMITY REVENUES
BECOME AVAILABLE LATER IN THE
YEAR.
ARE THE ASSEMBLY DIFFERS IN THAT
IT PUTS A ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR -- CONTRIBUTION TO THE
CALPERS CAL CALPERS.
LIABILITY BUT IT'S THE CALPERS
LIABILITY OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ON BEHALF OF THAT ARE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
NOW ONE THING ON THE PREVIOUS
PAGE THAT I SHOULD ALSO POINT
OUT IS JUST THAT.
THERE IS ALL THREE PLANS INCLUDE
MAKING A THE PENSION
CONTRIBUTION ON BEHALF OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOR TEACHERS THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY PLAN WOULD
MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS IN ADDITION
TO THAT ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES. TO CALPERS.
NOW -- THE KEY THING ABOUT THESE
CONTRIBUTIONS IS THAT THEY
SUPPLANT WHERE THEY ARE IN
DESIGNED TO BE IN PLACE OF THE
DISTRICTS CONTRIBUTIONS ARE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE DISTRICTS
WOULD OTHERWISE BE MAKING ON
THEIR OWN SO IT DOESN'T
REPRESENT ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO THE PENSION SYSTEMS.
AND IT DOES NOT.
REALLY ALTER THE LONG TERM
TRAJECTORY OF THOSE LIABILITIES
BUT IT DOES PROVIDE SOME
TEMPORARY TEMPORARY RELIEF TO TO
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- FOR TWO
YEARS IN THAT AREA SO IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ASSEMBLY CUT BACK ON
THE DECK PAGE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ASSEMBLY I HAVE ONE POINT. ONE
FIVE BILLION FOR THE CALPERS
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
CONTRIBUTION BUT THAT'S BECAUSE
THIS IS ADDRESSING THE LONG TERM
LIABILITY NOT JUST -- US A
PLANTATION OF THE NEXT TWO YEAR
CONTRIBUTIONS -- PARTIAL SO
PLANTATION I SHOULD SAY.
SO THEN THE OTHER FINAL POINT
I'LL MAKE ON THISSLIDE IS JUST
YOU'LL NOTE THAT NEITHER THE
SENATE NOR THE ASSEMBLY PLANS
INCLUDE FUNDS THAT.
ARE ALLOCATED FOR UNDOING SOME
OF THE BUDGET LIABILITIES THAT
THE GOVERNOR INCLUDES THE ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION.
AND WE THINK THIS IS REASONABLE
BECAUSE I'M ONE OF THE IDEAS
BEHIND ON DOING THE DEFERRALS IS
THAT THOSE ARE ACTIONS THAT THE
STATE COULD TAKE AGAIN IF IT
ENCOUNTERS FISCAL STRESS IN THE
FUTURE.
WE JUST THINK -- OUR OFFICE HAS
BEEN ON RECORD THAT YOU KNOW
THOSE RESOURCES PROBABLY WOULD
BE BETTER ALLOCATED TO BUILDING
HIGHER RESERVES OR ALTERNATIVELY
PAIN DOWN.
LONGER TERM DEBT WITH KIND OF
MORE.
WE JUST THINK THERE'S A BETTER
RETURN ON PAIN DOWN LONGER TERM
DEBT AND DIRECTING THOSE FUNDS
TO UNDOING THE DEFERRALS.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
THERE -- SO THAT TAKES US HERE
TO THE TO THE FINAL.
PAGE IN THIS SLIDE DECK.
THEN AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO STEP
BACK AND POINT OUT THE YOU KNOW
AT THIS MOMENT THE STATE HAS A
VERY LARGE ROUTE.
BUDGETARY SURPLUS HEALTHY
RESERVES AND BUT IT'S NOT LIKELY
TO BE A SITUATION THAT WILL
PERSIST ON A RECURRING BASIS.
AND SO ONE WAY TO THINK ABOUT IT
IS THAT THE BEST WAY FOR THE
STATE -- TO AIR FOR THE FUTURE
IS TO BUILD LARGER RESERVES NOW
THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR
RECOMMENDED IN THAT AREA WE
THINK THE ASSEMBLY -- GOES THE
FURTHEST AND THEN WE ALSO THINK
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO MAKING --
SUPPLEMENTAL DEBT PAYMENTS.
THE TARGETING THOSE MORE TOWARD --
DEBTS THAT WOULD HAVE A TWO MORE
DAYS PREPARE THE STATE FOR THE
FUTURE PROBABLY.
A BETTER USE OF THOSE RESOURCES.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK WE WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THE POSITION THAT
THE STATE IS AND IT IS.
KIND OF ONE ONE WAY TO SAY IT IS
THAT.
D. ACTIONS THAT THE STATE TAKES
NOW WITH THIS HEALTHY SURPLUS
WILL IN MANY WAYS TO FIND ITS
EXPERIENCE THROUGH THE NEXT
DOWNTURN.
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZES AVOIDING
HAVING TO MAKE AS MANY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS IN THE NEXT DOWNTURN.
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE STRONG A
SURPLUS POSITION NOW TO SET
ASIDE SOME OF THAT FOR RESERVES
WOULD LESSEN THAT.
ON THE OTHER HAND YOU KNOW THIS
IS A POLICY CHOICE AND TO THE
EXTENT THE MEMBERS.
WOULD PREFER TO BE IN A POSITION
WHERE YOU.
BE WILLING TO MAKE MORE --
POLICY CHANGES TO RESPOND TO A
RECESSIONARY SITUATION.
YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND OF THE
TRADE OFF.
AND SO ARE OUR RECOMMENDATION OF
COURSE IS TO DO THE RESERVES A
LITTLE BIT HIGHER AND AND TO PAY
DOWN MORE OF THE LONG TERM DEBTS.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
YOUR FROM FINANCE CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE HAVE
CROSSED PATHS BEFORE.
THAT'S RIGHT IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU IN THIS POSITION.
I KNOW THAT TERM.
SOME LONG STANDING INSTITUTIONAL
POLICIES DON'T DIE EASILY.
BUT I'M WONDERING COULD WE STOP
PUTTING PARENTHESES AROUND
SUBTITLES.
BRING TO A FINAL STOP DOING THAT
THIS.
THE CPA JUST GONE NUTS.
I AM.
I HAVE TO SAY IT SENATORS.
ARE LAUGHING YEAH.
I WOKE UP THIS MORNING AND
REALIZED THAT IT WAS ONE
QUESTION THAT I COULD PROBABLY
PREPARE MYSELF FOR FROM
[inaudible]
BUT WE HAVE A WORKING GROUP
THAT'S UNDER DEVELOPMENT TO LOOK
AT THAT ISSUE.
WELL IF YOU NEED ANOTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBER JUST LET ME
KNOW -- BUT OUT I COULD SHOW YOU
HOW TO DO UNDER LINES AND DOUBLE
UNDER LINES AT THE APPROPRIATE
PLACES BUT I CONCUR WITH YOUR
CONCLUSION I AM.
OF REAL CONCERNED [inaudible]
ABOUT.
NOT MISSING THIS OPPORTUNITY
WITH THIS BUDGET SURPLUS AND
THEN IT IN IT COMES IN A FEW
AREAS -- I I I RESULT A LITTLE.
MAYBE JUST LIKE A GENERAL
OVERVIEW MADAM CHAIR BUT WITH
FRONT PAGE. FOR ROOM WE WERE
SHOWING THAT THE GOVERNOR WANTS
TO PUT THREE BILLION AND TAKE
CALPERS.
THAT'S THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
BE DOING RIGHT NOW WITH THE
SURPLUS IN FACT IT MIGHT BE.
A LITTLE.
LOW IT COULD PROBABLY BE HIGHER.
I'M GOING GOING FORWARD BECAUSE
YOU CAN BENEFIT FROM LOWER.
ANNUAL REQUIRED CONTRIBUTIONS IN
THE FUTURE BUT YOU COULD ALSO
SAY WAIT A SECOND WE'RE REALLY
IN A TIGHT SPOT WE COULD USE IT
AS A AS A WAY.
TO OFFSET A FUTURE CONTRIBUTION
AND SAY LET'S TAKE IT FROM.
NINETEEN TWENTY APPLY IT -- SO I
I WAS I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT --
IN LOOKING AT THE BUDGET BUT I'M
I'M ALSO CONCERNED.
ABOUT.
THE FACT THAT.
I'M BIG OVERVIEW THAT WE HAVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW SOMEHOW
PROP NINETY EIGHT ISN'T CUTTING
IT.
AND I JUST WORRY THAT WERE NOT
PROVIDING ENOUGH MONEY IN THE
RESERVE. FOR FOR FOR THE SCHOOLS
WERE WERE WERE ACTUALLY.
YOU KNOW FIGHTING OVER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION OR ZERO AT LEAST
THE GOVERNOR IS IS TRYING TO
START FINDING -- A RAINY DAY
FUND FOR THE SCHOOLS BUT AS YOU
KNOW YOU'VE LOOKED AT ENOUGH
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS FROM ALL
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS OVER YOUR
YEARS AT STANDARD AND POOR'S IS
THAT.
THE THE UNFUNDED RETIREE MEDICAL
IS NOW SHOWING UP ON THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
AND AND I HAVE BEEN AMAZED AT
THE SIZE OF THE NUMBERS -- JUST
YOU KNOW WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
SACRAMENTO CITY IT'S IN THE NEWS
HERE LOCALLY [inaudible]
EVERY.
EVERY WEEK WE GET AN ARTICLE BUT
THEY'RE THEY'RE UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT FROM JUNE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS IT WAS FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF THE DEFICIT ANY WINTER ONE
POINT. ZERO SIX FIVE BILLION IT
WENT UP FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
BILLION IN ONE YEAR DOUBLED.
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING
WE NEED TO PAY ATTENTION. TO
SENATE SEPARATIST CAN UNIFIED IS
GONE FROM SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION UPSIDE DOWN TO
ONE POINT TWO BILLION UPSIDE
DOWN.
IN ONE YEAR FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS A SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED WENT FROM ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION TO ONE POINT.
SEVEN THEY WENT UP.
THERE DEFICIT WENT UP TWO
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION LA U.
S. THE WAS A REAL SHOCKER IT
WENT FROM.
TEN BILLION EIGHT FIFTY SIX TO
NINETEEN BILLION FIVE FIFTY SIX
AT EIGHT POINT SEVEN BILLION.
IN MORE LIABILITIES BEING
REPORTED ON THE THE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS SO I I AM.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE FISCAL
CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT TEAM AND
AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO FIND OR
LOAN.
MONEY TO SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT WE
DON'T SEEM TO HAVE THAT.
SUMMER THE BUDGET SO JUST
SOMETHING.
TO THINK ABOUT BECAUSE SHOULD
THIS RECESSION THAT WE'RE BOTH
CONCERNED ABOUT COM.
WE'RE GOING TO GET HIT BY.
ROOM DECLINING REVENUES.
INCREASED PAYMENT IT'S TO THE
PENSION PLAN BECAUSE THE PENSION
PLAN WILL SUFFER FROM A BAD
ECONOMY AND THEREFORE ANNUAL
REQUIRED CONTRIBUTIONS WILL GO
UP.
IN THE SCHOOLS WILL BE COMING TO
US AND WERE WERE FLASHING RIGHT
NOW CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE NOT.
THEY HAVE VERY LIMITED.
ABILITY TO RAISE REVENUES WERE
SAYING LA UNIFIED DOING A PARCEL
TAX IN A COUPLE WEEKS MAYBE A
WEEK OR NEXT WEEK.
SOME THINGS ARE WORKING ARE
TELLING US THAT WE'VE GOT TO BE
MUCH MORE CAUTIOUS.
WE WE HAVE AN INVERTED YIELD
CURVE WHICH YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
WHICH HAS BEEN.
AN ACCURATE INDICATOR OF A
UPCOMING RECESSION OVER THE LAST
SIXTY YEARS.
SO SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
AT LEAST TRYING TO WARN US A
LITTLE BIT.
THAT WE SHOULD REALLY BE LOOKING
AT WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW.
AND AND AND HAVING BEEN AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH THE RECESSION OTHER I'M
OLD ENOUGH YOU KNOW DID SOME OF
US DON'T REALIZE WHAT A
RECESSION IS LIKE IT WAS ELEVEN
YEARS AGO OR TWELVE YEARS AGO
WHEN WE HAD THAT.
THE GREAT RECESSION AND IN.
NINETY FOUR AND THAT'S TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO.
BUT IT YOU KNOW I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE COLLEAGUES OF HAVING
TO LAY OFF A THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
IT WAS IT WAS IT WAS NOT A
PLEASANT TIME TO BE A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR.
AND SO THE MORE WE CAN DO NOW.
TO POSITION OURSELVES FOR A
DOWNTURN -- THE BETTER OFF WE'RE
GOING TO BE SO OUR MANAGER THANK
YOU FOR AT LEAST LETTING ME.
SURE A FEW OF THOSE CONCERNS
PROVIDE I WANT TO WELCOME OUR
NEW.
LA -- AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US IN NUMBER AND FOR FOR JUMPING
INTO THE JOB.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU US
AND MORE LIKE FOR SURE YOU
PERSPECTIVE I'LL GO TO A VICE
CHAIR TEEN AND THEN TO CENTER
NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST A
QUICK QUESTION TELLING NOW --
THE THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY.
DECIDED TO HAVE CERTAIN
RESTORATION OF SERVICES LIKE AND
HELP SUPPORT SERVICES
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
AND WE SCORED THOSE IS ONGOING
RATHER THAN THE ADMINISTRATION
DID A SUNSET WHICH SEEMED A
LITTLE BIT ODD BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THOSE RESOURCES WOULD GO TO
HIRING PEOPLE THAN THEY WERE
CAPITAL THEY'RE NOT SOMETHING
THAT YOU COULD JUST SORT OF BUY
SOMETHING FOR A YEAR IN THE NOT
BY.
SOMETHING SO YOU BE HIRING
PEOPLE THAN LAYING PEOPLE OFF
COULD COULD YOU COMMENT IS.
ON THOSE ON THOSE DIFFERENCES
AND SORT OF PHONE WERE YOU THINK
ABOUT THE WELL.
I CAN COME IN AT A HIGH LEVEL
AND TO THE DEPENDING ON THE
AMOUNT OF DETAIL YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN HEARING I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE BUT WHAT --
I MEAN IN AT THE HIGH LEVEL WE
CONCUR THAT THESE ARE -- ARE
MORE ON GOING IN NATURE THESE
THE THE PROGRAMS THAT THIS
FUNDING IS GOING.
FOR AND OUR ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN.
TO RECOGNIZE THEM AS SUCH AND SO --
YOU KNOW.
IT I MEAN I THINK WE GENERALLY --
STINK THAT THAT'S PROBABLY
PAINTING.
TO PROBABLY A TRUER PICTURE OF
THE STATE'S FISCAL TRAJECTORY
OVER THE MULTI YEAR OUTLOOK SO --
THE I THINK WE WE AGREE WITH
THAT.
THE FOR SAME QUESTION FINANCE
WHEN THEY COME UP SENATOR NELSON
[inaudible]
STATE CONTEXT -- MORLOCK TALKED
BRIEFLY ABOUT THE LOCAL
EXPERIENCE AND NOW THAT
TRANSLATES TO WHAT WE DO HERE.
BUT A FEW YEARS AGO WE ADAM.
BIG SURPLUS TO NOT AS GREAT AS
THIS.
ONE THE GOT SPENT.
SPENT IN THE COMBINATION OF NEW
PROGRAMS BASED BUILDING.
AND EVEN SOME TAX DECREASES
[inaudible]
AND THEY DID NOT.
PROVED TO BE A FORMULA FOR THE
FUTURE.
THIS VERY QUICKLY.
THE ECONOMY SOFTENED.
I THINK WE STARTED WHEN I CAME
BACK IN OLD AGE WE WERE. FIFTEEN
BILLION IN THE RED. ONE UP TO
TWENTY FIVE BILLION.
SHOWS HOW QUICKLY THAT CAN COME
AROUND.
AND WE ARE VERY DEPENDENT.
TO ON THE WEALTH OF THE TECH.
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM NOT A COMMUNIST AND I DON'T
SPEAK WITH ANY PARTICULAR DATA
BUT I'M FEARFUL THAT THAT'S
GOING TO SOFTEN AS WELL
[inaudible]
AND SO.
WHAT I HAVE SUGGESTED AS TO THIS
BUDGET?
THE WE CONTINUE TO BE
[inaudible]
PRUDENT.
PRUDENT IN TERMS OF LONG TERM
BASE BUILDING [inaudible]
OBLIGATIONS.
I BELIEVE YOU'RE CAUTIONING US
IN THE SAME MANNER.
AM I CORRECT IN THAT.
YEAH IS IT BUT I THINK THAT SAYS
SOMETHING WE DO AGREE WITH YES.
ANOTHER SUBTLE THING.
AND AGAIN I DON'T HAVE THE DATA
BILL BY BILL.
BUT I DO READ A LOT OF THE BILLS.
AND OVER RECENT YEARS.
PARTICULAR LAST TWO YEARS IT
SEEMS TO BECOME MORE OF A HABIT
HERE.
OF PUTTING IN A GIVEN SPENDING
BILL FOR A CERTAIN IDEA.
SUBJECT TO FUTURE APPROPRIATIONS.
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
NOW THAT ISN'T.
NECESSARILY OF BINDING THING ONE
LEGISLATURE CAN'T BIND A FUTURE.
ONE BUT MY CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE
BUILDING.
PROGRAMS BASED ON FUTURE
EXPENDITURES.
VOTE BY FUTURE LEGISLATURE'S
WHAT THAT DOES IS PUT PRESSURE
ON THOSE FUTURE LEGISLATORS TO
EMBRACE THOSE PROGRAMS.
THERE IF YOU WILL WAITING IN THE
WINGS.
THAT IS NOT SO MUCH A QUESTION.
BUT AS AN OBSERVATION OF
SOMETHING THAT WOULD WAX FOR
QUESTION HERE MMHM MMHM.
YOU SIR MISTER MCCARTY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS I THINK WILL BE ADDRESSED
IN OUR EDUCATION PIECE IN A
LITTLE BIT BUT I CONCUR THAT.
SCHOOLS ARE STRAPPED IN BUT
CENTER MORE LIKE SAID.
ANYMORE WE COULD PUT INTO THAT
CAL STIRS OUR CALPERS PAYMENTS
ARE DISTRICTS CERTAINLY HELPS
THEM WITH THEIR ONGOING.
EXPENDITURES AND THE REALITY
THAT EVEN THE WORST SPENDING
CHáVEZ MODELS.
THESE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE STILL
STRAPPED RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO LA IN OAKLAND.
SO AS WHEN I GO BACK TO WHAT YOU
SAID AT THE LA ON THE YOU SAID
THE MAYBE YOU PREFER THAT WE
HAVE A HIGHER [inaudible]
RESERVE AMOUNTS.
THAT SAID ACCURATE.
IF THAT'S THE CASE IT WILL YEAH
HOW DO YOU PROPOSE TO DO THAT.
WELL MOSTLY I THINK.
WHAT WE ARE -- OUR POINT IS THAT
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD --
SHOULD CONSIDER ADOPTING A
HIGHER LEVEL OF OVERALL RESERVES
THAN WHAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED.
AND ACTUALLY BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY PLANS ARE HIGHER
THE ASSEMBLY BY A SOMEWHAT MORE
THAN THAN THE SENATE BUT SO.
I MEAN.
WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY --
SPELLING OUT A DEFINITIVE -- A
PRECISE NUMBER I THINK IT'S A
IT'S A DIFFICULT TO SETTLE ON
WHAT THE EXACT.
RIGHT LEVEL SHOULD BE BUT WE
THINK THAT THE HIGHER LEVELS
INCLUDED IN BOTH THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY PLANTS IN PARTICULAR
ASSEMBLY PLANTS.
ARE GETTING INTO THE RANGE THAT
WE THINK IS PRUDENT.
OKAY AND THEN AGAIN WHAT WE'RE
GONNA GET TO EDUCATION A BET.
BUT THE GOVERNOR AND HIS JANUARY
BUDGET.
THAT PUT INTO TO BUY DOWN SOME
THAT RETIREMENT OBLIGATIONS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND BOTH HOUSES
WHAT A LITTLE BIT MORE.
I SIMPLY THINK THAT SUCH A
PRUDENT APPROACH AND AND DO YOU
THINK IS OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
DO.
EVEN MORE KNOWING THAT.
IS SOMETHING THAT COULD HELP OUR
STRAPS SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
ABSENCE OF INCREASED LCF THAT
PROP NINETY EIGHT MONEY.
YES WE DO THINK IT'S HELPFUL --
IN PARTICULAR WE THINK THE
SUPPLEMENTAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE UNFUNDED LIABILITIES WILL
HAVE A SORT OF A LONGER TERM
BENEFIT -- SO THERE'S SORT OF A
TRADE OFF IF YOU PUT IF YOU MAKE.
A LARGER CONTRIBUTION THAN IS
REQUIRED TO THE PENSION SYSTEMS
NOW. FOR THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY
YOU HAVE A AN ABILITY.
TO INCREMENTALLY LOWER THE
ANNUAL CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WILL
BE NECESSARY GOING FORWARD.
IN A ANOTHER THING THAT THE
STATE CAN DO IS SIMPLY GIVE
MONEY UP FRONT TO PAY.
A PORTION OF THE PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS IN A SPECIFIC YEAR
NOT ADDING TO WHAT IS OTHERWISE
PAID BUT JUST PAIN PART OF THE
PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS ON THEIR
BEHALF.
AND THAT'S THAT'S ALSO INCLUDED
IN ALL THREE PLANS.
AND IT DOES PROVIDE.
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL RELIEF FOR
THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE WOULD JUST MAKE SURE THAT IT
YOU KNOW.
OUR POINT IS JUST THAT THAT IS A
FORM OF TEMPORARY FISCAL RELIEF
IN IN THAT AREA.
VERSUS THE OTHER BUT IT'S LARGER
IT'S LARGER UP FRONT TEMPORARY
FISCAL RELIEF THEN THE THE OTHER
OPTION OF PUTTING.
A LARGE CONTRIBUTION INTO THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY INTO THE
SYSTEM YES I I HEAR POINTS
ACTUALLY IS LIKE.
PAYING SOMEONE'S MORTGAGE
PAYMENT FOR A FEW MONTHS VERSUS
BUYING DOWN THE PRINCIPLE OF
THEIR LOAN THAT'S THE ANALOGY I
USED WITH MY COLLEAGUES THE
OTHER DAY OKAY THERE YOU GO.
SO AT IT ONCE MAYOR NOT BE MORE
RESPONSIBLE THAN THE OTHERS ARE
YOU RECOMMENDING A COMBINATION
OF THOSE OR HURT.
UNDER THE LOWER JUST WERE A CAST
THE THING WERE WERE RECOMMENDED
TO POINT OUT IS THAT.
NOTWITHSTANDING THE FISCAL
PRESSURES THAT MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE UNDER RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE ACTUALLY AT A LEVEL
WHERE.
IN A NON RECESSIONARY
ENVIRONMENT THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING LEVEL IS.
IS -- HI AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
PROVIDING THEM FISCAL RIVER YOU
KNOW THE THESE PLANS WOULD
PROVIDE FISCAL RELIEF AT A TIME
WHEN.
YOU KNOW THE THE REVENUES ARE
ARGUABLY AT A AT A HIGHER POINT.
AND SO IN THE FUTURE -- IN A IN
A WEAKER CLIMATE [inaudible]
YOU KNOW. ONE IDEA THAT WE HAD
EARLIER IN THE YEAR WAS THAT YOU
COULD -- SET ASIDE THESE FUNDS.
TO PROVIDE THE RELIEF TO THE
PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR A TIME WHEN
THE BROADER STATE BUDGET IS IN A
MORE STRESSED SITUATION.
OF COURSE THE THE AND FOR YOU
KNOW UNFORTUNATELY WITH THAT
YOU'RE NOT PROVIDING FISCAL
RELIEF -- RIGHT NOW AND THERE'S
THERE'S SOME DISTRICTS AS PEOPLE
HAVE MENTIONED THAT ARE.
THAT ARE -- ALREADY IN FISCAL
PRESSURE SO I MEAN I THINK WE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT IS YOU KNOW
KIND OF AT A CERTAIN POINT IT
BECOMES A CHOICE -- ON PART OF
THE LEGISLATURE WHICH HOW YOU
WANT TO PROCEED WITH THIS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE EVEN WITH A
LARGE SURPLUS THE RESOURCES ARE
FINITE AND YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE OF
ABOUT HOW TO ALLOCATE THEM SO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME SIR [inaudible]
MR OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE SERVING WITH YOU
ONCE AGAIN ON THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
I JUST WANT TO CHIME IN HERE
BECAUSE I THOUGHT OF THE ANALOGY
OF MAKING SOMEONE'S MORTGAGE
PAYMENT FOR THEM IS AN
INTERESTING AN APT ONE BUT JUST
LIKE THAT ANALOGY.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT THAT'S GOING TO PRINCIPLE
IN THE AMOUNT THAT'S GOING TO
INTEREST AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS WHEN WE MAKE A
CONTRIBUTION TOWARDS THE LONG
TERM PERSON STIRS LIABILITIES.
FOR PAYING DOWN A LOT MORE OF
FUTURE PAYMENTS THEN WE ARE IF
WE JUST ALLOW THEM. TO HELP US
MAKE THE PAYMENT THIS YEAR
INSTEAD OF THEM SO -- HI.
IF I GOT MY WAY IT WOULD ALL BE
A LIEU GOING TOWARDS LONG TERM
LIABILITIES BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO MAXIMIZE
THE IMPACT OF THOSE DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE INVESTING.
THAT WOULD YOU CONCUR WITH THAT.
YEAH A AGREE WITH THE
MATHEMATICS THAT YOUR SKETCHING
OUT THE THE THE TRADE OFF IS
THAT IT'S OVER THE LONGER TERM
YEAR AFTER YEAR IT'S GONNA IT
WILL REPRESENT A LESS NOTICEABLE
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR ANNUAL
CONTRIBUTION THEN.
YOU KNOW IT'S VERY NOTICEABLE
WHEN THE CONTRIBUTION RATES
DECLINED TO SIXTEENTH FROM 18%
216% BY -- PROVIDING THIS --
JULES SO PLANTATION IN THESE TWO
YEARS SO.
A I MEAN THAT'S REALLY THE
DIFFERENCE SIR I AGREE WITH YOU.
HOWEVER I THINK WE KIND OF
KICKED THE CAN BIND DOWN THE
ROAD IF WE MAKE THE PAYMENTS
THIS YEAR BECAUSE WE'RE JUST
GOING TO MAKE IT THAT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO ADJUST TO THOSE
HIGHER PAYMENTS.
NEXT YEAR BECAUSE NO ONE
PRETENDS THAT THE RATE AT THE
THE PERCENTAGE IS GOING TO GO
DOWN ANY TIME SOON.
YEAH I MEAN THESE ARE THIS IS
THESE ARE THE TRADE OFFS THAT
WE'VE TRIED TO SKETCH OUT AND I
I JUST THINK THAT.
pKNOW ONCE WE'VE PUT THEM BEFORE
YOU THEN IT'LL BE A DECISION OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE WANT TO FINANCE.
FINANCE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
COVERED A NUMBER OF THE KEY
DIFFERENCES SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THREE GENERAL POINTS ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE FIRST IS A POINT THAT I KNOW
WE ALL APPRECIATE IS THE FACT
THAT WE ARE -- CREATING THIS
BUDGET IN AN ENVIRONMENT OF A
HEALTHY SURPLUS BUT ALSO GROWING
RISKS.
AND I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THE
TRADE WAR WITH CHINA WHICH IS ON
GOING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WERE TEN YEARS INTO AN
ECONOMIC EXPANSION WHICH WILL BE
THIS SUMMER.
THE LONGEST SINCE WORLD WAR TWO
AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
ENVIRONMENT OF SLOWING GLOBAL
GROWTH AND IN ADDITION TO THAT
IN THE LAST COUPLE DAYS.
HAS SENATOR MORE WALK MENTIONED --
WE'VE SEEN AN INVERSION OF THE
YIELD CURVE IN WHICH RATES ON
THE TEN YEAR TREASURY NOTE OR
ACTUALLY LOWER THAN RATES ARE ON
A ONE MONTH TREASURY NOTE
MEANING THAT.
INVESTORS ARE DEMANDING LAST ON
AN ANALYZED BASIS TO LOCK UP
THEIR MONEY FOR TEN YEARS AND
THEY ARE FOR ONE MONTH BECAUSE
THEY ARE.
PROJECTING THAT RATES WILL BE
LOWER IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL RESERVE MAY HAVE TO CUT
THEM.
IN A RECESSION SO THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE'RE ALL PAYING
VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO AT
FINANCE AND I KNOW TO ROUTE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
THINKING ABOUT THIS THIS MORNING
I WAS REMINDED OF AN OLD SAYING
BY JAMES CARVILLE WHO WAS.
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN MANAGER IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO AND WORKING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE HE SAID AFTER THAT
HE SAID YOU KNOW I ALWAYS
THOUGHT IF THERE WERE
REINCARNATION.
I'D WANT TO COME BACK AS THE
PRESIDENT OR MAYBE A BATTING
AVERAGE OF FOUR HUNDRED HALL OF
FAMER IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES BUT
HE SAID.
NOW SEEING THIS I WANT TO COME
BACK AS THE BOND MARKET BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW YOU REALLY INTIMIDATE
EVERYBODY.
SO I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT TO WATCH VERY
CLOSELY WE'RE NOT -- PROJECTING
A RECESSION BUT WE ARE PLANNING
FOR IT.
THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IS AS A RESULT OF THAT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING A
BUDGET RESILIENCY AND I KNOW WE
ARE HAVINGAN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION TODAY AND OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE DAYS.
ABOUT RESERVES -- BUT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE A RECORD THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION THAT
WE WANT TO BUILD RESERVES WE
WANT TO PAY DOWN UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES AND WE WANT TO GET
RID OF SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
CAME UP OVER THE FROM THE LAST
RECESSION THAT WE ARE STILL
DIGGING OUR WAY.
OUT OF THE ADMINISTRATION
MAINTAINS A VERY FIRM POSITION
ON FINALLY PAYING DOWN THAT WALL
TAX WHICH AT ONE POINT WAS OVER
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS AND THE
DEBTS AND DEFERRALS -- THAT WERE
BEING DISCUSSED ARE PART OF THAT
SO THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
ADMINISTRATION COMMITMENT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT A
REQUISITE AMOUNT NOT JUST INTO
RESERVES BUT INTO PAYING DOWN
OUR UNFUNDED LIABILITIES BECAUSE
THOSE PAYMENTS NOT ONLY HELP US
NEXT YEAR.
BUT IN THE YEAR AFTER THAT AFTER
THAT AND AFTER THAT.
AND MOST OF ALL WE WANT TO PUT A
REAL EMPHASIS ON STRUCTURAL
BALANCE NOT ONLY -- IN ACTING A
BALANCED BUDGET THIS YEAR BUT
ALSO LOOKING OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS AFTER DAYS IN OUR MULTI
YEAR FORECAST MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE MATCHING ON GOING
SPENDING.
WITH ONGOING REVENUES IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE AN OPERATING
SURPLUS IN EVERY YEAR BECAUSE AS
ALL OF US KNOW IF WE END UP
OVERSHOOTING THE MARK AND HAVING
MORE RESERVES AT THE END OF A
GIVEN YEAR OVER THAT MULTI YEAR
PERIOD.
DAN WE EXPECTED WE CAN ALWAYS
SPEND THAT MONEY AT THAT TIME
BUT IF WE END UP HAVING LESS
MONEY AND GO INTO AN OPERATING
TO DEFICIT.
THEN WE'LL BE BACK AT THE TABLE
FIGURING OUT WHICH EXPANSIONS
WILL HAVE TO ROLL BACK.
AND SO ALONG WITH THAT WERE
HOPING THAT ALL MAJOR -- FISCAL
ISSUES THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED
THIS YEAR WILL BE CONSIDERED AS
PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS AND I
KNOW THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A
DISCUSSION AROUND SUNSETS AND
THAT HAS TO DO WITH MAKING SURE
THAT WERE BALANCED AND OUT YEARS
AS WELL.
AND HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THAT AS
PART OF THIS PROCESS AS WELL.
AND THEN THE LAST THING I WANT
TO MENTION VERY BRIEFLY -- WE
WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE THAT BUT
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE USED --
RELIED ON DEAL LESS REVENUES --
TO PUT TOGETHER THEIR BUDGETS
AND WE KNOW THAT SOMETHING THAT
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I ACTUALLY
TAKES PLACE WE KNOW THAT IN A
DEMOCRACY PUTTING TOGETHER A
BUDGET IS A POLITICAL PROCESS AS
IT SHOULD BE.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO REVENUES IN
PROJECTIONS OTHER PROFESSIONALS
AT THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE TAKE
THAT VERY SERIOUSLY AND THOSE
ARE COMPLETED BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR MAKES ANY MAJOR
DECISIONS ABOUT THE BUDGET.
SO WE DO APPRECIATE THAT WE DO
BELIEVE IN ORDER TO REALLY MAKE
THE NUMBERS WORK AND ACHIEVE
STRUCTURAL BALANCE OVER THE LONG
TERM.
WE DO RELY ON A TAX CONFORMITY
PACKAGE TO RAISE REVENUES TO PAY
FOR EXPANDED EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT WE DO THINK THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES -- IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES NOT TO ADOPT
THAT TAX CONFORMITY PACKAGE BUT
TO FUND THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE AT THE LEVEL THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING.
I'M SO HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THOSE DETAILS BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT INCLUDING THE TAX CUT FROM
THE PACKAGE WHAT THE HIGHER
REVENUES THAT RESULTS AND
INCLUDING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE.
IS THE BEST WAY TO GO HERE WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT AN MCO TAX --
BECAUSE THOSE REVENUES ARE NOT
CERTAIN AND RELY ON APPROVAL
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
WANT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE BEST PATH
FORWARD BUT WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THOSE REVENUES.
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED AS PART OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS BECAUSE AS
PART OF THIS PROCESS WE DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE REVENUE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR ARE COMMITTED TO
SPENDING.
IS ACTUALLY REVENUE THAT WE DO
HAVE IN HAND -- AND THEN THE
LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE WHICH
WE CAN TALK ABOUT EITHER TODAY
OR WHEN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES COMES OUT.
I KNOW THERE ARE SOME DIFFERENT
ASSUMPTIONS REGARDING THE GROWTH
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SPENDING OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET THAT RIGHT
BECAUSE IF WE UNDER SHOOT THERE
THERE COULD BE SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT.
WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT AS
WELL AND SO OVERALL YOU KNOW
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND A THE BUDGET
CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING WITH YOU MEMBERS OF YOUR
STAFF -- AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT
BUILDING A STRONG FOUNDATION
WHICH I KNOW SOMETHING WE ALL
AGREE ON REALLY IS THAT PREDATOR
TO EXPANDING PROGRAMS AND MAKING
A BUDGET THAT NOT ONLY WE CAN
STAND BEHIND THIS YEAR.
BUT IN THE YEARS TO COME AND SO
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR.
THANK.
YOU MISTER TING THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEES GREAT GREAT TO HAVE
YOU WE GOT USED TO HAVING A ME
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS SO IT'S
NICE TO HAVE. TO CHANGE IT UP A
LITTLE BIT.
QUICK QUESTIONS ON JUST TO
FOLLOW UP ON MY QUESTION --
TALLY HO WAS REGARDING THE
DECISION TO SUNSET WHAT WE
PERCEIVE AS ONGOING.
PROGRAMS DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES -- JUST
ONE UNDERSTAND WHY.
pTO ASSISTANCE TO BE A LITTLE BIT
DISINGENUOUS TO FUND THE PROGRAM
HOW.
TO HIRE PEOPLE FOR TWO YEARS AND
THEN.
LAY THEM OFF SO I JUST TRY TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT YOUR THINKING WAS AROUND
THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE FOR US WE
WOULD RATHER NOT DO IT IF YOU'RE
GONNA ST?
SUNSET IT IN TWO YEARS THEN WHY
EVEN PUT IT IN THE BUDGET TO
BEGIN WITH.
YEAH SO THAT WAS NOT AN EASY
DECISION AS PART OF THAT NAY
REVISION WHEN THE GOVERNOR WAS
THINKING THROUGH IT AND
BASICALLY FOR TWO REASONS ONE
MAJORITY KNOWLEDGE DAYS --
TRYING TO CREATE A STRUCTURAL
BALANCE IN THE OUT YEARS SO WE
FELT IF WE DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
TO EXTEND THIS BE ON TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND WE SIMPLY DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY TO DO IT.
THAT I ACCEPT AND ONCE REVENUES
CHANGER THE WHOLE BUDGET
ARCHITECTURE CHANGES IN SOME WAY
WHICH IS A CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING IN
THOSE SPECIFIC AREAS -- AND YOU
KNOW IT CAN BE EASY TO LOOK AT
THIS AND SAY THIS IS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE THIS WAY BUT WE TO
BELIEVE WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTHCARE GENERALLY.
AND DDS MORE SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE RATE STUDY THERE ARE A LOT
OF CHANGES IN A LOT OF REFORM
EFFORTS THAT ARE ON GOING SO WE
BELIEVE BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT'S MORE THAN TWO
YEARS FROM NOW -- THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL OF ADVANCED
AND WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO DELIVER A GREATER
LEVEL OF SERVICE WITH LESS COST.
SUE SO YOU'RE NOT ENVISIONING
THE THE WAY YOUR BUDGET
STRUCTURED YOU'RE HIRING PEOPLE
AND THEN LAY THEM OFF IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S
NOT WHERE YOU'RE.
ENVISIONED.
OVER IN BEIJING AT SUNSET RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT YOU
KNOW ONCE THOSE REFORM EFFORTS
HAVE TAKEN PLACE WHAT THOSE
EFFORTS WILL LOOK LIKE AT THAT
TIME BUT TO DIRECTLY ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION AND IF WE DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY -- WE HAVE TO FIND
ANOTHER WAY TO GET THE MONEY.
SENATE FOR THESE ONGOING
PROGRAMS WHAT ARE YOU THINKING.
ABOUT.
YOU TO YOU'RE TALKING. TO TO TWO
FORMER HEADS OF NONPROFIT SO AS
FORMER HEADS OF NON PROFITS YOU
YOU'RE GIVEN MONEY.
FROM GOVERNMENT YOU HAVE TO HIRE
PEOPLE TO DELIVER THE SERVICE
THAT YOU PROMISED TO GO.
DELIVER.
ANY BE HARD FOR US IN THIS
ECONOMY TO HIRE PEOPLE AND THEN
TELL THEM YOU CAN.
WHEN ARE YOU BUT ONLY
[inaudible] FOR TWO YEARS.
SAID THE ADMINISTRATION'S
POSITION RIGHT NOW IS BEYOND
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE THE ON GOING
REVENUE TO FUND THOSE PROGRAMS
BEYOND THAT DATE.
AT THIS TIME SO WHY ARE THE IN
THE BUDGET WENT UP JUST HAVE
REAL ONE TIME.
EXPENDITURES INSTEAD OF HAVING
THESE THESE TWO THINGS IN THE
BUDGET.
I THINK THE MAIN REASON IS WE
SEE IT WE UNDERSTAND THOSE NEEDS
RIGHT NOW THIS RATE STUDY HAS
BEEN IN THE WORKS FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS -- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
MEDICAID SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
TO INCREASE ACCESS WE WANT TO
INCREASE THOSE FOR PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX FUNDING SOWE ENVISION
THIS AS A BRIDGE WHERE WE ARE
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE RE
GETTING A GREATER LEVEL SERVICE
WHICH AS YOU NOTED.
THERE IS THE DEMAND OUT THERE
WHILE WE WORK TOWARD A SOLUTION
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE ON IT IS A
DIFFICULT TO TO THE CAN ARE YOU
DOING. TO PROVIDING THIS HIGH
LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY TO TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
OUR STATE.
NO IT WAS NOT AN EASY DECISION
TO INCLUDE THE SUNSET AND AS AS
YOU NOTED IT WAS NOT IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET IT IS SIMPLY
BECAUSE OUR REVENUE PICTURE FOR
THE OUT YOUR TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND AGAIN
THIS IS A PROCESS AS MENTIONED
THAT.
WITH IT HAPPENS BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR MAKES ANY DECISIONS
ACTUALLY CAME IN AT ONE POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS LOWER THAN
WE PROJECTED.
AND SO THEY'RE SIMPLY -- GOIG
BACK TO THE PRINCIPLE MATCHING
ON GOING SPENDING WITH ON GOING
REVENUE THERE SIMPLY WASN'T THE
ABILITY TO PUT THAT ON GOING
SPENDING AND BEYOND THAT YEAR.
PROGRAM WHICH WE WHICH WE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT THEN I WHAT
I'M CONFUSED AS TO WHY I WAS
EVEN IN THE BUDGET THAT.
WHY WAS IT WHY THE TWO YEAR
PROCESS BECAUSE WE DO WE DO
THINK THESE ARE IMPORTANT THINGS
TO DO AND SO IN ONE OF THE
THINGS WE ALWAYS DO WHEN THE
GOVERNOR'S AND ALL OF YOU?
MAKING YOUR DECISIONS THERE ARE
A LOT OF PIECES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PUT THEM
TOGETHER AND SO WE FELT WITH
THESE PIECES WHAT'S AT LEAST TRY
TO DO WHAT WE CAN WITH THESE TEN
MORE.
TO REVENUES ARE NOW MORE
TEMPORARY THAN WE THOUGHT THEY
WERE BEFORE EXPAND ACCESS NOW
AND HOPE WE CAN WORK TOWARD SOME
SOLUTION AND THAT'S WISHING TO
TAKE A NUMBER OF FORMS AT OUR
COMBINATION A COULD TAKE SOME
REFORM.
THERE COULD BE NEW REVENUES
EITHER IN THE LEGISLATURE THERE
CONTINUE REVENUES ON THE BALLOT
THEIR NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
COULD CHANGE BETWEEN NOW.
AND THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE'RE CERTAINLY HOPEFUL THAT THE
REVENUE PICTURE COULD IMPROVE
YOU KNOW I KNOW WE'RE ALL
TALKING ABOUT DOOM AND GLOOM UP
HERE WITH THE INVERTED YIELD
CURVE BUT A NUMBER OF THINGS
COULD HAPPEN SO.
IF THERE IS A WAY TO ENGAGE IN
THOSE REFORM EFFORTS AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE AN EQUAL OR
EVEN GREATER LEVEL OF SERVICE TO
PEOPLE WE DO WANT TO FIND A WAY
TO TO THAT.
BUT LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS THEY-AMOUNT OF ONE TIME VERSUS I'M
GOING SPENDING THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW WE SIMPLY WERE NOT
ABLE TO BEEN PUTTING TOGETHER AN
HONEST BUDGET THAT WE COULD
PRESENT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
EXTEND THOSE PROGRAMS BEYOND AND
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
TO QUESTION ON MCO TAX THAT THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT BOTH THE THE
SENATE VERSION IN THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION INCLUDING -- JUST WANT
TO GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHY THAT WAS INCLUDED.
I THINK I'LL SPEAK FOR OUR HOUSE
WE THOUGHT IT WAS A PRETTY
REASONABLE PROPOSAL TO PUT IN
SPECIALLY SENSE -- MANY OF US.
WHO HAVE BEEN HERE ACTUALLY
VOTED TO SUPPORT THAT?
TAX WITH INDUSTRY SUPPORT ALSO
GIVEN THE THE GOVERNOR'S HIGH
PRIORITY REGARDING HEALTH CARE
SMOKER.
OF SMART WAY TO FIND SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT HEALTHCARE PROPOSALS
HE WAS PUTTING FORWARD SO JUST
WANNA.
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING WHY
DOT TOSSING LIKE THE EASIEST OF
ALL THE DIFFERENT TAX PROPOSALS
PUT FORWARD.
THIS IS JUST ONE UNDERSTAND WHY
THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED IN YOUR
BUDGET.
YEAH SO THE MAIN REASON WE WE
PUT TOGETHER BUDGET THAT FUNDED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S KEEP
PROPOSALS WITHOUT READ THAT
REVENUE WE DO WANT TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON GETTING THAT
PACKAGE PASSED AND HOPEFULLY
GETTING FEDERAL APPROVAL BUT
IT'S SIMPLY NOT GUARANTEED AND
YOU KNOW IF THERE IS. ONE THING
HARDER THAN PREDICTING WHETHER
RECESSION WILL HAPPEN IT'S
PREDICTING WHAT'S GOING TO COME
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE ON ANY
GIVEN DAY.
SO I THINK WE FELT THAT LET'S
GET TO THE BUDGET WHERE WE KNOW
BASED ON OUR PROJECTIONS THAT
THESE REVENUES TO DATE THE BEST
CHANCE OF COMING IN.
AND THEN HEN IT COMES TO AN MCO
PACKAGE WERE APPROVAL IS
UNCERTAIN WE CAN WORK ON
CRAFTING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
FROM THE LAST TIME OF THIS GO
AROUND.
THESE MTO TAX PACKAGES ARE VERY
COMPLICATED I EVEN GOVERNOR
BROWN WHO HAS SOME EXPERIENCE IN
SACRAMENTO CLAIMS HE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT HIMSELF SO WE
REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH YOU TO
GET THE PARAMETERS EXACTLY RIGHT.
SO THAT WE MAXIMIZE THE CHANCE
OF APPROVAL IN DC AND WE KNOW
THAT THEY APPROVED A TAX IN OHIO
AND MOST RECENTLY IN MICHIGAN --
BUT WE JUST WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN GIVE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT'S GOING ON
THAT NEEDS NO EXPLANATION TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT WE ARE IN THE STRONGEST
POSSIBLE POSITION AND AS PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION -- GOVERNOR
WANTS TO WORK WITH MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO
ALLOCATE THOSE REVENUES -- BUT
WITH WE TO PUT IT IN THE BUDGET
PACKAGE AND FOR WHATEVER REASON
THOSE REVENUES DON'T COME
THROUGH IN THE WAY THAT WE INTO
ANTICIPATE.
AND WE HAD A NINE OR TEN SPEAKER
HOLE IN OUR BUDGET THAT WILL
HAVE TO PLUG LATER. TO TRULY%
APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT AND I
THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT I
THINK SOMEONE SHAMELESSLY WAS
QUOTED THAT HEALTHCARE IS
COMPLICATED.
SO I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON
THAT -- HAVE THE SAID THAT THIS
IS THIS IS A PROPOSAL THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE SOMEWHAT
ADMINISTRATION GLAD.
I KNOW THAT WHEN WE HAD REACHED
OUT TO THE MINISTRATION IN
JANUARY -- FOR ASSISTANCE IN
PARTICULAR FROM DH CS -- WE'RE
WERE UNABLE TO GET ASSISTANCE.
SO WE WOULD REALLY HOPE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT -- THAT
DEPARTMENT PARTICULAR COULD WORK
WITH US ON THAT THERE SEEM TO BE
SIGNIFICANT MATTER RETICENCE TO
ACTUALLY ENGAGE WITH WASHINGTON.
YOU KNOW IN IN THIS IN THIS LINE
OF WORK IF YOU DON'T ASK YOU
DON'T GET AND UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T ASK -- WE'RE
NOT GETTING AND THEN THE OTHER
PIECE OF IT IS HIS YEAH I I
THINK THERE DEFINITELY IS A WAY.
TO AGAIN -- PROPOSAL ATTACKS BUT
THAT ALSO WE COULD SET ASIDE ALL
THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS THAT WE
WERE FUNDING SO THAT IF WE CAN.
THEY DIDN'T COME TO FRUITION
THEY WOULD JUST END UP IN
RESERVE WHICH WOULD SEEM TO BE
FISCALLY PRUDENT WAY TO TACKLE
ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU THANK.
BEFORE I MOVE ON TO THIRTY
NIELSEN JUST KIND OF FOLLOW UP
ON SITTING FLASHPOINT -- I'M
ASSUMING THAT THERE ARE OTHER
WAIVERS THAT THAT -- VERTICALLY
IN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AREA THAT ARE.
AWAITING RESPONSE OR ARE IN THE
PIPELINE TO AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL IS AT OKAY NINE
TWO IN PARTICULAR AND THESE ARE
COMING UP IN THE UP COMING YEAR
THERE'S AN ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER
FOR OVERALL.
AND THEN IN NINETEEN FIFTEEN BE
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SO --
FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR COMMENTS
AROUND THE CONCERN ON THE NCL
TAX AND AND AND OUR SUCCESS RATE
WITH THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
DO YOU HAVE ANY CONCERNS ABOUT
THOSE.
TWO IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
WE'RE WATCHING VERY CLOSELY YES
OKAY ALL RIGHT SENATOR NELSON.
YOU MENTIONED THE A BIT AGO
ABOUT EXPANDING ACCESS AND USE
TEAM THE GOVERNOR SEEMS TO BE.
SENSITIVE TO THAT X. EXPANDED
ACCESS IN SOME AREAS.
AND THAT WOULD CARRY OVER I
TRUST.
TO POLICY BILLS THAT ARE MOVING
ALONG TO THERE ARE SOME THAT
WOULD BE THE CREATING VERY HUGE
FUTURE OBLIGATIONS.
ALL I WOULD SAY IS I COMMEND
YOUR SENSITIVITY TO THAT AS YOU
EXPAND ACCESS IN YOUR BUILDING
THE BASE FOR THE FUTURE AGAIN
THAT'S A QUESTION.
ABOUT MOVING AHEAD IN THE FUTURE.
AND THE SAME WOULD HOLD TRUE TO
WATCH WE JUST HAD A LITTLE BIT
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT.
PERSONNEL YEARSAND BEING
TEMPORARY OR LONG TERM POSITIONS.
IT'S LONG BEEN A DEFLECTION IN
OUR BUDGET.
THE AGENCIES -- WELL THEY GET
HUNGRY FOR MORE PERSONNEL.
AND THEIR ANSWER TO EVERY
PROBLEM IS MORE P. WEISS -- IT
ANOTHER AREA THAT DOES REQUIRE I
BELIEVE ATTENTION.
AND WITHIN THAT CONTEXT ANOTHER
AREA THAT WE'VE LET GET OUT OF
CONTROL IT IS NOT BEEN A BUDGET
BUSTER BUT IT'S CERTAINLY BEEN A
BUDGET PRESSURE.
IS ALLOWING ACCRUED ANNUAL LEAVE.
THAT IS CASHED OUT.
THE BEEN ATTEMPTS.
TO THE DOPE CURTAIL THAT A BET.
ON THE PAST BUT ALL OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL -- THIS IS
AGAIN JUST A PRECAUTION AS WE
BUILD OUR BUDGET AND AS WE'VE
EVEN HAD THESE VERY DIFFICULT
TIMES IN CALIFORNIA DOWN VERY
MUCH.
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IS AN
EXAMPLE.
SO WE DO HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS IN
THESE P. WEISS INCREMENTALLY
THEY CAN BE COME BIG PROBLEMS
DOWN THE WAY.
AND SENATOR MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER IS
ONE OF THEM -- IT'S MAY
THIRTIETH AND AND WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED THE COMPREHENSIVE
ANNUAL FINANCIAL REPORT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THE
CONTROLLER IS BEEN BLAMING IT ON
FISCALE -- BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS
TO YOU AND YOU HAVE A
COMFORTABLE MISS SIR -- ARE YOU
ARE YOU CONFIDENT A WATER
BALANCE SHEET IS GONNA LOOK LIKE
IN.
WHEN WE RECEIVE IT BEFORE WE
APPROVE A BUDGET?
SO I SHE DIED WILL NEED TO CHECK
BACK WITH -- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
FOLKS IN OUR DEPARTMENT WHO BOTH
WORK ON FACE CAL AND ARE IN VERY
CLOSE TOUCH WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE SO.
THAT SOMETHING THAT -- WILL MAKE
SURE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON A IN
TERMS OF THE STATE'S OVERALL
FINANCIAL POSITION AS THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S MENTIONED.
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- WE'RE PRETTY
CONFIDENT IN THE NUMBERS THAT WE
PUT OUT IN TERMS OF ARE
PROJECTED REVENUES TERMS OF OUR
RESERVES WHERE WE THINK THE
RAINY DAY FUND WILL BE.
AND ARE BROAD ESTIMATE OF SOME
OF OUR UNFUNDED LIABILITIES AND
I KNOW THE COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT GIVES A MORE
PRECISE AND SPECIFIC ESTIMATE OF
THOSE -- IN SOME CASES AS OF
JUNE OF LAST YEAR -- BUT I'M
HAPPY TO CHECK BACK ON THAT AND
SEE WHAT THE LATEST IS -- AND OF
COURSE THAT IS SOMETHING
ULTIMATELY THAT IS UP TO THE
STATE COMPTROLLER BUT OUR FOLKS
ARE IN VERY CLOSE TOUCH WITH
THEM.
A GOOD BECAUSE I'D LIKE YOU TO
FEEL CONFIDENT -- THE CAP FOR
FOR LAST YEAR HAD AN
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
BILLION.
AND IF WE ADD TO THAT -- EIGHTY
SIX TO NINETY ONE BILLION IN
UNFUNDED RETIREE MEDICAL WE'RE
GETTING CLOSE TO A QUARTER
TRILLION.
DOLLARS SO IT'S KIND OF ONE
THING TO TALK ABOUT A SURPLUS OF
TWENTY ONE AND A HALF BILLION
BUT WE LOOK AT THE BALANCE SHEET
IT'S LIKE.
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A LONG WAYS
TO GO SO ARE YOU.
FEELING COMFORTABLE THAT WERE
ADDRESSING THE RETIREE MEDICAL
AN INADEQUATE [inaudible]
FASHION.
SO YES THE STATE DOES HAVE ABOUT
PLANS TO PAY DOWN ALL THOSE
LIABILITIES ON THE LONG TERM OF
COURSE.
ALL YOU CAN DO IS STAY AS CLOSE
TO THAT PLAN AS POSSIBLE YEAR TO
YEAR AND WHEN YOU DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO.
EVEN MORE WHEN THE PLAN CALLS
FOR BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW AS A CPA
THESE DISCOUNT RATES THE ACTUAL
RATE OF RETURN CAN FLCTUATE
OVER TIME.
SO WHEN YOU DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE THAN
EIGHTY GIVES YOU TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY PUT IN
MORE AND SO THAT'S WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES SO
SPECIFICALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR THREE BILLION DOLLAR PAYMENT
TO CALPERS.
AND ALSO TO CAL STIRS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE PAYMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
BUT THEY'RE ALSO PAYMENTS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO MAKE.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BECAUSE
THE STATE PORTION OF THE CAL
STIRS LIABILITY IS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF THIRTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF UNFUNDED
LIABILITY.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS A PROPOSITION
TWO PAYMENTS IN THIS BUDGET PLUS
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE OUT YEARS
AND I BELIEVE THAT ONE POINT ONE
BILLION IN.
THE BUDGET YEAR IS ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT IS IN CONFERENCE --
FOR THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AND
WE BELIEVE THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW WE STILL HAVE
MANY YEARS AGO AS WE CHIP AWAY
AT THAT UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
BUT WE DO THINK THAT STEPS LIKE
THIS AND I KNOW THAT MEMBERS OF
THE ABOUT A ASSEMBLY IN THE
SENATE OPPOSE STEPS OF THEIR OWN
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE
[inaudible]
MR PEDICAB.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY GET THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE WE USED TO GET
OUR CAP FOR OUT BY THE END OF
DECEMBER -- IT WITH THE JUNIOR
RENDON HERE WE ARE ALMOST IN THE
JUNE.
IN OUR FISCAL YEAR ENDS JUNE
THIRTY SIDE IT HAS AT HAVE YOU
HAD ANY CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STATE CONTROLLER AND GETTING ARE
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
[inaudible]
COMPLETED IN.
SENATOR YOU HAVE YOU DONE ANY
ANALYSIS OF PITCH CAL AT ALL
THAT.
WE HAVE A AN ANALYST THAT IS
COVERING FISCALE AND WE DO.
HAVE SOME WE HAVE RECEIVED SOME
INFORMATION FROM THE STATE
COMPTROLLER THAT IT IS RELATED
TO THE FITZCO -- PROBLEM
PROBLEMS THAT THE BEEN HAVING
WITH THAT SO -- IT'S AN IT'S
ANOTHER ITEM THAT YOU KNOW WE
CAN CONTINUE TO LOOK INTO AS
WELL.
YEAH I GUESS MA'AM CHARM JUST
THE ONE I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE AS CENTERS WORKING REALLY
HARD ON THEBUDGET WE DON'T GET
SURPRISED WITH SOME NUMBERS.
AFTER WE FINISH THE BUDGET WHEN
WE SEE THE BALLOT SHE CAN GO.
WHY WHY WEREN'T WE NOTIFIED SO?
IF YOU'RE COMFORTABLE THEN WE
SHOULD BE COMFORTABLE BUT IF
THERE'S SOMETHING OUT THERE
THAT'S I WANT TO SAY BEING
HIDDEN BUT WE JUST DON'T WANT
SURPRISES RIGHT SO IF YOU COULD
HELP IN THAT REGARD I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
MR OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I'D
LIKE TO ECHO.
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY MR
TANG MY BIGGEST FRUSTRATIN WITH
THEADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET WAS
THE CHARACTERIZATION.
OF MANY OF THE EXPENDITURES AS
ONE TIME WHEN THEY WERE CLEARLY
ONGOING.
AND I JUST THINK DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S A TRANSPARENT WAY OF
APPROACHING.
BUDGETING A MISTER TING ASK YOU
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROGRAMMATIC
ELEMENTS THAT COULD BE
CHARACTERIZED THAT WAY.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO ASK SOME OF THE
NONPROFIT PROGRAMMATIC ONES FOR
EXAMPLE.
OF THE ELIMINATION OF SALES TAX
ON FEMININE HYGIENE PRODUCTS AND
DIAPERS I USED TO QUé BUT A
SUNSET ON THAT.
NOW THERE'S A SUNSET ON H. OR
SAYS READ PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES.
I DON'T THINK EITHER OF THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE LIKELY IN
TWO YEARS TO BE ROLLED BACK SO I
WONDER IF YOU COULD TALK ABOUT
WHY YOU CHARACTERIZE THOSE AS
ONE TIME INSTEAD OF ON GOING.
SO FOR THE AYE HSS -- THAT
SIMILAR TO SOME THE OTHER
PROGRAMS TALKED ABOUT WITH MR
TANKS AND A WE HAD THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THE
FISCAL SITUATION WILL LOOK LIKE
IN TWO YEARS AND WHETHER THERE
WILL BE.
ANY SORTS OF REFORM EFFORTS IN
THIS AREA BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WHEN IT COMES TO SPECIFICALLY
THE FEMININE HYGIENE PRODUCTS
AND A DIAPER AT SALES TAX
EXEMPTION.
THESE ARE NEW MEMBER NEW
MEASURES UP PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR SO -- NUMBER ONE AND WE
WILL ASSESS THE IMPACT OVER THE
UPCOMING YEARS BUT NUMBER TWO WE
SELL TO THAT IF WE ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE ADD TO THE
DISCUSSION WE WERE HAVING.
A MEASURES THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
INCLUDING MEMBER THE
ADMINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR ARE
BEING SUNSET AID DâN AT NEW
MEASURES THAT WE'RE PROPOSING BY.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
HAVE THE ON GOING BROKE MAN
BECAUSE GIVEN THE UPDATED MULTI
YOUR FORECAST -- UNDER OUR
PROJECTIONS WE WEREN'T CONFIDENT
THAT WE HAD THE ROOM TO INCLUDE
THOSE AS WELL WE THOUGHT LET'S
DO IT FOR TWO YEARS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT POLICY SOMETHING
OFFICE CARE ABOUT.
BUT WE CAN REVISIT IT AT THAT
TIME IN THAT BUDGET CYCLE.
OKAY WELL I MEAN I I THINK THAT.
OUR ASSESSMENT OF THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THOSE WILL BE ROLLED BACK
IN FUTURE LEADER YEARS IS VERY
LOW.
WHO MAYBE A LITTLE POLITICAL
FEASIBILITY?
I WOULD BE A GOOD WAY OF
CHARACTERIZING THAT SO.
I THINK IT'S MORE ON IS JUST TO
SAY THIS IS THIS IS AN ONGOING
EXPENSES NOT A ONE TIME EXPENSE
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
MEANS THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS IN.
FUTURE YEARS TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR BALANCE OUR BUDGET CONTINUES
TO BE BALANCED I THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
DO SO SOUNDS LIKE WE HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK THAT OUT
AS OUR HEARINGS OR CONTINUE.
THANK YOU I WOULD JUST ADD TO
THAT -- EACH IN TERMS OF THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF A PROGRAM TO
SUNSET SOME OF THE MEDI CAL
OPTIONAL BENEFITS.
THAT WE'VE TRIED FOR A COUPLE
YEARS NOW TO GET KIND OF BACK IN
THE MIX ONE OF THEM IS OPTICAL --
AND I SHARE THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY MY COLLEAGUES THAT
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE THAT.
IF WE'RE GOING TO START TO
PROVIDE OPTICAL THAT I WOULD NOT
WANT TO BE A SITTING MEMBER OF
THIS LEGISLATURE WILL WE STOP IT
AGAIN.
IT'S SO DEEPLY OFFENSIVE TO ME
THAT WE COVER OPTOMETRY WE TELL
YOU YOU NEED GLASSES AND THE WE
WON'T GIVE YOU THE ACTUAL.
CORRECTIVE -- TOOL SO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
I ANYTHING EITHER OF YOU TO MORE
LIKE TO JUST KIND OF A CLOSE IS
A WRAP UP.
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOU COMING FORWARD
TODAY THANK YOU.
WITH THEIR COLLEAGUES WE WILL BE
AGAIN.
IT'S LIKE THE FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL WE HAVE OUR NEW.
SPIRAL BOUND NOTEBOOK.
IT'S ALL PRISTINE CLEAN PAGES
AND THAT WON'T LAST LONG
[inaudible]
YEAH.
PAGE ONE OF THE AGENDA.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH.
CHILD CARE AND PRE K. THROUGH.
TWELVE ITEM.
SIXTY ONE HUNDRED STARTING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
CHILD CARE ACCESS.
GOOD MORNING SERRA CORTEZ AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WILL BEGIN WITH A OVERVIEW OF
EARLY EDUCATION ISSUES THAT YOU
HAVE IN YOUR BINDERS TODAY --
BUT I'LL JUST PROVIDE SOME
HELPFUL CONTACTS FOR ISSUES OF
ONE THROUGH.
NINE SO ON PAGE ONE OF THIS
HANDOUT -- THE BILL NUMBER SHOW
ALL THREE PLANS TOTAL SPENDING
FOR EARLY EDUCATION.
ALL THREE PLANS HAVE AROUND SIX
BILLION AT THIS TABLE ALSO SHOWS
THE ONGOING DIFFERENCES AND
ONGOING INCREASES AND ONE TIME
INCREASE SPLIT.
ON PAGE TWO OF THE HANDOUT IS
JUST FOR YOUR BACKGROUND SOME
HELPFUL CONTACTS ON SOME --
OVERVIEW INFORMATION ON CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS.
A PAGE THREE YEARS SOME KEY
ASPECTS ON THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONSIDER -- SLOW INCREASES TODAY --
SO KEEP A KEY ASPECTS OF THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM JUST
FOR BACKGROUND IS THE STATE
CONTRACTS WITH ET AGENCIES TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM.
AND FAMILIES RECEIVE A VOUCHER
THEY CAN REDEEM IN ANY SETTING
THAT MEETS THE NEEDS -- THAT
MEETS OUR CHILD CARE NEEDS.
ON AND WITH REGARD TO GENERAL
CHILD CARE TO KEEP HIS OF
INFORMATION IS THAT THE STATE
AWARDS CONTRACTS DIRECTLY TO
PROVIDERS.
AND THEN FAMILIES WOULD GO TO A
LICENSE SETTING WHERE THERE'S A
SLOT AVAILABLE THE LAST THING
Là HIGHLY ON THIS PAGE IS THAT --
THE RATES FOR THESE TWO PROGRAMS
OF THE USE DIFFERENT RATE
STRUCTURES.
ON PAGE FOUR IS ALSO SOME
BACKGROUND INFORMATION FOR THE
PROGRAMS WILL CONSIDERING THESE
ISSUES OF MULES CONSIDERING
THESE ISSUES.
AND THEN PAGE FIVE IS WHERE --
WE GET TO SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE DIFFERENCES IN THE PLANS
HERE.
SO WITH REGARD TO CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL SLOTS ALL PLANS ADDS
SLOTS IN THE NINETEEN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY THE GOVERNOR
PROVIDES A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE MILLION.
OFFER A PEACE LOTS THE SENATE --
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
MILLION AND THE ASSEMBLY TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT MILLION.
OF BOTH HOUSES PROVIDE A CHEN
ADDITIONAL GENERAL CHILDCARE
SLOTS THE GOVERNOR DOES IT
PROVIDES LOTS FOR THIS FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
THE SENATE INCLUDES SEVEN
MILLION -- GROWING TO TWENTY
NINE MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY INCLUDES A
HUNDRED MILLION.
IN ALL PLANNED OUT STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS ON THIRTY ONE
MILLION FOR TEN THOUSAND STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS.
PAGE SIX PROVIDES RICH CHILD
CARE A SOME REIMBURSEMENT RATE
AUGMENTATIONS PROVIDEDBY BOTH
HOUSES OF BOTH HOUSES -- ISSUE
WILL HERE LATER TODAY IS THAT
THE SENATE PROVIDES A HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE ASUS PROGRAM WAS
ASSEMBLY PROVIDESEIGHTY MILLION --
FOR AT FOR THE ACES A FUNDING
INCREASE ASUS RATES.
THERE'S ALSO THE AN INCREASE IN --
IN THE VOUCHER PROGRAM RATE FOR
A LACE FOR CERTAIN LICENSING
EXAM PROVIDERS -- AND TEN THE
ASSEMBLY PROVIDES FORTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE FIRST
AUGMENTATION OF A MULTI YEAR
PLAN.
AND THE SENATE ALSO.
THIS IS THE SENATE PROVIDE SIX
MILLION TO PROVIDE SPECIAL NEEDS
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR FOR PARTY
STATE PRESCHOOL.
I'M PAGE SEVEN SHOWS THE MAJOR
ONGOING AUGMENTATIONS -- TWO
THINGS THE HIGHLIGHT WOULD BE
CAL WORKS STAGE ONE CHILD CARE
THERE'S DIFFERENT FUNDING
AMOUNTS AND DIFFERENT POLICIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE AMOUNTS.
AND THEN -- THERE'S MAJOR ONE
TIME FUNDING PROPOSALS THE MAIN
ONE IS WITH REGARDS TO
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS -- IN PAGE
EIGHT AND NINE IS JUST A SUMMARY
TABLE FOR A YOUR RESOURCE.
I'M SO THIS CONCLUDES THE
OVERVIEW OF THE EARLY EDUCATION
BUDGET AND WITH THAT I'M WOULD
HAPPY TO GO INTO ISSUE ONE AND
MORE THOROUGHLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND START WITH
ISSUE ONE I'M SORRY THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE OVERVIEW BEFORE
WE START WITH ISSUE.
ONE SENATOR MORE LOCK -- YOU
DON'T DEFINE WHAT SLOTS MEANS SO
I'M JUST WONDERING IF.
SOMEONE'S WATCHING.
WHO COULD JUST THREW IN A SAID
WE'RE NOT USING DOLLAR AMOUNTS
COULD SO MAYBE YOU COULD JUST?
FOR THE PUBLIC EXPLAIN WHAT IS
SLOT.
YEP SO FOR PURPOSES OF BUDGETING
WE CAN THINK OF A SLOT AS
FUNDING AN ADDITIONAL CHILD TO
BE SERVED -- IN ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
AT THE CHAIR.
THE TWO JUST OF A PERSON. FOR A
KID SPACE FOR CHILD AT SPACE
[inaudible]
I'M JUST.
OKAY THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
OVERVIEW BEFORE WE GET SPECIFIC.
WE'LL GO HERE WITH ISSUE ONE
CHILD CARE ACCESS.
GREAT SO IN ISSUE -- ONE SO WE
DIDN'T PROVIDE SOME OF THE SITE
INFORMATION ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
HAND OUT SO THE MAIN DECISION
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS HOW MANY
ADDITIONAL SLOTS TO PROVIDE FOR
EACH PROGRAM IN THE AND THIS IS
THE AP PROGRAM AND THE GENERAL
CHILD CARE PROGRAM.
SO THERE IS A DEMAND FOR SLOTS --
AS A NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE FAMILIES
FAR EXCEEDS THE NUMBER OF
CURRENTLY FUNDED SLOTS.
IF THE COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED
IN PROVIDING FAMILIES WITH THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF CHOICE IN
SELECTING CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
THEN YOU MAY WANT TO PRIORITIZE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT SLOTS.
IF THE COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED
IN IMMEDIATELY INCREASING ACCESS
TO CHILDCARE SLOTS AND YOU MAY
ALSO WANT TO FIND MORE HP SLOTS --
IT WOULD TAKE AT LEAST SIX
MONTHS TO RAMP UP GENERAL
CHILDCARE SLOTS DUE TO THE STATE
CONTRACTING PROCESS.
ON THE OTHER HAND IF THE
COMMITTEE PREFERS THAT INCREASE
LOTS BE USE FOR CENTER BASED
CARE WITH HIGHER DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS IN MAY WANT TO
PRIORITIZE GENERAL CHILDCARE
SLOTS.
IF THE COMMITTEES INTERESTED IN
TARGETING A SPECIFIC AGE GROUPS
SUCH AS INFANTS -- YOU MAY ALSO
WANT TO PRIORITIZE GENERAL
CHILDCARE SLOTS AS A P. AND
GENERAL CHILDCARE PROGRAMS BOTH
SERVE IN FANS BUT THE STATE HAS
A LITTLE MORE ABILITY TO
PRIORITIZE BY AGE GROUP IN THE
GENERAL CHAIR OCCUR THE GENERAL%
CHILD CARE PROGRAM BECAUSE OF
THE CONTRACTING PROCESS.
THE MORE LOT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF I COULD
ASK FOR ANOTHER CLEAR VACATION
OF COURSE -- SO REPORT WE WE
HAVE SLOTS WE HAVE PROP. SIXTY
FOUR WHICH IS [inaudible]
MARIJUANA SO.
SO YEAH WE ARE A PART FOR SLIDES
AND I'M TRYING.
TRYING.
TRYING TO FIGURE.
THE NEXUS.
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE HAD A
LOT OF FUN WITH.
GOVERNOR BROWN AND HOW WE USE
PROP.
SIXTY FOUR FOR IN A LOT OF
ISSUES TRYING TO GET HOUSING AND
INTERNSHIPS FOR DOCTORS INSERT
CENTER SO.
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE?
GET THESE.
TOGETHER I DO YOU HAVE A LEGAL
OPINION OR ARE THE AUTHORS OF
PROP SIXTY FOUR FINE WITH THIS
OR WAS THAT PART OF THE
INTENTION OF THE BALLOT MEASURE.
SO I CAN SPEAK BRIEFLY TO THAT
AND IF WE NEED TO FOLLOW UP
AFTER WERE HAPPY TO DO THAT BUT
FOR THIS BUT THEY'RE DIFFERENT
TIERS FOR PROPS IT PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR IN TERMS OF WHAT
NEEDS TO BE FUNDED.
AND SO THIS YEAR WE HAD ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS --
GIVE OR TAKE IN THIS POCKET FOR
YOUTH EDUCATION AND PREVENTION
EFFORTS -- AND THEN THE
ADMINISTRATION UNDER THE
INITIATIVE HAS DISCRETION AS
LONG AS IT IS ONLINE WITH THAT
INTENT THAT THESE EFFORTS ARE
FOR YOU KNOW EDUCATION AND
PREVENTION OF DRUG ABUSE -- FOR
USE SO WE'RE PROPOSING THAT
ABOUT 75% OF THAT OR ABOUT 80% --
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS TO GO TO
WORD THE SLOTS AND THIS WE
ANTICIPATE WILL BE AN EXPANDING
FUNDING SOURCE OVER TIME AS
REVENUES INCREASED.
AND TO CLARIFY YOUR PROPOSAL THE
USES.
POTS LOTS FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN.
IN THAT BRIGHT.
JUST GO HOME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE KNOWN I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE CONFUSION ON THAT OURS ARE
PROPOSAL WOULD FIND AT EIGHTY
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SLOT.
OKAY.
GO AHEAD WITH THE MORE LIKE I'M
SORRY AND AND AND AND SO AREN'T
REAL THAT THE ISSUE WHEN IT IS
CHILD CARE ACCESS SO I EIGHTY
MILLION [inaudible]
DOLLARS.
I'M STILL TRYING TO GET THE
NEXUS ARE WE WERE NOT SERIOUS
ABOUT TEACHING [inaudible]
TODDLERS [inaudible]
ABOUT.
EDUCATION ON HOW TO USE OR NOT
USE CERTAIN.
I KNOW SENATOR FOR THIS MONEY WE
ARE PROPOSING THAT THAT THESE
ARE FUNDING SLOTS WITH THE
BELIEF THAT WHEN WE PUT AN
EMPHASIS ON THESE TYPES ON THIS
TYPE OF CHILD CARE BEING OF IT
I'M SORRY THESE TEXAS WHAT'S
BEING AVAILABLE.
AND THAT WILL REDUCE -- DRUG
ABUSE IN THE FUTURE AND THAT'S
THE ONE THE INTENTIONS OF THE
PROPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE A SCIENTIFIC STUDY.
FOR SOMETHING THAT.
PROVIDES THE NEXUS OR OR OR IS
THIS A STRETCH AND TO HELP ME
OUT I SO THE LANGUAGE INCLUDED
IN PROP SIXTY FOUR AND FIVE
CALLS OUT SPECIFIC AND GENERAL
THINGS THAT THE MONEY SHOULD BE
SPENT ON INCLUDING THINGS LIKE
SCHOOL RETENTION.
AND SO WE'RE PUTTING OUT THE
SLIDES AND A LOT OF THESE TALKS
ARE GONNA GO TO AMUSE ZERO
THROUGH ALWAYS ZERO THREE
THIRTEEN AND CAN BE USED FOR
THINGS LIKE AFTER SCHOOL AND
SUMMER TIME FUNDING -- AND
PROVIDING EVEN OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN -- ACCESS TO STABLE
CARE THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO IT
THAT IS DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
AND TO HAVE THAT STABILITY
MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MR MCCARTY FOLLOWED BY MR
OBERNOLTE JUST A QUICK QUESTION
IN IN FOLLOWING UP ON MISTER
MORLOCKS POINT -- FOR IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S UNCLEAR
BASED ON THE PROPOSITION WHETHER
OR NOT THESE FUNDS -- MAY BE
PROGRAM TO THE BUDGET PROCESS --
DO YOU.
DO YOU HAVE AN OPINION OR FEEL
DIFFERENTLY.
SO THE PROP SIXTY FOUR FUNDS
CITY ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF THERE'S A
LOT OF DETAIL ON THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE OF PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR IN TERMS OF WHAT HAPPENS
NOW.
IT HAPPENS A DECADE OR SO DOWN
THE ROAD BUT RIGHT NOW -- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTERPRETATION
OF THE PROPOSITION IS THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROGRAM BE
SPECIFIC FUNDS -- SO LONG AS IT
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE PROPOSITION AS WE WERE
DISCUSSING.
THOUGHT MOVEMENT IN THIS INTO
THE TABLES WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM THE LA -- AS WELL HI HOW
INTERESTING AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
SOME LACK OF CLARITY ON EXACTLY
HOW MUCH THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DIRECT THESE TO THE FUNDS.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF REASONS
WHY THAT MIGHT BE THE CASE ONE
IS THAT THE FUNDS ARE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED TO
CERTAIN DEPARTMENTS THERE'S ALSO
SOME LANGUAGE IN THE MEASURE
THAT -- THAT THAT -- LMITS THE
AUTHORITY POTENTIALLY -- OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADJUST
ALLOCATIONS TO PROGRAMS -- UP
THROUGH THE NEXT ABOUT ROUGHLY
ALMOST TEN YEARS -- AND EXACTLY
WHAT THAT MEANS I THINK THERE'S
A LACK OF CLARITY SO WHAT IS AN
ALLOCATION TO A PROGRAM IS THAT
HAVE SPECIFIC IS THAT -- AND I
THINK THAT'S PART OF WHERE
pLEGAL GRAY AREA SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CERTAINLY -- CONCERT TO
CONSULT WITH COUNSEL ON IF
THEY'RE FURTHER QUESTIONS BUT I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WHERE THERE'S
POTENTIALLY SOME LEGAL
UNCERTAINTY THAT'S VERY
DIFFERENT FROM OUR EXPERIENCE
WITH PROP TEN FOR EXAMPLE
ANOTHER IS THAT THAT WE WERE
VERY CLEAR THAT WE HAD --
APPROPRIATIONS AUTHORITY.
YEAH I THINK THERE'S LESS
CLARITY HERE THAN IN IN SOME
OTHER AREAS BECAUSE OF THAT BUT
CERTAINLY IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE AND WE THINK THERE'S A
STRONG ROLE FOR OVERSIGHT.
AND CERTAINLY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THESE ALLOCATIONS
REGARDLESS.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY.
THANK YOU I I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF PIECES HERE RIGHT PEOPLE
WITH THE AFTER SCHOOL PIECE --
AND I GUESS THE BIG PICTURE IS
THAT THE JANUARY BUDGET DIDN'T
FOCUS ON CHILD CARE SO MUCH HAD
PRESCHOOL ACCESS AND SO.
PLEASE AT THE MAY REVISE IN THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY ALL
PRIORITIZE INCREASING CHILD CARE
ACCESS SO THAT'S A BIG POSITIVE
AND IT'S AN FOR SAID THEY WERE
KIND OF PITTING AFTER SCHOOL
VERSES.
CHILD CARE BUT I THINK THE FIRST
THING IS THAT I WANT TO CLARIFY
APPROACH TO ADDRESS TO TO SUMMER
MITCHELL SO THE FIRST PRPOSAL.
IT WAS BROUGHT AS FAR AS WHAT
THE SIXTY SIXTY FOUR MONTHS AGO
TO AND THEN YOU CLARIFY THAT
WOULD GO.
TO THAT THE VOUCHER PROGRAM AND
YOU'RE SAYING ZERO THREE
THIRTEEN BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
MOST KIDS.
MOST MOST MOST THE VOUCHER
PROGRAM THE DOCTOR PROGRAM WOULD
GO [inaudible]
TO YOUNGER KIDS. ZERO THREE FIVE
RIGHT.
THAT IS NOT A THAT IS NOT
CORRECT FOR ALL OF OUR VOUCHER
PROGRAM SO IT REALLY DEPENDS
UPON THE THE AGE RANGE OF THE
CHILDREN SERVE REALLY DEPENDS
UPON -- EITHER THE CAL WORKS
STAGE THAT THEY'RE IN -- OR
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE IN A CAL
WORKS VOUCHER PROGRAM -- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS FOR LIKE OUR
STAGE THREE PROGRAMS AND OUR ARE
A P. PROGRAM -- THERE ACTUALLY
ARE QUITE A LARGE PORTION OF THE
POPULATION THAT'S BEING SERVED
THAT IS AGES SIX TO THIRTEEN
OKAY MYBE A LARGE BUT IT ARE
THERE MORE THAT ARE BELOW. FIVE
FOR EXAMPLE FIVE NO THAT'S NOT
MY UNDERSTANDING I I CAN PULL UP
IN PROVIDER OFFICE WITH THE
EXACT PERCENTAGES BASED ON OUR
MOST RECENT INFORMATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I DON'T
HAVE THAT WITH YOU RIGHT NOW BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF CHILDREN SERVED AT
LEAST.
IN THOSE PROGRAMS -- ARE OF THE
SCHOOL AGE OKAY I WITH MY
EXPERIENCE TO RUN IN ONE THAT
THEIR YOUNGER NOW.
AND THEN -- WILL EITHER WAY ALL
HOUSES ABOUT TWO HOUSES IN THE
GOVERNOR WENT TO PRIORITIZE
ABOUT JUST LOTS OF THAT THAT'S A
GIVEN AND TO THE HOUSES ONE OF
FOCUS ON AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
LATER ON I I THINK IT'S CLEAR
THAT.
WE CAN YOU KNOW GO BACK AND WORK
BUT WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT YOUR
HONORING THE WILL OF OTHERS.
IS VERY CLEAR WHEN THEY WROTE
THIS PROP SIXTY FOUR THE WITH BY
THE GOVERNOR IN THE BALLOT
ARGUMENT IT SAID.
TAX REGULATE.
MARIJUANA CAN USE THAT MONEY IS
TO FOCUS ON PROGRAMS LIKE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS THEY DID MENTION
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS WERE PLAYING
IN THE GENERAL FUND.
IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR TV
COMMERCIAL [inaudible]
PRETTY SIMPLE.
LEADING LADY IN WEST LOT OF REAL
ESTATE HERE [inaudible]
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
FUNDS AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS I
DIDN'T SEE THE COMMERCIAL CHILD
CARE PROGRAM SO.
I JUST THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE
INTELLECTUALLY HONEST WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT HONORING.
THE WILL OF THE VOTERS AND I
THINK THIS IS BEING YOU KNOW TOO
CUTE BY HALF.
A FEW MONTHS AFTER THIS MEASURE
IS FINALLY BEING IMPLEMENTED SO
WE SHOULD KEEP THAT.
IN CONSIDERATION AS WE MOVE
ALONG THE PROCESS [inaudible]
THIRTY NIELSEN [inaudible]
RUSSIAN ANALYST.
CANNABIS REBEL TAX REVENUES OF
THE NOT BEEN QUITE WHAT WAS
EXPECTED.
OF A LOT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SOUGHT THE GRAVY TRAIN WAS
COMING.
AND IT APPEARS THAT TO AN AWFUL
LOT OF THOSE TAXES ARE BEING
AVOIDED.
ISN'T THAT OCCURRED TO ME THE
CONCERNED WHEN I FIRST READ THIS
I SAID WHAT WE'RE BASING THIS ON
THESE REVENUES BUT SO FAR.
IN TERMS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
THAT SIXTY FIVE WE'VE NOT SEEN
THE THE BONANZA THAT WAS
EXPECTED FROM TAXES FROM.
MARIJUANA HAVE WE SO I THINK
THERE IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
LACK OF CERTAINTY ON WHAT THESE
REVENUES WOULD BE PARTICULARLY
IN THE EARLY YEARS AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT -- OUR
OFFICE IS NOTED -- IN THE PAST
IS THAT SUCH A WITH A NEW
INDUSTRY THAT'S RAMPING UP --
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY ON REVENUE SO YES --
I YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT THAT
THE REVENUE TO COME AND I'M
SOMEWHAT LOWER THAN THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION ORIGINALLY.
ANTICIPATED -- BUT IT'S I THINK
UNCLEAR EXACTLY WHERE WE THINK
THAT THAT ONE I THINK THAT THAT
ESTIMATES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COME FORWARD
WITH ARE PROBABLY IN THE
REASONABLE RANGE ON AND TWO I
THINK THAT THERE'S A LACK OF
CERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT THE
ULTIMATE REVENUES MIGHT BE AND
CERTAINLY THEY MAY.
WILL GROW OVER TIME -- SO I
THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S JUST A VERY
DIFFICULT THING TO PROTECT.
HI CLINT COME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I JUST TO CLARIFY TO WE
ESTIMATED -- TO THIS EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S GOING TO
CHILD CARE SLOTS WAS PREMISED ON
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS OF TAX REVENUE BEING --
RECEIVED IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE
JUST RECEIVED A TOWARD A THIRD
QUARTER TAX PAYENT THAT IS
TRAINING IN LINE WITH OUR
ESTIMATE AND ACTUALLY SLIGHTLY
ABOVE SO WE DO HAVE SOME
EVIDENCE THAT.
THIS SHOULD BE A FAIRLY ACCURATE
AMOUNT.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY THANK YOU.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU I JUST WANTED TO
BRIEFLY.
ECHO BY AGREEMENT WITH MISTER
MCCARTY'S COMMENTS ON THE PROP
SIXTY FOUR FUNDING.
I THINK WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF
THE FACT THAT WHEN WE TELL
VOTERS ONE THING AND THEY
APPROVE SOMETHING AND THEN WE DO
ANOTHER THEIR A LOT LESLIE LESS
LIKELY TO TRUST US THE NEXT TIME
WE GO TO THEM ASKING FOR THEIR
APPROVAL FOR SOMETHING SO.
I THINK THAT THE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT WITH THE ASSEMBLY IS
DONE IN THAT RESPECT WE'VE ALSO
WE'VE WE HAVE A LOT OF FUNDING --
FOR THE THE SLOTS BUT WE USED TO
PROP SIXTY FOUR MONEY FOR THE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS WHICH I
THINK IS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU MISTER TING IN THE
NUMBER OF WEIGHING IN ON THE
AFTER SCHOOL VERSUS AP
FLASHPOINT MYSELF MR TING.
THANK YOU TO STONE.
IT'S JUST A QUICK COMMENT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR PUTTING
IN -- MONEY.
FOR KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES
SOMETHING THAT HAVE BEEN VERY
MUCH OF A BIG FAN OF I THINK ONE
THING.
THAT -- SORT OF CHANGE AT LEAST
ON MY THINKING WAS ALEJO'S
TESTIMONY AND SENT TO THIS YEAR.
REGARDING.
WHAT DISTRICTS HAD ACTUALLY USED
THE KINDERGARTEN FACILITY
FUNDING AND ALSO WHAT DISTRICTS?
NEED KINDERGARTEN FACILITY
FUNDING AS WELL AS WHICH
DISTRICTS HAVE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN WHICH ONES DON'T
AND I THINK MY ASSUMPTION BEFORE
A GO IN THIS PRESENTATION WAS
THAT MANY OF THE DISTRICTS IN
NEED WERE THE ONES THAT -- HAD
NOT MOVE TOWARD FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN WHERE HE WAS.
BASED ON THE LA ANALYSIS THAT
ACTUALLY HE WAS IN FACT THE
OPPOSITE WHERE.
DISTRICTS THAT WERE IN THE MORE
AFFLUENT AREAS WERE THE ONES WHO
PURPOSELY DECIDED THEY DIDN'T
WANT FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
BECAUSE THEY COULD HAVE PEOPLE
PICK UP THEIR KIDS AT NOON --
UNLIKE OTHER OTHER AREAS WHERE
YOU HAD TO GET A WORKING
FAMILIES WHO REALLY NEEDED --
FULL DAY.
SCHOOL SO -- THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WE ENDED UP.
DOING CUTTING THAT NUMBER A
PARTICULAR -- BECAUSE WE FELT
THAT -- THERE WASN'T AS MUCH OF
A NEED AS WE HAD THOUGHT.
AND PUTTING SOME OF THAT MONEY
MORE TOWARD ONGOING SLOT SUCH AS
WANTING FELLOW COULD JUST AGAIN
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THAT ANALYSIS THEY DID REGARDING --
THE KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES AND
WHERE THE MONEY IT WAS GOING AS
WELL AS HER THAT THE NEED.
BEHIND -- WHO ACTUALLY?
MAKE CHOICES AROUND FOR THE
KINDERGARTEN VERSUS VERSUS NOT
[inaudible]
FOLKS CAMILLA [inaudible]
WHAT?
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE I'M
SO WE DO JUST WANT TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE WILL BE
SPEAKING ON FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN ON ISSUE.
NINE BUT FOR THE TIME BEING.
WOULD YOU MIND JUST READ THE
QUESTION REALLY QUICKLY SURE
JUST.
I THOUGHT THE THE PRESENTATION
YOU MADE IN SUBCOMMITTEE WAS I
THINK THEY'RE INTERESTING WHAT
ONE OF OUR ASSUMPTIONS GOING
INTO THE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
AS WAS GOING IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WAS -- ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS WE HAVE SUCH A DIFFICULT
TASK WITH PRESCHOOL SLOTS.
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS WAS REALLY
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF FACILITIES
WE HOPE THAT HAVING MORE
CONSTRUCTION OF KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS AND ALSO ASSISTED THE
PRESCHOOL UPTICK.
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK.
YOUR ANALYSIS OF WHAT DISTRICTS
ACTUALLY.
DIDN'T HAVE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN AND WHAT WHAT
DISTRICTS I'M MORE SORT OF
ACTUALLY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
KINDERGARTEN FACILITY MONEY WAS
I THINK YOU KNOW VERY
INTERESTING AND AND ALSO CHANGE
OUR THINKING.
AROUND THIS WHICH IS WHY WE
ENDED P LOWERING THE GOVERNOR'S
NUMBER A LITTLE BIT AND PUTTING
SOME MORE MONEY TOWARDS SLOTS.
SO IF YOU COULD JUST KIND OF GO
THROUGH WHAT.
A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT YOU FOUND.
IN TERMS OF WHO.
WHAT?
WHO'S NOT PARTICIPATING IN FOR
THE KINDERGARTEN -- WHO IS
ACTUALLY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES --
GRANTSGET AGAIN WE ONE MILLION
SO PRESCRIBED.
BUT THEN ALSO -- IDENTIFYING
WHETHER OR NOT THE MOST NEEDY
DISTRICTS ARE IN FACT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE FUNDS SURE OF
COURSE.
I THINK YOUR MOSTLY REFERENCING
THE INITIAL ONE HUNDRED MILLION
THAT WAS PROVIDED FOR FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN THOUGHT.
I FOR KINDERGARTEN FACILITY
GRANTS LAST YEAR -- SOONER
UNDERSTANDING HAVE WITH THEIR
FIRST ROUND OF APPLICATIONS.
EIGHT BECAUSE OF HOW THEIR
PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED A LOT OF
THE GRANTS AND IT'S GOING TO
DISTRICTS THAT ARE ALREADY
RUNNING FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
AND I'M IN TERMS OF TARGETING
THOSE GRANTS TOWARDS.
LOW INCOME DISTRICT THAT ARE
RUNNING PART DAY KINDERGARTEN WE
FOUND THAT MOST OF THE DISTRICTS
RUNNING PART DAY KINDERGARTEN IN
THE STATE ARE ACTUALLY A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER INCOME -- IN SO WAY
THAT STRESS PART OF
CONSIDERATION AS A LEGISLATURE
DECIDES -- TO FIGURE OUT HOW HOW
IT WENT TO STRUCTURE THE GRANT
PROGRAM MOVING ON I THINK THE
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE
FOUND WHERE THEY WERE SEVERAL --
OTHER CONSTRAINTS DISTRICTS FACE
WHEN DECIDING WHETHER TO RUN PER
DAY VERSUS FULL DAY KINDERGARTN
AND MOST OF THOSE WERE NOT
NECESSARILY RELATED TO FACILITY
CONSTRAINTS -- WE FOUND THAT
FIRST.
OUR FRIENDS PLAYED INTO THE
DECISION AS TO WHAT DISTRICTS
WOULD RUN SOME PARENTS JUST HAVE
FOR THEIR CHILD'S ATTEND A
SHORTER DAY PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE.
THAT A LONGER PROGRAM IS NOT A
SUIT IS NOT SUITABLE FOR KIDS
THAT YOUNG.
A SECOND -- PART OF THIS WAS
TEACHER PREFERENCE SO SOME
TEACHERS JUST PREFERRED HAVE
PART DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS
AND THESE TEACHERS MAY GO ON TO
PROVIDE OTHER AND SECTION ON AN
INJECTION DURING OTHER PARTS OF
THE DAY SO FOR EXAMPLE THEY
MIGHT TEACH SCIENCE.
OR MATH TWO OLDER KIDS OR THEY
MIGHT BE PULLING STUDENTS OUT
FROM OTHER CLASSROOMS FOR
INTENSIVE READING --
INTERVENTIONS AND THEN A THIRD
ISSUE THAT WE FOUND WAS SOME
DISTRICTS HAD CHALLENGES FINDING
A ON GOING SOURCE FOR STAFF
FUNDING IF THERE IS ADDITIONAL
STAFF THAT MIGHT BE NEEDED. TO
CONVERT AND RUN FULL DAY
PROGRAMS AND SO AN OVERALL WE
FOUND THAT.
WHEN HE CAME?
TO DISTRICTS THAT ARE RUNNING
PART DAY KINDERGARTEN THAT
PICTURE IS REALLY JUST A LITTLE
BIT MORE COMPLEX THAN JUST
FACILITIES ALONE.
THANK YOU SO CELLS LIKE.
WITH THAT ANALYSIS IT WASN'T
THAT.
DISTRICTS WHO WERE -- NOT DOING
DISTRICTS WERE DOING PART TIME
CAN CARDS HAS LIKE A LOT THAT
WAS BY CHOICE IT WASN'T
NECESSARILY.
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF RESOURCES
OR CERTAIN CONSTRAINTS.
THAT WAS OUR UNDERSTANDING AS
WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- I I I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS FUNDED AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND I'VE ALWAYS
YOU KNOW.
FELT IT WAS UNFORTUNATE WHEN WE
ALLOWED ONE GROUP ONE SERVICE
OFFERING TO BE PITTED AGAINST
THE OTHER I THINK I WOULD JUST
PUSH BACK A LITTLE BIT I
APPRECIATE.
THE PROP -- SIXTY FOUR
PROPONENTS ADVERTISE AN AFTER
SCHOOL BUT I THINK SOMETIMES WE
GET CAUGHT UP IN SEMANTICS
THERE'S A WHOLE POPULATION OF
WORKING PARENTS WHO DON'T HAVE
THE LUXURY OF PICKING THEIR
CHILDREN UP BY SIX O'CLOCK.
WHO ALSO DON'T WORK JUST MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY AND SO THE
BENEFIT OF THE A. P. SLOT
PROGRAM IS THOSE ARE AFTER
SCHOOL SETTINGS FOR SCHOOL AGE
KIDS -- THAT MEET THE NEEDS OF A
WORKING PARA A BUS DRIVER WHO
WORKS TO ELEVEN AT NIGHT -- OR
THOSE WHO WORK VERY WILL
SCHEDULE THE MAY WORK WEEKENDS
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THE SCHOOL
BASED AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
CALLED AT SIX AND AREN'T OPEN ON
THE WEEKENDS SO I FULLY
APPRECIATE THE NOTION OF WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT
PROP SIXTY FOUR DOLLARS ARGUES
FOR ABOUT.
THIS BUT I JUST WANTED TO
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY THAT THAT I
THINK WILL WE SAY AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WE ENVISION ALL SORTS
OF MAKER PROGRAM THAT MAY BE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUBS OR SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS THAT IN THAT.
SIX AND THE VALUE OF THE A. P.
PROGRAM IS IT CAN MEET THE NEED
OF A BROADER POPULATION PARENTS
AND IT ALSO AFFORDS.
FOR CHOICE IN TERMS OF THE
SETTING THAT MEETS THEIR WORK
SCHEDULE THEIR LIFE AND THEIR
CHILDREN'S NEEDS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ON ISSUE.
ONE THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD OUT ADAM
OPEN PENDING CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE MOVING ON TO ISSUE TO
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS AND
ELIGIBILITY.
THE KEY DECISION BEFORE YOU IS
WITH REGARDS TO ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE PRESCHOOL IS ALL PLANT --
ALL PLANS PROVIDED THIRTY ONE
MILLION FOUR TEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS
SO JUST A LITTLE BACKGROUND
CURRENTLY ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PART DAY
PORTION OF THE PROGRAM BUT THE
FULL DAY PROGRAM IS ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE THAT MEET
THE WORK.
REQUIREMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR INCLUDES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO REMOVE THE WORK
REQUIREMENT FOR PARENTS TO BE
WORKING OR IN SCHOOL TO BE -- OR
IN SCHOOL TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
FULL DAY PROGRAM.
THE SENATE AMENDS -- THAT WERE
REMAINS AT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
BY PROVIDING PRIORITY TO A FULL
TIME SLOTS FOR WORKING.
PARENTS IN THOSE ATTENDING
SCHOOL -- IN THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTS
THE GOVERNOR'S LANGUAGE BUT ALSO
A MEN'S ELIGIBILITY EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY TO INCLUDE ALL
FAMILIES THAT LIVE IN A SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE AREA WERE 80% OR MORE
STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
OF FOR THIS ACTION WE RECOMMEND
THE SENATE WE PREVIOUSLY
EXPRESSED CONCERN THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD REDUCE
ACCESS TO WORKING FIVE ACCESS TO
THE FULL DAY PROGRAM FOR WORKING
FAMILIES.
AND THE SENATE OPTION WOULD AT
LEAST ENSURE THAT WORKING
FAMILIES GETS FIRST CALLED THE
SLOTS THE FULL DAYS LOTS
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THURMOND.
GERMAN JUST A CLARIFICATION --
IF REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT FOR
PARENTS TO BE WORKING OR IN
SCHOOL WHAT.
WHAT PROBLEM ARE WE TRYING TO
SOLVE?
THAT I WOULD THINK THAT PART OF
THE CONCERN THAT THAT WE HAD
WITH THE PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW THE
THE WAY THAT THE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED IS WE WANT
LOW INCOME CHILDRENTO HAVE
ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL PROGRAM SO
WE GIVE ALL LOW INCOME FAMILIES
ACCESS TO THAT PROGRAM.
WHETHER THAT'S CAM AT THE VERY
LEAST THE PARTY THREE HOUR
PROGRAM.
I THINK THERE ARE.
THERE IS SOME INTEREST IN IT
THERE'S BEEN SOME INTERESTING
PROVIDING I THINK THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE THIS PROGRAM
TO BE LARGER OR LONGER DURING
THE DAY I THINK THE WAY THAT WE
ARE AT THE STATE.
PRIORITIZING OUR LIMITED
RESOURCES IN THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FUNDING FOR ALL ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN IS TO SAY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
WHERE -- WHERE THERE IS SOMEBODY
AVAILABLE FOR CARE YOU CAN USE
THOSE THE PARTY PROGRAM IF YOU
HAVE PARENTS WORKING OR IN
SCHOOL AND THERE'S NOBODY
AVAILABLE FOR CAN YOU CAN BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FULL DAY?
WE THINK THAT THAT'S A
REASONABLE WAY TO PRIORITIZE THE
WAY THAT WE USE OUR FUNDING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WORKING PARENTS
STILL HAVE ARE ARE ABLE TO PUT
THEIR CHILD IN A PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM THAT ALSO PROVIDES
CHILDCARE THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
BUT OUR CONCERN WITH WITH MOVING
IN THE DIRECTION OF THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED.
SO MAYBE IF I GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE -- I'M I'M A STUDENT SO
I NEED.
MY CHILD TO BE TAKEN CARE OF BUT
I'M ONLY IN CLASS IN THE MORNING
BUT I I NEED THE AFTERNOON TO DO
THE READING OF THE WRITING AND
GET BY.
ASSIGNMENTS DONE SO I STILL
COULD USE FROM CHILD CARE IS
THAT.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING?
I'M JUST GONNA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THE PURPOSE BEHIND
ELIMINATING THE WORK REQUIREMENT
I THINK IS IS SEVERAL FOLD SO
FIRST IT'S DEFINITELY A PRIORITY
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
TO INSURE -- ACCESS TO A LONGER --
PRESCHOOL DAY -- AS WE ARE
EXPANDING -- AND WORKING TOWARDS
THE GOAL THIS ADMINISTRATION
WHICH IS EVENTUALLY UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL -- WE FIND THAT THERE
ARE MANY DEVELOPMENTAL BENEFITS
TO A LONGER PRESCHOOL DAY I
THINK THE OTHER PIECE THAT WE'RE
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT IS. TO
THE EXTENT THAT -- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A LOW INCOME FAMILIES WHO
ARE TRYING TO ACCESS THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
IT CAN BE A BARRIER -- TO HAVE
ONLY A THREE HOUR PROGRAM FOR
THOSE FAMILIES ESPECIALLY IF
TRANSPORTATION IS AN ISSUE.
SO I THINK THATONE OF OUR
CONCERNS IS OPENING UP -- TO OF
A FULL DAY PROGRAM TO PROVIDE --
YOU KNOW MORE ACCESS TO FAMILIES
WHO OTHERWISE WOULD NOT BE ABLE.
TO TO UTILIZE THESE PROGRAMS.
WHO?
CAN AFFORD TO HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT'S ONLY THREE HOURS A DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
THAT'S WEBER.
YES I I AM I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND I THINK --
ELIMINATE THE GOVERNOR'S DESIRES
IS POINTING UP TO ELIMINATE SOME
OF THE WORK REQUIREMENTS REALLY
REST ON WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
CHILD.
MUCH MORE THAN WHAT'S BEST FOR
ALWAYS THE ADULT AND OF COURSE
WE FEEL A LOT OF THE NEEDS OF
THE ADULTS BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA NEEDS AND WE'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO TALK ABOUT --
WORKING TOWARD A PRESCHOOL FOR
ALL.
AND AND IT WOULD NOT BE
CONTINGENT UPON WHETHER ANYONE
HAD A JOB WITH WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE OF THE CHILDREN THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SERVE.
AND I THINK THAT BECOMES
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT OUR PRESCHOOL EFFORTS.
I'M PLEASED THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE IDEA THAT ANYONE WHO
LIVES IN THAT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY ALSO HAS ACCESS TO IT
BECAUSE ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE
FACED A FEW YEARS AGO WAS THAT
MANY OF US HAD EMPLOYEES WHO
WORK FOR US.
WHO COULD NOT AFFORD TOP HERE
WHO COULD NOT AFFORD PRESCHOOL
IT WAS TOO EXPENSIVE ANNE AND
THEY WERE PEOPLE MAKING FIFTY
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR?
BUT WHEN YOU BASICALLY HAVE TO
PAY A THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
FOR CHILDCARE FOR PRESCHOOL
THAT'S IT THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE SO I
HAVE STAFF WHO COULD NOT AFFORD.
TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO DECENT
PRESCHOOLS AND THAT'S
UNFRTUNATE BECAUSE WE WORKING
ON ALL THE PRESCHOOL EFFORTS WE
COULD DO IT.
GETTING SLOTS FOR THOSE WITHOUT
A INCOME AND SO IF WE COULD GO
SO IT WAS ALMOST A DISINCENTIVE
FOR PEOPLE TO GO TO WORK BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T FOR PRESCHOOL.
AND SO I THINK CHANGING THOSE
ELIGIBILITY SO THOSE WHO LIVE IN
THAT COMMUNITY MAKING IT
AVAILABLE TO THEM WILL IT MAKES
AVAILABLE TO TO ALMOST NOT
EVERYONE BUT SURELY OF A LARGE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WE THINK WE'RE FUNDING BUT
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE NOT BECAUSE OF
THE LOWER?
INCOME REQUIREMENT THAT WAS
THERE AND SO THOSE FAMILIES WHO
LIVE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES MANY
OF THEM THE WORKING POOR COULD
NOT AFFORD TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN TO A DECENT PRESCHOOL.
AND I THINK THAT IN ITSELF WAS A
TRAGEDY WITH ALL THE EFFORTS WE
WERE DOING AB ONE MEMBER OF MY
STAFF WAS A STRONG DVOCATE THE
PRESCHOOL AND HE WAS AT ALL THE
MEETINGS AND HELPING US
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY.
AND SHE WAS NOT ELIGIBLE OF FOR
ANY SUPPORT TO PUT A KID THERE
AND COULD NOT AFFORD TO SEND A
CHILD TO DECENT PRESCHOOL.
THAT WAS TRAGIC INSIDE I'M
PLEASE IT WOULD LOOKING AT THIS
WHOLE IDEA OF THE 80% IN TERMS
OF BILLS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
MAKING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ELIGIBLE BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
SENATOR NIELSEN FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY THIRTY
NIELSEN I APPRECIATED YOUR
RESPONSE AND THE LOGIC I WILLING
TO ENTERTAIN SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT
IT BUT WITH A CAUTION.
WHEN THIS CHILD CARE THING
BECAME A BIG DEAL IN THE
EIGHTIES WITH THE ADVENT OF THE
GAIN PROGRAM WHICH THEN BECAME
CAL WORKS? ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES AND
PREMISES.
IT WAS THAT.
THE INDIVIDUAL ON THIS WOULD BE
THE PARENT.
WAS ON THE TRACK TOWARDS
IMPROVING EMPLOYABILITY IT
WASN'T WORK FOR IT WASN'T GET A
JOB IT WAS AND PROVE YOUR
WORKING SKILLS.
AND I'D HATE TO SEE THAT KIND OF
DYNAMIC REMOVED FROM ANYTHING
THAT WE'RE GOING FORWARD AND IT
WOULD SEEM TO ME THIS THIS MAY
BE A STEP IN THAT DIRECTION.
THAT YOU DO NOT HAVE TO WORK YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE ANY
OBLIGATION AND I WOULD SAY NOT
JUST WORK BUT BE ATTENDING SOME
KIND OF UP THE SCHOOLING.
OR CAREER TECH SKILLS TO DEVELOP
YOUR EMPLOYABILITY THAT DOES
NEED TO GO HAND IN HAND.
AM JUST CLARIFICATION AND YOU
KNOW ALL NO I'M NOT GOING TO
THIS THE WHOLE -- CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE BUT THIS IS A THOUGHT
MY NORMAL FROM ABOUT -- THAT'S
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM TO JIM
NIELSEN YOU'RE RIGHT IT DOES
HELP YOU KNOW IT IS DIRECTLY
CONNECTED TO WORK REQUIREMENTS
JOB REQUIREMENTS IN SCHOOL --
STATE PRESCHOOL HAS A HISTORY
LONGER THAN THAN THE GAME
PROGRAM -- YOU KNOW THE THE
STATE GOT INVOLVED IN THE CHILD
CARE BUSINESS WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT ASKED WOMEN TO GO TO
WORK IN THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
AND SO THE AP PROGRAM AND AND
STATE PRESCHOOL DATES BACK THERE
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT ASKED WOMEN
TO GO TO WORK AND SO IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THE PROGRAM
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WILL HIT
LATER.
IN THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM WHERE
THOSE -- HOURS IN ELIGIBILITY
STILL DIRECTLY LINKED TO YOUR
WORK AND JOB REQUIREMENTS.
MOVING ON TO MISTER MCCARTY.
YEAH THANK YOU I JUST WANTED TO
TOUCH ON THEM THE ELVES
ELIGIBILITY SO WE HAVE THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY HERE AND OF
COURSE IN THEOUT YEARS TAKE A
GROSS FOR THE TEN THOUSAND SLOTS.
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE THE
ASSEMBLY REALLY ADDRESSES TWO
ISSUES ONE AS AS DOCTOR WEBER
NOTED.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FAMILIES WHO
LIVE IN HIGH COST AREAS OR
BECAUSE OF JUST THE LGBT RATES.
THEY'RE THEY'RE TOO RICH TO GET
THE FREE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
BUT THEY'RE TOO POOR TO PAY.
UC BERKELEY RATES TO GO TO A
FULL DAY PRESCHOOL WHICH IS.
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU LIVE
BETWEEN LITERALLY ONE IN TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH AND SO
I THINK THAT'S WERE TRYING TO
GET.
AND ALSO IS NOT JUST THE TEN
THOUSAND SLOTS FOR THAT THEY
WERE LOOKING AFTER THE ENTIRE.
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PLUS
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS FOR FOR
FAMILIES A LOT OF AMMAR AND
ELLIE ACE AND SOMETIMES WE HAVE
TO SEND.
THE MONEY BACK BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T FIND SOMEBODY IN THAT
CERTAIN INCOME BRACKET.
BUT THERE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN A HIGH POVERTY NEIGHBORHOODS
TO MAYBE MAKE SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A FAMILY OF
FOUR ARE THEY RICH WITH A
HOUSING COSTS PROBABLY NOT COULD
THE BENEFIT FROM UTILIZING THAT.
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THAT'S
THERE WITH LOSING THEM THE SLOT
BACK.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF ADD OVER
HERE ON N. STREET.
SO THAT'S PROBABLY YOU KNOW NOT
SUPER EFFICIENT SO.
THIS ADDRESSES BOTH THOSE AND
GETS TO THE POINT WHERE ONE DAY
WE LIKE TO HAVE.
UNIVERSAL BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON I TARGETED
UNIVERSALISM AND FOCUSED ON THE
KIDS WHO NEED THE MOST AND KIDS
WHO ARE IN THOSE AREAS.
WHICH COULD BENEFIT SOME OF THAT
SO -- THAT SOMETHING THAT I
THINK THAT WE OUGHT TO CONSIDER
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
FOR YOU TO STAY PRESCHOOL.
SEEN THEM THANK YOU REMOVE WANT
ISSUE THREE CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL RATES.
BOTH HOUSES PROVIDER RATE
INCREASE -- GRAY INCREASES IN
THEIR PLAN BUT FOR DIFFERENT
PROVIDERS SO THE SENATE PROVIDES
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION TO INCREASE
THE HOURLY RATES OF LICENSE EXAM
PROVIDERS AND THOSE ARE THE
THOSE ARE PROVIDERS ON THE
VOUCHER PROGRAM AND ALSO FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO INCREASE -- TIP TO PROVIDE AS
A SPECIAL EDUCATION ADJUSTMENT
FACTOR FOR STATE FOR PARTY CITY
PRESCHOOL.
THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES FORTY FIVE
MILLION -- IN NINETEEN TWENTY
GROWING TO EIGHTY MILLION ON
GOING FUNDING IN -- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TOWARDS INCREASING
RATES UNDER A NEW SINGLE
REIMBURSEMENT REIMBURSEMENT RATE
SYSTEM -- THE REGARDING THE
ASSEMBLY ACTIONS WE THINK THE
GENERAL IDEA OF MOVING TOWARDS A
ONE RATE SYSTEM IS WORTH A WILD --
GIVEN THE COME GIVEN THE CHILD
CARE TAX SYSTEMS COMPLEX WERE A
REIMBURSEMENT RATE STRUCTURES --
THE ONE THING WE WOULD NOTE IS
THAT THE TARGET RATE SET FORTH
BY THIS PROPOSED BY THIS
PROPOSAL ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER THAN UNDER CURRENT LAW --
ADVOCATES ESTIMATE -- OUT IN THE
TOTAL FUNDING WOULD BE UP TO
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ROUGHLY HALF OF WHICH WOULD BE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS ON ISSUE.
THREE THREE MORE UP. TO DATE.
DEFINITIONAL CLARIFICATION NOW
WE'RE USING THE TERM RATES.
SO HOW DOES THAT RELATE TO SLOTS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU PLATE WITH IS
WHAT WE PAY FOR THE FLAT.
YEAH I'M JUST.
MAYBE SOMEONE TO WATCH AND I'M
JUST TRYING TO HELP OUT.
IT'S WHAT WE PAY FOR THE SLOTS
TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC ON HIS TV
SET A MARK OF MORE LIKE BUT IT'S
WHAT WE PAY.
AND AND THE NOTION OF THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
VERSUS THE RETAIL MARKET RATE
IT'S THE DIFFERENT RATE SYSTEMS
BASED ON THE THE PLACE OF THE
CARE BE A FAMILY DAYCARE OR A
CENTER BASED CARE [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE FOR CHILD
CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION ONE
TIME FACILITIES INVESTMENT.
THEGOVERNOR PROVIDES TWO AND
FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR A
FACILITY OFFICIALLY GRANT
PROGRAM -- BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED AS
BUDGETED -- BUT THE SENATE --
WHAT THEY DIFFER ON WITH REGARDS
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
DIRECTING HOW THE FUNDS MUST BE
SPENT THE SENATE SET ASIDE EIGHT
SETS ASIDE BY PERCENT OF FUNDS
TO HELP CURRENT PROVIDERS ME
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS AND THE
SEVEN THE ASSEMBLY ALLOWS CD TO
USE UP 25% OF FUNDS TO CONTRACT
WITH?
FINANCIAL INTERMEDIARIES TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
GRANTEES.
ON THE ASSEMBLY ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL GRANT FUNDING BY
USING FUNDS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
FOR A FACILITIES LONG PROGRAM --
AND THE SEEM REASONABLE USE OF
THE FUNDING.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
I CLEARLY COLLEGE THIS IS OUR
FIRST RUN THROUGH OF THE BINDER
AND SO WE WILL BE TAKING ACTIONS
IT'S ONE TO MAKE ONE COMMENT YES
PLEASE FIND AND SO -- WE
APPRECIATE THE APPROVAL -- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REQUEST IN THIS
AREA -- WOULD YOU WANT TO MAKE A
POINTABOUT SOME OF THAT --
SPECIFICALLY THAT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WORKLOAD
THAT COULD CREATE -- AND
ESPECIALLY -- IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE CHANGES TO ALIGN THE USE
OF THE FUNDING WITH A BEFORE
FIFTY TWO NOT BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PRIORITIZING AND THIS WILL
COME UP PERHAPS A COUPLE OTHER
TIMES TODAY.
IS THE MASTER PLAN ON EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE -- WHICH THE
GOVERNOR'S MAKING A PRIORITY AND
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE CHILD CARE
SPACE -- AS YOU NOTED MADAM
CHAIR OFTEN IN THIS AREA GROUPS
ARE PITTED AGAINST EACH OTHER SO
WE DO ONE AT ZOOM OUT AND TAKE A
REAL STRATEGIC LOOK AT THIS.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS LANGUAGE WHEN ADOPTED DOES
NOT CONSTRAIN -- THE ABILITY --
A FOR THE GOVERNOR AND WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT
THAT -- IN ONE PIECE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT HAS THE
ASSEMBLY IS BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CAN
EDUCATION HAVE YOU FINISHED YOUR
WORK.
IT WAS DONE.
YES WE HAVE THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT.
YES I DIDN'T WANT TO PASS UP ON
THE PROPOSAL IT'S IN THE IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
THE LOAN VERSES THE GRANT THAT
SOMETHING WE HAD HEARD ON THE
PRIOR REVOLVING LOAN FUND THAT.
THE IT JUST WASN'T AS SUCCESSFUL
AS FAR AS THE LONE SO.
IS THAT SOMETHING I KNOW YOU YOU
KNOW WANT TO GET AHEAD OF THAT
THE MASTER PLAN BUT THE NOTION
WITH THESE GO OUT.
IN A COMBINED GRANT TYPE.
EFFORT AS OPPOSED TO LOAN IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU ALL
SUPPORT HER WHICH ARE OUR
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND JESSICA CAN
SPEAK TO THAT THAT WE DO WANT TO
RESOLVE BEFORE MAKING ANY CHANGE
THERE.
AND I JUST WONDER IF I COULD
CLARIFY -- ARE YOU ASKING ABOUT
THE USE OF THE REVOLVING LOAN
FUND AS PART OF THE FUNDING
SOURCE HERE ARE YOU WORK ARE YOU
ASKING ABOUT.
THE INTENT FOR HOW THE FUNDING --
WOULD GO OUT -- TO TO INDIVIDUAL
GRANTEES YEAH WHAT WHAT WHAT
BOTH UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IS
THAT IT WOULD GO OUT UNDER THE
PRIOR RULES THE REVOLVING.
LOAN FUND WHICH HAS HAD LIMITED
SUCCESS RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO -- NO THIS IS NOT
INTENDED THAT THE ONE TIME --
FACILITIES INVESTMENTS IS NOT
INTENDED TO MERE -- THE EXISTING
CHILD CARE REVOLVING LOAN FUND --
IN ADDITION -- WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE -- THE AT THE THOUGHT
BY THE ASSEMBLY -- TO ELIMINATE
THE REVOLVING LOAN FUND AND MOVE
THOSE FUNDS INTO THIS PROGRAM
I'M CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE CONSTRAINT
UNDER THE EXISTING PROGRAM I
THINK THE ONLY CONCERNS WE HAVE
ABOUT -- THAT MOVING SHIFTING
THAT FUNDING FROM THE REVOLVING
LOAN FUND INTO THIS POT OF MONEY --
IS THAT.
THE THE FEASIBILITY OF IT IS A
LITTLE BIT QUESTIONABLE JUST
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE LOAN
REPAYMENTS BEING MADE INTO THAT
PROGRAM -- AND IN ADDITION --
THAT PROGRAM ALSO HAS A
COMPONENT THAT PROVIDES NO
INTEREST LOANS.
FOR THINGS LIKE HEALTH AND
SAFETY -- RENOVATIONS AND SO
WANTED TO KIND OF SPEAK WITH
STAFF UNDERSTAND SORT OF THE
INTENT BEHIND -- THAT THAT MOVE
AT THIS TIME OKAY.
YEAH AND I GUESS THERE'S SOME
LOGISTICS ISSUES TO THAT OF
THIRD SAID AT NON GOVERNMENT IT
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY IF IT SHUTS
DOWN WHO'S THE LONG TERM.
OWNER OF THAT I THINK WE WANT TO
PROTECT THAT.
TAXPAYERS INTEREST THERE BUT
CREE.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE IT IT'S
ABLE TO BE UTILIZED EFFICIENTLY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
ISSUE.
FOR MOVING ON TO ISSUE FIVE
CHILD CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION
ONE TIME WORKFORCE INVESTMENT.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANTS AND
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
ADOPTED -- APPROVED IS BUDGETED
WITH AMENDED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- THE THE SENATE
SPECIFIES THAT TH ALLOWABLE
USES INCLUDE TRAINING ON SERVING
CHILDREN WHO ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND TRAINING FOR A
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ON HOW TO
OPERATE SMALL BUSINESSES THE
ASSEMBLY SPECIFIES THAT STIPENDS
I'M SHALL BE ALIGNED WITH THE
STATE'S QUALITY RATING SYSTEM.
AND THE SUPERINTENDENT SHALL
DEVELOP GUIDELINES FOR LOCAL
PLANNING COUNCILS TO ADMINISTER-THE GRANTS ON THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER -- THESE
FUNDS WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THE
SPEED OF THE STATE SPENDING ON
OTHER WORK FIRST TRAINING
ACTIVITIES A STATE CURRENTLY
SPENDS ABOUT FIFTY MILLION
ANNUALLY ON PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING FOR
PRESCHOOL -- CHILDCARE PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS. ONE QUESTION I HAD A
THE ADMINISTRATION -- IT IT
APPEARS TO US THAT THE LANGUAGE --
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PLAYED LEGISLATURE
HAS AN OVERSIGHT ROLE WITH
REGARD TO HOW THE FUNDS ARE
SPENT -- AND AND REALLY LIMITS
OUR ENGAGEMENT.
A IS THERE A CONCERN WITH THE
APPROACH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
HAVE TAKEN WITH REGARD TO OUR
ENGAGEMENT.
SAID THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES
IT IS SUPPOSED TO THAT LANGUAGE --
MAINLY BECAUSE THE MASTER PLAN
FOR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE WE
REALLY WANT THAT TO BE A KEY
VEHICLES TO INCORPORATE SOME OF
THESE LONG RANGE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND SO WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
LACK OF FLEXIBILITY THAT WE
WOULD HAVE IF THAT LANGUAGE IS
ADOPTED.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I SHOULD POINT OUT ALSO ON A
SEPARATE ISSUE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES SUPPORT THE
SENATE CLARIFICATION TO SUPPORT
A BROADER RANGE OF PROVIDERS AND
LEARNING NEEDS -- INCLUDING IN
THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS SO
ON THAT SPECIFIC ITEM THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES SUPPORT THAT
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
WHAT'S YOUR TIME FRAME -- AROUND
THIS YET ONE MORE ENGAGEMENT AND
STUDY ABOUT THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SYSTEM I THINK I'VE
LIVED THROUGH ADULT I'VE LOST
COUNT -- AND IT'S WHAT YOUR TIME
FRAME IN TERMS TO YOUR
EXPECTATIONS WHEN DEAL.
HAVE A CLEAR DIRECTION AND A
ROADMAP YES SO -- WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS -- A PROPOSAL FOR MONEY
IN THE BUDGET -- FOR TO FUND
THIS MASTER PLAN AND SO ASSUMING
THAT THAT GOES FORWARD -- RIGHT
NOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS AIMING
FOR NEXT YEAR FALL -- TO REALLY
DO A ROBUST EFFORT AND LOOK AT
ALL OF THIS AND THE REPORT READY
BY NEXT FALL AND I SHOULD.
EMPHASIZE THAT WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PRIORITIES
AND IT'S EASY TO TALK ABOUT
EVERY ISSUE BEING A PRIORITY BUT
FOR THE GOVERNOR AND FOR THE
CHIEF OF STAFF AND LERI THIS IS
REALLY HER LIFE'S WORK AND SO
THIS WILL BE A PRIORITY OF THE
MINISTRY.
AND I WOULD JUST PASS OF THE TWO
OF THEM THAT THAT WE NOT START
FROM GROUND.
ZERO THAT THERE HAS BEEN YEARS
OF WORK IN TERMS OF SIMILAR
EFFORTS TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
BOTTOM OVERALL INFRASTRUCTURE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION SO THAT
WE NOT START AS IF WE HAVE A
CLEAN SLATE BECAUSE WE REALLY
DON'T.
AND SO I HOPE THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION FROM THE ASSEMBLY
FROM JUST LAST YEAR AND AND
OTHER SIMILAR EFFORTS WILL BE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT YES I DON'T
EXPECT TO POINTS ON THAT NUMBER --
ONE IN SPECIFICALLY THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE PREVIOUS
EFFORTS OF CALM AND FOLKS ARE
READING THEM AND LOOKING INTO
THEM AND SO THAT WILL PROVIDE A
BIG BASS FOR WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
DIES -- AND THEN THE SECOND
THING IS I KNOW A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION AROUND HERE WHETHER
IT WAS FOR THESE AFTER SCHOOL
SLOTS WHETHER WAS RELEASED
PRESCHOOL SLOTS.
IS AROUND FUNDING AND WE KNOW
IT'S ALWAYS A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE IN TERMS OF
WHERE NEW REVENUE MAY COME FROM
BUT THAT IS WITHIN THE PURVIEW
OF THE PROPOSED MASTER PLAN FOR
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO PUT
TOGETHER.
EXCELLENT WE APPRECIATE THE
PRIORITIZATION THE FOCUS
ATTENTION MOVIE NOT DOCTOR WEBER.
NEXT YEAR -- ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES I I SEE HERE -- THAT
THAT'S MENTIONED IN THE IN THE
LANGUAGE THEY FOCUS ON ENGLISH
AS A SECOND LANGUAGE AS AS A AS
A AB. ONE OF THE SERVER
POPULATIONS WHERE ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE AND YET WE KNOW.
THAT THAT ITSELF IS SOMEWHAT
NERO BECAUSE ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
IS A MUCH BROADER CHALLENGE OF
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES AND ALL
AND OFTENTIMES THOSE ARE THOSE
CHILDREN END UP ENTERING.
OF SCHOOL WITH A LOW ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY -- WHO ARE ENGLISH
WHO SPEAK ENGLISH LANGUAGE TO
SPEAK THE LANGUAGE ENGLISH IN
TERMS OF VOCABULARY -- BUT
CHALLENGE SO THAT WHEN WE LOOK
AT LATER ON I'M LOOKING AT
TESTING AND REFINING THAT.
KIDS IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES AS
OUR SCHOOLING SO LOW IN ENGLISH --
AND LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT'S MAINLY
BE ENGLISH PROFICIENCY MUCH MORE
THAN ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE AND SO I I THINK WE
HAVE TO BROADEN OUR PERSPECTIVE
OR AT LEAST ENHANCE OUR
PERSPECTIVE WITH REGARDS TO WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN PRESCHOOL.
AND CHILDCARE BECAUSE MANY FOLKS
WHO UNDERSTAND ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY -- SO THAT THOSE
CHILDREN WHO ARE WHOSE PARENTS
MAY SPEAK ENGLISH BUT DON'T
SPEAK IT IN A MANNER THAT ALLOWS
THE STUDENTS TO BE PROFICIENT IN
IT.
ARE OFTEN IGNORED IN TERMS OF
THEIR LIVES THE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THEIR THEIR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE -- AND AS A RESULT THE
END UP WITH LOWER VOCABULARY
DOING VERY POORLY AT THE
BEGINNING AND SEEM TO NEVER
CATCH UP AS WE'RE FINDING WITH
OUR LCF DATA SO.
WE CAN ACTUALLY BE PUSHING THIS
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY IN YET EVERY
TIME I TURN AROUND LENDS IT
COMES IN SECOND LANGUAGE SECOND
LANGUAGE READ ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY WHICH COVERS MORE
THAN JUST SECOND LANGUAGE.
AND INCLUDING COMPASSES EIGHT A
HUGE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
PARTICULAR POOR CHILDREN.
A MANY AFRICAN AMERICAN CHILDREN
WERE IN GREAT NEED OF ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY.
EARLY ON SO THAT THEY THEY
DEVELOP EIGHT EIGHT AM. EIGHT
EIGHT A USE OF THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE THAT THE END IS THE USE
OF KNOWLEDGE REALLY THE LANGUAGE
OF KNOWLEDGE THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
THEN DO EXTREMELY WELL SO I
WOULD URGE EVERYONE TO LOOK AT
THE SECOND LANGUAGE.
CONCEPT AND BASICALLY MOVE
OURSELVES TO ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
WHICH IS A MUCH BETTER CONCEPT
STUDY AT UCLA.
THAT SHOW THAT LA VETTING
SUFFICIENCY IS A MAJOR CHALLENGE
AND NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
THIS IS A PLACE WHERE YOU
STARTED BECAUSE THEN.
YOU COULD MOVE ON TO ADD THAT
WHEN THEY ENTER KINDERGARTEN AND
THEY'RE MUCH BETTER OFF IN A
MUCH FURTHER HIT.
AND SEVEN MINISTRATION
DEFINITELY WANTS TO WORK WITH A
NOTE THE SENATE LANGUAGE AND
WORK WITH ALL THE ON THAT AND
ONE POINT.
I SHOULD MAKE ABOUT THIS IS
BECAUSE THIS IS FOR TRAINING
SPECIFICALLY SO DIFFERENT FROM
SOME THE FORMULAS WE SEE FOR THE
HOUSE YET THAT FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT YOU
COULD FOR TRAINING ACCOMPLISH
BOTH OF THOSE PURPOSES RIGHT AND
AND AND AND AND AND I THINK
THAT'S TRUE.
BU AND BUT IT HAS TO BE IN THE
IN THE LANGUAGE HERE.
IN ORDER FOR IT TO EVER GET TO
THE PLACE WHERE YOU WANT TO BE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
NIELSEN.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER FOR BRINGING UP THAT POINT.
PROFICIENCY. FOR DECADES WE HAVE
DIMINISHED PROFICIENCY.
IT IS SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
I APPRECIATE -- ALL THE MORE
BRINGING IT UP BUT PLEASE TAKE
THIS DID MANAGEMENT SRIOUSLY.
THAT WE HAVE GOT TO BE FOCUSING
ON PROFICIENCY.
IT IS OUR GREATER DEFICIENCY I
BELIEVE RIGHT NOW. TO A BROADER
POPULATION.
SENATOR MORE LOT.
I'M TRYING TO CATCH THE VISION
MADAM CHAIR AND SO I MAYBE
FORGET FINISH THE SENTENCE WITH
I WORK IN A SPEND A QARTER
BILLION DOLLARS.
IN ONE YEAR [inaudible]
THE TRAIN [inaudible]
CHILD CARE.
EMPLOYEES AND I'M.
ARE WE DOING A CERTIFICATE
PROGRAM ARE WE DOING THIS MULTI
YEAR RIGHT -- WHAT'S THE WHAT'S
THE VISION HERE I YEAH THAT'S
AND I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
IT'S ACTUALLY ONE TIME OVER FIVE
YEARS SO THAT'S THAT'S ONE PIECE
OF IT -- I THINK THE OTHER
PIECES THIS IS A CONVERSATION
THAT I THINK HAS BEEN ONGOING
FOR MORE YEARS THAN I'VE BEEN ON
THIS ASSIGNMENT.
ABOUT HOW WE IMPROVE OVERALL
QUALITY -- AND PROFESSIONAL EYES
ARE CHILD CARE WORK FORCE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION -- AT
POINTED OUT IN ITS IN ITS --
REPORT AS WELL AS A SENATOR
MITCHELL POINTED OUT THAT THERE
ARE MANY OTHER REPORTS INCLUDING
OUR STATE ADVISORY COUNCIL HAS --
HAS REPORTS ON THIS ON THEIR
MANY NONPROFIT SAID REPORTS ON
THIS -- THAT OUR OUR CHILD CARE
IT NEEDS TO ALSO BE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE --
AND LOOKING AT YOU KNOW WHAT
SHOULD WE INCREASE OUR
REQUIREMENTS FOR FOLKS TO DO
PROVIDE THIS CARE.
AND I THINK THAT WE SEE THIS AS
PART OF A LARGER CONVERSATION
AROUND THE ENTIRE CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THINGS LIKE THAT YOU
ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
RATES OF REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND
HOW YOU ARE -- PROVIDING AT A
SALARY FOR THE FOLKS WHO HAVE
THIS HIGHER EDUCATION LEVEL --
AND THEN YOU KNOW HOW DOES THAT
FIT INTO THE SCHOOL READING THIS
CONVERSATION AND HOW YOU
INCREASE ACCESS TO THE TARGETED
WAY THAT REALLY PROVIDES THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF BENEFIT FOR
STUDENTS.
SO THE VISION IS THAT THIS IS A
PIECE OF A MUCH LARGER --
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW OUR
CURRENT HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKS I THINK IS
WHY IT'S SO MPORTANT FOR US TO
AS ADMINISTRATION TO ENGAGE IN
THAT -- IMPORTANT MASTER PLAN
PLANNING PROCESS BECAUSE WE TALK
ALL THE TIME AND AND THE CHILD
CARE WORLD ABOUT THE THREE LIKE
IT'S STILL CHILD CARE YOU KNOW
SLOTS.
ARE ACCESS RATES IN QUALITY.
AND I THINK THAT -- IN OUR
CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE WE KIND
OF HAD SOME VERY YEARS WITHOUT
AND SO WE WANT TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL AND STRATEGIC ABOUT HOW
WE MAKE.
INVESTMENTS MOVING INTO THE
FUTURE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
BRINGING UP ALL OF THOSE ALL
THOSE BUCKETS ARE RISING IN A
WAY THAT IS ALSO A FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE STATE.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON ISSUE.
FIVE SEE NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
SIX CHILD CARE AND EARLY
EDUCATION.
THIS IS THE BUCKET OF ALL THE
INVESTMENTS.
I'M ISSUE SIX DISPLAYS ASSEMBLY
PRIORITIES -- THIS ASSEMBLY
PROVIDES SIXTEEN MILLION FOR
DATA COLLECTION TEN MILLION FOR
LOCAL PLANNING COUNCILS AND FOUR
MILLION FOR CD TO COLLECT
PROVIDER INFORMATION AND TWO
POINT TWO FIVE MILLION FOR ON
GOING FOR A NEW COUNCIL.
ON THE ASSEMBLY ALSO PROPOSES TO
AN ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION FOR
STATE OPERATIONS FOR CD EASE
EARLY LEARNING CARE DIVISION
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO TWO
MILLION THAT ALL PLANS PROVIDE --
AND WE WERE -- WE SO WE
RECOMMEND THE SENATE HERE --
BECAUSE THE TWO MILLION PROVIDED
BY ALL PLANS REFLECT AN 11%
INCREASE IN CD EASE EARLY
EDUCATION STOP CITY IS LIKELY TO
A IS LIKELY TO FIND INCREASING
THE STAFF EVEN TO THE US --
SENATE LEVEL CHALLENGING WITHIN
A SINGLE YEAR.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION CARE TO
COMMENT ON THE PROPOSAL YES OF
FINANCE ALSO GENERALLY SUPPORT
SAID THE SENATE -- ON THESE
PROPOSAL ON THESE PROPOSALS WHEN
IT COMES TO THE DATA SYSTEM --
WERE NEUTRAL ON THE SPECIFIC
ITEM REGARDING WORKFORCE DATA
COLLECTION -- BUT MORE GENERALLY --
THE ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING --
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW ON A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM
PROPOSAL THAT CAN INCORPORATE
ALL THESE ELEMENTS SO WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE OTHER EFFORTS -- ARE
DUPLICATIVE OR MAYBE TO FORGET
ABOUT THAT HALF.
FOR WHEN IT COMES TO THE COUNCIL
THAT IS PROPOSED THAT WE BELIEVE
ALSO THAT THERE IS A STATE
ADVISORY COUNCIL RIGHT NOW ON
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE.
AND THAT CN ACCOMPLISH THE WORK
OF THE PROPOSED COUNSEL FROM THE
COMMISSION -- AND THEN FINALLY --
SIMILAR TO WHAT LA A MENTION
WHEN IT COMES TO THE CD -- WE
SUPPORT THE SENATE PROPOSAL.
AB OUT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU TO MOVE ON
TO FIFTY SEVEN CAL WORKS STAGE
ONE CHILD CARE INVESTMENTS.
ALL PLANS HERE PROVIDE MORE
FUNDING FOR CAL WORK STAGE ONE
CHILD CARE AND MAKE CHANGES TO
THE PROGRAM SO CURRENTLY A
FAMILY PARTICIPATES IN STAGE ONE
CHILD CARE UNTIL COUNTY DEEMS
THE FAMILY STABLE.
AT THAT POINT THE FAMILY
TRANSITIONS FROM STAGE ONE TO
STAGE TO CHILD CARE EACH COUNTY
WELFARE DEPARTMENT ESTABLISHES
ITS OWN DEFINITION OF STABLE SO
HOW LONG THE FAMILY RECEIVES
STAGE ONE CARE VARIES AMONG THE
COUNTY'S.
ATTEMPT TO MAINTAIN SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE A STAGE ONE FAMILY
VERIFIES ELIGIBILITY MULTIPLE
TIMES PER YEAR AND THEN THE
HOURS OF CAREPROVIDED ARE
DETERMINED BY REQUIRED
ACTIVITIES.
THE GOVERNOR IN THE ASSEMBLY'S
PLAN REQUIRE THAT ALL FAMILIES
REMAIN IN STAGE ONE CHILD CARE
FOR A MINIMUM OF TWELVE MONTHS
BEFORE THE COUNTY MAY TRANSFER
TO STAGE TO CHILD CARE.
UNDER THE SENATE PLAN ALL
FAMILIES I'M IN STAGE ONE ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FULL TIME CARE BUT
THE LENGTH OF THE TIME ON STAGE
ONE WOULD STILL BUT BE
DETERMINED BY THE COUNTY.
THE SENATE PLAN ALSO FUNDS A
DATA SHARING SYSTEM BETWEEN
COUNTIES AND CONTRACTORS TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESS OF
TRANSFERRING FAMILIES FROM STAGE
ONE TO STAGE.
TWO UNDER ALL PLANS ONCE A TERM
IN ELIGIBLE A FAMILY REMAINS
ELIGIBLE FOR CHILD CARE FOR ONE
YEAR OR UNTIL THE FAMILY
TRANSFERS TO STAGE TO WHICHEVER
COMES FIRST.
THE BOTH HOUSES CHANGE POLICIES
SUCH THAT STAGE ONE FAMILIES
REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR CARE FOR
TWELVE CONSECUTIVE MONTHS
WITHOUTHAVING TO RE VERIFY
ELIGIBILITY.
THE STATE ADOPTED THIS POLICY IN
STAGE TO WIN THREE A FEW YEARS
AGO AND COST ENDED UP BEING
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER THAN
INITIALLY BUDGETED.
DEPENDING ON HOW FAMILIES
RESPOND COST COULD ALSO BE
HIGHER THAN EXPECTED AND
CONTINUE TO GROW IN THE OUT
YEARS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MOVING ON TO
ISSUE EIGHT OTHER CHILD CARE
INVESTMENT.
FOR NINE ISSUE EIGHT ARE ALSO
ASSEMBLY PRIORITIES ON THE
ASSEMBLY PROVIDES THAT FORTY
SEVEN MILLION ONGOING FOR THE
EMERGENCY CHILDCARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER CHILDREN.
ON THE ALSO INCLUDE TWO TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGES -- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CHANGES RELATED TO
VOUCHER PROGRAMS ONE RELATED TO
A PAYMENT BASED ON THE
AUTHORIZED HOURS OF CARE AND ONE
RELATED TO A P. AGENCY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND JUST A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON THE FOSTER BRIDGE
PROGRAM IT WAS CREATED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO ALLOW
FOSTER FAMILIES. TO ACCESS
IMMEDIATE CHILDCARE SLOTS UP TO
ONE YEAR -- UNTIL ONGOING SLOTS
BECOME AVAILABLE ORANGE ONGOING
TALKS BECOME AVAILABLE ON A
REGULAR SUBSIDIZE -- CHILD CARE
SYSTEM -- WITH REGARD TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR OUR
PAYMENTS BASED ON THE HOURS
AUTHORIZATION OF CARE -- WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THERE'S A
COST ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN THIS.
BECAUSE I SO.
THREE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OOPS WE
FUNDED.
THE BRIDGE PROGRAM.
BUT NOT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OR WAS
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FINDING
OUT OF COURT FOR CONTINUE TO
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHTEEN WAS WHEN IT STARTED BUT
IT DIDN'T CONTINUE IT'S A IT'S
AN ONGOING PROGRAM.
OKAY SO THAT WAS THE TH SO IF WE
WERE.
TO NOT.
ADOPT THE ASSEMBLY.
VERSION WITH THAT STOP.
THIS IS JUST AN INCREASE OF THE
CURRENT PROGRAM OKAY SO THE
FUNDING THAT WAS ADOPTED IS ON
GOING SINCE THIS WOULD BE AN
INCREASE.
OKAY AND IS THERE -- I KNOW THAT
THE PROGRAM ITSELF HAS BEEN VERY%
ESSENTIAL TO ASSISTING ON THE WE
HAVE MANY MORE FOR CHILDREN.
IN NEED OF FOSTER CARE FAMILIES
THAN FAMILIES THAT HAVE COME
FORWARD YET TO TAKE SUCH
CHILDREN.
SO ANYTHING LIKE THIS IS VERY
VERY BENEFICIAL TO GETTING OUR
CHILDREN PLACED IN GOOD STABLE
HOMES -- IS THERE.
DOES LA -- HAVE ANY DATA ON WHAT
THE NEED GAP IS FROM THE FUNDING
WE'VE PROVIDED SO FAR.
AND OUT.
IN WHAT THE ASSEMBLIES --
RECOMMENDATION MIGHT YOU KNOW IS
IT GOING -- TO MEETING NEED GAP.
SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY DATA ON
HAND THIS THIS THAT THEY DID
NEED IS A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO
MEASURE HERE BECAUSE THIS IS
INTENDED TO BE A BRIDGE PROGRAM
SO THERE ARE FOSTER FAMILIES
THAT ARE ON SOME OF THE OTHER
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS NOT JUST ON
THE EMERGENCY BRIDGE.
PROGRAM -- SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY
DATA TO EVALUATE THAT THE WHAT
IS JUST THE NEED AND WHAT DOES
THE CURRENT FUNDING MEET THE
LEAK NEED OR WHAT IS AN ACCESS
TO THE NEED FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
CAN I CAN SAVE COMPETE PURELY
ANECDOTALLY THAT WHEN I WAS
RUNNING AT A P. -- ON OUR AGENCY
THAT THIS WAS THE PRIMARY CALL
WE WOULD GET FROM FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO WOULD BE WILLING TO TAKE A
FAMILY MEMBER OF ON THE ON THE
EMERGENCY CALL BUT BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T.
AT YOU KNOW ALREADY LICENSE
FOSTER PARENTS.
MANY YOU DON'T WORK FULL TIME AS
TO THE FIRST QUESTION ALWAYS WAS
CAN I GET SOME HELP WITH
CHILDCARE SINCE I'M.
HAVING THIS UNEXPECTED --
OPPORTUNITY -- AND SO IT WAS.
WE GET LOTS OF CALLS EVERYDAY IN
MANY THE AP AGENCIES I WORKED
WITH THE AND EXPERIENCE IT TOO
LIKE I SAID PURELY ANECDOTAL BUT
IT IT'S A GAP KIND OF IN -- ARE --
AND COMPREHENSIVE KIND OF FOSTER
CARE SERVICES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE.
I'LL JUST BRIEFLY SAY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT WE SUPPORT
THAT MERITS OF THIS PROGRAM BUT
SIMPLY BELIEVE THAT WE WANT MORE
OUT CALM AND OTHER DATA BEFORE
AUGMENTING IT AT THIS TIME.
FAIR ENOUGH.
THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR MITCHELL
BBS HEALTHCARE ACTUALLY HAVE N
ANSWER TO MISTER MCCARTY'S
QUESTION GREATLY OR SO EXCELLENT --
THE EXCELLENT STAFF AT THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE DIVISION
DEPARTMENT OF ED -- HURT YOUR
QUESTION AND SENT ME THIS
INFORMATION -- SO THE PERCENTAGE
OF SIX YEAR OLDS AND ABOVE -- IN
STAGE THREE AT CAL WORKS CHILD
CARE IS 60% -- IN A P. PROGRAM
IS 45% STAGE TWO IS 39% -- I
DON'T HAVE THE STAGE ONE NUMBERS
BUT THEY'RE USUALLY PRETTY
SIMILAR TO STAGE -- TWO BUT I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT THIS DOES
NOT INCLUDE FIVE YEAR OLDS WHO
MAY OR MAY NOT BE IN
KINDERGARTEN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TRANSITIONING IF YOU WILL FROM
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION TO
KINDERGARTEN AND PRESCHOOL
FACILITIES MOVING ON TO ISSUE.
NINE WE WENT AWAY -- EMILY WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AN ISSUE NINE THE GOVERNOR
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY EACH PROVIDE
FACILITY FUNDING TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
OR PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
ON PAGE ONE OF THE HAND OUT IN
YOUR BINDERS IT SHOWS THE KEY
DIFFERENCES AMONG THE THREE
PLANS.
WHEREAS THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
SIX HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND THE SENATE APPROVED
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AND
ASSEMBLY APPROVED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION.
TURNING TO PAGE TWO HERE WE
HIGHLIGHT A FEW KEY DIFFERENCES
IN SOME ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
FIRST THE TWO HOUSES TARGET THE
GRANTS RATHER DIFFERENTLY.
THE SENATE TARGETS THE GRANT
SPECIFICALLY TO LOW INCOME
DISTRICTS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONVERTING PART DAY KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS TO FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
IN CONTRAST THE ASSEMBLY
BROADENS THE GRANT PROGRAMS
INCLUDE ALL DISTRICTS CONVERTING
PART DAY KINDERGARTEN OR PER DAY
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS TO FULL DAY
PROGRAMS.
THE ASSEMBLY ALSO MAKES COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS GRANT FUNDING.
SECONDLY THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AND ELIGIBILITY RULES IN THE
SENATE PLAN MOST CLOSELY ALIGNED
WITH OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
INTEREST IN THESE FACILITY
GRANTS WHICH WAS BASED ON A
RECENT SURVEY THAT WE SENT TO
LOW INCOME DISTRICTS CURRENTLY
RUNNING PARDEE KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS.
THIRD THE SENATE PURPLES
PROPOSAL IS COORDINATED WITH THE
STATE'S MAIN SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM.
UNDER THE SENATE PLAN AT NEW
CLASSROOMS BUILT UNDER THESE
THREE THESE GRANTS WOULD FACTOR
INTO DISTRICTS ELIGIBILITY --
FOR OTHERS STATE FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL FACILITIES IN CONTRAST
THE ASSEMBLY PLAN WOULD NOT
FACTOR IN ANY OF THESE NEW
CLASSROOMS INTO DISTRICTS
ELIGIBILITY.
LASTLY WE KNOW THAT THIS FAMILY
ADOPTS A BROADER ELIGIBILITY
RULES BY ALL ONLY PROVIDES FIFTY
MILLION MORE THAN THE SENATE WE
BELIEVE THIS MAY RESULT IN THE
ASSEMBLY PLAN BEING OVER
SUSPECTS SUBSCRIBED.
AND IF YOU DECIDE TO TAKE
ASSEMBLY IS APPROACH WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER HOW
YOU MIGHT WANT TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING MIKE'S POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS.
THANK YOU. THREE MORE LOT.
MADAM CHAIR I'M WONDERING IF I
COULD ASK SENATOR REID QUESTION.
OF COURSE YOU MAY THIRD A RAW
FOOD ARE YOU OPEN TO RECEIVING A
QUESTION.
CERTAINLY OPEN TO THE LOWER PART
OF THE ANSWER.
YOU'RE THE CHAIR OF SUB ONE AND
SO.
THE GOVERNOR WANTS SIX HUNDRED
MILLION AND YOU'RE SAYING A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION AND
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
HOW THAT DISCUSSION WENT TEN WHY
YOU'RE WILLING TO DISAGREE WITH
THE GOVERNOR?
A LOADED QUESTION.
I THINK I CAN WIN AND THAT IF
YOU DON'T NO NO NO NO I ONE MORE
EXPERIENCE CALLING FROM THE
ASSEMBLY MY LA ON AND GO OVER TO
THE SURE IF I MAY UM OUR
ASSESSMENT OF THEIR SIX HUNDRED
MILLION THAT WAS PROVIDED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WE SURVEYED -- DISTRICTS ARE LOW
INCOME AND PROVIDING PARTY
KINDERGARTEN TO SEE IF THERE WAS
INTEREST IN THESE GRANTS AND OUR
RESULTS SHOW THAT THERE WAS NOT
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF INTEREST AND SO.
THE SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY BOTH
DECREASE THE AMOUNT PROPOSED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE THINK
THAT MOVES IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
DOES THAT.
IN AMERICA THAT'S GREAT SO MR
Và SPOTIFY UNDEAD.
DO YOU WANT TO REBUT.
YES SIR THE THE FIRST THING I'LL
SAY IS AND IT IS TRUE FOR ALL OF
US BUT FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN IS
A REAL PRIORITY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND I KNOW WITH
SO MUCH DO FOR PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE BUT IF MOVING UP THE
WAGE LADDER -- FOLKS WHO REALLY
DO WANT TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN DO NOT
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY WE THINK
THAT'S A REAL ISSUE SO THAT'S
WHY WE PUT IN. SIX HUNDRED NINE
DOLLARS IN THE MAY REVISION --
WHEN IT SPECIFICALLY COMES TO
DEMAND THE TRUTH IS YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALL FOR CASTING WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO MANDATE WILL BELIKE?
BUT IF MORE THAN HALF FOR
EXAMPLE OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
CURRENTLY HAS PARTAKEN REGARDING
DO APPLY FOR FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THAT BY ITSELF WILL EXCEED THE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WE'VE MADE AVAILABLE AND IF
IT TURNS OUT THE DEMAND IS LOWER
THAN WE FORECASTED OBVIOUSLY
THAT MONEY DOES NOT GO AWAY IT
GETS SWEPT BACK RIGHT INTO THE
BUDGET CAN BE USED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES WHETHER FOR EARLY
MORNING.
OR OTHERS AND I'LL MAKE ONE
POINT ALSO ON WHEN IT COMES TO
LOW INCOME.
SCHOOLS VERSUS OTHER SCHOOLS SO
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT NEEDS TO
BE A PRIORITY AND IT IS A
PRIORITY IN OUR PROPOSAL AT THE
SAME TIME -- OR FOCUS REALLY IS
ON CONVERTING PART DAY TO FULL
DAY US BUSINESS ESPECIALLY FOR
THE FIRST YEAR THE PROGRAM
ACROSS ALL SCHOOL SO WHAT WE
WANT TO PRIORITIZE LOW INCOME
SCHOOLS WE THINK THAT OTHER
SCHOOLS THAT MAY NOT FIT
SPECIFICALLY WITH THAT WITHIN
THAT INCOME BRACKETS.
BUT WE'RE QUE -- PARENTS ALSO DO
NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEND
THEIR KIDS TO A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM SHOULD BE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR STATE FUNDING
AS WELL.
SO.
A ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
FINDING IT'S DIFFERENT.
THIS YEAR FROM PRIOR YEARS IS
THAT.
GOVERNOR BROWN WOULD ISSUE A
BUDGET AND YOU KNOW IT IS.
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD PUSH HIM A
LITTLE FURTHER OUT SAY WANT TO
SPEND MORE.
AND YOUR BOSS IS SORT OF GONE
WAY OUT AND I'M KIND OF THINKING
WHO PUSHES.
BACK.
IN SO I SEE THIS IS MAYBE ONE OF
THOSE EXAMPLES OF SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO PUSH IT BACK A LITTLE
BIT.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW HOW OFTEN IT
OCCURS AND WE'LL FIND OUT AS WE
GO THROUGH.
THIS PROCESS BUT I FIND IT
ENCOURAGING THAT IS THE THE I
MEAN THE VIRUS SENATOR ROBB I
JUST THOUGHT.
I WOULD GIVE THEM AN ATTA BOY.
PERCENT OKAY THIS IS GREAT WE'VE
GOT SOME HONEST DEBATE AND IT
ISN'T JUST GOING TO BE.
THE MAX AMOUNT SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MADAM.
CHAIR MISTER MCCARTY DID YOU
WANNA ADD TO CENTS SURE WELL TO
BE HONEST IT'S NOT LIKE WE TOOK
THE DIFFERENCE AND PUT IT IN THE
RESERVE WHICH YOU PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE LIKELY RE PRIORITIZE IT.
FOR OTHER EARLY LEARNING
PRIORITIES BUT I THINK MISTER
TEEING MENTIONED THIS A LITTLE
WHILE AGO.
THERE'S BEEN TWO REPORTS NOW.
THAT TALKED ABOUT WHILE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN IS IS A GREAT
QUESTION WE SHOULD BE DOING IT.
WE STARTED LAST YEAR AND JUST
pTHAT AND THE DEMAND WASN'T THERE
WITH THE WITH THE AMOUNTS THAT
WAS APPROPRIATE LAST YEAR NOR
THIS YAR'S SO.
THAT WE THINK IT WAS JUST AN
APPROPRIATE LOWERING THE AMOUNT
TO FOCUS ON WHAT THE REAL NEEDS
ARE -- THE ASSEMBLY ONCE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT BECAUSE WE
FOCUS NOT JUST ON KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES BUT PRE K. FACILITIES
AS WELL WE WE HAVE HEARD FROM
THE OTHER -- ISSUE WE HEARD FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAID
THESE PROGRAMS ARE THREE LEGGED
STOOL THERE'S THERE'S LOTS AND
RATES AND QUALITY.
AND THE THAT THE FACILITIES ON
THE RATES PEAS ARE GO HAND IN
HAND SO IF YOU DON'T ALWAYS HAVE
THE FACILITIES YOU SOMETIMES
HAVE TO TURN BACK MONEY AND SO.
MAKING SOME OF THESE -- SCHOOL
SITES AND DID NOT JUST FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN BUT FULL DAY
PRESCHOOL -- PROGRAMS WOULD ALSO
BE A GOOD USE OF THAT ONE TIME
MONEY.
PAYMENT YOU'RE JUST TO TRY TO
FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTION -- YOU KNOW BUDGETING
IS A BALANCING A PRIORITIES IN
THE ONE THING THAT YOU'RE.
ANALYSIS ON PAGE TWELVE WILL
NOTE.
IS THE ONE OF THE PRIORITIES WE
BALANCED WAS THIS PRIORITY
VERSUS.
THE CRITICAL NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR STUDENTS.
ACROSS THE BOARD K. THROUGH.
TWELVE AND INTO OUR HIGHER END
OPERATIONS AND SO.
THE MONEY THAT WE DID REMOVE
FROM THIS PARTICULAR LINE ITEM
IN THE BUDGET.
YOU WILL NOTE.
AT ISSUE FORTY ONE ON PAGE FORTY
FOUR OF YOUR ANALYSIS.
WAS MOVED INTO THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL -- FOR A MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES PROGRAM -- WITH
VARIOUS PARTNERSHIPS -- WITH
COUNTY.
MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
THE QUESTIONS ON ISSUE.
NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING
NONE MOVING INTO THE BIG
[inaudible]
KAHUNA.
PROP NINETY EIGHT ISSUE TEN
PEOPLE.
THANK YOU LA -- FOR OUR PROP
NINETY EIGHT PRIMER WHICH I HAVE
TO RE READ EVERY YEAR.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU KIND OF COUPON WITH
THE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT THAT'S
IN YOUR BINDERS OVERVIEW OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT K.
TWELVE ISSUES.
STARTING WITH PAGE ONE OF THAT
HANDLE BOTH HOUSES ADOPTED
SMALLEY REVENUE PACKAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR.
OF THOSE REVENUES LOWER REVENUES
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
YOUR WITH THE STATE IS REQUIRED
TO ALLOCATE TO SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO MEET THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE -- BUT RATHER THAN
REDUCE FUNDING TO THAT MINIMUM
LEVEL BOTH HOUSES UP TO PROVIDE
THE SAME LEVEL OF FUNDING AS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION.
UNDER ALL THREE PLANS TOTAL
GENERAL FUND AND LOCAL PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE FOR SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
IS EIGHTY ONE POINT ONE BILLION
AN INCREASE OF TWO POINT NINE
BILLION OVER EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
LEVEL.
BY TURNING TO PAGE TWO ALTHOUGH
THE PLANS ALL HAVE THE SAME
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THEY DIFFER IN
A COUPLE KEY WAY IS.
A FIRST THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
INCLUDES -- DEPOSIT INTO THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT SCHOOL
RESERVE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE MILLION THAT'S THE
LARGEST OF THE THREE PLANS --
THE SENATE DEPOSITS NINETY
MILLION AND THE ASSEMBLY HAS NO
DEPOSIT.
OUT THE LOWER DEPOSITS UNDER THE
TWO HOUSES PLAN I PRIMARILY
BECAUSE THE HOUSES HAVE THOSE
SMALLER REVENUE PACKAGES.
THE PLANS ALSO MAKE DIFFERENT
CHOICES ABOUT THE MIX OF ONE
TIME AND I'M GOING SPENDING.
THE SENATE PLAN SPENDS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION LESS
ON ON GOING PROGRAMS THAT HAS
AVAILABLE AND I'M GOING
RESOURCES.
SO THAT GIVES THE PLAN A SMALL
OPERATING SURPLUS MOVING FORWARD.
THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN IS FAIRLY
CLOSE TO THE SENATE AS FAR AS
THAT MIX.
BY THE ASSEMBLY PLANTS SPENDS
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION MORE
AN ON GOING PROGRAMS THAN IT HAS
AVAILABLE IN ONGOING RESOURCES
AND SO THAT CREATES A SMALL
DEFICIT MOVING INTO NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET CYCLE.
UNDER ANY OF THE THREE PLANS.
BOB RATHER SMALL BUDGET CUSHION
A MUCH SMALLER THAN YOU HAD IN
PREVIOUS YEARS AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO YOU BECAUSE WHEN
YOU HAVE THAT SMALLER CHRISTIAN
ONGOING PROGRAMS AND MORE
VULNERABLE TO REDUCTIONS THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN.
DURING THE NEXT ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER BUILDING A LARGER
BUDGET QUESTION I YOU COULD DO
THAT BY MAKING ELECTED DEPOSIT
INTO THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT SCHOOL RESERVE.
OR ALLOCATING MORE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FOR ONE
TIME ACTIVITIES.
FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY -- BUT NOT
THE GOVERNOR THE SENATE UP TO
EIGHTEEN SOMETHING KNOWN AS THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT TRIP
ACCOUNT.
THIS IS A MECHANISM THE STATE
CREATED LAST YEAR TO ADJUST
SCHOOL FUNDING AND RESPONSES IN
RESPONSE TO CHANGES IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEED THAT HAPPENED ONCE
THE YEAR IS OVER.
WE RECOMMEND THE ASSEMBLY
SECTION BECAUSE WE THINK THE
TRIP ACCOUNT WITH SOME STEPS
WITHOUT FUNDING ADJUSTMENTS OVER
TIME.
I TURNING TO PAGE THREE ON SOME
OF THE SPECIFIC K. TWELVE
PROPOSALS THE LARGEST
AUGMENTATION UNDER ALL THREE
PLANS FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
GOVERNOR IN THE SENATE EACH
PROVIDE TWO BILLION TO FUND THE
STATUTORY COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION ON TOP OF THAT
AMOUNT WE THINK THE EMPHASIS ON
ON L. CFF UNDER ALL THREE PLANS
MAKE SENSE.
THAT'S GOING TO GIVE SCHOOLS A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABILITY TO
PURSUE THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS
AND FLEXIBLE IN STRATEGIC WAYS.
THE NEXT LARGEST ITEM A SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
BOTH HOUSES REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CREATE A
NEW SIX HUNDRED NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM.
INSTEAD THE HOUSES UP TO
EQUALIZE EXISTING SPECIAL
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING RATES
AND TO PROVIDE NEW ONGOING
FUNDING. FOR PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE DISABILITIES.
WE THINK THE HOUSES TAKE A MUCH
MORE PROMISING APPROACH FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND WE RECOMMEND YOU
MAINTAIN -- HOUSES APPROACH IN
YOUR FINAL BUDGET PACKAGE.
THERE ARE TWO OTHER NOTABLE
DIFFERENCES THE SENATE HAS TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO MILLION
ONE TIME TO SUPPORT ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE.
INTENDED TO INCREASE COLLEGE
PREPARATION AND COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE RATES AMONG LOW
INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND FOSTER YOUTH.
I THE ASSEMBLY HAS AN ACTION TO
SHIFT SOME FUNDING FOR CREEK
TECHNICAL EDUCATION FROM A
PROGRAM THAT IS ADMINISTERED BY
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO A
DIFFERENT PROGRAM THAT'S
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
WE THINK THAT SHIFT CREATES MORE
COHERENT APPROACH TO CREATE
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND WOULD
RECOMMEND YOU ADOPTED.
THE NEXT TWO PAGES IN YOUR HAND
OUT A SHORT OF KEY FUNDING
DIFFERENCES THAT ARE IN
CONFERENCE SO PAGE FOR A SHOWING
YOU THE DIFFERENCES AN ONGOING
SPENDING.
PAGE FIVE THE SHOWING YOU THE
DIFFERENCES IN ONE TIME SPENDING
WILL COVER ALL OF THESE ITEMS
AND LATER AGENDA ITEMS.
BY TURNING TO PAGE SIX AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OF THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED MODIFICATIONS
TO THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED LAST%
YEAR.
EACH HOUSE THEN WENT ON TO ADOPT
SOME OF ITS OWN MODIFICATIONS TO
THE FORMULA.
I BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES WE
THINK THE SENATE PLAN WOULD
REDUCE SOME OF THE VOLATILITY IN
THE FORMULA WILL STILL PROVIDING
STRONG INCENTIVES -- FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS IN STUDENT OUTCOMES.
BOTH HOUSES ALSO PROVIDE MORE ON
GOING FUNDING FOR FACULTY -- BUT
THEY HAVE SOME DIFFERENCES IN
THE AMOUNT APPROVED.
AND FINALLY THE HOUSES TAKE
DIFFERENT ACTIONS FOR SOME ST'S
SUPPORT SERVICE PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER
IS ANSWERED HOUSING PROGRAMS.
PAGE SEVEN SHOWS YOU THE KEY
DIFFERENCE IS AN ONGOING
SPENDING FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND PAGE IT SHOWS YOU
THE DIFFERENCES AND ONE TIME
SPENDING.
WITH THAT OF CLOTHES AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
OF COURSE.
SURE -- ON PAGE TWO THE SIZE OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT RESERVE
DEPOSIT.
ARE YOU USED TERM CUSHION BUT
BUT HOUSE THE RAINY DAY FUND
HOUSE AT CALCULATED.
SO THE SIZE OF THE DEPOSIT INTO
THE RAINY DAY FUND IS DRIVEN BY --
SOME FORMALISM THE CONSTITUTION.
THAT WERE PART OF PROPOSITION
TWO THAT THE VOTERS APPROVED IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN I AT A HIGH
LEVEL ARE THOSE FROM LESS
REQUIRED DEPOSITS WHEN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE.
IS GOING FASTER THERE IS SWEETLY
ABOVE THE PRIOR YEAR FUNDING
LEVEL ADJUSTED FOR CHANGES IN
STUDENT ATTENDANCE AN INFLATION
FACTOR.
SO THE MORE REVENUE THAT YOU
HAVE GENERALLY THE LIGHT TO
DEPOSIT THAT'S REQUIRED THE
LOWER DEPOSITS UNDER THE HOUSES
PLANNER BECAUSE ARE MAINLY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE LOWER REVENUE
ESTIMATES.
AND WHO WAS THE GOVERNOR'S.
RECOMMENDATION CALCULATED
ACCORDING TO THE FORMULA.
YES SO THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED MAKING THE DEPOSIT THAT
WAS REQUIRED UNDER THEIR REVENUE
PACKAGE.
WE DO NOTE THAT YOU ALWAYS HAVE
THE OPTION OF MAKING A LARGE
DEPOSIT THEN THAT AND THEN WHAT
IS REQUIRED.
BEGIN OPTIONAL DEPOSIT -- BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION A PROPOSED
MAKING THE CONSTITUTIONALLY
REQUIRED DEPOSIT UNDER THEIR
REVENUE ANOTHER ASSUMPTIONS
WHAT'S THE CURRENT BALANCE IN
THE RAINY DAY FUND -- CURRENTLY
IT HAS A ZERO BALANCE THE STATE
HAS YET TO MAKE A DEPOSIT INTO
THE REST ARE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT RESERVE.
SO WE HAVE.
ZERO WITH GET THE GOVERNOR
RECOMMENDING.
THE CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED
AMOUNT BUT WE HAVE BOTH HOUSES.
BUT LOWER MATH.
OKAY.
NEXT QUESTION IS ON PAGE --
THREE ON THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING THAT WAS.
WHY ONE OF THE BIG ANNOUNCEMENTS
AT THE MAY REVISED?
WAS FOR THE GOVERNOR TO PUT MORE
FUNDING IN THE SPECIAL EDUCATION --
AND NOW THERE'S PUSH BACK IN YOU
AGREE WITH THE PUSH BACK SO I'M
JUST WONDERING WAS HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT.
WAS IT NOT WELL THOUGHT OUT OF
PREMATURELY WITH.
I TINK WE HAD SOME OF THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD IN JANUARY --
THERE WASN'T A WHOLE LOT OF
CHANGE TO THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM IN MAY IT WAS BUT A MUCH
LIGHTER DOLLAR AMOUNT -- SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INCENTIVES THAT THE PROGRAM
WOULD CREATE WE THOUGHT IT WOULD.
PENALIZE DISTRICTS THAT WERE%
MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES -- WE ALSO THOUGHT
THERE WERE BETTER WAYS TO
DISTRIBUTE THAT FUNDING --
FOCUSING ON SOMETHING LIKE
EQUALIZATION COULD DISTRIBUTE
THAT FUNDING A LITTLE BIT MORE
BROADLY -- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ATTRACTED FUNDING
PRETTY NEARLY TO A SUBSET OF
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE.
OKAY -- WHICH HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE BAKER CRIES HAVING SERVED ON
SUB ONE THAT TO GET MORE MONEY
FOR A FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
SO THE GOVERNOR'S DURING THAT
TIME.
ABOUT TRYING TO ADJUST THAT LAST
QUESTION ON PAGE FOR THE CT
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM WE'VE
BEEN TRYING. TO ENCOURAGE --
MORE FUNDING FOR CAREER TRAINING
EDUCATION AND I'M JUST WONDERING
WHY IT'S IT'S ZERO ACROSS THE
BOARD.
SURE SO FOR THAT THAT -- ONE
IT'S REALLY THE PROPOSAL IS
REALLY A SHIFT OF FUNDING SO
IT'S MORE ABOUT WHETHER YOU WANT
TO FIND AT THE KICKOFF STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM WHICH IS RUN
OUT OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OR YOU WANT TO FIND THE CITY AND
SOME OF GRANT PROGRAM WHICH IS
MORE OF A A COMPETITIVE GRANT
BASED PROGRAM THAT'S FROM OUT OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO THAT'S REALLY THE
ISSUE THAT'S IN CONFERENCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ADMINISTRATION WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND AT ALL.
I'LL MAKE A COUPLE VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS -- FIRST AND MOST
IMPORTANT ON THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT LEVEL -- THE
ADMINISTRATION OF COURSE
SUPPORTS OUR MAY REVISION
REVENUES COMPLETE WITH THAT TAX
CONFORMITY PACKAGE WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
AND ALSO PROVIDES MORE REVENUE.
ACOSTA BUDGET BUT I DO WANT TO
ALSO POINT OUT FOR THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE -- ONE
IMPORTANT TO KNOW IF WE IF THAT
COMMITTEE ADOPTS A LOWER REVENUE
TARGET BUT OVER PROPERTY TO
GUARANTEE AT THE LEVEL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED.
REVISION AND THEN -- BECAUSE AS
WE ALL KNOW PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT IS BASED ON ACTUAL
REVENUES NOT ESTIMATED REVENUES
SO REVENUES DO CON AND ABOVE --
WHAT THE LEGISLATOR IS
PROJECTION -- OVER THE UPCOMING
YEAR -- ACCORDING TO THE WAY
WE'RE SEEING THE PROPOSITION
NINETY GUARANTEE RIGHT NOW THAT
ADDITIONAL MONEY -- WILL
ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE DEPOSITED IN
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT RESERVE
RATHER THAN BEING GOING DIRECTLY
TO SCHOOLS AT ALL AS THE
LEGISLATURE IS PROJECTING.
SAID THAT COULD CREATE A WHOLE
OF POSSIBLY SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET
PACKAGE IF THE LEGISLATURE MOVES
FORWARD THAT WITH THAT APPROACH.
I'M I'M HERE TO APPLY THE
GOVERNOR I'M I I WANT TO VOTE
FOR A FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR COUNTRYSIDE BOTH FOR
TRIPLE THAT.
LOOKING AT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
WITH WITH THE NINE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR DISTRICTS IN AND
LOOKING AT THEIR FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS.
WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT ISSUES AND
AND AND IT'S EMBARRASSING THAT
THE BALANCE CURRENTLY IS.
ZERO TOLD.
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING UP TO IT
I APPRECIATE.
SO I WILL SAY IT WHILE WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THANKS -- IT'S
DOING IT BECAUSE IT IS REQUIRED
BY THE CONSTITUTION [inaudible]
RIGHT.
BUT YOU GET TO PROPOSALS THAT
ARE LOWER.
THE BY A TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THREE
OPTIONS I AM TELLING YOU
PUBLICLY I SUPPORT YOURS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] THIRTY
ALSO.
IT'S NOTED HERE ON PAGE.
THREE THE K. TWELVE PRIORITIES
AND THE ASSEMBLY ACTION WAS TO
SHIP THE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
FROM THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM.
A TO THE CAREER TECH ADD
INCENTIVE GRANTS -- THEN IT WAS
ASSEMBLY REMEMBER WHAT THE LOGIC
WOULD THAT BE SHOWN PARTY.
SURE THAT SYMPATHY WITH IT BUT I
YEAH THE NOTION WAS WE ARE WE
ALL LIVE CD WE TRIED TO TO HAVE
A THAT.
AS A AS A CATEGORICAL FOR YEARS
AGO.
AS AS OPPOSED JUST A ONE TIME.
AS THE PRIOR GOVERNOR.
HAD IT AND SO WE WE SAT ON THE
AMOUNT OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION
BUT LAST YEAR WE HAD TO PROGRAMS
ONE AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM
KIND OF RUNNING A K. TWELVE
EFFORT.
AND THIS QUE TWELFTH AND SO I
THINK THAT THE THE THE THE
LARGER ADVOCATES FOR C. T. AND
THE ASSEMBLY FELT IT WAS BETTER
TO KEEP IT IN OR THE EXISTING.
K. TWELVE CT PROGRAM AND THAT
THEY HAVE THE THE CENTER
GRANVILLE'S GO.
YEAH IS THE THE K. TWELVE
INCENTIVE GRANT EFFORT WHICH HE
BEEN USING WITHOUT WAS BUT
SUPPORT WAS MORE SUCCESSFUL SO
WAS JUST A GOOD SOLID IN UNDER.
ONE WELL AS AS A DADDY THE
SENATE GRANT PROGRAM YEARS AGO I
COMMEND YOU FOR THIS YOU KNOW
BUT BUT THREE YEARS AGO.
MAYBE FOR NOW THE WHOLE
INCENTIVE GRANT WAS WIPED OUT.
REX.
AND THEN IT CAME SAILING BACK
AND WAS EXPANDED FROM JUST GREW
TECH B<c.cyan> AG ADD TO ALL CAREER</c>
TECH.
AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
IS IT'S SOME DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING. TO THESE CAREER TECH
PROGRAMS THAT REALLY ARE
SUCCESSFUL AND THIS
DISCRETIONARY.
REVENUE HAS GIVEN THEM A HUGE
BOOKS SO I'M VERY MUCH IN
SYMPATHY WITH THIS ASSEMBLY
ACTION [inaudible]
MR BROUGHT.
I THANK YOU SO.
I JUST HAVE TO EXPRESS ALL OF
FRUSTRATION HERE.
JUST TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT.
VIEW HERE SO WERE.
THE MINISTRATIONS OF FUNDING
JUST THE BARE PROP NINETY
GUARANTEE AND AND THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY HAVE DONE.
SUBS A LITTLE BIT MORE I MEAN
ALIKE ON THE ORDER OF A COUPLE
PERCENTAGE POINTS.
AND IF WE PASS.
THIS WAY WE WILL BE ABOUT
DIGITAL AMOUNT TO A MODEST PER
CAPITA STUDENT SPENDING INCREASE
WILL TAKE US JUST TO ABOVE
GINGER JUST OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
IN K. TWELVE EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT PUTS US FORTY FIRST IN THE
COUNTRY [inaudible]
AND A THE GIVEN THE COST IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO BE IN THE
TOP TEN NOT IN THE BOTTOM.
TEN SO I'M JUST WONDERING MATHIS.
I KNOW I'M I'M PREACHING THE
CHOIR AND WE WOULD ALL LIKE TO
FIND CALTRAIN TWELVE EDUCATION
AT A HIGHER LEVEL MR MCCARTY AND
I HAVE A BILL ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO CHEAT IT
EXPRESSES THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
TO GET.
TO THE FIFTIETH PERCENTILE AMONG
STATES.
THAT WERE SENT OVER TO THE
SENATE BUT NOT NOT THAT'S JUST
INTENT LANGUAGE THAT THE
DECISIONS THAT AFFECT THAT
HAPPENED HERE.
EVERY YEAR AND I'VE BEEN ON
CONFERENCE DOWN THREE YEARS AND
EVERY YEAR WE TALK ABOUT WANTING
TO FUND K. TWELVE EDUCATION AT A
HIGHER LEVEL I THINK IF YOU LOOK
AT THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IN
K. TWELVE IN CALIFORNIA A LOT OF
THEM.
STEM DIRECTLY FROM THE FACT THAT.
WE DON'T FUNDED AN PPROPRIATE
LEVEL SO I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT
THE WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLAN IS ON THIS.
AND THE REASON WHY I'M
FRUSTRATED I MEAN I KNOW WE CAN
POUND THE TABLE SO WE WANT MORE
MONEY AND THERE IS MORE MONEY
BUT EERY TIME WE MAKE A
DECISION TO FIND.
ANOTHER PROGRAM AND I THERE'S
LOTS OF NEEDS OUT THERE AND IT
TUGS AT THE HEARTSTRINGS EVERY
TIME WE WE TALK ABOUT -- EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION OR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN OR
AFTER SCHOOL AND YOU KNOW THAT
THESE ARE ALL CERTAINLY GOOD.
PROGRAMS BUT EVERY TIME WE SPEND
A DOLLAR IN ONE OF THOSE IT'S A
DOLLAR THAT WE COULD HAVE SPENT
ON K. TWELVE AND I JUST KIND OF
FEEL LIKE.
WE NEED.
TO MEET OUR COMMITMENT. TWO
EXCELLENTK. TWELVE EDUCATION
BEFORE WE DIVERSIFY SO. TO PUT
IT BACK ON THE THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES THEIR PLAN HERE YOU
KNOW YOUR EVERYYEAR TO GET TO A
POINT WHERE WERE.
NOT IN THE BOTTOM HALF OF THE
PER CAPITA STUDENT FUNDING AND
FOR K. TWELVE AMONG STATES.
SO WE CERTAINLY SHARE THAT GOAL
OF WANTING TO INVEST MORE IN OUR
SCHOOLS THAT IS A PRIORITY OF
THE GOVERNOR AND SO THE FIRST
POINT AND I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS
BUT THIS HAPPENS YEAR BY YEAR
AND SO WE ARE NOW TO PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT LEVEL.
LESS THAN A DECADE AGO WAS FORTY
SEVEN BILLION NOW WE'RE
PROPOSING ABOUT EIGHTY BILLION
SO THAT'S OVER ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WOULD YOU THINK THAT IS WE
ARE GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
AND THEN THE SECOND POINT I WANT
TO MAKE IS THAT THERE IS A
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD ABOUT HOW
WE CAN INVEST EVEN MORE IN THE
YEARS TO COME CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER PRESSURES ON THE GENERAL
FUND.
BUT I WILL POINT OUT IN THIS
BUDGET ALTHOUGH PROP PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT IS THE PRIMARY
VEHICLE FOR SENDING MONEY TO
SCHOOLS THERE ARE OTHER MEASURES
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
TAKING THAT REALLY DO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE AND WE HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT CAL STARS
BEFORE.
THAT BY ITSELF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S GOING TO CAL
STARS -- ON BEHALF OF SCHOOLS WE
ALSO HAVE YOU MEASURES IN OUR
BUDGET FOR TEACHER TRAINING WERE
ACTUALLY RE BENCHING THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEEING PULLING OUT SOME
NON ELLIE A PRE CASE LOTS WE'RE
ADDING NEW PRE K. SLOT SO I
THINK WHEN YOU ADD UPALL THESE
MEASURES TOGETHER.
IT IS A PRETTYSIGNIFICANT
PACKAGE RESPECTING THE FACT AS
YOU STARTED THAT WE DO HAVE MORE
TO GO FROM HERE OKAY WELL.
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND I I
THINK THAT.
A LOT OF THE STATISTICS THAT I
QUOTED DON'T INCLUDE EFFORTS
INCLUDING THE ONES THAT YOU
MENTION IN OUR FACILITIES
FUNDING -- AND OUR BOND FUND AND
THEN ANOTHER.
THAT WERE TAKING BUT I JUST
THINK WE ALL NEED TO BE MINDFUL
OF THE FACT THAT PROP.
NINETY EIGHT IT IS COMPLETELY IN
A SEPARATE.
CONSIDERATION THEY ON THE LEVEL
AT WHICH WE SHOULD BE FUNDING
EDUCATION AND I THINK WE GET
CAUGHT UP.
IN THIS IDEA THAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT HE SHOULD BE THE LEVEL
THAT WE FIND.
K. TWELVE EDUCATION AT YOU KNOW
AND THEN WE MOVE ON TO OTHER
THINGS AND IT'S KIND OF THIS
ARTIFICIAL CONSTRUCT I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE A HOLISTIC
LOOK AT WHAT OUR MISSION IS
SUPPOSED TO BE IN FUNDING K.
TWELVE FIGURE OUT WHAT
APPROPRIATE FUNDING LEVEL FOR
THAT.
IS AND THEN JUST MAKE SURE
THAT'S ABOVE WHAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT OF THE RESTRICTIONS THAT
PUTS ON WHICH WILL BE.
SO SO IN OTHER WORDS I MEAN I
THINK THE PERSON WE'RE LOOKING
AT PROP NINETY EIGHT IS KIND OF
THE CEILING AND IT SHOULD BE THE
FLOOR.
AND I REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
IN FUTURE YEARS TO YOU KNOW TO
BE MINDFUL OF THAT BECAUSE I
WANT TO BE SITTING HERE ANOTHER
THREE YEARS FROM NOW HAVING THIS
THE SAME DISCUSSION ABOUT IT
[inaudible]
THE GARAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER FISHER -- I
JUST WANTED.
COME BACK TO THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM AND CREW TECH
EDUCATION CENTER BRIDGES FOR A
MOMENT JUST.
TO INDICATE THAT I I HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE A DIALOGUE.
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE IS I
UNDERSTAND THE K. TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
IT IS DIRECTLY ALIGNED WITH
REGIONAL WORK FORCE NEEDS.
PUTTING TRAINING FOLKS BOTH
YOUNG AND SOME NOT SO YOUNG. FOR
THE JOBS THAT ACTUALLY EXIST IN
A REGION.
AND THAT THE CAREER TECH EDUCATE.
EDUCATION SAID OF RIP PROGRAM IS
MORE ALIGNED WITH GIVING.
FOLKS SORT OF A A JOB EXPERIENCE
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S OUT THERE.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT I HAVE THE
RIGHT SIDE PICTURE ON IT THAT'S
WHY I HOPE WE GET TO HAVE A
DIALOGUE ON IT BUT IF THAT'S THE
CASE.
THEN FOR AREAS SUCH AS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN FOR IN ONE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
FRANKLY I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO FUND PROGRAMS THAT
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY.
WHAT THE SKILLS ARE IN THE JOBS
ARE IN THE REGION?
AND GIVE FOLKS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRAIN UP FOR THOSE JOBS SO
THEY ACTUALLY CAN SECURE.
A GOOD SOLID.
WELL PAYING A POSITION AT THE
END OF THE OF THE PIPELINE AND
SO I DON'T WANT TO LOSE SIGHT OF
THAT IN MAY AND I DON'T FRANKLY
CARE WHO RUNS IT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE K. THROUGH TWELVE THAT'S
I'M AGNOSTIC ON THAT.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
ABOUT THAT -- BEFORE WE
ELIMINATE ONE PROGRAM -- IN
FAVOR OF ANOTHER ONE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE ONE WE'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO THIS GOING TO BE THE
SURVIVOR.
IS GOING TO ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH.
THAT VERY VERY IMPORTANT
OBJECTIVE AT LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU OF STRUCTURE WILL SAY --
FROM FINANCE AND A BRIEF WE TURN
INTO MY COLLEAGUE BUT THAT IS A
PERSPECTIVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SHARES I THINK
THE GOAL OF EXPANDING ACCESS TO
CREATE TECHNOLOGIC ASIAN
SOMETHING THAT ALL OF US CARE
ABOUT BUT THAT SPECIFIC EMPHASIS
ON REGIONAL COORDINATION
REGIONAL ASSESSMENT OF NEEDS.
AND REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS ACOSTA
INSTITUTIONS IN A SPECIFIC AREA
IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION MADE THE PROPOSAL
THAT IT'D.
BUT MAY JUST FOLLOW UP I I DON'T
KNOW I ASSUME THERE'S SOME.
STUDY YOUR REVIEW THAT AT SOME
POINT WILL GO ON TO WHICH YOU
HAVE TO PROGRAMS IT ESSENTIALLY
DO THE SAME.
THAT SOMEWHAT DO THE SAME THING
THAT WE CAN DETERMINE WHICH ONE
IS MORE.
EFFECTIVE IN ACCOMPLISHING THE
OBJECTIVE MAYBE THEY BOTH ARE
AND IF THEY BOTH ARE MAYBE THEY
MERGE AND IF THEY'RE NOT MAYBE
WE SHOULD JUST.
ELIMINATE ONE OR THE OTHER
WHETHER IT'S STRONG WORKFORCE
WHETHER ITS CREW TECH -- IN SAID
EDUCATION INCENTIVE GRANT I
DON'T KNOW.
AMBER ALEXANDER WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND SENATOR ROTH
YOU'VE YOU'VE HAD ON THAT ONE OF
THE KEY DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
K. TWELVE COMPONENT OF THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM IN THE
C. T. E. INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM.
AND REALLY THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
WHY BOTH PROGRAMS EXIST AND WERE
ENACTED IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET.
ON THE CAGE WALL FROM WORK FIRST
PROGRAM REALLY IS ALIGNED WITH
REGIONAL WORKFORCE NEEDS -- THE
EIGHT REGIONS THAT ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAMS DEVELOPED LOCAL
PLANS AND THAT IDENTIFIES THE
KEY PRIORITY INDUSTRY AREAS IN
THEIR IN THEIR REGIONS.
AND THEN THE CITY PROGRAMS THAT
ARE AWARDED FUNDING UNDER THE
GRANT PROGRAM HAVE TO ALIGN WITH
THOSE IDENTIFIED REGION
IDENTIFIED INDUSTRY PRIORITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN -- LOCALLY
DETERMINED.
WE WILL THERE BE SOME ULTIMATE
REVIEWED TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER ONE OR THE OTHER IT
BETTER ACCOMPLISHES THE GOALS OF
WHETHER BOTH ACCOMPLISH VERY
VERY IMPORTANT GOALS COMING TO
THE SAME.
POINT FROM DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS.
AND AND THATIS -- A DISCUSSION
THAT HAS BEEN OCCURRING SINCE
LAST YEAR I THINK THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO PROGRAMS HAS
REALLY THEIR OBJECTIVE THE
CAREFUL STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM IS IS MORE WORK FOR
STRIPPING.
ON THE C. T. E. INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM IS AS YOU MENTIONED --
YOU KNOW TO INCENTIVIZE CITY
PROGRAMS LOCALLY BUT THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY ALIGNED TO WORK
FORCE NEEDS IN THE REGIONS -- SO
THE CONVERSATION HAPPENED
HAPPENING BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ON HOW THE
TWO PROGRAMS CAN COMPLEMENT EACH
OTHER.
AND HOW -- ELEAZAR APPLYING FOR
BOTH PROGRAMS CAN LEVERAGE THAT
FUNDING TO REALLY PROMOTE CTP --
YOU KNOW TO TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
FINE I DIDN'T MEAN TO BELABOR
THIS I JUST WANTED.
TO INDICATE THAT I'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS BEFORE WE ELIMINATE
ONE PROGRAM OVER ANOTHER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS
ISSUED IN.
GOTICKETS WE GOT BACK TO THE
BLUE PAGES ALL RIGHT.
A PROP NINETY EIGHT ISSUE.
TEN THANK YOU SO I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS IF I MAY
TURN THINGS OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
FOR ISSUE ELEVEN PERFECT.
ANY QUESTIONS.
I THOUGHT WE'D GONE BACK COME TO
DO EVERYBODY'S COOL THAT'LL BE
PASSED ISSUE.
TEN WONDERFUL ISSUE ELEVEN THANK
YOU.
BRIAN ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ISSUE OF IN HIS
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION --
THERE ARE A COUPLE SMALLER ITEMS
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SITE
HERE THE SENATE PROVIDED ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING.
TO A SCENE OF A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR CONSTRUCTION TRADES
PROGRAM.
AND THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDED ONE
MILLION EACH TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN SIX DIFFERENT
COUNTIES -- THE LARGEST ISSUE AS
WE JUST DISCUSSED IN THE LAST --
ISSUE.
IS THE ASSEMBLY SECTION TO
CONSOLIDATE K..
TWELVE TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS UNDER THE EXISTING CITY
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THE ASSEMBLY IS
ACTION ON THIS.
THING.
WE ALL OF ALREADY HAD A
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS I WON'T
BELABOR THESE POINTS.
HELLO JUST NOTE THAT -- WHAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE FIELD IS
THAT THERE IS SOME CONFUSION
ABOUT WHAT WAS THE STATE'S
INTENSE AND SETTING UP THESE TWO
PROGRAMS ALTHOUGH THERE IS --
THIS DIFFERENCE IN SCOPE THAT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED ABOUT THE
ALIGNMENT WITH REGIONAL
WORKFORCE NEEDS [inaudible]
THAT'S NOT -- TAKING
CONTRADICTORY OF WITH THE GOALS
OF THE SEATING INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM MOM MANY PROGRAMS ARE.
LOOKING AT BOTH OF THESE AS
POTENTIAL SOURCES OF OF FUNDING
AND SO THERE'S UNNECESSARY
DUPLICATION OF EFFORT IN TERMS
OF APPLICATIONS.
AND MAKING THESE DECISIONS ABOUT
WHICH IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE
FUNDS FOR US WE WE THINK.
THESE ISSUES COULD BE RESOLVED
BY CONSOLIDATING UNDER SINGLE
AGENCY CD DOES. TO OUR MIND
APPEAR TO BE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE AGENCY GIVEN THEIR
HISTORY WORKING WITH K. TWELVE
CT PROGRAMS.
AND WE THINK IT'S A WORTHWHILE
DISCUSSION IF YOU'D LIKE TO
REVISIT THE SCOPE OF THE C. T.
INCENTIVE GRANT IN MAKING THIS
DECISION TO CONSOLIDATE UNDER
THAT AGENCY [inaudible] THIRTY
SKINNER.
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
LA -- IN IN.
MAKING THAT RECOMMENDATION
ASSESSED.
THE ISSUES FOR EXAMPLE THAT --
GENERAL ROTH POINTED OUT OF THE
AT LEAST FROM WHAT THE MATERIALS
I'VE READ ABOUT THE CITY.
PROGRAM WHICH I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF BUT IT IS NOT
NECESSARILY FOCUSED ON THE JOB
SKILL DEVELOPMENT UNIQUE TO A
PARTICULAR REGION -- SO IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS THAT.
YEAH AS WAS DISCUSSED A LITTLE
BIT IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE TWO PROGRAMS IT
WOULD BE THE FOCUS THAT THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM HAS.
ON REGIONAL JOB SKILLS AND
CERTAINLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS A
REASONABLE INTEREST IN ST --
THAT THAT POLICY OBJECTIVE IS
INCLUDED AND THEIR K. TWELVE CT
PROGRAMS.
WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT -- RATHER
THAN CONTINUING THESE TWO
PROGRAMS THAT ARE LARGELY
DUPLICATIVE WITH THIS -- THE
SLIGHTLY NUANCED DIFFERENCE IN
SCOPE.
AB TO REVISIT THE SCOPE OF THE
C. T. INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT INCLUDES THAT
CONCERN IF THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO BE
A PRIORITY [inaudible]
SENATE ROTH.
WELL I'M DO I'M JUST CURIOUS AND
I I NEED.
TO FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR MORLOCKS QUESTION AND GO
BACK TO THE BOOKS ON THIS ONE AS
WELL BUT IN THE IN THE X. CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION CENTER GRANT
PROGRAM IT'S ADMINISTERED BY
CITY.
THAT'S CORRECT THE SOLE OF MY
UNDERSTANDING WITH RESPECT TO
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
IT'S SORT OF A REGIONAL CLEVER
TELL US I'M SORRY THAT SIXTEEN
SENATE GRANT PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY CDC THIS STRONG
WORK FORCES MINISTERED BY.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES RIGHT MY
UNDERSTANDING ON THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM HOWEVER IT'S A
IT'S A IT'S A REGIONAL
CLEVERNESS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S EMPLOYER ORGANIZATIONS.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGES K. THROUGH
TWELVE ELEAZAR K.. TO TWELVE TO
TRY TO IDENTIFY JOB SKILLS AND
THEN K. AS IN FOR IN TERMS OF SO
THAT'S THE DEMAND SIDE WHICH
FRANKLY I THINK WE NEED.
TO IMPROVE BUT THAT'S THE DEMAND
SIDE IN TERMS OF IDENTIFYING
SKILLS AND JOB NEEDS.
AND THEN THE EDUCATIONAL A
COLLABORATION DECIDES TO HOW TO
DESIGN THE THE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS. TO MEET THOSE
SKILLS IN THOSE JOB NEEDS
WHETHER IT'S AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL OR AT THE CASE OF
TWELVE I GOT THE RIGHT GENOCIDE
PICTURE YOU DO.
SO TODAY DOES THE CAREER TECH
EDUCATION CENTER GRANT PROCESS.
IN COMPASS THAT SAME TYPE OF OF
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
BUT NOT ON A REGIONAL BASIS NOW
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MANAGER [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
I JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT FROM
PLEASE -- SO I KNOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE STRONG WORK FORCE
VERSUS C. T. -- SPECIFICALLY ON
THE INVESTMENTS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- THE ADMINISTRATION --
SUPPORTS ITS OWN PROPOSAL AND
DOES NOT SUPPORT THOSE
AUGMENTATIONS -- NOT BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT WORTHY PROGRAMS BUT
BECAUSE THEY FALL WITHIN THAT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE SO WOULD BE.
PREMISED ON REDUCTIONS IN OTHER
AREAS OF THE EIGHTY ONE POINT
ONE BILLION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I SEE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS.
WE WILL MOVE ON TWO WELL BUT
FIRST WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM THE
LA JOH.
ON CAVE TO FOURTEEN PENSION RATE
RELIEF PROPOSALS.
ALRIGHT SO FOR THIS ISSUE WE
HAVE ANOTHER HANDOUT THAT TO SET
THE STAGE BECAUSE YOU'LL BE
HEARING ABOUT THIS AND THIS ITEM
AND THEN SEVERAL SUBSEQUENT
ITEMS THROUGHOUT YOUR CONFERENCE
AGENDA.
ALSO STARTING WITH PAGE ONE BOTH
THE GOVERNOR THE GOVERNOR IN
BOTH HOUSES HAVE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS RELATED TO THE PENSION
COSTS FOR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND AS YOU KNOW -- THE STATUS TO
PENSION SYSTEMS FOR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES CAL STAR IS
ADMINISTERS PENSION BENEFITS FOR
STATE POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES LIKE
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS.
AND CALPERS ADMINISTERS PENSION
BENEFITS FOR ALL OTHER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES LIKE CAFETERIA WORKERS
OR BUS DRIVERS.
AT TO READ REITERATE SOMETHING
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S SAID
EARLIER -- THE PROPOSALS BEFORE
YOU REALLY COME IN TWO FLAVORS
SOME ARE INTENDED TO PROVIDE
SCHOOLS OF SHORT TERMBUDGET
RELEASED OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
I THINK THE ANALOGY THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MCCARTY AND
OBERNOLTE RAISED EARLIER ABOUT
THAT BEING LIKE THE SOMEONE
PAYING -- A MORTGAGE PAYMENTS ON
YOUR BEHALF FOR TWO YEARS AS AN
APT VERY APT ANALOGY.
THE OTHER PROPOSALS ARE INTENDED
TO PROVIDE LONG TERM RELEASED BY
PAYING DOWN UNFUNDED LOT PENSION
LIABILITIES.
AND AGAIN THAT'S A BIT MORE LIKE
PAYING DOWN THE PRINCIPAL OF OF
THE MORTGAGE SOMETHING HAT
REDUCES COSTS AND PAYMENTS OVER
A PERIOD OF TWENTY TO THIRTY
YEARS.
THAT SO STARTING IN WITH JUST
THE SHORT TERM PROPOSALS I MAY
HAVE A TABLE WITH THAT AND PAGE
TWO OF OUR HAND OUT -- THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION IN SHORT TERM
RATE RELEASE.
THE SENATE PROVIDES ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION IN THE ASSEMBLY
PROVIDES ONE POINT TWO BILLION.
APART FROM THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS
THERE REALLY TWO MAJOR
DIFFERENCES AMONG THE PLANS.
FIRST THE GOVERNOR PROVIDES
RELIEF SPECIFICALLY FOR TEACHERS
AND OTHER EMPLOYEES COVERED BY
CAL STAR IS WHEREAS BOTH HOUSES
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR EMPLOYEES
COVERED -- FOR BY EITHER PENSION
SYSTEM.
THE GOVERNOR IN THE ASSEMBLY
ALSO PROPOSED TO PAY FOR ALL OF
THAT RELIEF NOW AS PART OF THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET.
WHERE IS THE SENATE DIFFERS SOME
OF THOSE COSTS TO NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET?
TURNING TO THE LONG TERM
PROPOSALS AT THE GOVERNOR AND
BOTH HOUSES MAKE A PAYMENT OF
TWO POINT THREE BILLION TO
REDUCE.
THE SCHOOL SHARE OF UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES THAT CAL STAR IS.
BY THE ASSEMBLY MAKES THAT
PAYMENT BUT ALSO HAS ANOTHER
PAYMENT OF ONE POINT TWO BILLION --
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE POOL OF
FUNDS -- THAT'S USED TO
ADMINISTER BENEFITS -- FOR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES WHAT
PAYMENT TO CAL CALPERS --
TURNING TO PAGE.
THREE WE RECOGNIZE THAT ALL
PLANS HAVE A BOTH SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM RELATE RATE RELEASE ON
THAT SIDE WAS A KEY PART OF ALL
THREE PACKAGES.
BUT ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES BEFORE
YOU IS ON THE MARGIN HOW MUCH
FUNDING YOU ONE ALLOCATE NOW TO
SHORT TERM VERSUS LONG TERM
RELEASE.
AND AND MAKING THAT DECISION WE
WOULD URGE YOU TO PRIORITIZE THE
LONG TERM RELIEF. ONE REASON IS
THAT THAT GETS YOU AGREE TO
RETURN. FOR EVERY DOLLAR YOU PUT
IN THE SHORT TERM RELEASED A
SCHOOL SAVE A DOLLAR OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT TWO YEARS --%
BUT FOR EVERY DOLLAR YOU PUT
INTO LONG TERM RELIEF A SCHOOL
SAVE TWO TO THREE DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT FEW DECADES.
ANOTHER REASON IS THAT THE LONG
TERM RELIEF PROVIDES -- SORT OF
BUDGET HELP FOR DISTRICTS ON
MORE OF A SUSTAINED BASIS SO
RATHER THAN JUST HELPING
DISTRICTS BALANCE THEIR BUDGETS
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS -- THAT
COULD HELP SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
THE ECONOMIC UPS AND DOWNS THAT
LIE AHEAD.
A HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
YEAH. ONE TWO ISSUE TWELVE
CHARACTERS AND CALPERS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES.
I'M SORRY BELIEVE FOR AN ISSUE.
THIRTEEN OF COURSE WE ARE --
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA THANK
YOU.
NO PROBLEM.
SO -- THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA IS THE STATE'S PRIMARY
MECHANISM FOR FUNDING.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS THE GOVERNOR IN NINETEEN
TWENTY TO REFLECT A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT A THREE POINT.
26% AND ALSO FUND SOME OF THE ON
GOING COSTS IN NINETEEN TWENTY
OF SUPPORTING THE LCS PFAFF --
IS SPECIFICALLY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS OF
THAT COST WITH SOME ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDS.
THE SENATE PROIDES THE SAME
INCREASE AVAIL CFF IS THE
GOVERNOR BUT ELIMINATES THE
FUNDS SPONSORED DOES NOT USE ONE
TIME FUNDS TO COVER ANY ONGOING
I'LL SEE IF OF COSTS.
IN THE ASSEMBLY -- PROVIDES A
LARGER INCREASE OF ABOUT TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION.
REPRESENTING AN EFFECTIVE COLA
RATE OF THREE POINT 88%.
OF THE ASSEMBLY ALSO DEDICATES
ONE HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN MILLION
AND ONE TIME FUNDS TO PAYING
SOME ON GOING COSTS AND I'LL SEE
IF OF CONSISTENT WITH OUR
OFFICES --LONG STANDING
RECOMMENDATION ON USING ON GOING
FUNDING SOURCES TO COVER ON
GOING COSTS WE ARE RECOMMENDING
THE SENATE ACTION IN THAT REGARD.
OF BUDGETING SUCH THE WITH THE
IN YOUR ON GOING PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT THE PACKAGE YOU ARE
ABLE TO COVER THE ENTIRE COST OF
ELSE IF [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEE NINE AGAIN WILL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN PENDING.
MISTER MCCARTY SORRY I THOUGHT
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM FINANCE DO
SO.
SURE I'LL SAY VERY BRIEFLY THAT --
FINANCE GENERALLY SUPPORTS THE
SENATE APPROACH TO THIS ISSUE.
OKAY -- AND SO -- MY COMMENTS
WILL BE.
WHAT DAHLE CHANNEL WHAT MISTER
OBERNOLTE HAD NOTED EARLIER?
WHICH IS -- YEAH WE HAVE
INCREASED SCHOOL FUNDING AS AS
YOU KNOW TWO BY. 50% A ROUGHLY.
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
OR STILL FORTY FIRST THE NATION
AND ANY GETS ITS MIND -- BLOWING
TOO MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE'VE HAD THIS HUGE
INCREASE AND WE HAVE MORE
DISTRICTS ON THE BREAK THERE
BEFORE.
YOU KNOW RIGHT HERE.
IN -- IN SACRAMENTO LA IN
OAKLAND NOPE SENATOR ROTH.
THIS AND THE SENATE HAD A
LENGTHY HEARING WITH FAKE MATT.
A FEW MONTHS AGO -- BUT I TUNED
IN IT AND WATCHED YOUR HEARING I
THOUGHT IT WAS IT WAS GREAT
DISCUSSIONS FAR AS WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
WITH OUR WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SO -- YOU KNOW
THIS CALL IS IS IS AN IMPORTANT
CALL ABOUT IT IT'S JUST A BAND
AID I THINK WE NEED A REALITY
CHECK.
THAT WE CAN PUT OURSELVES IN THE
BACK AS FAR AS WE'RE WE'VE BEEN
SINCE THE GREAT RECESSION.
BUT TODD TELL THAT TO SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW IT.
SUPERINTENDENTS ARE TEACHERS IN
THE WORKS AS FAR AS WHAT THAT
REALLY MEANS IN OUR CLASSROOMS
ON I WANT TO BE THAT FUN PLACE
HERE AND SAY THAT.
NEGATIVE STOP I THINK IT'S JUST
A REALITY CHECK FOR SEARS
UNDERSTAND AND WE'VE BEEN AS YOU
NOTED THERE ARE TWO ISSUES THERE
IS HOW WE ALLOCATE FUNDING
WITHIN THE GUARANTEE AND THAT'S
YOU KNOW THE DISCUSSION AROUND
THE CALL AND SO WE BELIEVE THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT.
FOR NOW IS THREE POINT 26% AND
WE ALSO KNOW THERE'S A
DISCUSSION WHICH LA -- BRIEFLY
TOUCHED ON AROUND CERTIFICATION
AND HOW THAT CALL -- WHAT
HAPPENS TO IT IN FUTURE YEARS I
AM HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THAT AS
WELL A DAY AS YOU NOTED --
LARGER CONVERSATION ABOUT WHERE
EDUCATION FUNDING GOES FROM HERE
AND SAID THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
NOT SUPPORT THE SPECIFIC.
INTENT LANGUAGE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSED -- BUT WE DO
WANT TO ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHERE
EDUCATION FUNDING GOES FROM HERE
[inaudible]
THIS WEBER.
YES -- I I APPRECIATE THE THE
THE CONVERSATION FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AND ALL AND AS YOU
KNOW I'VE I'M JULIE VERY SILENT
WHEN IT COMES -- TO RAISING US
UP FROM FORTY ONE TO WHEREVER WE
WANT TO BE -- MAINLY BECAUSE
I'VE HEARD THAT CONVERSATION FOR
SEVEN YEARS AND I'VE SEEN NO
PROGRESS AND IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT
IT'S OUR FAULT -- AND I DON'T
ENGAGE IN THE CONVERSATIONALIST
PEOPLE SERIOUS ABOUT ACTUALLY
DOING THAT AND IT'S GONNA TAKE
MORE THAN JUST.
A SHUFFLING THE CHEERS ON THE
TITANIC.
THE REALITY IS IS THAT PROP
THIRTEEN GUIDED US IN AND
CHANGED US IMMENSELY AND WE'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THAT NOW
SINCE. NINETEEN SEVENTY I THINK
IT WAS A WHENEVER AND IT WOULD
NOT CHANGE IT WILL NOT CHANGE
UNTIL WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
LOOKING AT REVENUE WHERE IT
COMES FROM AND HOW WE FUND
SCHOOLS.
AND SO I YOU KNOW I AS A AS I
DON'T SAY A WHOLE LOT BECAUSE IT
YOU KNOW I I I'M FRUSTRATED BY
OTHER THINGS AND AND THOSE
THINGS I CAN PROBABLY SOLVE.
THIS ONE CAN BE SOLVED TO WITH
THE COURAGE DOESN'T LIVE WITHIN
BOTH HOUSES TO DO IT AND HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT -- REQUIRES
DRAMATIC CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE CAN TALK ABOUT BEING FORTY
ONE OF FORTY EIGHT AND A HALF
ALL FORTY EIGHT OF FORTY IF WE
CAN TALK ABOUT OUR SCHOOLS
SINKING AND THEY'RE DROWNING.
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT WE
ENVISION HOW WE WANT TO BE LIKE
KENTUCKY IN NEW YORK MASS
WHEREVER WE WANT TO GO.
BUT IT'S NOT WOULD NOT GOING
THERE WITH THE CONSTANT PROCESS
THAT NGUYEN GAYS IN NOW.
SO I AM LOOKING FOR A GROUP OF
SIRIUS LEGISLATORS WHO REALLY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
AND BE COURAGEOUS ABOUT GETTING
THE INFORMATION TO CALIFORNIA
AND THAT'S DECIDING THAT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO.
WE ARE NOT ONLY SINKING OUR K.
TWELVE WAS THINKING OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS AND ALL OF
THOSE BECAUSE OF HOW WE FUND
EDUCATION.
SO WE NEED TO STOP THINKING THAT
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE CAN.
MAYBE NOT GIVE ADDITIONAL SLOT
IN PRESCHOOL THAT WE ALL OF A
SUDDEN GOING TO RISE UP TO
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
AND AND I'M NOT THE GREAT.
ECONOMIST AROUND HERE MOST OF
YOU ARE BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN IN THIS CONVERSATION
TOO LONG.
SO I JUST WILL SAY TO MY
COLLEAGUES AS WE COUNTY TALK
ABOUT THE WONDERFUL WORLD OF WE
WANT TO DO AND ALL OF A
RESOLUTION SYSTEM.
HE WAS MOTIVATION TO GET TO THE
TOP.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO WORK
WITHOUT SOME SERIOUS CHANGE
[inaudible]
THAT'S ALMOST [inaudible]
WHO WE?
PREFECT WEBER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
FOURTEEN ISSUE FOURTEEN A
SPECIAL EDUCATION YES -- SNOW TO
EARLIER THE GOVERNOR PROVIDED
ARE PROPOSED PROVIDING SIX
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX MILLION
AN ON GOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION RELATED SERVICES.
TO A SERVING SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES OR
WHO WERE LOW INCOME FOSTER YOUTH
AND ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS.
OF BOTH HOUSES REJECTED THAT
PROPOSAL AND BOTH HOUSES ADOPTED
A POLICY OF PROVIDING THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE MILLION AN
ON GOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. TO GLIDE SPECIAL
EDUCATION PER PUPIL FUNDING
RATES UP TO THE NINETIETH
PERCENTILE.
IN ADDITION BOTH HOUSES
DEDICATED SOME FUNDING --
SPECIFICALLY FOR SUPPORTING
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES TWO
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS.
HOWEVER THE THIS FUNDING AMOUNT
AND THE APPROACH DIFFERENT
BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES.
THE SENATE PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION -- FOR TWO PURPOSES
FIRST TO MAKE MOST FOUR YEAR
OLDS WITH DISABILITIES ELIGIBLE
FOR TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
AND THIS ALLOWED THEM TO
GENERATE FUNDING UNDER THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AND SECOND TO PROVIDE A FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLAR PER CHILD GRANT
FOR EVERY THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLD WITH DSABILITIES SERVED IN
ANY MAINSTREAM EDUCATIONAL.
ENVIRONMENT.
THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES TO
INTRINSIC STEAM MILLION.
TO MAKE AN ADJUSTMENT TO THE
EXISTING K. TWELVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING FORMULA
CURRENTLY THIS FUNDING FORMULA
RELIES PRIMARILY.
AND K. THROUGH TWELVE ATTENDANCE
OF COURSE THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS WHO
DON'T COUNT AS ATTENDANCE.
AT THE ASSEMBLIES PROPOSAL WOULD
DOUBLE COUNT KINDERGARTNERS
ESSENTIALLY USING THAT SECOND
COUNT OF KINDERGARTNERS AS A
PROXY FOR FOUR YEAR OLD.
NOW WE'RE RECOMMENDING THE
ASSEMBLY CTION ON THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS ALTHOUGH IT'S A LARGER
DOLLAR AMOUNT WE THINK IT'S A
MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD APPROACH
AND IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATE'S LONGSTANDING -- APPROACH
TO FUNDING K. TWELVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND SPECIFICALLY
INTENT OF NOT PROVIDING ANY
INCENTIVE FOR INAPPROPRIATELY
IDENTIFYING CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES OR SERVING THEM AND
ONE ENVIRONMENT AS OPPOSED TO
ANOTHER.
IT'S ALTERNATE OVER TO MICHAEL I
JUST GOT TO SPEAK ON THE PERFECT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- SO A COUPLE THINGS
AT THE FIRST IS TO PROVIDE SORT
OF SOME CONTEXT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S AT THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL -- WHICH YES AS NOTED
EARLIER -- HAS NOT CHANGED SINCE
JANUARY -- WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED
ON ADDRESSING THE ISSUES RATHER
SUCH OCCASION IN AREAS OF THE
STATE WHERE THERE ARE -- LAYERS
OF CHALLENGES SO OUR FOCUS IS ON
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
HIGH PERCENTAGES OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES.
AS WELL AS HIGH PERCENTAGES OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE LOW INCOME --
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
USE IN FOSTER CARE WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET OUT WITH OUR
PROPOSAL -- IS THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FACED BY THE KEEP BY
THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THESE.
CONCENTRATIONS OF POPULATIONS --
THAT ARE IN AND IN THE SCHOOLS --
AND I I I I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THAT -- THERE IS SOME CONCERN
AROUND -- THE NUMBER OF SCHOOLS
THAT ARE WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FUNDING
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
WHERE THE GREATEST NEED IS AND
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE.
TARGETING THE FUNDING -- IN
REGARDS TO THE TWO PROPOSALS --
PROVIDED BY BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY I THINK OUR MAJOR
CONCERNS ON THE EARLY EDUCATION
PIECE -- ARE JUST THE AS THE
NATURE OF HOW THE FUNDING IS
PROVIDED ON AN EIGHTY A BASE
MODEL.
WHICH MAY GROW IN THE OUT YEARS
AT A GREATER RATE THAN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE GROSSED WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FISCAL
IMPACTS OF THAT.
OF AN ADDITIONAL THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL AND THE PROVISION OF
EARLY TRANSIT OR THE EXTENSION
OF REALLY TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TO INCLUDE --
CHILDREN WITH IT PEACEFUL WE WE
DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE POLICY
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT.
GIVEN THE NATURE OF PROP NINETY
EIGHT IN THE ON GOING A PICTURE
THAT -- HERE WE MAKE WE MAY FREE
UP SOME FUNDS IN THE BUDGET
YOU'RE FOR THAT BUT THAT THE
GUARANTEE DOESN'T NECESSARILY
GROW IN THE OUT YEARS. TO
ACCOMMODATE THE INCREASED COST
OF THAT [inaudible]
MESSAGING.
ARE DISCUSSED EARLIER COMMENT ON
THE COMMISSION POLLS.
HERE WE WE WE COMMENDED
REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND WE HAD SEVERAL
MAJOR CONCERNS WITH IT.
OUR OUR IRST MAJOR CONCERN WAS
THAT A ADOPTED THE INAPPROPRIATE
AND POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS FISCAL
INCENTIVES FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD BE RECEIVING THE
FUNDING -- UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WE ESTIMATE THAT.
EACH ELIGIBLE CHILD WOULD
GENERATE ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND ON GOING FUNDING.
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WERE
BENEFITING UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
BY CONTRAST THE AVERAGE STUDENT
WAS SPECIAL EDUCATED.
RECEIVING SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA RECEIVES
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
SERVICES FROM LOCAL FUNDING
SOURCES.
THIS INDICATES THAT THERE'S A
VERY STRONG INCENTIVE NOT ONLY
TO NOT REDUCE SPECIAL EDUCATION
IDENTIFICATION RATES IN THOSE
DISTRICTS PUT ACTUALLY TO
INCREASE THEM IN ORDER TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
IN ADDITION WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ALLOCATION OF FUNDING
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS
HAS BEEN NOTED.
OF RELATIVELY SMALL SHARE OF
DISTRICTS WOULD QUALIFY FOR
FUNDING ABOUT A QUARTER OF
DISTRICTS WOULD RECEIVE ANY
FUNDING.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND LOOKING AT THE COLLECTION OF
DISTRICTS THAT WOULD BENEFIT WE
WE DON'T SEE A PARTICULAR RHYME
OR REASON.
THERE'S NO STRONG CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE LIST OF
BENEFICIARIES UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND LISTED --
AND SELF REPORTED SPECIAL
EDUCATION EXPENDITURES THERE ARE
MANYDISTRICTS THAT HAVE VERY
HIGH SPECIAL EDUCATION
EXPENDITURES THAT WOULD RECEIVE
NOTHING.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE -- BELOW AVERAGE
SPECIAL EDUCATION EXPENDITURES
THAT WOULD RECEIVE A QUITE A LOT
OF FUNDING UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
JUST A FALL TWO MINISTRATION
COULD YOU COMMENT AS TO WHY.
ONLY TWENTY FIVE WHY WHY YOU
CHOSE TO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
ONLY.
REALLY BENEFIT 25% OF THE
DISTRICTS IN A TIME WHEN THE
POPULATION ACROSS THE STATE'S
GROWING.
CERTAINLY SO I I WOULD REFER
BACK TO MY COMMENTS FROM EARLIER
ABOUT -- WANTING TO TARGET THESE
FUNDS -- TO THE THE DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE -- THIS SORT OF A
GREAT NUMBER GREATEST NUMBER OF
BARRIERS ARE COMBINED -- WHERE
YOU'RE DEALING WITH -- A
POPULATION OF STUDENTS THAT MAY
HAVE IN ADDITION TO NEEDING
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES I'M
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS AROUND --
YOU KNOW NEEDING ADDITIONAL HELP
IN IN ACQUIRING ENGLISH AND
POTENTIALLY ADDITIONAL
CONNECTIONS TO SOCIAL SERVICES --
I THINK THAT AS YOU KNOW.
WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION AROUND SPECIAL
EDUCATION THIS IS AN AREA.
OF GREAT INTEREST FOR THIS
GOVERNOR AND I THINK REGARDLESS
OF THE OUTCOME OF THIS
CONVERSATION FOR THIS YEAR -- WE
INTEND TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION IN FUTURE YEARS --
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
WORKING WITH YOU ALL -- TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE INEQUITIES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY INHERENT IN
OUR EIGHTY SIX OH TWO FORMULA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] THIRTY
ROCK [inaudible]
SO.
I HAVE SOME BASIC CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CONCENTRATION GRANT ANYWAY.
WHERE YOU HAVE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICT LINED UP SIDE BY SIDE?
SCHOOLS ON EITHER SIDE OF THE
LINE ONE DISTRICT OVER 55% FREE
AND REDUCED LUNCH ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS FOSTER KIDS
THE OTHER ONE WAS LESS THAN 55% --
BUT BOTH HAVE AS A DISTRICT BUT
BOTH HAVE 70%.
IN THE INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS.
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS FUND FOR KIDS.
ONE DISTRICT GETS A
CONCENTRATION GRANT RIGHT.
THE OTHER DISTRICT DOESN'T.
BUT THE PERCENTAGES IN THE
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL SITES.
ARE THE SAME.
IT DOESN'T COST ANY LESS IN THE
ONE DISTRICT TO EDUCATE THE KIDS.
THEN IN THE OTHER THE MONEY GOES
THROUGH THE DISTRICT NOT BE
BASED ON THE SCHOOL SITE RIGHT.
TO UNDERSTAND MY POINT YES I I
THINK I'M I MAY BE
MISUNDERSTANDING YOU SO --
ACCORDING TO OUR FORMULAS THE S.
ANY SCHOOL THAT HAS -- AND
DUPLICATED -- CFF PERCENTAGE
ABOVE 55% SO I I BELIEVE IN BOTH
QUé IN THIS CASE BOTH OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- COOL SITE IS SUPPOSED
TO DISTRICT NO SCHOOL DISTRICT
I'M TALKING ABOUT SCHOOL SITES.
TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH THEN
ALLOCATE FUNDS -- FOR AT ALL ALL
STUDENTS TO THE SCHOOL SITE
BASED ON THEIR LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. ONE
DISTRICT GETS CONCENTRATION
GRANT AND THE OTHER DOESN'T
CORRECT -- I BELIEVE THAT BOTH
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S UNDER
YOUR EXAMPLE WOULD RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR CONCENTRATION IF
THEY HAD A HIGHER THAN AVERAGE
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS A
DISABILITY RETIREMENT
DISABILITIES NOW.
ON TOP OF MY BASIC PROBLEM WITH
CONCENTRATION GRANTS.
SO THAT I'LL GET TO MY QUESTION
WHAT'S THE NEXUS BETWEEN.
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNER AND FOSTER
[inaudible]
CHILD.
PERCENTAGES IN A DISTRICT AND
EDUCATING SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS
BECAUSE THE DISTRICT FORTY GETS
CONCENTRATION GRANT MONEY. TO
EDUCATE THE FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
AND FOSTER KIDS.
WE'RE TALKING NOW ABOUT SPECIAL
NEEDS.
YOUNG FOLKS AND THE EXTRA MONEY
THAT IT TAKES TO EDUCATE THEM SO
WHAT'S THE NEXUS BETWEEN THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT PEAS.
AND FUNDING SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND THAT'S MY PROBLEM.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
SO YOU CAN CORRECT ME THAT'S MY
PROBLEM IS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION I THINK I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION NOW SO
WE TOOK A LOOK AT THE
PERCENTAGES OF STUDENTS WHO ARE --
AS I'D IDENTIFIES AND DUPLICATED
FOR THE PURPOSES OF ELSE EFF.
ON THE PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS --
WITH DISABILITIES WHO IDENTIFIED
FOR LC FF -- WERE HIGHER THAN
THE STUDENTS WITHOUT
DISABILITIES WHO ALSO QUALIFIED
AS AN DUPLICATED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF L. CFF.
AND THAT CONCENTRATION WAS
SPECIFICALLY STRONGER AMONG
FOSTER YOUTH AND ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS -- FOSTER USE
HAD AS MANY MAGNITUDES OF
INCREASE FOR LIKELIHOOD OF BE
IDENTIFIED -- FOR HAVING IT AS A
NEED FOR AN IEP -- SO THERE IS A
CORRELATION BETWEEN BEING A
DUPLICATED STUDENT AND HAVING A
DISABILITY.
WELL YOU KNOW THE PRICE AS I
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM AND THIS
IS MY FIRST YEAR.
AT THIS RODEO IN EDUCATION BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE COST OF
EDUCATING SPECIAL NEEDS YOUNG
FOLKS.
IS SO GREAT -- WAS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ESSENTIALLY
CREATES WINNERS AND LOSERS IN --
SPECIAL ED ARENA DOESN'T IT I
MEAN SOME.
DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO GET MORE
MONEY BECAUSE THEY HAVE MORE OF
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS FOSTER KIDS
AND AND FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH
AND OTHER DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO
BE LEFT WITH WHAT THEY GET UNDER
THE NORMAL.
SPECIAL NEEDS FUNDING ALLOCATION
FORMULA WHICH IS CERTAINLY
INSUFFICIENT EVEN AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL.
WHAT IS NET FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS OR
SOMETHING?
SO -- I THINK THAT ONE THING I'D
LIKE TO KIND OF GO BACK ON HIS
EARLY COMMENT I MADE ABOUT YOU
THIS WE SEE THIS IS SORT OF A
FIRST STEP AND AGAIN THIS IS A
TARGET APPROACH FOR THE DOLLARS
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING -- ON A
MULTI YEAR PROCESS IN WHICH WE
LOOK AT THE ENTIRETY OF HOW WE
FUND ON SPECIAL EDUCATION THE
STATE.
ANDSO SO WE SEE THIS AS SORT OF
STEP ONE BUT RECOGNIZING THAT
YES THERE ARE A LOT OF CONCERNS
ON THINGS LIKE EQUALIZATION OF
BASE RATES -- EXTREMELY HIGH
COST LOW INCIDENCE A STUDENTS IN
THE COST OF CARE FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WE RECOGNIZE THOSE
THINGS AND WE AND WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO HAVE.
MORE LONG TERM DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT HOW TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES I'LL JUST
MAKE ONE POINT ON THAT AS
JESSICA MENTIONED.
THE END GOAL IS REALLY TO GET
MORE RESOURCES ACROSS AS WE WERE
DISCUSSING FOR THIS SPECIFIC --
AND YOU POINTED OUT THE NEXUS
THAT IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT -- SCHOOLS
WITH UNDER LOCATED PEOPLES.
WHO ALSO HAVE KIDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS -- SOLVING BOTH OF THOSE
TOGETHER CREATES ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES COMPARED TO SOLVING
ONE OR THE OTHER AND THEIR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED SO FOR THIS AUGMENTATION
WE WANT TO TARGET THAT NEXUS
THAT YOU MENTION.
OKAY THANK YOU.
IF I MAY CONTRIBUTE BECAUSE OUR
OFFICES DONE SOME WORK ON THE
OVERLAP BETWEEN.
THOSE DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS INDIAN
DUPLICATE ACCOUNT INSTANCE WITH
DISABILITIES-- WE WOULD AGREE
WITH FINANCE THE THERE IS --
OVERLAP AND IT DOES VERY BASED
ON THE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES.
IN PARTICULAR FOSTER YOUTH ARE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE DISABILITIES
AND FOR THAT SPECIFIC REASON --
THE STATE'S CURRENT K. TWELVE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
PROGRAM -- INCLUDES ME OUT OF
HOME CARE -- FUNDING FORMULA
WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY TO THOSE AREAS THAT
SERVE MORE FOSTER CHILDREN MORE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING FOR
THEM.
THE ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE MORE
COMPLICATED.
BASED ON THE LITERATURE ITS
SUCCESS THAT IS LARGELY.
REFLECTIVE OF INAPPROPRIATE
DIAGNOSTIC PROCEDURES THAT -- OR
OR INEFFECTIVE TREATMENT
PROCEDURES WHERE -- WHEN A CHILD
HAS BOTH -- ENGLISH LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY DIFFICULTIES AND A
DISABILITY IT CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO IDENTIFY THAT DISABILITY
DISENTANGLE IT AND PROVIDE THEM --
APPROPRIATE SUPPORTS AND
RECENTLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
MADE ACTIONS TO ADDRESS THAT
DIAGNOSIS OF A PROBLEM AND
DEVELOPING A NEW MANUAL THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT ISSUE WHEN
IT COMES TO LOW INCOME STUDENTS
THIS IS LARGELY WHAT IS DRIVING.
THE STATE'S ARE AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SPECIAL
EDUCATION CONCENTRATION GRANTS
PROPOSAL IS THE NUMBER OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND WE JUST
DON'T FIND A STRONG CORRELATION
BETWEEN THAT POPULATION INSTANCE
WITH DISABILITIES.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF LITERATURE
THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THIS AND
SOME STUDIES FIND A POSITIVE
CORRELATION BUT MANY OF THEM
DON'T.
AND LARGELY THE ONES THAT DON'T
FIND THAT CORRELATION USE AT
FOUR PM AS THEIR MEASUREMENT.
OF STUDENT POVERTY THAT JUST
TENDS NOT TO SHOW A STRONG
CORRELATION WITH STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND MY AND MY ONE OF MY PROBLEMS
IS.
A DISTRICT THAT HAS 51%.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS FREE
AND REDUCED LUNCH FOSTER KIDS
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL [inaudible]
GETS.
AND NOW FUNDING NOTHING UNDER
THIS NEW PROPOSAL OTHER THAN
WHAT THE DISTRICT WOULD NORMALLY
GET SOONER WILL SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUND ON OCCASION RIGHT.
CORRECT SO THE DIFFERENCE OF
FOUR PERCENTAGE POINTS MAKES A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN GETTING EXTRA
MONEY.
AND NO MONEY.
IN AN ARENA WHERE NOBODY GETS
ENOUGH MONEY. TO COVER THE COST
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SORT THIS
OT I APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORT TO TRY
TO DO THIS AND I'M NOT GOING TO
BELABOR ANYMORE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
YEAH I JUST WANT -- TO BRIEFLY
OUT ON THAT I I CAN THAT.
THIS -- THIS THIS PLAN.
HAS.
A COUPLE BIG WINNERS.
LARGELY THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
LARGELY -- LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHICH IS A BIG DISTRICT
AND NEEDS HELP HAS A BIG ISSUE
WITH.
WHAT SPECIAL AT POPULATION BUT
THIS IS THE ISSUE AND ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS AND ACTUALLY THE
PROPOSAL FOR LA THAT WOULD HAVE
HELPED LA HELP HELP SACRAMENTO A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
EQUALIZATION BUT?
IT JUST IT THAT WAS AN A FAIR.
PLANNED FOR THE OTHER SIX
DISTRICTS IN MY DISTRICT AND THE
THOUSAND DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO.
I THINK THE THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY -- GOT A RIGHT HERE
RECOGNIZING THERE IS A NEED BUT
THERE IS THERE IS A A FAIR WAY
TO ALLOCATE.
THE RESOURCES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND MISS SKINNER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SEVERAL.
WORKED WHERE I'M.
SORT OF HAVING TROUBLE AS WELL.
IN GENERAL WE DO NOT FIND
SPECIAL EDUCATION ADEQUATELY AND
WELL ALL THREE PROPOSALS ARE A
STEP.
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WITH YOU
KNOW VARIOUS PROS AND CONS.
WOULD PROBABLY STILL DON'T GET
IT AT GET USOUT WHAT WE NEED
WHICH I THINK IT'S BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED -- BUT ON THE
ALEJO'S POINT WELL THERE.
WHILE THE RESEARCH MAY NOT SHOW
A CORRELATION BETWEEN A HIGHER
NUMBER OF SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS AND
INCOME IN OTHER WORDS THAT.
I WONDER IF WE HAVE ANY DATA ON
THE THE HOW WELL.
THE CHILDREN.
IN OUR LOWER INCOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
ARE IDENTIFIED.
WITH A SPECIAL NEED OR NOT IN
OTHER WORDS.
IT.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT.
OR I COULD IMAGINE THAT THERE'S
FACTORS THAT.
CONTRIBUTE TO A LITTLE LOWER
DETECTION RATE.
PARTLY THE SCHOOL ITSELF.
GIVEN THAT WE DO NOT ADEQUATELY
FIND -- SPECIAL NEEDS THAT IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S INTERESTS AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT IN YOUR PURPOSE WE
TRYING TO DO IT BUT THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY IN THEIR INTERESTS
TO IDENTIFY.
WHAT'S OF KIDS WHO NEED ARE YOU
PIECE -- SO THAT MAY BE A FACTOR
ADDITIONALLY -- DEPENDING ON THE
OTHER PRESSURES THE PARENT OR
PARENTS OF THE LOWER INCOME
CHILD MAY HAVE IS OR EVEN THEIR
ACCESS TO OTHER -- HEALTH CARE
THAT MIGHT.
IDENTIFY THAT SPECIAL NEEDS THAT
I WOULD GUESS THAT THERE WOULD
BE DATA THAT INDICATES THAT ARE
MIDDLE INCOME IN HIGHER INCOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PROBABLY HAVE A
HIGHER IDENTIFICATION.
OF KIDS IF WITH SPECIAL NEEDS SO
I GUESS WHAT.
I WHAT I EAT.
ON THE ONE HAND I SEE THE LOCAL
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
TRYING TO GET AT IF THAT IF WHAT
I'M DESCRIBING IS REAL.
MORE FINDING TO THE LOWER INCOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO TRY TO HELP
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO THE PROPER
VALUATION AND IF THERE ARE KIDS
WITH -- I EP NEEDS WE CAN GET
THEM THE AP.
ON THE OTHER HAND WHAT YOU'VE
RAISED THAT THERE MIGHT BE A
PERVERSE.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF THIS.
BUT HOW CAN WE ACHIEVE.
A I MEAN WE WANT EVERY KID WHO
IS ACTUALLY.
IN NEED OF AN I. E. P. M. THEIR
APPROPRIATE SPECIAL NEEDS --
FINDING TO GET THAT SO.
WHAT YOU KNOW HOW DO WE I THINK
THAT'S REALLY FOR ME THE
CHALLENGE HOW DO WE ACCOMPLISH
THAT?
THINK IT SAID.
VERY PERSONAL QUESTION -- IT'S A
FIRST TO TALK ABOUT THE
UNDERLYING MECHANISMS FOR THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN INCOME AND
DISABILITY WHICH I MENTIONED
BRIEFLY EARLIER.
THERE ARE GENERALLY SPEAKING
THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT --
CAUSAL MECHANISMS FIRST THERE IS
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT -- POOR
MATERNAL HEALTH AND IN
PARTICULAR PORT MATERNAL
NUTRITION WHICH IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE INCOME.
IS LINKED WITH LOWER BIRTH
THROUGH WEIGHTS WHICH ARE LINKED
WITH THE INCIDENCE OF SPECIFIC
LEARNING DIABILITIES WHICH ARE
BOTH THE MOST COMMON.
SOURCE OF DISABILITY AMONG K.
TWELVE STUDENTS AND THE LARGEST
SOURCE OF VARIABILITY BETWEEN
IDENTIFICATION RATES BETWEEN
DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
NO COUNTRVAILING THIS AND THIS
IS MORE OF AN ANECDOTAL POINT IS
SOMETHING.
THAT I THINK YOU WERE GETTING AT
THIS IDEA THAT.
IN MORE AFFLUENT AREAS WHERE
THERE ARE MORE CUT THROAT
PARENTS WERE WHO ARE THINKING
ABOUT.
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS AND WHAT NOT
THAT THERE IS IN SOME CASES IF
YOU IF YOUR CHILD THE STRUGGLING
THERE'S THIS IDEA THAT YOU CAN.
GET THEM AND I A P. AND THAT
WILL GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
ACADEMIC SUPPORT WHICH WILL
ULTIMATELY -- A SYSTEM GOING ON
I WOULD SAY I AM NOT SEEN
RIGOROUS DOCUMENTATION THAT THAT
IS IN FACT HAPPENING I HAVE
HEARD IT FROM THE FIELD.
BUT IT IS POSSIBLE THAT THIS
COMBINATION OF FACTORS WHICH
INDICATE THAT BOTH LOW INCOME
AND HIGH INCOME SHOULD BE
ASSOCIATED WITH DISABILITIES IS
ONE REASON WHY THE LEISURE
DOESN'T SHOW.
A CLEAR CORRELATION BETWEEN
INCOME.
AND DISABILITY RATES.
NOW.
IT'S CERTAINLY JUST BRIEFLY
EARLIER DOESN'T SHOW THAT
CORRELATION BUT WHAT ABOUT.
X. SO THAT'S JUST FLAT WHETHER
THEY EXIST.
THAT -- SPECIAL NEED EXISTS OR
NOT BUT WHAT ABOUT THE ACTUAL
IDENTIFICATION OF THE NEED.
YES SO I THINK THAT IS A VERY --
CURRENT OF OBSERVATION AND
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE AN ON
GOING POLICY CONCERN OF COURSE
THE INTENT OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES EDUCATION ACT
IS THAT ALL STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS WILL BE IDENTIFIED
IN WILL BE PROVIDED WITH
APPROPRIATE INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT.
THAT GOAL IS.
NOT BEING REALIZED I THINK IS A
FAIR STATEMENT -- BY THE THE
QUESTION BàN HOW DO WE
RECOGNIZE IN EVERY SINGLE
INSTANCE FOR EVERY STUDENT
WHETHER IT'S APPROPRIATE TO GIVE
THEM AN AYE A PEER.
NINE I THINK THE LITERATURE
WOULD INDICATE THAT THERE'S SOME
DANGER IN TRYING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THROUGH YOUR FUNDING
MECHANISM.
THAT THE MORE LIKELY RESULT OF
TRYING.
TO ENSURE APPROPRIATE THE
IDENTIFICATION THROUGH THE VERY
BLUNT INSTRUMENT OF PROVIDING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH MORE OR
LESS FUNDING OFTEN JUST RESULTS
AND CHILDREN BEING
INAPPROPRIATELY OVER IDENTIFIED
WITH DISABILITIES.
AND SO PERHAPS.
FINDING THE MORE NUANCED ANSWER
TO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY CHILD WHO HAS SPECIAL
NEEDS.
IS BEING SO IDENTIFIED PERHAPS
WE SHOULD LOOK AT OTHER POLICY
TOOLS RATHER THAN FUNDING.
THANK YOU HAVE A COUPLE
CONVERSATION ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ISSUE.
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE.
FIFTEEN DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS [inaudible]
ELIA.
THE GOVERNOR SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
ALL APPROVED THREE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVES TOTALING
FORTY FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND AND
THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION ON
GOING FEDERAL FIND.
THE SENATE ADOPTED PLACE HOLDER
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD FOCUS EACH
OF THESE INITIATIVES ON ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. FOR IT INITIATIVE
THAT FOCUSES ON TRAINING
TEACHERS AND SPECIFIC SUBJECTS
THE SENATE PROPOSES TO PROVIDE
SLIGHTLY MORE FUNDING FOR
TRAINING IN THE AREAS OF WRITING.
READING AND LITERATURE MATH AND
SCIENCE AND SLIGHTLY LESS
FUNDING FOR TRAINING AND OTHER
SUBJECTS.
ASSEMBLY APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WITH AMENDMENTS TO
INCLUDE TEACHER TRAINING ON
AFFECT ON ETHNIC STUDIES.
THE KEY ISSUE BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE IS WHETHER TO TARGET
THESE INITIATIVES TOWARDS
SUPPORTING ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
SPECIFICALLY THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER HOW THESE
PROPOSALS ALIGNED WITH STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT RESULTS.
BASED ON THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DASHBOARD.
IT INDICATES THAT THE STUDENT
THAT STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
AND FOSTER YOUTH LAGGED BEHIND
THE MOST IN MATH AND ENGLISH
PERFORMANCE RELATIVE TO OTHER
STUDENT GROUPS.
IN CONTRAST TO ENGLISH LEARNERS
HAVE COMPARABLE OR BETTER
OUTCOMES THAN MANY OTHER STUDENT
GROUPS IN THESE AREAS INCLUDING
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISPANIC
HOMELESS AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE DISTRICTS
RECENTLY FLAGS FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SOLELY BASED ON POOR
PERFORMANCE.
FROM THEIR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES BY COMPARISON ONLY
FIFTY NINE DISTRICTS WERE
SIMILARLY FLAG DUE TO POOR
OUTCOMES FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
PART WEBER -- YES ONCE AGAIN --
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR RESEARCH
AND INFORMATION IT SHOWS WHO THE
LOWEST PERFORMING INDIVIDUALS
ARE AND SO I THINK OF JUST
MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T JUST
SIMPLY TARGET ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS ONLY BUT THE ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY.
IS OBVIOUSLY A GREAT NEED
BECAUSE ALL THE PHOTOS OF THE
FOLKS THAT REALLY AT THE BOTTOM
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU'VE JUST GIVEN US SO.
IF WE'RE GOING TO DO STAFF
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON WHAT THE GREATEST
NEED IS IN TERMS OF THE GAS AND
WE SEE FOR WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
TERMS OF THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND THOSE AREAS OF THE AREAS
WHERE WE GET THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
NOT THAT WE DO AN AWFUL LOT WE
DO A LOT WE DO QUITE A BIT ON ON
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS -- IN
TERMS OF THE BY LEGALLY PROGRAMS
AND THINGS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
IN THE DISTRICTS BUT WE DO VERY
LITTLE TRAINING ON ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY.
AND THAT CUTS ACROSS ALL OF THE
AREAS WHERE OUR STUDENTS ARE NOT
PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH WITH THIS
WRITTEN OR ORAL LANGUAGE AND
HAVING -- THERE'S SOME NEW
STRATEGIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED THAT WORK WELL -- WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ART
EDUCATORS ARE GETTING THAT
TRAINING AND ADMINISTRATORS GET
MY TRAINING SO THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY IS.
AND THEY BEGAN TO TEACH AND TO
DEAL WITH THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
NOT PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH.
WE HAVE TOO MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
WOULD NOT PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH
ORALLY OR IN WRITTEN LANGUAGE
AND THAT IS UNFORTUNATE.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'LL JUST SAY VERY BRIEFLY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION ENVISIONS
THIS IS A IN A BIG VERY
MEANINGFUL PROPOSAL AND WE
CERTAINLY.
APPRECIATE THAT OF MUCH OF THIS
WILL GO TOWARD HELPING WITH
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
PEOPLE SPECIAL EDUCATION BY.
THE GOVERNOR ACTUALLY ENVISION
THIS AS A BROADER PROPOSAL --
FOR TEACHER DEVELOPMENT FOR A
NUMBER OF ISSUES AND GIVING
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES THE
FLEXIBILITY BASED ON THEIR
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THEY NEED IN
THEIR DISTRICTS WHERE TO FOCUS
IS WHAT THE NUMBER OF THESE
RESOURCES SO IF IN THIS CASE WE
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
SIXTEEN ONGOING KICKING TWELVE
EDUCATIONAL INVESTMENT TALIA.
IF YOU SIXTEEN CONSISTS OF THREE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS RELATED TO
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS PRACTICE
REIMBURSEMENTS AND SCHOOL
COUNCILS.
I REALIZE WE PREVIOUSLY TOUCHED
ON THIS EARLIER BUT ISSUE
SIXTEEN FOR SPECIFICALLY FOCUSES
ON THE ASUS PART.
SO AND AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
BOTH HOUSES PROVIDED
AUGMENTATION FOR ASUS
ESTABLISHED BY PROPOSITION FORTY
NINE ON THIS PROGRAM LAST
RECEIVED AN INCREASE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND IT CURRENTLY RECEIVES AN
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION OF SIX
HUNDRED MILLION.
THE CURRENT AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING
RATE IS EIGHT DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN CENTS PER STUDENT PER
DAY.
THE SENATE ACTION WOULD RAISE
THIS RATE BY 17% TO NINE DOLLARS
AND FIFTY EIGHT CENTS.
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION WOULD RAISE
IT SLIGHTLY LESS BY 14% TO NINE
DOLLARS AND THIRTY ONE CENTS.
THE SENATE COVERS EIGHT
AUGMENTATION WITH ON GOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FINDING
WHERE AS THE ASSEMBLY ALLOCATE
FUNDING FROM PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR NEXT ON SCHOOL
BREAKFAST REIMBURSEMENT THE
SENATE PROVIDES FIFTEEN POINT
THREE ON GOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT TO ESTABLISH A
CALIFORNIA.
GROWN FOR HEALTHY KIDS PROGRAM
THIS PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL TEN CENT
REIMBURSEMENT FOR EACH BREAKFAST
SERVED IN CERTAIN SCHOOLS
OFFERING STUDENTS ACCESS TO FREE
CALIFORNIA GROUND FOR FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES.
WE NOTE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
CURRENTLY PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENT
FOR MEALS SERVED TO LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND THE FUNDING FROM
THIS POPOSAL WAY TO SUPPLEMENT
THOSE SUBSIDIES.
LASTLY ASSEMBLY PROVIDES ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND ON
GOING GENERAL FUND TO PRIDE NEED
BASED.
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING CONFERENCES HOSTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
STUDENT COUNCIL WHICH IS A
STUDENT RUN NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GREAT ALSO VERY
BRIEFLY -- ON PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR AND THE ATARI STRUCK THAT
FUNDING I KNOW WE ALREADY HAD
THAT CONVERSATION -- AND FOR
ASUS MORE SPECIFICALLY OUTSIDE
OF PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR WE DO
BELIEVE CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRINCIPLES OF LCF PFAFF THAT IF
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES SCHOOLS
WANT TO USE THAT MONEY FOR THAT
PURPOSE.
THEY CAN DO SO AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IN OUR PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE THAT WE
DIRECT RESOURCES TO LC A FAST
AND SPECIAL LAD AND THEN WITHIN
THAT GIVE DISTRICTS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE THEIR OWN
CHOICES.
AND FOR THE CALIFORNIA GROWN FOR
HEALTHY KIDS AS WELL AS THE
STUDENT COUNCIL FUNDING WE
BELIEVE THAT THE SAME APPROACH
I'VE NOT DIRECTING THAT IN OUR
PROPOSITION NINETY PACKAGE BUT
GIVING LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT IS
THE RIGHT APPROACH.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
REGARDING.
YEAH I I DON'T KNOW IF WHEN I
GET BACK INTO HOW WE FUND IT BUT
I THINK TALKING ABOUT THE ACES
PROGRAM IS APPROPRIATE RIGHT
HERE AND AS YOU NOTED AND AS YOU
KNOW THAT EARLIER.
I'M SURE MITCHELL THIS WAS THE
CREATOR SORTS **** OVER A DECADE
AGO AND HAD STATIC.
FUNDING IN THERE WITHOUT A COLA.
FOR ALL THOSE YEARS INCLUDING
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
AND SO THEY DID HAVE SOME SOME.
FRANKLY SOME GOOD NEWS AS THEY
WORK CUT DURING THE RECESSION
ONE K. TWELVE SCHOOLS ARE BUT
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WE'VE BEEN
ACTUALLY SEVEN YEARS NOW WE'VE
BEEN INCREASING K. TWELVE
FUNDING.
ACES PROGRAM AND ONLY HAD
INCREASE ONCE AND WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN THAT MEANS THAT WE WE KNOW
WE INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE IN
CALIFORNIA -- CITIES HAVE AND
WE'VE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WITH OUR
OTHER PROGRAMS WITH AYE HSS
OTHER STATEWIDE PROGRAMS AND THE
REALITY IS IT'S SIMPLE
MATHEMATICS -- YOU KNOW THERE'S
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF KIDS YOU
NEED TO SERVE -- COSCO UP SO AS
I MEAN YOU SIR FEWER KIDS AND WE
WE VALUE THESE PROGRAMS THEY
THEY FOCUS ON IN RICHMOND FOR
FOR FOR OUR KIDS PUT ON LEAVE.
AT LOW INCOME BROWN TO BLACK
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA -- WHO YEAH
BUT FOR THIS MAY NOT HAVE IT A
POSITIVE THING TO DO AFTER
SCHOOL HELP SOMEONE HOMEWORK
KEEP SOMATIC TROUBLE IT'S WHERE?
POLICE CHIEF LOVE THESE PROGRAMS
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S NOT
REALISTIC TO SAY THAT.
DISTRICTS WILL USE THEIR
DISCRETIONARY LCF PFAFF TO
PRIORITIZE THIS BECAUSE THEY DO
PRIORITIZES BUT THERE ARE OTHER
PRIORITIES ARE HEMORRHAGING
RIGHT NOW.
PAYING THE BILLS AND SO HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE SAW THAT THEY CUT
BACK ON OR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND THAT DOESN'T SERVE ANYBODY
WELL AND SO -- YOU KNOW BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE CENTER OF
ROUGHLY THE SAME AMOUNT OURS IS.
A WAS A LITTLE LOWER BECAUSE WE
JUST TIED IN THE PROP.
SIXTY FOUR AMOUNT BUT IF WE WANT
TO VALUE THE ASUS PROGRAM AND
THE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND YOU THINK THEY THERE THERE
WERE THE SHOULD BE FUNDED -- WE
SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT WE DID
FOR THE OTHER PROGRAMS AND
REALIZE THAT THESE -- COST
INCREASES LABOR INCREASE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES ARE REAL AND
OTHERWISE WE'RE JUST GONNA
STARVE AND IN THESE PROGRAMS
WILL ESSENTIALLY.
GO OUT OF BUSINESS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND.
DUG OUT OKAY PERFECT ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WILL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE SEVENTEEN ONE TIME K.
THROUGH TWELVE PROP NINETY EIGHT
INVESTMENTS ELIA.
YES SO ISSUE SEVENTEEN INCLUDES
EIGHT LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS. FOR
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT EXPENDITURES -- WE WON'T
GO THROUGH ALL OF THESE JUST
HIGHLIGHT THE TWO LARGEST WOULD
BE THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE.
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION FOR THE COLLEGE
READINESS BLOCK GRANT THIS --
PROVIDES FOR A FREE LOW INCOME --
ENGLISH LEARNER A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT MAY EQUAL PER A STERN
FUNDING.
AMOUNT -- FOR WHICH UP.
APPLICABLE DISTRICTS MUST SUBMIT
A PLAN FOR HOW THEY WILL IMPROVE
COLLEGE GOING RATE FOR THOSE
STUDENTS.
AND THE ASSEMBLY IS PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION FOR THE
LOWEST PERFORMING STUDENTS BLOCK
GRANT WHICH WOULD PROVIDE AGAIN
EQUAL PER PUPIL FUNDING. FOR
STUDENTS MEETING THE FOLLOWING
CONDITIONS THAT THEY DID NOT
MEET STATEWIDE STANDARDS AND THE
MOST RECENT ASSESSMENTS OF
READING AND MATH.
AND THAT THEY DO NOT BELONG --
TO ANY OF THESE TARGETED GROUPS
LOW INCOME.
ENGLISH LEARNERS FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESS YOUTH OR SENSE WITH
DISABILITIES -- OUR OVERALL
COMMENTS -- CONSISTENT WITH HER
EARLIER COMMENTS ARE THE WE
ENCOURAGE YOU AS PART OF YOUR
OVERALL PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE.
TO INCLUDE A MIX OF BOTH ONE
TIME AN ON GOING FUNDING THE
MORE ONE TIME FUNDING TO
DEDICATE THE LARGER YOUR CUSHION --
AND ALSO TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
DEDICATE. ONE TIME FUNDS WE
WOULD -- ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO PROVIDE FLEXIBLE FUNDING
SOURCES THAT ALLOW SCHOOLS.
TO PURSUE ANY NUMBER OF LOCAL
PRIORITIES.
MINISTRATION YEAH VERY BRIEFLY
ON THE COLLEGE READINESS BLOCK
GRAND -- THERE AT SOME MORE TO
THE ROOT MOST THAT PREVIOUS
ISSUE WE BELIEVE THAT DISTRICTS
CAN APPROACH THAT FOR LCS FAST
AND I THINK GET FINANCE WERE.
STILL LOOKING AT THE DATA AND
IT'S NOT COMPLETELY CLEAR THAT
THE PROGRAM IS ACHIEVING
EVERYTHING.
GAD THAT WARRANTS THIS FULL
REINVESTMENT PROPOSED BY THE
SENATE -- AND THEN ON THE LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS BLOCK GRANT
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT -- THIS
FUNDING IS A LITTLE BIT
PREMATURE IN THE SENSE OF WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR MORE OUTCOME
DATA AND THAT.
FULL AMOUNT OF FOR THAT MOST
RECENT PREPARATION HAS JUST BEEN
EXPENDED [inaudible]
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ISSUE EIGHTEEN K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
INVESTMENTS ELIA.
IF YOU EIGHTEEN CONSISTS OF TWO
PROPOSALS THE MOST NOTABLE ISSUE
IS THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
ASSEMBLY PROVIDES FIFTEEN
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
EXPAND FIBER BROADBAND AT
SCHOOLS THAT ARE CONSIDERED
POORLY CONNECTED TO THE INTERNET.
THE SENATE REJECTED THIS
PROPOSAL WITHOUT PREJUDICE.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR INTRODUCED
THIS PROPOSAL AND THE ME
REVISION WE HAD CONCERNS OVER
THE LACK OF SPECIFICITY
SPECIFICITY CONCERNING?
HOW THE STATE WOULD MEASURE THE
NEED FOR IMPROVED CONNECTIVITY
AS WELL AS HOW IT WOULD ASSESS
PROGRESS TOWARDS ADEQUATE
CONNECTIVITY?
IF THE COMMITTEE DOES DECIDE TO
PROCEED WITH THAT THE PROPOSAL
WE RECOMMEND IT IMPROVE THE
PROPOSAL BY FIRST DEFINING WHAT
POOR CONNECTIVITY AND ADEQUATE
CONNECTIVITY MEAN. TO YOU
ALLOWING SCHOOLS TO USE THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE CONNECTED BE
SOLUTION RATHER THAN LIMITING
GRANTS TO SOLELY FIBER SOLUTIONS
AND THREE ADDING REPORTING
LANGUAGE TO ENHANCE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. FOR THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IN ISSUE EIGHTEEN THE
GOVERNOR SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
EXPLAINS ALL CONTAIN SOME
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH BUT HAVE DIFFERENCES IN
RESPECT TO HOW THE FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED.
THE GOVERNOR AND SENATE APPROVED
AN INCREASE TO LOCAL ASSISTANCE
TO ALIGN WITH THE FEDERAL GRANTS
AND AVAILABLE FUNDING.
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL WOULD
REDUCE LOCAL ASSISTANCE FOR
HOMELESS STUDENT SERVICES IN
ORDER TO FIND THREE ADDITIONAL
STATEWIDE COULDN'T COORDINATORS
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS.
ONE WE ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER WHETHER THESE FUNDS
ARE BEST BET AUGMENTING LOCAL OP
ASSISTANCE OR STATE OPERATIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRICTION OF ALL
SAY JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON THE
BROADBAND AT THAT IS A IMPORTANT
PRIORITY FOR THE GOVERNOR AND
REALLY FOCUSED ON RESOURCES THAT.
DO NOT SIMPLY ALLOW FOR COMPUTER
BASED ASSESSMENTS BUT ACTUAL.
GIVING MORE ACCESS TO DIGITAL
LEARNING SO WE THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT OPEN TO CONVERSATIONS
ON THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT BUT
WE BELIEVE THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS SHOULD BE A PRIORITY.
QUESTION FOR MEMBERS.
THOROUGH.
WITH RESPECT TO THE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE I'M CERTAINLY
NINE OF SUPPORTIVE OF MAKING
SURE SCHOOLS -- HAVE THAT SORT
OF CONNECTIVITY WHAT DID WAS
THERE ANY SORT OF ASSESSMENT AS
TO WHAT THE NEED.
WAS OR IS.
YES SO SO THERE ARE -- A FEW
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE LOOKED AT WHAT THE THE
DIFFERENT A SCHOOL DISTRICT
ABILITIES TO ACCESS WHAT WOULD
PUT ONE COULD CONSIDER HIGH
SPEED INTERNET ARE ACROSS THE
STATE AND IT REALLY.
DEPENDS UPON HOW YOU DEFINE --
WHAT HIGH SPEED IS -- WE KNOW
THAT FOR MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS
WE RECENTLY HAD YOU KNOW FUNDING
GO OUT THROUGH OUR BIG PROGRAM
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM --
THAT WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COULD ADMINISTER THE THE ASPECT
THAT THE COMPUTER BASED
ASSESSMENTS OUR STATE -- AND WE
KNOW FROM THAT WORK THAT THERE
ARE MANY WHO HAD -- AS TEMPORARY
SOLUTIONS PUT IN PLACE TO ACCESS --
THE INTERNET AT A SPEED THAT A
LOT FOR THOSE ASSESSMENTS -- BUT
THAT THERE IS SOME NEED TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THOSE AGAIN AND
SEE IF -- AN OPTION LIKE FIBER
COULD BE IS THE REASON I BRING
UP FIBERS BECAUSE IT ALLOWS FOR
SCALING UP OF INTERNET SPEED --
AS AS CAPACITY GROWS -- I THINK
WE'RE ALSO INTERESTED IN -- AT
ADDRESSING THE FACT THAT -- YOU
KNOW DEPENDING AGAIN ON WHICH
MEASURE YOU LOOK AT AND THERE
ARE SOME DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
VERY LOW ACCESS SPEEDS -- IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER DISTRICTS
AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT LIMITS A
STUDENT'S ABILITY -- TO TO
ACCESS OR DIGITAL LEARNING TYPE
pOF ENVIRONMENT AS OPPOSED TO
JUST HAVING ACCESS TO THE STATE
ASSESSMENTS.
IS THE REASON I ASK MY QUESTION
IS OF YOU KNOW WHY FIFTEEN
MILLION IS SUPPOSED TO THIRTY
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM IF IF IT'S
IMPORTANT TO US AND TO THE
ASSEMBLY US ON THE SENATE SIDE
THE ASSEMBLY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
SCHOOLS ARE HAVE CONNECTIITY.
AND IT'S A ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROBLEM THEN MAYBE WE
NEED TO FIND ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND FIX THE PROBLEM.
I'M JUST TRYING.
TO UNDERSTAND FIFTEEN THE REGIS
PICK A NUMBER OR WAS IT BASED ON
SOME.
ECHO MY COLLEAGUE AT THE END
HERE. FOR YES THE QUESTION HOW
DID WE GET -- TO FIFTEEN THERE
IS NO SECRET IN THE SAUCE ON
THIS ONE I THINK WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS AS HIS INITIAL
INVESTMENT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE THE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
FARTHEST BEHIND.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
INTEND TO LOOK AT FOUR AM OUR
NEXT BUDGET PROCESS IS A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT
CONNECTIVITY INNER INTERSTATE
THROUGHOUT FIRST ALL OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND HOW WE CAN CREATE.
A LARGER PLAN -- TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES MOVING FORWARD GOT
IT AT ALL SAY TO WEST FOR QUICK
THINGS FIRST AS JESSICA
MENTIONED FIFTY MILLION IS A
MODEST INITIAL INVESTMENT WE
KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING TO CONNECT
ALL THE SCHOOLS THAT NEED
BROADBAND WITH FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
BUT THE SECOND TING THING TO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE STUDY OF
DAYS -- IN ADDITION TO THE
EFFORTS CHASKA MENTION THE
MINISTRATIONS ALSO PUTTING
TOGETHER ITS ANNUAL FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN AND PEOPLE
ARE ACTIVELY WORKING ON THAT AND
WHEN THAT IS RELEASED IT WILL
HAVE A COMPONENT.
FOCUSED DIRECTLY ON THIS ISSUE
WHEN WHICH SHOULD INFORM NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET COVER SELECTS YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT WILL TRANSITION.
TO ISSUE.
NINETEEN K. TWELVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
KENNETH COUPON WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THIS ITEM
COVERS FOR DIFFERENCES IN
TRAILER LEGISLATION TRIED
LEGISLATION AFFECTING K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS.
FIRST THE GOVERNOR AND SENATE
APPROVED LANGUAGE THAT
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS CHARTER
SCHOOLS FROM DISCOURAGING
ENROLLMENT FOR ANY REASON.
I INCLUDING A STUDENTS PASS
ECONOMIC PERFORMANCE OR
DISABILITY STATUS.
BY THE ASSEMBLY REJECTED THAT
CHANGE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SENDING IT TO POLICY COMMITTEE.
ISSUE IN CONFERENCE COMMITTEE IS
WHETHER TO ADOPT THOSE CHANGES
NOW OR TO FOR THEM TO THE POLICY
COMMITTEE TO IRON OUT A FEW
REMAINING ISSUES.
A SECOND ALL THREE PLANS ADOPTED
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
IMPLEMENT A MORE STREAMLINED
PROCESS FOR MONITORING MOTHER
TEACHERS.
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE A STATE
CREDENTIAL FOR THE SUBJECT THEIR
TEACHING.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED ADDITIONAL
CHANGES TO EXTEND THE STATE'S
CREDENTIAL REQUIREMENTS AND THE
MONITORING -- TO ALL CHARTER
SCHOOL TEACHERS NOT JUST THOSE
IN CHRIST SUBJECT AREAS.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU AND
CONFERENCE IS WHETHER TO
MAINTAIN.
THE CREDENTIAL FLEXIBILITY
CHARTER SCHOOLS CURRENTLY HAVE
FOR THEIR NON CORE TEACHER IS
WHETHER TO APPLY THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS TO ALL TEACHERS IN
THE STATE.
THIRD OF THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR APPROVED LANGUAGE
ALLOWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE RECEIVED EMERGENCY LOANS TO
PAY.
A FULL SALARY TO RETIRED
ADMINISTRATORS WHO ARE WE HIRED
INTO THEIR FORMER POSITIONS.
AT THE ISSUE AND CONFERENCE AS
WELL THEY TO MAKE THAT PROVISION
ON GOING AS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES.
A SUNSET AFTER TWO YEARS AS THE
SENATE PROPOSES OR REJECTED
ENTIRELY AS THE ASSEMBLY AT
PROPOSES.
FINALLY BOTH HOUSES APPROVED
LANGUAGE ALLOWING THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO EXCEED THE MAXIMUM RATIO OF
ADMINISTRATORS TO TEACHERS
WITHOUT FACING A FISCAL PENALTY.
THE ISSUE IN CONFERENCES WITH
THAT PROVIDE THAT WAIVER FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS AS THE SENATE
APPROVED.
OR FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS AS
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED.
OF THOSE FOUR ISSUES -- NONE ARE
DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO A SPECIFIC
APPROPRIATION OR A BUDGET ACTION.
ALL OF THEM TO SOME EXTENT TO
INVOLVE A SOME IMPORTANT POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS FOR YOU.
AND SO WE THINK.
IF YOU WANTED TO DEFERRED THESE
ISSUES TO A POLICY COMMITTEE
COULD CERTAINLY FEEL COMFORTABLE
DOING THAT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OF FINANCE A VERY
BRIEFLY WE SUPPORT THE SENATE
APPROACH ON THESE ISSUES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT GIVEN THE
CONVERSATION AROUND EDUCATION
AND THE FOCUS ON IT FOR THIS
BUDGET PROCESS.
THAT THESE ISSUES ARE GERMANE
AND SHOULD BE DEALT WITH THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. THREE
MORE LOT.
MORE PHILOSOPHICAL MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
BUT NO I DID.
WE HAD A CONVERSATION THIS
MORNING WITH ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND IN OTHER SERVICE
AT WORK REAL HARD TO PUT BILLS
THROUGH COMMITTEES AND THEN.
GET THEM ON THE FLOOR IN.
GAME APPROVED IN IN AND I'M JUST
WONDERING.
WHAT WE'RE DOING WE'RE TRAILER
BILLS THIS YEAR WE'RE SAME OLD
SAME OLD -- OR OR BECAUSE
BECAUSE WE SHOULD BE WORKING ON
FINANCES NOT POLICY RIGHT IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
TIME JUST KIND OF CURIOUS.
SOME.
WHAT I GUESS IT DEPENDS?
ON A MONTH PERSPECTIVE I THINK
IN OUR EXPERIENCE THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS OF THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION WE HAD AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT TENDED TO DO
QUITE A BIT OF POLICY -- IN THE
BUDGET -- AND I KNOW CERTAINLY
MY MY VICE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE HAS --
FREQUENTLY EXPRESSES HIS -- THIS
MAY WITH THE TRAILER BILL --
EXPERIENCE AS AS IT HAS EVOLVED
OVER THE YEARS -- AND SO I THINK
THAT IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
TRY TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION WHAT THEY PUT FOR
THE BUDGET AND TRY TO THAT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS AS MUCH
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NEAR VERY
WELCOME.
ANY OTHER QUITE THIS OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANT.
TO EXPAND ON THE COMMENTS.
IN PARTICULAR REGARDING THE
CHARTER SCHOOL ENROLLMENT FEES.
BOB FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
DEALT WITH.
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WITHOUT A ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS ISSUE IN THE ASSEMBLY
THIS YEAR -- MANY MANY HOURS OF
TESTIMONY MANY MANY HOURS OF
DEBATE I DON'T THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN REALLY
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED.
IS PART OF THE BUDGETARY PROCESS
INSIDE DOES STRONGLY RECOMMEND
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION ON THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GIVE US ONE QUICK SECOND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK IN YOUR MANY HOURS AT
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE CANNELLA FAR SOMETHING. FOR
FUN.
I HEARD THAT.
JUST LIKE LINED UP YES.
THAT WAS VERY
.
TELL THE PM -- THE FINNISH ISSUE
NINETEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
A LINE AT THE SIDE BAR WILL MOVE
ON NOW.
TO ISSUE TWENTY STUDENTS
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
[inaudible]
HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON ELIA.
AND COROLLA THE LA ALSO THIS
ITEM -- STUDENT CENTRE FUNNY
PURGATORY BROUGHT A LITTLE BIT
OF BACKGROUND BEFORE WE GET INTO
THE SPECIFIC DIFFERENCES SO JUST
AS A REMINDER LAST YEAR THE
STATE ADOPTED A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WHICH CONSISTS OF THREE
COMPONENTS ONE BASED FUNDING
THAT'S BASED ON ENROLLMENT. TWO
OF FUNDING THAT'S BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS IN
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
AND THEN THREE OUTCOMES BASED
FUNDING BASED ON PRIMARILY
NUMBER OF US ASSOCIATE DEGREES
CERTIFICATES NUMBER SOON TO
TRANSFER.
I'M.
THIRTY THERE BEEN SOME CONCERNS
WITH -- IN THE FIRST YEAR WITH
SOME OF THE RELIABILITY QUALITY
OF THIS TO NOW COME DATA SO THE
GOOD MINISTRATION AT SOME -- TO
KEEP PROPOSALS IN THIS BUDGET
BETTER IT BEFORE YOU FOR
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST IS.
TO IT SHOULD STOP TO THINK THAT
THE STUDENT OUTCOMES PORTION OF
THE FORMULA -- IS SCHEDULED
UNDER CURRENT LAW TO INCREASE
UNTIL EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IT'S
ABOUT 10% OF THE FORMULA OF THE
TOTAL FOR NEW ACOSTA.
GROWING 215% NINETEEN TWENTY AND-THEN 220% IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FIRST
IS TO POSTPONE THAT SCHEDULED
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF THE
FORMULAS BASED ON OUTCOMES.
AND THEN SECOND GIVEN SOME OF
THE CONCERNS WITH THE STUDENT
OUTCOMES FUNDING TO CAP THE
ANNUAL GROWTH IN THE AMOUNT THAT
ANY INDIVIDUAL COMMITTEE BECAUSE
THE STRICKEN RECEIVED FROM.
UNDERSTOOD OUTCOMES PORTION OF
THE FORMULA.
EACH OF THE THOUSANDS TOOK
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT ACTIONS THE
THE TWO PIECES OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUT DIDN'T.
TAKE ON THE ENTIRE THING SO THE
SENATE -- ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO DELAY THE THE
SCHEDULED INCREASE IN THE THE
PORTION OF THE FORMULAS BASED ON
STUDENT OUTCOMES -- BUT THEN IN
TERMSINSTEAD OF APPLYING THIS
CAP YOUR YOUR GROWTH TO THE TO
THE OUTCOMES PORTION INSTEAD --
MAKES TO POLICY CHANGES ONE IS
TO CALCULATE THAT PORTION BASED
ON A THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE
JUST TWO NOW COMES TO SMOOTH OUT
THE COSTS.
AND THEN SECOND -- PROVIDED
FUNDING -- ONLY FOR THE HIGHEST
DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE EARNED BY
STUDENT IN THAT PARTICULAR YEAR
NOT JUST -- ANY NUMBER OR FOR
ANY -- OR THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
DEGREES TO FORGET THE STUDENT
EARNS THAT YEAR.
THE ASSEMBLY OF EXPERTS POSE --
TO KEEP IN PLACE THE CURRENT --
OF FUNDING FORMULA RATES OF THAT
MOVING FORWARD ONLY 10% OF THE
FORMULA WOULD.
BE BASED ON STUDENT OUTCOMES --
BUT DID ADOPT -- THE FUNDING
FORMULA -- CAP ON THE STUDENTS
ON THE STUDENT OUTCOMES PORTION
SO -- DIFFERENT APPROACHES THE
SENATE PHYSIQUE MODIFYING HOW WE
TREAT OTHERS TO NOT COME
PERSONAL FORMULA THE ASSEMBLY
THE KEY CHANGES.
TO LOCK IN PLACE THE PORTION THE
FRONT OF THE FUNDING FORMULA
BASED ON STUDENT OUTCOMES.
ARE WE ACTUALLY RECOMMEND THE
SENATE VERSION HERE WITHIN THE
SENATE VERSION ADDRESSES SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT -- WE'VE SEEN
WITH SOME OF THE DATA BY --
CREATING A MUCH MUCH MORE -- A
SMOOTHER BUT YOUR YOUR CHANGE IN
THAT IN FUNDING BY USING A THREE
YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE.
AND BY USING ONLY THE HIGHEST
DEGREE EARNED WOULD AVOID SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT FROM --
PEOPLE PEOPLE ABOUT ABOUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR EXAMPLE I
COULD YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATES TO GET ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
ONLY AT ONE POINT WHICH IS THAT
HE PLAN TO EXPLORE WHAT WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE REVISIONS TO
THE FUNDING FORMULA IN THE
UPCOMING YEAR -- BUT FOR NOW WE
WE BELIEVE IN A REVISION IS THE
BEST APPROACH.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SEE NONE WILL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE TWENTY ONE ONLINE
COLLEGE ELIA.
THIS IS A THIS IS A AND ASSEMBLY
ACTION THE GOVERNOR AND SENATE
HAD NO PROPOSAL.
ON THE JUST BE BRIEF BACKGROUND
YES ABOUT YESTERDAY LAST YEAR --
THE STATE ADOPTED AS PART OF THE
TEAM NINETEEN BUDGET I CREATED A
NEW ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE --
THE IN THAT FIRST YEAR THAT ONLY
CAN YOU CALL JUST PROVIDED WITH
ONE HUNDRED MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT COULD BE SPENT OVER
SEVEN YEARS.
AND IN ADDITION WAS OPERATE WITH
TWENTY MILLION THAT IT WOULD
RECEIVE ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION IS. TO TWO
PIECES FIRST IT'S TO REDUCE THE
ONGOING FUNDING ABOUT FROM
TWENTY MILLION TO FIVE MILLION.
AND THEN IT WOULD BE TOOK THE
SECOND OPTION WOULD BE TO TAKE
FIFTY MILLION OF THE HUNDRED
MILLION PROVIDED A ONE TIME
FUNDING LAST YEAR -- AND USE IT
FOR OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PURPOSES.
AND I'LL ADD THAT DAIS ONLINE
COLLEGES RAMPING UP ITS
OPERATIONS IS SCHEDULED TO BEGIN
ENROLLING STUDENTS THIS FALL SO
THE GOVERNOR BELIEVES THAT WE
SHOULD NOT BE REDUCING FUNDING
AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU IN THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
THOROUGH.
BUT I GUESS MY QUESTION IS WHAT
WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT OF
FIFTH OF ONE HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME WAS TO BE USED FOR START UP
OVER SIXTY SEVEN YEARS. SEVEN
YEARS WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT
OF TAKING FIFTY MILLION.
AWAY FROM THAT OF BUCKET -- TO
USE FOR OTHER PURPOSES DURING
THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR.
PERHAPS WITH AN ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT THE ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DOING.
IN THE IN OUR RUN UP TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
AND MAKING FURTHER ADJUSTMENTS
IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION YES AND
WE DON'T SO IN TERMS OF THE
SHORT TERM WE DON'T THINK THAT
WOULD BE A LOT OF IMMEDIATE
EFFECTS -- THE AND THE FOLKS FOR
THE ONLY COMMITTEE CALLED
PROVIDED SOME INFORMATION AND
NONE OF THE ONE TIME FUNDING
ACTUALLY BEEN SPENT I THINK WHEN
WE ARE.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM IN MARCH --
ARE UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE
LESS THAN A MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE ONGOING FUNDING HAD BEEN
SPENT.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN SOME BAD
LEVERAGE SOME OF PHILANTHROPY
DOLLARS TO HAVE TO START SOME OF
THESE ACTIVITIES SO THAT'S
MOSTLY WHAT EXPENDITURES HAVE
BEEN THIS ONE TIME FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE WE DON'T THINK IT HAS
AN IMMEDIATE EFFECT ON THEIR ON
THEIR ACTIVITIES.
BUT THAT BEING SAID TO BE THEY
ARE EXPECTED THEY WOULD HAVE
THIS FUNDING FOR SEVEN YEARS AND
IF YOU'RE REDUCING THAT AMOUNT
AND HALF AND THAT DOES MEAN THAT
THEY'RE LIKELY THEY WILL LIKELY
NEED TO CHANGE WITH OUR LONG
TERM PLAN IS IN TERMS OF WHAT.
WHAT ACTIVITIES ARE PILING ON
SPENDING?
AT THIS POINT WE HADN'T RECEIVED
THE SPECIFIC DETAIL PLAN ON HOW
THAT HUNDRED MILLION WAS TO BE
SPENT WE CAN GIVE YOU ANY
SPECIFICITY IN TERMS OF WITH
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES WOULD BE
REMOVED.
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT THERE.
THERE ARE THREE ONLINE COLLEGE
pGOING TO ROLL OUT.
IN AUGUST WITH CLASSES BEGINNING
IN OCTOBER I GATHER THEN THAT
REDUCING THE ONE TIME BUCKET
FROM A HUNDRED TO FIFTY MILLION
IS PROBABLY NOT GOING TO IMPACT
THOSE THREE ONLINE PROGRAMS.
THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE OUR
THAT WOULD BE OUR EXPECTATION IT
IS MOVING FORWARD AT OTHER
PROGRAMS RAMPING UP WITH THE
CHANGES WOULD BE.
DID DID THEY DID THE ONLINE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ADMINISTRATORS GIVE YOU ANY IDEA
OF WHAT THEY EARN NEXT WITH THE
FOLLOW UP PLANS ARE FOLLOWING
PLANS ARE FOR ONLINE PROGRAMS.
GIVE ME IN REGARDS TO THE THE
REDUCTION OF THE FIFTY NINE
DOLLAR NO BEYOND THE THREE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE APPARENTLY
GOING TO START IN OCTOBER AMMAR.
I HAVE NOT HEARD OF IT SPECIFIC
I KNOW THAT THEY ARE IN --
LOOKING INTO POTENTIAL WHAT
THROUGH THOSE OTHER PATHWAYS
WOULD BE I KNOW THAT THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO I BELIEVE GET TO UP
TO TEN PATHWAYS THAT THEY WOULD
BE DEVELOPING -- BUT WE HAVE NOT
HEARD OF ANY SPECIFIC.
JUST THAT THEY ARE STILL LOOKING
INTO WHAT UP WITH THOSE PAST
MIGHT BE AND WHAT WOULD BE THE
BEST.
OPTIONS THAT MIGHT THAT THEY
COULD CONNECT EMPLOYERS IN THIS
INSTANCE WITH.
AND MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS FERGUSON
HAS SOME COMMENTS AS WELL
CERTAINLY I THINK WHAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT IF YOU WERE TO REDUCE
THAT FIFTY MILLION IT STARTS TO
CHANGE.
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICE TOOL FOR WILL BE
WOULD BE CREATED AND PROVIDED TO
THE STUDENTS.
IT WOULD IMPACT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF ADDITIONAL -- PATHWAYS MOVING
FORWARD SO CERTAINLY I THINK.
YOU KNOW I JUST LIKE TO TAKE IT
BACK TO REALLY THE UP THE
FUNDAMENTAL PURPOSE OF THE
ONLINE COLLEGE AND THAT IS WE
KNOW THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
SOME COLLEGE BUT NO DEGREE.
IT'S IN THE MILLIONS WE KNOW
THAT THEY WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS -- AND
OUR GOAL IS TO TRY AND IMPROVE
ECONOMIC MOBILITY THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS SO TO THE EXTENT YOU
WERE.
TO PRODUCE FOR RE DIRECT THOSE
RESOURCES TOWARDS OTHER PURPOSES --
IT WOULD CERTAINLY UNDERMINE
THAT BROUGHT GOAL.
WELL I MEAN MY GUESS THE REASON
I'M ASKED WE SENATE HAD NO
PROPOSAL ON THIS BUT I'M.
REVIEWING THE ASSEMBLY IS
PROPOSAL AND I'M TRYING. TO TO
SORT OF NOODLE THIS OUT -- THIS
ONE HUNDRED MILLION WAS
APPROPRIATED IN THE LAST BUDGET
PROCESS.
AND IF ONE MILLION OF THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION HAS BEEN SPENT --
AND WE'RE MOVING INTO THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO MOVE PRETTY
QUICKLY AND INCREASED THE BURN
RATE.
BETTER PRETTY SIGNIFICANT RATE
OF TO TO BURN THROUGH FIFTY
MILLION LET ALONE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION IN THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR
AND OF COURSE BUDGET.
BEING OF MATTER BALANCING
PRIORITIES WHICH YOU WILL DO ALL
THE TIME AND WE TRY TO PLAY IN
THAT GAME.
OF IF THERE'S ANOTHER USE FOR
THE MONEY TEMPORARILY WE MADE I
WANT TO PUT THAT TO A DIFFERENT
USE.
I THINK I I UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM A NOTE THAT
THE ONLINE COLLEGES BUDGET WAS
RECENTLY -- TAKEN BEFORE THE THE
ONLINE CULTURES BORDER YEAH I
BELIEVE IT HAD BROOKLEY FORTY
EIGHT MILLION AND PLANNED
EXPENDITURES FOR THE UPCOMING
YEAR SO THERE CERTAINLY WORKING
TOWARDS EXPENDING THESE.
RESOURCES I THINK I WOULD
APPLAUD THEM IN BEING PRUDENT IN
THEIR USE OF THESE RESOURCES --
AND TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING THE BEST VALUE FOR OUR
DOLLAR.
OKAY THAT SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU
VENTURE THANK YOU MISS SKINNER
FOLLOWED BY MR TING.
DID I HEAR YOU CORRECTLY THAT
YOU JUST SAID THEY PLAN TO SPEND
FORTY EIGHT MILLION JUST NEXT
YEAR. FOR MORE MONEY AFTER THE
FOR YES SAID AT THE GOAL OF THAT
IS BOTH ONE TIME AND ONGOING
EXPENDITURES TO DEVELOP AND
ACQUIRE TECHNOLOGY. TO I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WE'VE ONLY
ALRIGHT THIS WHAT WAS AUTHORIZED
LAST YEAR WAS A HUNDRED MILLION
ON YOU KNOW OVER THE SEVEN YEARS
AND TWENTY MILLION OPERATIONAL
IF THEY'RE GOING TO SPEND FORTY
EIGHT MILLION OF IN ONE YEAR.
THEN IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THEY'RE
EXPECTING US TO GIVE THEM QUITE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY
STARTING IN THE FOLLOWING FISCAL
YEAR.
BUT THAT SEEMS PRETTY BIG LEAP.
WELL I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THAT
IS ROUGHLY ONE QUARTER OF THE
HUNDRED MILLION IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND YOU WOULD.
LIKE TO SEE THE BIGGEST EXPENSES
IN THAT FIRST YEAR -- SO THE
THIS PROGRAM OR RATHER.
ONLINE COURSES WAS NOT
CONTROVERSIAL.
IN THE DISCUSSIONS.
AROUND -- IN FACT MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND
DISTRICTS DO OFFER ONLINE
COURSES AND THERE WAS A LOT OF
SENTIMENT -- TO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD TAKE THE
APPROACH OF SUPPORTING THE
PROPOSAL POINTED OUT SUCH THINGS
AS THERE WOULDN'T EVEN BE
ACCREDITATION OF THIS A
CENTRALIZED ONLINE PROPOSAL --
COLLEGE AND FOR YEARS AND THAT
THERE WAS EXISTENCE OF THESE
PROGRAMMES ELSEWHERE AND THERE
COULD BE -- YOU KNOW WE COULD
EITHER DISTRIBUTE -- FUNDS
ACROSS THE STATE OR PICK CERTAIN
REGIONS THAT YOU KNOW MY EITHER.
HAVE MOST APPETITE FOR IT --
HIGHEST NEED -- BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WAS VERY -- SET.
ON THIS PROPOSAL AND AS I
INDICATE THERE WA A IT WAS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL.
AND SO I WONDER GIVEN THAT.
THE THE PROGRAM IS ONLY SPENT
HIS IS INDICATED.
THAT.
A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY TO DATE
AND EVEN IF THEY PLAN TO SPEND
ANOTHER FORTY MILLION WHICH
SEEMS PRETTY.
DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE IN THE
FIRST YEAR -- WHETHER WE ARE
WISER RE VISITING THAT CONCEPT
OF STRENGTHENING THE ABILITY OF
OUR COMMUNITY CALL EXISTING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS THAT
HAPPENED PREDATION. TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ONLINE COURSES.
END OF THESE PATHWAYS COULD NOT
BE FULFILLED THROUGH THAT.
SO I WOULD NOT THE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET DID INCLUDE SOME ONE TIME
FUNDING I THINK GOES THROUGH THE
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE.
THAT WAS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
FUNDING -- THAT WOULD GO OUT ITS
GRANTS -- TO THE FOR TRADITIONAL
CAM YOU COLLEGES SO THAT THEY
COULD DEVELOP THEM ONLINE
PROGRAMS BUT THOSE PROGRAMS WE
COULD POTENTIALLY ALIGNED WITH.
SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES OF THE
ONLINE COLLEGE
EVEN IF THERE ISN'T
AN ACCREDITATION -- OR AN
ACCREDITATION AUTHORITY THAT HAS
ACCREDITED THE PROGRAM THAT
EMPLOYERS WILL I KNOW THE
PROGRAM WELL ENOUGH THAT THEY
WILL HAVE BUT THEY WILL BE --
WILLING TO HIRE -- INDIVIDUALS
TO COMPLETE THOSE PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
THE NIGHTMARE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I AM INTRIGUED BY THE ASSEMBLY
RECOMMENDATION THIS IS.
THIS IS REALLY COOL -- THIS WAS
A VERY CONTROVERSIAL ITEM LAST
YEAR.
AND THE CAMPUSES OF FOR THAT
WHAT WAS SEVENTY TWO OTHER
DISTRICTS FOR WERE NOT AMUSED BY
THE PROPOSAL IN.
ELOY OAKLEY THE CHANCER LOBBY.
PRETTY AGGRESSIVELY.
TO GET THIS THING OFF THE GROUND --
SERVICE ONE OF THE VINE AND THEN
CHOOSE ME -- THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE HAVING A TOUGH TIME --
TO JUST LOOK AT THIS WEEK AT LA.
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
THEIR UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT.
FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE MILLION AND
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT'S ONE
BILLION. THIRTY FOUR TO WIN A
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE YEAR
WHICH WOULD BE PROBABLY THE OPEN
UP THE OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
AND I DOUBT THEY HAVE A PROGRAM
TO START PAYING THAT DOWN LIKE
YOU DO.
AND INTO THESE COLLEGES ARE
GOING TO COME TO US.
AND TO HELP US OUT WE CAN WE WE
JUST DON'T KNOW HOW TO RUB TO
NICKELS TOGETHER TO START.
ATTACKING.
THIS PROBLEM THIS FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS LIKE I I SIT HERE I I
SAY WHY DO WE START A NEW
PROGRAM.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SEVENTY TWO
AND A?
SEVEN TWO SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY
TWO DISTRICTS.
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR CAMPUS I
SHOULD AND I DON'T HAVE ALL THE
NUMBERS MEMORIES BUT WHY ARE WE
DOING SOMETHING NEW AND
INNOVATIVE IN EXPENSIVE WHEN
WHEN WE'VE GOT.
STAGGERING NUMBERS SOME
STAGGERING NUMBERS TO LOOK AT
AND SO IT KIND OF GIVES ME THAT
LET'S GET REAL MOMENT.
BY COULD STEAL A PHRASE -- BUT
THE I THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SHOULD REALLY REEVALUATE.
THIS WHOLE ENDEAVOR.
I'M.
YOU ALREADY LOOKED AT A COUPLE
OF OTHER.
INITIATIVES BY OUR FORMER
GOVERNOR A GOVERNOR BROWN AND I
I THINK.
HE WOULD DO THE CITIZENS A
SERVICE BY TAKING A HARD LOOK AT
THIS ONE AS WELL.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
I'LL MAKE YOU VERY -- BRIEF
COMMENTS -- AND DON'T WHATEVER
HURTS THE DEBATE THAT I KNOW ALL
THE PARTS SPENT LAST YEAR BUT
JUST TWO QUICK THINGS I THINK.
FIRST IS THAT -- FOR SAYS WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN THIS PROPOSAL WAS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED AT
INDIVIDUALS IN THE WORK FORCE
YOU DON'T HAVE A CREDENTIAL AND
WHO FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS THAT
I KNOW YOU'VE DISCUSSED OF MIND
ARE FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS
OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM SO WE DIED --
I GUESS GOVERNOR BROWN DODD AND
GOT THIRTY SOME AGREES -- WE TO
FIND ANOTHER WAY TO REACH THEM --
AND THEN THE SECOND POINT TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT COST PRESSURES
IS THAT ANY NEW INITIATIVE
REQUIRES SOME START UP COSTS BUT
WE BELIEVE THAT INITIATIVE LIKE
THIS.
IF RUN WHILE WILL SERVE THE
STUDENTS POSSIBLY AT A LOWER
COST.
AND I I I UNDERSTAND IT'S A
NOBLE CONCEPT.
NOBLE CAUSE.
BUT I I'M NOT GOING TO BUY MY
WIFE A DIAMOND RING WHEN I'VE
GOT. TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN CREDIT CARD DEBT.
A LITTLE MORE DEAD COME ON NOW.
I'M JUST SAYING I'M JUST SAYING
IN.
IF IF IF OUR HOUSE ISN'T IN
ORDER. ONE GRADUAL LIKE THAT --
YEAH.
SHE'S BEEN WITH ME FOR ALMOST
THIRTY NINE YEARS BABY AND I
HAVE BEEN REALLY BLESSED.
THANK YOU KNOW THE POINT I'M
TRYING TO MAKE AN THAT IS YOU
DON'T BUY A LUXURY ITEM.
WHEN YOU'RE DE YOU KNOW WHEN
WHEN WHEN WHEN THE WHEN YOUR?
HOUSEHOLD BANK STATEMENTS ARE
TELLING YOU MAY BE WITH WE GOTTA
FOCUS SOMEWHERE ELSE.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT.
I'M JUST I'M JUST SAY IN WHICH
WE WERE GONNA HAVE SOMETHING
COMING OUT OF FRONT PORCH.
SOON IF WE HAVE A RECESSION IT'S
GOING TO BE AWFUL AND SO THAT'S
WHY.
I JUST WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS THANK
YOU.
OKAY MISTER MOORE LE CAMILLA TO
STOP BY YOUR HEAD.
MR TING FOLLOWED BY.
TING FALL BY MISTER.
MAYES.
THANK YOU SIR JUST A QUICK POINT
OF CLARIFICATION TO ALEJO -- SO
DOWN.
SIR AT THIS POINT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAS BEEN A MILLION.
AND IT'SONE MILLION OUT OF THE
TWENTY MILLION ON GOING.
THAT WAS THAT WAS OUR OUR
UNDERSTANDING IT I THINK THIS
INFORMATION IS FROM FROM MARCH
OR APRIL SO IT'S OKAY IT COULD
CHANGE THAT WAS OUR
UNDERSTANDING AT THAT TIME BUT
BUT ROUGHLY IN THE KNOWN AS OF
MARCH OR APRIL IS A MILLION OUT
OF THE TWENTY MILLION ON GOING.
PLUS THERE IS THE OTHER.
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME.
IS THAT CORRECT RESEARCH ONE
MILLION OUT OF THE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE SO IT'S I GUESS
GOING BACK.
TO FINANCE WHY NOT.
AGAIN.
IF THE MONEY'S NOT GETTING SPEND
WHY NT.
SPEND SOME OF THE MONEY OR HALF
THE MONEY THIS YEAR ANOTHER ONE
TIME THINGS WE'VE LISTED OFF.
DAD CAPITAL ITEMS THAT REALLY
COULD BE USED INSTEAD OF KEEPING
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
BANK ACCOUNT SINCE.
THEY THEY SAY THEY HAVE A PLAN
BEEN BEEN FAIRLY.
HAVE HAD A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
EXECUTING.
BUT I WOULD SAY IS THEY HAVE A
PLAN TO RAMP UP AND THEY ARE
RAMPING UP IN THEIR HIRING STAFF.
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE MOVING DOWN
THAT PATHWAY AND THAT TAKES TIME --
BUT CERTAINLY I THINK.
WE THINK THE RESOURCES THAT HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED WILL BE NECESSARY
OVER THAT SEVEN YEAR PERIOD TO
SUPPORT THE COLLEGE TO SUPPORT
THE STUDENT.
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY IT'S IT'S
THAT GOAL RIGHT OF SERVING THOSE
STUDENTS WHILE WE THINK THOSE
RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY TO DO
THAT.
RIGHT BUT AS AS WOULD BE TYPICAL
WE WOULD NOT.
TRADITIONAL PREPARATION IS
APPROPRIATIONS SPENT OVER TWO
YEARS WE WE DON'T APPROPRIATE IN
GENERAL UNLESS FOR DOING
CONTAINS APPROPRIATION WITH THE
IDEA THAT WE'RE SPENDING
SOMETHING SEVEN YEARS.
DOWN THE LINE SO WHY.
WHY WHY IS IT SO IMPERATIVE? FOR
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO BE SITTING IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S BANK ACCOUNT RATHER
THAN.
BEING USED BY THE STATE FOR DEBT
REPAYMENTS ARE THE CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES.
AGAIN I THINK I JUST GO BACK --
TO THEY WERE SET ASIDE TO WHAT
THE A PLAN IN MIND TO EXPAND
THEM ON THAT COLLEGE ON THE
FRONT AND SO CERTAINLY IF WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT BUDGET RESILIENCY
BY HAVING THOSE PROGRAM TODAY --
THOSE ARE GOING TO BE FUTURE
EXPENSES PROGRAM TOMORROW.
UNDERSTOOD THE JUST ECHOING MY
PLACE MY SENATE COLLEAGUES THAT
HAD DIFFICULT TIME.
EXECUTING AND AND SPENDING THAT
MONEY SO -- AT WHAT POINT DO WE
SAY PERHAPS -- THESE ARE.
NICE PLANS BUT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING DONE AND WE WANT THE
MONEY BACK BECAUSE WE WE JUST
WENT THROUGH YOU KNOW THREE
THREE PLUS HOURS ON K. TWELVE AN
AFTER SCHOOL AND WE STARTED WITH
THE VERVIEW AND THE DDS.
THE ITEM FROM CENTS FIFTY YOU
KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT A NUMBER OF
THINGS WHICH ARE.
PRIORITIES RIGHT THESE ARE NOT
THESE ARE NOT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
SO.
SO WHILE THE CHANCELLOR'S GOT A
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN HIS ACCOUNT WE'RE GONNA TELL
SENIORS AND DISABLED FAMILIES
SORRY WE'RE GONNA SUNSET YOUR
SERVICES IN TWO YEARS.
SO I THINK. TO THAT UP FRONT I
THINK WE'D HAVE TO TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND NON PROPOSITION
I NAY TO THESE ARE WITHIN THE
GUARANTEED TO CERTAINLY THEY
COULDN'T SUPPORT.
ON THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS -- BUT
WE DO HAVE A A PLAN THAT THE
ONLINE COLLEGE HAS HE PLANNED TO
SPEND THOSE RESOURCES IN SUPPORT
OF STUDENTS TO DEVELOP PROGRAMS --
AND TO SEE THAT THOSE STUDENTS
ARE ABLE TO IMPROVE THEIR
ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR FORGET TO
WRITE THANKS FOR THE
CLARIFICATION PROP NINETY IS
HALL ALL SWITCHED ANALOGY SO.
RIGHT NOW AT A TIME WHEN WE'VE
DOUBLED EDUCATION SPENDING FROM
FORTY BILLION TO EIGHTY BILLION --
WE HAD THREE MAJOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GO ON STRIKE.
WE HAVE ANOTHER THREATENING TO
GO ON STRIKE WE HAVE -- YOU KNOW
HOW LAST COUNT ROUGHLY HALF HAVE
TO DISTRICTS IN THE STATE.
CONCERNED WHY WHY ARE WE SITTING
ON THIS MONEY AND HAVING IT IN
THE BANK ACCOUNT RATHER THAN.
PUTTING IT IN CAL STARS PUTTING
ANY CALPERS DOING SOMETHING THAT
COULD REALLY.
ASSIST THESE -- DISTRICTS.
SO I THINK -- THE KEY POINT IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND THIS MONEY UNLESS THERE IS
A SHARP SHIFT IN DIRECTION ON
THIS COLLEGE IT IS PART OF OUR
PROPOSITION NINETY PACKAGE IT'S
PART OF THE CAPITAL PLAN.
SO -- AND THE MONEY IS SITTING
THERE BUT IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW
WITH LIKE YOU MENTIONED A NUMBER
OF EXPENDITURES -- OFTEN TAKE A
COUPLE OF YEARS DEPENDING ON
LEGISLATIVE AND GOVERNOR
DIRECTION SO -- YOU KNOW IF IF
IF THIS ISSUE IS GOING TO BE
RENEGOTIATING SUMS ARE MORE
SIGNIFICANT WAY IF WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY GOING FORWARD THAT'S A
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION.
BUT WITH WITH THE PROJECT GOING
FORWARD WE DID WANT TO SET ASIDE
THIS MONEY IT IS ONE TIME MONEY
IT IS FOR START UP COSTS THIS IS
A NEW INITIATIVE.
SO WE THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
PUT THAT ASIDE AND I BELIEVE I
CAN CONFIRM WITH MY COLLEAGUES
BUT IT IS PROBABLY EARNING MONEY
ATTHE NORMAL BANK DEPOSIT RATE.
WHICH IS WHAT.
YOU KNOW THE MONIES CAN SPEND
YOU AND I'LL CHECK ON THE NEXT
PLANE GO TO VEGAS BECAUSE
CLEARLY.
IT'S I DON'T I DON'T THINK IT
WILL CLEARLY IT'S NOT GETTING
SPENT.
AND AND CLEARLY WHATEVER PLAN IS
BEING PUT TOGETHER.
REALLY HAS AN AMOUNT TO HASN'T
AMOUNTED TO VERY MUCH I THINK
THAT'S THE CHALLENGES WHEN.
THE THE CHANCELLOR THE NEW CEO'S
BUT HOUSE FOR ARTICULATION OF
PLANS IT'S NOT BEEN VERY CLEAR --
NOT BEEN VERY CONVINCING SAID
WHICH IS WHICH IS WHY WE TOOK IN
ASSEMBLY ACTION THIS YEAR.
AND GIVEN.
THAT ARM WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PRIORITIES WE REALLY WOULD URGE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE A HARDER
LOOK AT REALLY WHAT DOES.
THIS PROGRAM NEED IN THE NEXT
YEAR TO WHICH I THINK MAKES
SENSE WHAT REALISTICALLY COULD
BE SPENT AND AND FRANKLY THAN
THE REST SHOULD BE.
REDIRECTED AMONGST.
MANY OF ALL OF OUR COLLECTIVE
SURE PRIORITIES I THINK WE HAVE
MANY SURE PARKS [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
THANK [inaudible]
MR MAYES.
I WASN'T PREPARED TODAY TO
DEFEND ONLINE COLLEGES BUT I I
DO FEEL -- THE NEED -- TO TO
DEFEND SOME FOLKS THAT THAT LIVE
IN IN MY DISTRICT IN A RURAL
PART.
OF THE STATE YEAH AND A
COMMUNITY LIKE THE ONE THAT I
GREW UP IN AND STILL LIVE IN.
YOU KNOW I WANT TO MY LOCAL
COMMITTEE COLLEGE -- FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS -- AND I DROVE
TO GET TO MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE I
DROVE TWENTY MILES A TO BE ABLE
TO GET TO MY MY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
AND I KNOW AS I'M LOOKING AROUND
SOME OF THE THE THE OTHER
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE LIVE IN --
INTENSE THAT PARTS OF THE
STATE'S WAS SO THERE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES ARE DON'T HAVE THREE OR
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS WITH LOTS
OF FACULTY THEY CAN HAVE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT BY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS --
THE DAY -- THAT THAT IS NOT THE
CASE FOR MY FOR MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT -- ARE MY SCHOOL OF MY
COMMITTEE CALLS DISTRICT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
HAVE THIS TYPE OF A PROGRAM IN
OUT WHILE I WOULD LOVE TO SAY
THISA LUXURY ITEM -- I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A LUXURY
ITEM -- BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU
THAT A FRIENDS THAT I GREW UP
WITH THE NETWORK NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO GO ON
TO COLLEGE BECAUSE THERE WEREN'T
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO BE
ABLE TO GO AWAY BECAUSE THEY HAD.
TO A TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND SO I
FEAR I JUST FEAR THAT THE
CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING TODAY
IS HEY WELL YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
DO AWAY WITH THIS PROGRAM.
ALL TOGETHER.
WITH THAT SAID I AM SENSITIVE --
TO THAT THE CHAIRMAN OF OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE IN REGARDS TO
HOW ONEY IS BEING SPENT AND IT
WOULD SEEM APPROPRIATE -- TO
HAVE -- THIS CHANCELLOR OF THE
ONLINE COLLEGE SHORT THE CEO
WHOEVER IS A TO BE ABLE TO COME --
BUT BEFORE THIS BODY AND SAY
WHAT DO YOU DILLON -- AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE NOT SPENDING
MONEY AS QUICKLY AS A NEED TO BE
SPENDING MONEY THEY HAVEN'T --
SUBMITTED PLANS LIKE THE NEED TO
SUBMIT PLANS.
IN BACK TO BACK TO MY POINT IS
I'VE GOT -- KIDS THAT LIVE IN MY
DISTRICT IN MY HOMETOWN THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE'RE NOT PROVIDING FOR THEM AND
THEY NEED TO GET ON WITH IT IF
THEY'RE GOING TO SPEND THE MONEY.
MR MCCARTY TO FOLLOW UP TO THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE MISS SKINNER ON
DECK AS WEL FOLLOW UP JUST THIS
TOPIC BUT STATE SENATOR IN GOV.
IS BEFORE ME.
QUIT MUSCULAR.
I'M JUST FOLLOWING UP ON THE
COMMENTS IS SO THE I HAVE NO
OBJECTION TO ONLINE COURSES AND
I WANT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE ONLINE COURSES
AND I AM CONVINCED.
THAT IT ABSOLUTELY IS A NEED
BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY YOU'RE ONE
OF THE DISADVANTAGES STILL OF
OUR COMMUNICABLE **** IS
ORIENTATION TOWARDS THE FULL
TIME STUDENT.
WHO IS AVAILABLE YOU NINE FIVE
TO GO TO SCHOOL WHEN WE KNOW SO
MANY PEOPLE?
ARE HAVING TO WORK AND THEN TRY
TO FIT THEIR EDUCATION AND AND
THAT'S EVEN STUDENTS TO WRITE
OFF A HIGH SCHOOL BUT THEN WE
ALSO HAVE STUDENTS.
THAT NEED TO COME BACK AND WHO
ARE WHO ARE IN MIDDLE OF A
CAREER CHANGER NEED NEW SKILL
SET OR WHATEVER SO I WANT.
MORE ONLINE COURSES THE ISSUE
AND THE CONTROVERSY LAST YEAR
AND I THINK IT'S BEING WELL
POINTED OUT AGAIN TODAY IS THAT.
WE'RE NOW HAPPY TO SET SOMETHING
UP THAT IS GOING TO TAKE YEARS
TO REALLY BE OPERATIONAL WHEN
THE NEED IS NOW AND WHEN WE HAD
DISTRICTS IN COLLEGES UP AND
DOWN THE STATE.
WHO SHOWED A DESIRE AND A
WILLINGNESS TO FULFILL THE NEED
AND WHO ARE ALREADY ACCREDITED
AND WHO ALREADY HAVE CURRICULUM
SO THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
DEVELOP CURRICULA?
AND THEY ALSO CAN PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT FOR THOSE STUDENTS TO
TAKE THE CLASS ONLINE BUT MADE
THEN NEED THE IN PERSON.
SO I ROMANTICALLY THIS COLLEGE
NEW DISTRICT IS LOCATED RIGHT BY
OWN DISTRICT RIGHT IN OAKLAND --
NOW I DOUBT -- FOR EXAMPLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES THAT IF
THERE ARE SOME STUDENTS IN YOUR
AREA WHO DECIDE TO TAKE THE
ONLINE COURSES FROM THIS.
THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO
OAKLAND TO GET THE SUPPORT SO IF.
THE IF THE OAKLAND BASED
DISTRICT HAS IN MIND THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO SET UP
SATELLITE SPOCK'S AROUND THE
STATE TO PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT
AND I DON'T KNOW AND MAYBE
THAT'S WHY THE NEED TO SPEND
FORTY EIGHT MILLION I DON'T KNOW
BUT THAT SEEMS TO ME.
A REAL DUPLICATE TO EFFORT GIVEN
THAT WE HAVE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
SO MY ISSUE IS MUCH MORE.
HOW DO WE BEST TO LIVE FOR ON?
COURSES AND ONLINE TEACHING MOST
COST EFFECTIVELY AND MOST
EDUCATIONALLY EFFECTIVELY.
AND I THE LAKE BEEN THE LAST
YEAR'S DISCUSSION WAS EVEN LA --
THAT RAISED THAT THE USE OF
EXISTING ACCREDITED.
LOCATIONS WHO ALREADY HAVE
CURRICULA MAY BE A WISER COURSE.
BUT IT WAS OUR THE
ADMINISTRATION LAST YEAR IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THAT WAS BE
RESET ON THIS -- PROPOSAL BUT
LASTLY -- JUST POINT OUT AND I
WOULD ASK.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANOTHER.
THING THAT WE IN PROP NINETY
EIGHT THAT WE'VE GUARANTEED FOR
SEVEN YEARS.
THIS IS THE ONLY PROP NINETY
EIGHT EXPENDITURES THAT I CAN
THINK OF THAT WE SAID OKAY YES
WE'RE GOING TO SET THIS ASIDE
FOR SEVEN YEARS.
FINANCIAL LIKE TO SPAWN BEFORE
GOING TO THE DIGITAL MEMBERS OR
I THINK AT THE SET ASIDE IS TIED
UP WITH THE FACT THIS IS A BRAND
NEW.
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE SAID THAT IS
IT IS DIFFERENT BUT IT'S
DIFFERENT FOR THAT REASON.
MR MCCARTY NOT LINKED IS NOT
CALLED THE CAPITAL BUT THAT'S
OKAY.
HELLO BUT IT'S FOR START UP
COSTS YES.
YEAH A FEW -- THOUGHTS ON THIS
SO WE WE DID SPEND QUITE A BIT
TIME TALKING ABOUT THIS.
IN JUST TO GET THE CONCLUSION
AFTER THIS DISCUSSION WE HAD
STUDENTS IN THE AUDIENCE WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
BEING HUNGRY.
AND VETERANS ONE OF THE GOOD
GUYS RESOURCE CENTERS APPS BOOKS
ADVOCATING.
FOR THE THE POINT A PROGRAM IN
THE EMOJI PROGRAM AND SO WE JUST
THOUGHT YOU KNOW WHAT THERE ARE
OTHER NEEDS TODAY.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THIS PROGRAM
SHOULD GET THE DEATH PENALTY SO
LET'S LET'S TAKE A STEP BACK THE
WHOLE PROGRAM SO.
YEAH THERE THERE IS A BIG NEED --
TO EDUCATE -- CALLED ADULTS WHO
DON'T HAVE HIGHER EDUCATION OR
EVEN A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
BECAUSE HE JOBS OF TODAY AND
TOMORROW ACQUIRE DOING ONLINE
PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW -- WE HOPE
NOT AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
THERE'S AN ARRANGEMENT THIS
SHOULD BE STUFF IT'S DIFFERENT
WE'RE NOT GOING.
TO COMPETE BUT THE BIG PICTURE
IS -- THESE PROGRAMS ARE GONNA
GET APPORTIONMENT WHICH YOU KNOW
EQUIVALENT OF EIGHTY EIGHT SO
THEY'RE GONNA GET MONEY PER
STUDENT PER SLOT AS YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER PER SEAT.
SO DO THEY NEED A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION.
BECAUSE IS A HUNDRED ONE TIME.
THERE'S TWENTY ON GOING AND
TWENTY ON GOING AGAIN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY SO HUNDRED
MILLION AND THEY'VE SPENT NOT
ONE MILLION. SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO I THINK THE REALITY IS THAT
YOU KNOW THIS PROGRAM CAN EXIST.
BUT DO THEY NEED THIS SLUSH FUND
RIGHT NOW WHEN WE CAN REEVALUATE
IT EVERY YEAR.
IT DOESN'T SEEM THAT THERE ARE --
GOING TO UTILIZE THIS ANYTIME --
TODAY TOMORROW OR IN THE NEAR
FUTURE AND OUR PRIORITIES FOR
OUR STUDENTS TODAY I KNOW --
MISTREATING TALKED ABOUT SOME
ISSUES ARE DISTRICTS SISTERS A
PURSE BUT OUR PLAN TALKED ABOUT --
INC IN INCREASING FUNDING FOR
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS ON
GOING IN ONE TIME.
PART TIME FACULTY HOURS FOR TOO
MANY CALLS TO HELP STUDENTS.
UP FULL TIME FACULTY.
HUNGER FREE CAMPUSES TO MAKE
SURE WE DEALING WITH OUR
STUDENTS.
BASIC NEEDS ISSUES -- AND I
THINK YOU KNOW THOSE ARE REAL
PRIORITIES FOR FOR OUR TWO
MILLION COMMUNITY COLLEGES TODAY.
AND SO THIS IS JUST ABOUT
PRIORITIES AND SELL I DON'T
BELIEVE THIS NOTION THAT BY
DOING THIS IT'S SAD DEATH
PENALTY FOR THE PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE GONNA GET
APPORTIONMENT AS IT'S BEING
ROLLED OUT THIS IS A BUSINESS
MAYBE THEY NEED A LITTLE START
UP MONEY.
BUT I THINK WE TOOK A GAS LAST
YEAR ON THE START UP AND WE OVER
APPROPRIATED WILDLY AND I THINK
THIS IS.
A KIND OF A MID COURSE
CORRECTION SO.
THANKS THANK YOU MISTER KING.
THINK ABOUT TURN THAT'S ONE OF
THE CLEAR.
FIVE MY COLLEAGUE FROM PALM
SPRINGS IS COMMENTS CLIPPING.
WE ARE ALL VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
ONLINE EDUCATION FOR
COMMUNICABLE CHOSE.
SO WHAT HAPPENED A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO -- WE WORK WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN WORKED WITH
PREVIOUS CHANCELLOR AND WE ASKED.
ALL THE DIFFERENT CAN UNICOM
JUST UP AND DOWN THE STATE TO
START DOING ONLINE PROGRAM.
WHICH HAS BEEN VERY EXCITING TO
WATCH BECAUSE HE WAS A MORE
EFFICIENT WAY -- THE ONE THING
THAT WE LOVE I KNOW UNIVERSALLY
AS LEGISLATORS WE ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES EVERY SINGLE
EVERY SINGLE ONE FROM THE DO
AMAZING THINGS EVERY DAY WITH.
ALL TESTING POPULATIONS PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO SCHOOL OR CHANGING
CAREERS AND SO WE WE WERE ALL
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ONLINE ON
ONLINE PROGRAMMING AT THE
COMMUNICABLE JUST TO GET
STUDENTS THROUGH FASTER.
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL THIS IS VERY
DIFFERENT?
IT WAS A PROPOSAL TO CREATE A
ENTIRELY NEW OPERATION.
ARE AN ENTIRELY NEW ONLINE
CAMPUS.
OUR FEA WAS THAT IT WOULD
COMPETE WITH EACH OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THEIR ON
LINE PROGRAMS AND THEY STILL
HAVEN'T.
COMPLETELY DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
WON'T DO THAT THEY SAY THEY WANT
TO THAT BUT THAT HASN'T BEEN
TOTALLY PROVEN -- WE ARE THE
CONCERN IS A SENSE OF MIXED
MESSAGE BECAUSE WE TOLD.
OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM GO DO ONLINE.
GOOGLE DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
COLLEGE DID AND AND START
GETTING RESULTS IN AND THEY'RE
DOING THAT SO SO.
IT SENDS A REAL MIXED MESSAGES
TO SAY HEY YOU BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
SO INSTEAD OF GIVING YOU MORE
MONEY WE'RE GOING TO PUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER HERE FIFTH AND LET
IT SIT THERE AND GOOD LUCK WITH.
YOUR STUFF BUT THIS IS JUST
GOING TO KIND OF SIT THERE SO I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WERE.
WE'RE WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH SO
WE ARE COMPLETELY -- PROUD I
THINK OF ALL THE DIFFERENT WORK
THAT ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE DOING UP
AND DOWN STATE ESPECIALLY IN THE
ONLINE THERE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE.
THIS PROPOSAL IS A COMPLETELY
NEW.
PROGRAM -- AS I THINK ALL THE
COLLEAGUES HAVE SORT OF TALKED
ABOUT THAT WE HAD SOME CONCERNS
WITH LAST YEAR.
AND WE CONTINUE CONCERNED HOW TO
CASF CONCERNS WITH THIS YEAR AND
I THINK WE WE WANT TO GIVE THE
NEW CHANCE A CHANCE -- FOR CLEAN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SUCCESSFUL.
HAVING SAID THAT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT HE HAS EVEN UNDER OUR
ASSEMBLY PREPARATION WHICH AGAIN
IS FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
MORE.
THAN ENOUGH MONEY OVER EVEN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS TO REALLY DO
SOMETHING.
VERY INTERESTING AND AGAIN GIVES
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO BE
BUSINESS FROM THE OTHER
COMMITTEE COLLEGE PARTIES.
AND AGAIN ALSO CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. TO KEEP MOVING ONLINE
SO THAT THAT REALLY WAS THE IDEA
BEHIND THE THICK [inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER [inaudible]
YES CLUB.
AS I LISTEN TO THE CONVERSATION
AT YOU KNOW I I'VE FIRST BEING
VERY HONEST I'VE NEVER BEEN
FAVOR THIS PROPOSAL.
ONLINE COLLEGE I I THINK IT'S A
WASTE OF RESOURCES AND I DON'T
AND BEING AN EDUCATOR I DON'T
THINK IS THE BEST WAY FOR US TO
REALLY BE ENGAGED IN.
ONLINE EDUCATION -- BECAUSE WE
HAVE ALREADY THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE IT REQUIRES A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO DO ONLINE
INSTRUCTION AND TO DO IT WELL
OKAY.
SO -- AND GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY
AS WELL AS THE THE BROAD.
SWEEP OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA ALL OVER THE
STATE AND AND AND AND I'VE I'VE
BEEN A PART OF AND SEEN A LOT OF
THE ONLINE INSTRUCTION.
I MEAN IT'S AN AMAZING THING AND
AND THE FACT THAT THEY CAN WE
CAN DO WHAT WE CAN DELIVER
ALMOST ANY CURRICULUM THAT WE
WANT.
ACROSS THE STATE TO SET UP A
WHOLE COLLEGE IT DOES NOTHING
BUT ONLINE INSTRUCTION.
I THINK LIMITS WHAT WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IN TERMS OF ONLINE
INSTRUCTION BECAUSE YOU ALREADY
HAVE AN AMAZING INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT HAVING BEEN SAID -- YOU
KNOW AYE AYES I STILL GET THE
SENSE THAT THAT THE THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY ARE.
ARE ARE BASICALLY HIT HESITANT
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL OF OF ONLINE
INSTRUCTION WHICH I THINK IS IS
THE WORST THING THAT CAN HAPPEN
WHEN YOU TRYING TO DEVELOP A NEW
ENTITY.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING TO
DEVELOP A COLLEGE WHEN WE DECIDE
WE'RE GONNA DO YOU SEE YOU SEE
MERCED A WHERE WE'RE GOING TO DO
IT WE SET ASIDE WHICH IS TRUE.
A CHUNK OF MONEY TO HANDLE IT SO
WE'RE GOING TO REALLY DO A
COLLEGE YOU HAVE TO SET ASIDE A
CHUNK OF MONEY BECAUSE THOSE WHO
ARE PLANNING CAN'T WAIT EVERY
YEAR FOR AN ALLOCATION BECAUSE
THAT HINDERS.
THE THE NEW PROJECTS ARE YOU IF
YOU GO TO A NEW COLLEGE OR NEW
WHAT WE'VE DONE NEW COLLEGES IN
AT THE UNIVERSITY -- WE HAVE TO
SET ASIDE MONEY IT'S SOMETIMES
PAINFUL TO DO BUT YOU HAVE TO DO
IT BECAUSE INVESTMENT HAS TO BE
TO IT TO TRY TO RECRUIT.
FACULTY AND AND AND BY HARDWARE
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT YOU
HAVE TO DO YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO HAVE MONEY THIS SET ASIDE SO.
IT'S REALLY CLEAR THAT YOU HAVE
TO DO THAT.
IT'S ALSO AS I LISTEN TO US TALK
SOMEWHAT DANGEROUS BECAUSE AT
SOME POINT IT SAYS TO PEOPLE WE
GIVE YOU MONEY BETTER SPENT
RIGHT AWAY EVEN IF YOU HAVE A
GOOD REASON SPENT.
BECAUSE IF NOT WE WILL COME BACK
AND GET T AND THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS A PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHEN
THEY DON'T ALLOW YOU ROLL MONEY
OVER THEY JUMP UP IN THE LAST
THREE WEEKS IT START BY AND ALL
KIND OF SUFF THE TITLE ONE AND
STUFF THEY MAY NEVER USED IS.
STORED SOMEWHERE AND MAYBE IT'S
YOU KNOW GET EATEN BY RATS OR
WHATEVER BUT THE BUT THEY USE
THE MONEY BECAUSE THAT THEY
DON'T THERE'S A DISTRICT WE COME
BACK AND SAY ALL WE CAN TAKE
THAT BACK FROM YOU BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T USE IT.
SO EVERYBODY GOT SMART STAR USES
STEPH SO WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
WE START TELLING PEOPLE YOU ONLY
SPEND A LITTLE BIT SO WE DON'T
TAKE IT FROM YOU.
SO THEREFORE THE NEXT GROUP THAT
COMES ALONG THE WORD IS CLEAR
SPEND YOUR STUFF EVEN IF YOU
DON'T NEED.
TO SO.
I'M IN A WEIRD POSITION WITH
REGARD TO THIS BECAUSE I'M NOT
AN ADVOCATE OF THIS AT ALL --
AND I WOULD PROBABLY TAKE ALL
THE MONEY AND SAY WELL THIS KIND
OF AS A SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLAR
LOSS AND MOVE ON AW AND IF
THAT'S WHAT WE WILL DO WE NEED
TO DO IT.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO THAT
BEFORE THEY GET TO THE FORTY
THREE MILLION THAT YOU TALKING
ABOUT -- THEN WE NEED TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT TO IT BUT I'M NOT
HEART WISE I'M EITHER BEING YOUR
BILL I'M WITH YOU YOU KNOW ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER BECAUSE I'M NOT
INTO THIS BECAUSE I THINK.
THE AND I TOLD I TOLD THE LAST
GOVERNOR THAT THAT WHAT HE
WANTED TO ACCOMPLISH COULD
EASILY BE ACCOMPLISHED IN THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER IT'S SYSTEM.
WOULD MORE RESOURCE IS GOING TO
A COMMUNICABLE IS THIS ALREADY
HAS AN AFFRONT NOMINAL ONLINE
EXPERIENCE AND TARGETING THOSE
THINGS AND THEN WITH THOSE YOU
CAN YOU KNOW THEY CAN HOOK UP
ANYWHERE YOU WANT.
AS WELL AS MANY BY SEE ISSUES
DOMINGUEZ HILLS AS THE GREATEST
KIND OF THING WE ARE DO A WHOLE
A WHOLE LIBRARY DEGREE IN A IS
ONLINE RIGHT NOW FOR THE WHOLE
STATE -- A GUN TO EPPING SAN
JOSE AND UP AND THEY GET
TOGETHER MAYBE EVERY THREE OR
FOUR MONTHS OR WHATEVER FOR ONE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE WHOLE --
DEGREE AND AND LIBRARY SCIENCES
ONLINE BECAUSE THERE IS NO NEED.
FOR ONE PROGRAM IN ONE SECTION
SO ALL I'M SAYING IS THAT IF WE
DON'T DO IT WE NEED TO DO IT
GIVEN THE HUNDRED TWENTY BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEY CALL ME IF THEY
REALLY WANT TO PLAN ABOUT.
OUR CHANCES SHOULD COME HERE AND
TELL US WHAT THEY CAN DO WITH
THE MONEY THOUGH COULD YOU JUST
DON'T GIVE A PERSON  HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS MILLION
DOLLARS AND SAY GOAL GO FORTH
AND BE GOOD -- THEY NEED TO TELL
WHAT THEY WILL DO BUT OTHERWISE
IF WE WE START TAKING A PROBLEM
TELL YOU THE WORD TO GET AROUND
REAL QUICK IN THE STATE.
THAT IF THE IF THEY GIVE YOU
SOME MONEY.
YOU BETTER USE IT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE I'LL COME BACK AND
TAKE IT FROM ME.
EXACTLY.
SO.
IF I JUST MIGHT ADD I DON'T WANT
TO REPEAT WHAT'S BEEN
ARTICULATED BY ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES -- BUT BUT BUT I
CLEARLY RECALL OUR EXPERIENCE
LAST YEAR AND ONE CHALLENGE WAS --
THE CONCEPT WAS IT -- COMPLETELY
THAT IT IN THE JANUARY PROPOSAL --
WE WERE TOLD ONE THING WE WERE
TOLD THAT THE WITH GOING TO
OFFER CERTIFICATES AND A. A.'S
THAT DIDN'T CHANGE WIN THE
CHANCE OF THEN CAME BACK BEFORE
US.%
AND SO IT WAS CLEAR TO US THAT
IT WAS A MOVING TARGET.
I CONTRADICT THAT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THIS YEAR
WERE HE'S GOT PLANNING DOLLARS
TO LOOK AT THE FEASIBILITY OF A
NEW C. ISSUE.
IN STOCKTON.
SO WHAT PROBABLY WOULD HAVE SET
MUCH BETTER WITH ALL OF US LAST
YEAR.
IS IF YOU'D COME FOR IT WITH THE
CONCEPT AND ASK FOR PLANNING
DOLLARS RESOURCES -- THEN WE
COULD.
COME BACK THIS YEAR LOOK AT A
PLAN AND BE BETTER POLLS -- TO
SUPPORT YOU IN YOUR QUEST TO
FULLY FUND WHATEVER THE TIME IT
WAS.
JUST SEEMS -- IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
FOLLOW EIGHT EIGHT CONSISTENT
OUT LINE OF THOUGHT THAT FOR ONE
INSTITUTION REQUIRES PLANNING
AND INVESTMENT.
AN APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT FOR PLANNING TO
DETERMINE THE FEASIBILITY OF ITS
VALUE.
VERSUS AN IDEA THAT THAT THAT
CHANGED MIDSTREAM IN TERMS OF
WHAT.
THE ULTIMATE.
GOAL WOULD BE FIRST WE WERE TOLD.
A A THE CERTIFICATE THAT WE WERE
TOLD NO -- AS I RECALL S. CI YOU
CAME IN SUPPORT ME AND WE WERE
CLEAR THAT WAS TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
KIND OF ELEVATED THEIR CURRENT
POSITION SO SEAD YOU TALKED
ABOUT OF WE HAVE YOU KNOW --
CLERK TYPIST.
TO AND THEN YOU WANT TO BE A
CLERK TYPIST WNDER IF YOU COULD
TAKE THIS TRAINING ONLINE AND
MOVE UP.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S ALSO WHAT
WE ARE EXPERIENCING REMEMBER
LAST YEAR IT APPEARED TO BE A
MOVING TARGET AND NOW WE'RE
HEARING.
THAT YOU SPENT ONE TENTH OF THE
DOLLARS ALLOCATED.
IN A CLIMATE IN WHICH WE HAVE
MORE IN THE THE WE HAVE
RESOURCES I THINK THAT.
THE ONE PIECE THAT WOULD ADD TO
WHAT EVERYONE ELSE IS SHARED ON
AND I THINK IT'S REFLECTED -- IN
BOTH THE ACTION TAKEN BY THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE QUESTIONS MY
SENATE SUB ONE SURE ASK IN TERMS
OF WILL YOU INDEED BE CRIPPLED
BY HAVING THE BUDGET CUT AT
LEAST FOR THE NEXT YEAR.
IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS.
MR OBERNOLTE.
ALL WAY AND QUICKLY MADAM
CHAIRMAN.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT NOT TO
THROW THE BABY OUT WITH THE BATH
WATER HERE.
IF YOU FAST FORWARD A HUNDRED
YEARS FROM NOW.
I THINK NO ONE WOULD DISPUTE THE
FACT THAT MOST EDUCATION WILL BE
ONLINE.
IN A WITH PERIODIC VISITS TO AN
IN PERSON FACILITY.
AND HOW WE GET FROM HERE TO
THERE IS THE QUESTION NOW
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S BEST
ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH THE
TRADITIONAL.
COMMUNITY OLLEGE SYSTEM OR IF
IF IT REQUIRES A NEW ONLINE
INSTITUTION I'VE GOT TO RECENT
EXPERIENCE ON THIS LAST YEAR I
WENT BACK TO GRADUATE SCHOOL
OBVIOUSLY I DID IT.
THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING
PROGRAM BECAUSE I GOT TO BE IN
SACRAMENTO EVERY DAY.
BUT I DO REALLY GAVE ME AN
APPRECIATION.
FOR HOW COMPLICATED IT IS TO DO
ONLINE EDUCATION WHILE IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN JUST
THROW TOGETHER ON A WEBSITE AND
EXPECT PEOPLE TO LEARN IN A WAY
THAT SUPERIOR TO DOING IT IN
PERSON SO -- I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON THE LONG TERM HERE
FOCUSING ON THE FACT THAT IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE A AN EASY LEFT.
TO GET THIS PROGRAM UP AND
RUNNING AND AND I'V I'M OF THE
OPINION THAT WE OUGHT TO GIVE
THEM THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED. TO TO DO THE JOB THAT
WE'VE GIVEN THEM EVEN IF IT'S
TAKING A LITTLE LONGER TO ROLL
OUT THAN WE EXPECTED.
TO TO AND THE SENATOR OFF.
YOU KNOW I GUESS I HELP START
THIS DISCUSSION SO.
I PROBABLY SHOULD TRY TO FINISH
THE TERM.
I HAD SOME RESERVATIONS -- MINE
THIS PROPOSAL WAS FIRST BROUGHT
TO WAS SO I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT --
CREATING A NEW ENTITY HIRING A
NEW PRESIDENT AND A WHOLE BUNCH
OF IT EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENTS
AND CREATING A BRIDGE
BUREAUCRACY WITHOUT -- REALLY.
HITTING THE MARK ON OF THE FIRST
MARK ON THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
THAT ARE SET OUT BUT I WAS
CONVINCED THAT -- REALLY IN
ORDER TO GET SOME DECENT METRICS.
INSTEAD OF SPREADING A LITTLE
BROTHER LIMITED.
EARLY SPEAKING LIMITED AMOUNT OF
MONEY OVER.
BUT ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN OR
SO COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT WE WE
REALLY OUT OF FOCUS THIS EFFORT
AND ONE SO WE COULD SET SOME
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND OBTAIN
SOME MEASUREMENTS -- I THINK THE
DIFFICULTY THAT I HAVE AND OF
COURSE WE DIDN'T TAKE UP WE
DIDN'T HAVE A PROPOSAL IN THIS
SO WE DON'T HAVE A HEARING ON IT
I THINK ONE OF THE DIFFICULTIES
THAT I HAVE.
IS UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPACT
OF TAKING FIFTY MILLION AWAY
FROM ONE HUNDRED MILLION WE'VE
HEARD THAT THE A OF THE BOARD
APPARENTLY IS APPROVED A FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
WHICH I ASSUME IS FOR THIS NEXT
BUDGET YEAR -- AND I I GUESS I
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE GET THE INFORMATION.
IN LEARNING WHAT THAT WHAT THE
NEXT BUDGET YEAR.
IS LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT DO THEY
IN FACT NEED THAT IN ORDER TO
GET GOING WHERE THEY NEED TO BE
GOING BECAUSE HAVING I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HAVING
APPROVED THIS THING.
WHETHER WITHOUT RESERVATIONS WE
OUGHT TO GIVE IT AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO WHY THIS SUCCEED OR FAIL GIVE
IT ENOUGH TIME SO WE CAN SEE
WHAT THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
ARE.
AND SEE WHAT THE MEASUREMENTS
ARE AND WHETHER IN FACT HITS THE
MARK OR DOESN'T HIT THE MARK AND
IF IT DOESN'T WE NEED TO GO BACK
TO SQUARE ONE AND FIGURE OUT
ANOTHER WAY. TO TO CREATE AN
ONLINE EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
THAT'S THE WAVE OF THE FUTURE
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NEVER GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET AHEAD OF THE BOW
WAVE.
IN TERMS OF EDUCATING.
AND MEETING DEMAND FOR STUDENTS
AND SEES.
IN IN BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITIES SO.
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT POINT --
MANAGER I DON'T KNOW HOW WE GET
THE INFORMATION BUT WILL HAVE TO
FIGURE IT OUT BEFORE WE HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH OUR COLLECTION
THE ASSEMBLY.
AND THAT WE WILL WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TWENTY TWO
VETERAN RESOURCE CENTERS.
HELLO.
THE FOR THE THERE IS NO
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON THIS
ISSUE -- BOTH THE SENATE ANDASSEMBLY ADDED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BUT TOOK DIFFERENT
APPROACHES.
AS FOR THE SENATE -- PROVIDED
FIFTEEN MILLION IN ONE TIME --
TO EXPAND OR CREATE NEW VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTERS.
OF THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDED TEN
MILLION ONGOING PROBLEM THE
GENERAL FUND -- FOR VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTERS SYSTEM WIDE.
AND PROVIDED SEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION ONE TIME FOR FOR
SPECIFIC.
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS IN
SPECIFIC COLLEGES.
I WOULD JUST POINT OUT A COUPLE
BIG THINGS FOR YOU TO AS YOU'RE
CONSIDERING THIS ISSUE ONE IS
THE CURRENT ONGOING -- FUNDING
FOR THE VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER
IS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS SO
TAKING THE ASSEMBLY ACTION WOULD --
SINCE THE TRIPLE THE AMOUNT OF
ONGOING FUNDING THAT THE PROGRAM
IS RECEIVING.
AND SECOND -- WOULD POINT OUT
THAT THE STATE HAS PROVIDED
THIRTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
EXPAND OR CREATE NEW VETERANS OR
CENTERS OVER THE LAST. TWO YEARS --
NINE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BASED ON THE
INFORMATION WE RECEIVE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FIFTY NINE
OUT OF THE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
COLLEGES RECEIVED AWARDS.
AND WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS --
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION THAT
REMAINS UNSPENT SO IT HAS YOUR
DELIVERY AND THINKING ABOUT WHAT
AN AMOUNT YOU WANT TO PROVIDE IT
TO STICK TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
THERE IS SOME FUNDING THAT
CURRENTLY HAS.
HAS BEEN AND SPEND YOU CAN ALSO --
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION IN TERMS
OF DECIDING HOW MANY STE SENATE
CENTERS YOU LIKE TO OPERATE.
YOU LIKE TO FUND.
FINANCE WE'LL SAY VERY BRIEFLY --
WE BELIEVE THAT TO ME COLLEGES
CIRCUS CAN ALREADY USE THEIR ON
GOING ALLOCATION FROM THIS IN
EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM
SO WITHIN PROPOSITION -- NINETY
EIGHT WITH WHERE THEY CAN RELY
ON THAT FUNDING RATHER THAN
PUTTING A NEW FUNDING WITHIN THE
GUARANTEED.
ACTIONS MR MCCARTY YEAH I JUST
REAL BRIEFLY TALKED ABOUT THAT
EARLIER FOR AWHILE BUT BUDGETS
ARE ABOUT CHOICES AND LITERALLY
THE TEN MILLION THAT WE THAT WE
CUT FROM THE ONLINE.
IS RIGHT HERE FOR THE VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTERS THANK YOU THE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR ROBB.
I GUESS THIS IS FOR FINANCE ONE
OF THE COMMENTS THAT I RECEIVED
FROM THE FIELD AS WE USED TO SAY
IN THE MILITARY.
IS THAT AS THIS MONEY THAT
SPRINT PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED FOR
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS.
MOVES THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHAU CHANCES OFFICE DOWN
TO THE INDIVIDUAL COLLEGES -- IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE EARMARKED AND
IF IT IS THE YEAR MARKETS
IGNORED AND IN SOME CASES AT
LEAST.
THE MONEY DISAPPEARS INTO THE
GENERAL FUND OF THE PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INVOLVED.
CAN ONLY IF THE VETERANS
RESOURCE -- EMPLOYEE KNOWS THAT
THE MONEY IS HEADING THERE-- AT
LEAST IN ONE PARTICULAR CASE I
WAS THE MONEY.
OF FENCED IN HOLD BACK INTO THE
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER --
THAT'S ANECDOTAL INFORMATION I
DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU DID A SURVEY WITH THE
SURVEY RESULTS WOULD BE BUT MY
POINT IS I THINK WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY.
TO IF WE APPROPRIATE MONEY HERE
IN THE GOVERNOR AGREES BY
SIGNING THE BUDGET. FOR VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTERS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY
AT THE AND THAT THE MONEY
ACTUALLY FINDS ITS WAY INTO.
A VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS AT
THE INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES INVOLVED NO CRITICISM
OF THE CHANCES OFFICE OF
SOMETIMES THINGS JUST HAPPEN BUT
I I DO THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR PROCESS -- HERE IF
IN FACT THE INFORMATION THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED TO ME YEAH HAS ANY
DEGREE OF ACCURACY.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK
[inaudible]
THE QUESTIONS.
OKAY SEEN THAT LOOK ROOM ON TO
ISSUE TWENTY THREE STUDENT
HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS ELIO.
THIS IS THE MAIN REVISION
INCLUDED PROPOSALS THAT ADDRESS
STUDENT FOOD AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY AT UC AND CSU BUT BUT
TAP NOTHING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- BOTH HOUSES ADOPTED
THE YOU SEE IF YOU MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS BUT THEN ADDED ON
THEIR OWN INITIATIVE TO ADDRESS
FOOD AND HOUSING AND SECURITY.
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON THE
THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS ARE TO NOT
THAT DIFFERENT THEY'RE JUST
SOMEWHERE DIFFERENT APPROACHES.
SO -- RELATED -- TO FOOD
SECURITY THE SENATE PROVIDED
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME OF
WHICH FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IS
TO CONDUCT AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
COST EFFECTIVENESS OF COLLEGE
BASED FOOD PROGRAMS.
THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME THE
DIFFERENCES HERE NOT TOO
DIFFERENT.
HOUSING AND SECURITY -- THE
SENATE PROVIDED NINE MILLION
AND HOUSING AND SECURE STUDENTS
AND THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDED TEN
MILLION ONE TIME FOR A RAPID RE
HOUSING PILOT PROGRAM.
IT'S ON THE HOUSING ISSUE
THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT IS
ONE THERE'S THE DIFFERENCE OF
ONE TIME VERSES ON GOING.
ON THE OTHER ISSUE THAT OPEN A
IS THAT THE THE THE LANGUAGE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROPOSAL'S
IS DIFFERENT A LITTLE BIT IN
THAT THE SENATE LANGUAGE IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE -- BROUGHT IN
PROVIDES MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
COLLEGES AND AND CAMPUS IS
BECAUSE THE LANGUAGE IS THE SAME
FOR YOU SEE IF YOU -- IN TERMS
OF HOW THOSE FUNDS WILL BE SPENT
WHERE THE ASSEMBLY APPROACH IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE PRECISE.
PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF EXACTLY --
WHAT'S EXPECTED WITH UP WITH
THOSE FUNDS.
UNDER THE L. L. HAVE A
PREFERENCE I WE DON'T WE DON'T
HAVE A SPECIFIC DATE IS JUST
MORE OF IT I GOT YOU ON OUT OF
TARGETED PROGRAMMERS FLEXIBILITY.
GOT IT.
UP FINANCE AS EARLIER NOTED --
IN THE NAY REVISION THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSE A PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FOR UC AND CSU FOR RAPID
RE HOUSING SO WHILE IT'S NOT
GOURMET REVISION WE ARE OPEN TO
LOOKING FOR MONEY WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE TO FIND.
THAT LEVEL OF RESOURCES FOR SOME
RESOURCES FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS WELL AND
FOR THE OTHER ITEMS THAT HOW I
MENTIONED **** WITH -- WE WERE
MATCHING IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
BALANCE WITHIN THE GUARANTEE
WHAT WE CAN.
FOR THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR FACULTY.
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR FACULTY.
SO THIS IS ANOTHER ISSUE WITH
THE GOVERNOR HAD NO SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL BUT THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE BOTH MADE AUGMENTATIONS
SO THEY'RE TWO DIFFERENT FACULTY
PROGRAMS HERE THAT THAT ARE --
BEFORE YOU FIRST IS THE FULL
TIME FACULTY PROGRAM AND THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT WAS JUST CREATED
LAST YEAR.
THE FUNDING PROVIDED TO THE
PROGRAM RECEIVE FIFTY MILLION
ONGOING LAST YEAR -- MUST BE
USED TO INCREASE THE PERCENTAGE
OF INSTRUCTION -- ALCHEMY
BECAUSE THAT IS THAT IF TALK BY
FULL TIME.
FULL TIME FACULTY BUT THE SENATE
PROVIDED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR THE PROGRAM.
THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDED FOR ME
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS -- SO
AGAIN JUST WITH A DIFFERENCE IN
AND AND NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING THERE.
THE ASSEMBLY DID ALSO --
HABITABLE LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES
COLLEGES TO USE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY BEST PRACTICES WHEN
HIRING A NEW FULL TIME FACULTY.
SO THAT IS ANOTHER DIFFERENCE --
THE OTHER -- THE OTHER PROGRAM
IS PART TIME FACULTY OFFICE
HOURS WHICH IS A CAT ONE
STANDING CATEGORICAL ON IT THE
COMMUTE COLLEGES HAVE.
E. S. SENATE PROVIDED AT THREE
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR COLA TO THE PROGRAM WHAT
THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES US SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING.
I'M JUST ONE THING TO KEEP IN
MIND FOR THAT PROGRAM BUT THE
PROGRAM THAT LAST YEAR RECEIVE
TWELVE MILLION ONGOING AND THERE
WAS A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME APPROPRIATION.
I MEAN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION YET
AND THROUGH THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR IS NOT HERE YET ON
IT BUT WE WE WOULD EXPECT THAT
SOME OF THAT FUNDING WOULD
REMAIN AVAILABLE.
SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO KEEP THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION AS YOU'RE
DECIDING HOW MUCH FUNDING. TO TO
ALLOCATE TO THE PERSON FACULTY
PROGRAM.
FINANCE SAID THESE ITEMS ARE NOT
GENERALLY IN OUR PROPOSITION
NINETY PACKAGE I WILL POINT OUT
THOUGH THAT SELL OIL MENTIONED
THERE WAS A FIFTY MILLION
ONGOING APPROPRIATION FROM LAST
YEAR AND THAT IS MAINTAINED IN
OUR BUDGET.
AND CHRIS ONE TO MAKE ONE OTHER
POINT YEAH AND I ALSO KNOW
BECAUSE OF THE 50% RULE -- ALL
OF THE INCREASES ON THE
APPORTIONMENT SIDE YOU HAVE A
50% OF THOSE RESOURCES GENERALLY
GOING TOWARDS -- INSTRUCTIONAL
COSTS AND FACULTY SALARIES AS
WELL.
FACULTY PURPOSES NOT SALARIES.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FIFTY TWENTY FIVE OF A
VARIETY OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADJUSTMENTS.
MISTER WILLIAM ALL WALK THROUGH
SOME OF THE THE THE KEY AREAS
THROUGH THEIR NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT -- HERE WHERE THERE IS
LIKE A PROPOSAL FOR THE GOVERNOR
BUT THEN THERE ARE MANY OTHER
DECISIONS IN THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY SO.
THE GOVERNOR PROVIDED -- TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO
SUPPORT -- IMMIGRANT.
IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES -- THIS
FOR FOR STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES
AT THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES THIS
IS A FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDE
THOSE EIGHTEEN NINETY IN
NINETEEN NINETY WE PROVIDED. TEN
MILLION ONE TIMES THIS WOULD
TAKE THAT ONE TIME FUNDING AND
MAKE ONGOING.
THE SENATE -- THE SENATE ACTION
WAS.
TO REJECT THE PROPOSAL WITHOUT
PREJUDICE AND THE ASSEMBLY --
ADOPTED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
THE NEXT AREA IS THE WHAT'S
CALLED THE FUND FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS WHICH IS ACTUALLY
CONSISTS OF FOUR DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS -- THE THE GOVERNOR HAD
NO PROPOSAL THE SENATE PROVIDED
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO
ALL FOR PROGRAMS THAT WAS FOR A
COST OF TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE ASSEMBLY -- PROVIDED
AUGMENTATIONS TO TWO OUT OF THE
FOUR PROGRAMS THE POINT THE
PROGRAM AND DO MUCH OF PROGRAM.
THE THE SENATE ALSO PROVIDES --
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
INCREASE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TRANSFER PROGRAM TO
INCREASE OUTREACH ACTIVITIES.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT ONLY
IN WITHIN A PROPOSAL NOT IN THE
OTHERS.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER --
ACTIONS THAT ARE RELATED TO THE
ASSEMBLY PLAN THE ASSEMBLY --
PROVIDED FOR POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR DREAM
RESOURCE CENTERS AND TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR A CHILD
DEVELOPMENT CENTER POVERTY
COLLEGE.
IN ADDITION THE ASSEMBLY ALSO --
ADDED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
EXIT EXAM -- THE FOR MAKING
CENTER AT THE SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT FROM
THE FIELD ACT WHICH IS THE FROM
SCHOOL BUILDING REQUIREMENTS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
BUT THIS IS A A FEDERALLY OWNED
FACILITY -- IN ON UNDER CURRENT
LAW -- THAT WOULD HAVE.
TO RIGHT HERE TO FILL BACK FROM
THE THE PROPOSES TO EXEMPT THAT --
THE WHAT WE DO HAVE OUR ON ONE
PROPOSAL AND LEGAL SERVICES HERE
WE RECOMMEND THE SENATE.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THE LEGAL
SERVICES ON RECEIVE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME LAST YEAR FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THAT THE PROGRAM BEING
ADMINISTERED BY DSS AS PART OF
ITS LARGER IMMIGRATION SERVICES
FUNDING PROGRAM.
WHERE THEY CONTRACT WITH
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS IN OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE SST INDICATED THAT NONE
OF THE ONE TIME FUNDING HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED PART SORRY?
ANOTHER ONE COMPANY HAD BEEN
SPENT IN IN -- EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
SO WE THINK THAT THAT FUNDING
CAN BE REPURPOSED TO COVER THE
NINETEEN TWENTY COSTS IF THERE
IS AN INTERESTING FUNDING THE
PROGRAM ONE TIME AND THAT COULD
BE PROVIDED IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FINANCE.
I'LL MAKE ONE COMMENT ON THAT
LAST POINT REGARDING THE TEN
MILLION FUNDING SO WE BELIEVE --
BUT CONVERSATIONS WITH DSS THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THAT
SPENDING.
OF THAT MONEY WILL BE SPENT IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND SO WE
BELIEVE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THE BUDGET FOR
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES WE'VE
ALREADY REACHED OUT TO US SENATE
STAFF ON THIS AND HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS.
ANY CONCERNS IN THE UPCOMING
WEEK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CETERA WHAT GIVEN THE FACT THAT
TEN MILLION HASN'T BEEN SPENT
THAT WAS APPROPRIATED LAST YEAR
DO YOU BELIEVE THE NEED TO BE
TWENTY MILLION ASSURES THAT WHAT
I UNDERSTAND.
SO I BELIEVE THAT WAS AT TEN
MILLION ONE TIME APPROPRIATION
AND THAT THIS IS AN ONGOING
APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT'S CORRECT SO IT WAS TEN
MILLION ONE TIME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET AND
WE'RE PROPOSING TEN MILLION
ONGOING I THINK.
FOR WHAT WE'RE SIGNALLING IS WE
WILL HAVE A CONTINUE DISCUSSION
WITH THE STAFF.
I MEAN IF THERE'S A DO WE KNOW
WHAT THE NEED IS.
I THINK IT I THANK YOU THAT'S
THE HARDSHIP THAT DSS HAS PUT
FORWARD I THE WE KNOW HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE IN THE SYSTEM WE
KNOW THE TYPE OF SERVICES THAT
THEY WILL LIKELY NEED -- BUT
IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY AT THIS
TIME TO KNOW HOW MANY WILL AVAIL
THEM THEMSELVES OF THIS SERVICE.
AND WHETHER THAT WILL RAMP UP
OVER TIME BUT CERTAINLY WE KNOW
THERE'S A NEED FOR APROPOS OF
OUR EARLIER CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHETHER TO BANK MONEY HERE TO
APPROPRIATED AS NEEDED.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THERE'S TEN
MILLION DOLLARS SITTING THERE WE
COULD USE A TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IT HAS NOT BEEN.
COMMITTED RIGHT HANDED TO THE
EXTENT WE ALL WANT TO TAKE CARE
OF IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES. TO
THE EXTENT THAT THEN THE NEED
EXCEEDS TO TEN MILLION DOLLARS
DURING THE BUDGET YOU'RE THE I
ASSUME THAT CAN BE A BUDGET
ADJUSTMENT CORRECT.
SO IT IS WITHIN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SO THERE IS A
TRADEOFF.
YES SIR I THINK WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS.
YEAH YEAH IT'S SUBJECT TO
DISCUSSION OF WHAT'S INCLUDED
WITHIN THE GUARANTEE BUT YES YOU
ARE CORRECT OKAY.
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTOOD THANK MANAGER THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THIS IS WHY THE TOPIC OF LAW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADJUSTMENTS
I'D LIKE TO RAISE AN ISSUE THAT
I THINK NEEDS ATENTION AND THIS
IS REGARDING SOMETHING THAT.
APPLE THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE GREED ON THE START OF
THIS YEAR WHICH WAS THE
EXTENSION OF THE CALIFORNIA --
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM TO THE
SECOND FOR YOUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
I VERY MUCH SUPPORT.
HOWEVER NONE OF THE COLLEGE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN MY
DISTRICT WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT THE WAY THAT
THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY WORDED.
THE END OF THAT IS BECAUSE THAT
FUNDING HIM FOR THE FIRST YEAR
AMENDED ITS AND FAIRNESS THIS IS
A A PROBLEM WITH -- THE PROGRAM
LAST YEAR.
THAT REQUIRES COMMUNITY COLLEGES%
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE FEDERAL
DIRECT STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM.
AS A CONDITION FOR GETTING THAT
FUNDING AND THE REASON WHY MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAMPER
DISSIPATE IN THAT FUNDING IN
THAT PROGRAM IS THAT.
IF YOU PARTICIPATE IN YOUR
DEFAULT RATE ON THOSE STUDENT
LOANS IS TOO HIGH THEN YOU LOSE
YOUR PELL GRANTS AND MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN'T AFFORD
TO LOSE THEIR PROGRAMS.
AND SO NONE OF THEM CAN
PARTICIPATE AS AND THERE ARE.
A BUNCH OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND IS EXACTLY THIS SAME
OPPOSITION MOST OF THEM IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
AND I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S
EQUITABLE SO I MEAN WE'RE WE'RE
TELLING PEOPLE FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR ALL I REALLY THINK.
THAT WHEN WE WRITE THAT THAT
INTO THE BUDGET I WOULD REQUEST
THAT WE WE GET RID OF THAT
STRING BEING ATTACHED TO IT
BECAUSE I WOULD BE REALLY NICE
IF MY CONSTITUENTS GOT FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
TO SO JUST WANTED RAISE THAT
POINT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
DIRECTOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL MOVE ON LOCAL.
WE ARE [inaudible]
ORAL HISTORIES.
AT TWO TWENTY SIX IT'S REQUIRED
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
LET'S SEE.
CURRY STARTING IN ISSUE TWENTY
SIX RECENT CONCENTRA SLUDGE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THE ISSUE BEFORE USING ASSEMBLY
ACTION TO PROVIDE ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR AN ORAL HISTORY OF
THE LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES.
THE FUNDING WOULD BE PROVIDED TO
THE ORAL HISTORIES PROGRAM --
WHICH IS A DONE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY IN THE STATE ARE
CONVINCED.
ON THE PROGRAM CURRENTLY IS
RECEIVING A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON
GOING.
THANK YOU -- SO WE DIDN'T
PROPOSE THIS AUGMENTATION THANK
YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEE NONE WILL MOVE ON MOVING ON
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
LA ALSO PROVIDE US WITH AN
OVERVIEW.
ON THEIR FINANCIAL AID ISSUES
THAT'S RIGHT MADAM CHAIR POSTING
HOUSING WITH THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
YOU HAVE A HAND DOWN YOUR BINDER
THAT SUMMARIZES SPENDING LEVELS
IN MAJOR COMMONALITIES AND
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE HOUSES
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
AS WELL AS THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION.
OUT COVERS THE REST OF THE
HIGHER ED AGENDA.
ITEMS.
PAGE ONE SHOWS THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF ON GOING AND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT THAT THE GOVERNOR
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY EACH PROVIDE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. TO GIVE YOU
THAT THE BIG PICTURE IF YOU WILL.
THE TOTALS LINE TOWARD THE
BOTTOM OF THE TABLE SHOWS THAT
BOTH HOUSES APPROVED HIGHER
LEVELS OF SPENDING THEN THE
GOVERNOR APPROXIMATELY TEN POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS. FOR EACH
HOUSE VERSES THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED AMOUNT OF TEN POINT.
TWO BILLION DOLLARS A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN TEN POINT.
TWO OVERALL THE ASSEMBLY SPENDS
FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS MORE
THAN THE SENATE -- SO THEY'RE
NOT THAT FAR APART REALLY IN
TERMS OF DOLLARS.
THE BOTTOM LINE BOTTOM TWO LINES
OF THE TABLE SHOWSOF THE SENATE
SPEND SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
MORE THAN THE ASSEMBLY ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
WHILE THE ASSEMBLY SPENDS MORE
THAN THE SENATE -- FOR ONE TIME
PURPOSES.
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE IS
ABOUT ADDRESSING DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE HOUSES OF COURSE BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
HOUSES DID TAKE A NUMBER OF
IDENTICAL ACTIONS.
ON CAL STATE UNIVERSITY IN YOU
SEE SUCH AS FINDING COMPENSATION
INCREASES IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
EACH HOUSE.
THIS IS ON PAGE TO EACH HOUSE
DOES PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AT THE
UNIVERSITY'S THOUGH THE HOUSES
DIFFER SOMEWHAT.
ON THE EXACT LEVELS ENROLLMENT
IS COVERED IN ISSUE THIRTY THREE
ON THE AGENDA.
ACTUAL I DISCUSS LATER HOUSES
DIFFER ON FUNDING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY'S RESPECTIVE STUDENT
SUCCESS INITIATIVES.
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO UC'S
INITIATIVE.
PAGE THREE SHOWS EXAMPLES OF
DIFFERENT SPENDING PRIORITIES BY
THE TWO HOUSES.
YOU CAN SEE SOME THERE -- THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE THREE NOTES THAT
IN A NUMBER OF CASES THE HOUSES
ARE SEEKING TO ACHIEVE THE SAME
GOALS REALLY BUT THEY DIFFER ON
EXACT AMOUNTS THAT THEY PROVIDE
OR ON PROGRAMMATIC DETAILS AND
SO YOU'LL BE DISCUSSING THAT TO
THOSE ISSUES -- LATER TODAY AND
PERHAPS TOMORROW MORNING.
PAGES FOUR AND FIVE ARE REALLY
JUST INTENDED AS A REFERENCE
GUIDE THE YOU CAN SEE ALL THE
AUGMENTATIONS UNDER THE THREE
PLANS.
IN ONE PLACE YOU HAVE CSU ON
PAGE FOUR AND YOU SEE ON PAGE.
FIVE WE WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT ALL THREE PLANS PROVIDE
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT.
NEW GENERAL FUND RESOURCES FOR
EACH.
OF THE SEGMENTS ONGOING GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT FOR YOU SEE US
USING FOR CSU INCREASES BY ABOUT
10%.
A EAR OVER YEAR AND I'M GOING
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR YOU SEE
INCREASES IN THE 78% RANGE YEAR
OVER YEAR.
SO PAGE SIX THEN SUMMARIZES THE
MAJOR COMMONALITIES AND
DIFFERENCES FOR THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND FINANCIAL AID.
BOTH THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
PLANS CONTAIN ADJUSTMENTS ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH. TO FIND GROWTH IN
CASELOAD PRIMARILY FOR THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION BOTH HOUSES MAKE
POLICY DECISIONS TO EXPAND CAL
GRANT SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS.
THE ABILITY HOUSES DO TAKE
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT APPROACHES
AND HOW TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
ALSO BOTH HOUSES SEEK TO ADDRESS
TEACHER SHORTAGES.
AND ENCOURAGE FAMILIES TO SAVE
FOR COLLEGE THOUGH.
THE HOUSE IS TO HAVE DIFFERENCES
ON HOW TO GO ABOUT ACHIEVING
THOSE GOALS.
AS YOU'LL HEAR IN ISSUE THIRTY
EIGHT THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTED THREE
CAL GRANT RELATED -- CHANGES FOR
A GROUP OF UNDOCUMENTED AND
CERTAIN OTHER STUDENTS COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS.
AB FINALLY ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
HAND OUT YOU HAVE HERE A A LIST
OF ALL THE FINANCIAL AID
AUGMENTATIONS.
UNDER THE THREE PLANS TO WERE
HAPPY.
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE OR JUST LAUNCH INTO ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN ON UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA I WOULD ASK MEMBERS
ONLY IF YOU HAVE KIND OF A TEN
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL QUESTION ON
THE OVERALL LA ALL PRESENTATION
IF THE SOMETHING SPECIFIC LET'S
WAIT TILL WE GET TO IT ON THE
CHIN.
ISSUE.
ITEM NUMBER SPECIFICALLY MISTER
MOORE Là YOU'VE GOTTA.
I WOULD JUST MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION ON PAGE.
ONE THAT.
YOU YOU PUT A COLUMN BEFORE
GOVERNOR THAT SAYS -- LAST YEAR.
THE SO WE CAN SEE THE DIFFERENCE.
THAT'S IT MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
FAIR ENOUGH.
PLEASE TAKE ON THIS PLAN IS THE
MAKE A NOTATION THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AVAILABLE
FOR WE GET TO THE SPECIFIC ISSUE
ITEMS.
SEEING NONE LET'S GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED WITH ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN YOU SEE RETIREMENT
PROGRAM.
SO THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU INVOLVES
OF FUNDING FOR UC'S UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITY.
HOUSES ADOPTED A GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
THE UNFUNDED PENSION LIABILITY.
EACH ALSO ALSO ADDED CONDITIONS
TO THAT FUNDING AND BOTH HOUSES
CONDITIONS RELATE TO DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLANS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OFFERS ITS EMPLOYEES.
FOR SOME CONTEXT THE UNIVERSITY
OFFERS TWO TYPES OF DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLANS FOR EMPLOYEES.
THE FIRST EFFECTIVELY
SUPPLEMENTS PENSION BENEFITS FOR
EMPLOYEES AND THE SECOND DOT
pALLOWS EMPLOYEES TO OPT OUT OF
THE PENSION BENEFITS AND ONLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN.
THE ISSUE FOR CONFERENCE HERE
THAT THE HOUSES DIFFER ON THE
SPECIFIC CONDITIONS THEY SAID ON
THE FUNDING.
IN THE SENATE OF THE CONDITIONS
ARE MOSTLY AROUND YOU SEE UP
STUDYING THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLANS MORE.
STUDYING THE FINANCIAL IMPACT OF
THE DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLANS
ON THE FINANCES OF A UC'S --
PENSION SYSTEM AND ALSO A
STUDYING THE IMPACT OF THE
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLANS ON
LOW WAGE WORKERS.
THE ASSEMBLY BY CONTRAST A
CONDITION THE FUNDING ON YOU SEE.
NO LONGER OFFERING DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLANS FOR EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE REPRESENTED BY UNIONS
OPEN CONTRACTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS.
ARE CURRENTLY FOR CUSTOM CONTEXT
THERE ARE -- TWO UNIONS
REPRESENTING FIVE BARGAINING
UNITS WITH OPEN CONTRACTS AND
THEY REPRESENT ABOUT 17% OF YOU
SEE EMPLOYEES SO THAT'S THE
ABOUT THE UNIVERSE OF OF
INDIVIDUALS TO BE AFFECTED BY --
THIS PROPOSAL THE REMAINING YOU
SEE EMPLOYEES WOULD STILL UNDER
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION RECEIVE
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLANS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FINANCE LIKE ONE POINT HERE
WHICH IS THAT THE GOVERNOR --
INCLUDED THIS IN THE NAY
REVISION TO REDUCE THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY OF THE UC RETIREMENT
PROGRAMS AND DOESN'T BELIEVE IT
SHOULD BE TIED TO ANY OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT ARE BETTER ADDRESSED
THROUGH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
THANK YOU QUESTION THIRTY MORE
LOT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- JUST A
FEW THOUGHTS ON A OFFERING A
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION OPTION DOES
NOT HAVE AN ADVERSE IMPACT.
ON THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY OF THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN SOMETHING
IT IS TO BE RESEARCH BY THE BY
THE SENATE REQUESTED THAT.
I WOULD JUST SAY THE DEFINED
BENEFIT PLAN IS NOT A PYRAMID
SCHEME IT'S NOT RICK.
BUT DEPEND ON NEW EMPLOYEES
COMING IN. TO TO PROP IT UP WILL
ALSO SAY THAT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA HAS AN UNRESTRICTED
NET DEFICIT OF NINETEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S ALSO.
A PROBLEM THAT WE NEED TO TO
LOOK AT BUT THE DC PLAN A
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN THAT
WAS NEGOTIATED WITH JANET NEPAL
TANO AND JERRY BROWN WAS.
GOING TO BE PROBABLY ONE OF THE
FINEST COMPONENTS OF THEIR
LEGACY.
AND AND SO I GET NERVOUS OR I
GET REALLY CONCERNED WHEN IDEAS
OF MODIFYING.
OF THAT.
STRATEGY ARE ARE BROACHED --
DECADES AGO THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
TRANSITION DATA DEFINED BENEFIT
PLANS BECAUSE THEY COULD FORDHAM
AND WE'RE IN A DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION WORLD IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
AND IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR WITH
BEEF THEM UP.
WHICH IS SORT OF
COUNTERINTUITIVE BUT GOING
TOWARDS A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION.
PLAN IT IS THE PROPER STRATEGY
FOR ACHIEVING BETTER FINANCIAL
SUSTAINABILITY IN THE FUTURE FOR
GONNA DIG OUT OF THIS WHOLE WE
GOT A START PROVIDING MORE
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLANS.
BECAUSE IF THE ECONOMY TANKS
THEN THE DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION
PLAN TENG'S AND THEN THE PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS GO UP WHEN WERE
CUT THE BUDGET I MEAN IT'S JUST.
A CONVERGENCE OF TWO TRENDS THAT
ARE CHEST -- NASTY AND AND A
BEEN THERE DONE THAT.
SO CURRENTLY.
LISA THE LAST NUMBERS I'VE SEEN
37% OF NEW.
UC EMPLOYEES ARE TAKING THE DC
OPTION.
AND I WOULD ASSUME THAT PERHAPS
THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
MILLENNIALS SO THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO TRANSPORT THEM THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE PORTABLE SO WHEN
THEY LEAVE THEY GET THEIR MONEY
MAKE THE GO SOMEWHERE ELSE BUT
IN A ROLLOVER IRA.
WORK OR WHATEVER.
SENATOR GLAZER ROD.
PROPOSED A BILL LAST YEAR TO TO
ALLOW ALL STATE EMPLOYEES TO
HAVE THE OPTION YOU WANT TO BE A
DC OR D. B..
AND THAT BILL FAILED BUT THAT IS
GOING TO BE I THINK IN THE
FUTURE THE DIRECTION WE SHOULD
BE GOING.
ESPECIALLY FOR FOCUS ON
FINANCIAL VIABILITY SO SO PLEASE
PLEASE WE SHOULDN'T BE GOING
BACK TO ADJUST THE BE FOR
EVERYBODY -- YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE
GOT SOMETHING THAT'S WORKING AT
UC AND IT'S A MODEL.
FOR THE REST OF THE STATE.
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE THEM SENATOR ROBB.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE -- ONE MOVE
YOUR DECISION HERE.
OF THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL WAS --
TO MAKE THE FUNDING CONTINGENT
ON ELIMINATING THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION OPTION A SENATOR
AND IT OCCURRED TO US TO ME THAT.
THE ONLY REASON -- TO DO THAT
WOULD BE IF THE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN.
AND THE PARTICIPATION HAD SOME
ADVERSE IMPACT ON THE DEFINED
BENEFIT PLAN BY CAUSING
EMPLOYEES WHO -- WOULD OTHERWISE
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PLAN TO FLIP
TO A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN
SOMEHOW IMPACTING THE DEFINED
BENEFIT PLAN IF IN FACT IT DID.
AND SO -- WHAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
DECIDED TO DO WAS CONDITION THE --
THE FLOW OF FUNDS TO A
DETERMINATION THAT IN FACT THERE
WOULD BE NO IMPACT ON THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN.
FROM CONTINUING TO DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN OPTIONS SO
THAT'S WHY THIS LANGUAGE WAS
PREPARED THE WAY IT WAS NOT TO
PRESUME THAT THERE WAS ANY.
ADVERSE IMPACT ON THE DEFINED
BENEFIT PLAN [inaudible]
BUT TO SET THE CONDITION FOR THE
FLOW OF THE MONEY.
AS OPPOSED TO THE CONDITION
BEING THE COMPLETE ELIMINATION
OF THE DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
OPTION.
MAY I RESPOND MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU I'M.
SIR ROTH I'M IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE TEN YEARS AGO.
A CALIFORNIA'S NEGOTIATED -- A
NEW FEAR FOR ITS EMPLOYEES.
AND WHO WE SAID YOU KNOW YOU CAN
HAVE A LOWER.
FORMULA AND WILL HAVE A DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN WITH IT.
SO THAT I WILL PUT IN YOU PUT
INTO PERCENT WILL PUT INTO
PERCENT AND AND AND SO WAS A
HYBRID.
AND SO THAT THAT WAS AGREED TO
BY THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE UNIONS
AND AND THE ELECTION WAS MADE AT
THE DATA HIGHER.
BUT WE ALSO NEGOTIATED THAT YOU
COULD.
GO OUT OF THE D. B. PLAN INTO
THE DC PLAN IF YOU IF YOU WANTED.
TO WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
REQUEST.
THAT OPPORTUNITY BUT WE RAN INTO
INTERNAL REVENUE.
SERVICE REV RULING TWO THOUSAND
SIX HIGH FROM.
FORTY THREE WHICH SAID THAT.
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T MOVE INTO
ANOTHER CLAN.
YOU ONLY GET ONE CHOICE NOT TO
AND IF YOU HAVE A SECOND CHOICE
YOU JEOPARDIZE THE TAX.
EXEMPT STATUS OF THE DB PLAN.
AND SO WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
CHANGE THAT REPRESENT. TEN YEARS
LATER -- THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
UNIONS LIKE ASK ME AND S. CI YOU
AND AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL HAVE
BEEN PRETTY PERSUASIVE WITH THE
US TREASURY.
DEPARTMENT AND THE IRS TO NOT
CHANGE THAT RECRUIT SO SO RIGHT
NOW YOU CAN'T EVEN DO THAT
UNLESS WE HAVE A A MAJOR CHANGE
IN FEDERAL LAW.
SO I COULD SAVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF TIME.
IN DOING A STUDY.
BASED ON JUST THE THE FUND WE'VE
HAD AN ORANGE COUNTY.
MAYBE I STAND I THOUGHT THE THE
PROPOSAL WAS TO ELIMINATE THE
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION.
PLAN OPTION FOR EMPLOYEES RIGHT
RIGHT NOW IT'S JUST IT'S
OPTIONAL.
SO WHEN YOU BECOME AN EMPLOYEE
OF THE UC SYSTEM YOU CAN SAY DO
I WON'T BE IN THE DB PLAN OR THE
DC PLAN RIGHT AND 37% FROM SAID
WILL TAKE THE DEATH.
THE CITY.
BUT IT DOESN'T ELIMINATED THE BE
PLAN.
PERHAPS I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE PROPOSAL I
THOUGHT THE PROPOSAL WAS
[inaudible] TO TO NOT INSIST
THAT A DEFINED BENEFIT DOT
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN BE
OFFERED TO REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES.
YEAH RIGHT YEAH THAT THAT THE
TICKET HERE THEY WANT TO
ELIMINATE THE WHOLE PROPOSITION
WHICH I DON'T THINK IT'S A
WITHOUT A GOOD FISCAL MOVE I
THINK WE'RE SAYING THE SAME
THING.
AND WHAT I SAID WAS I WAS NOT
PREPARED TO DO THAT.
UNLESS THERE WAS SOME ADVERSE
IMPACT ON A DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN.
AND TO MY NEEDS TO SAY THAT
THERE'S NOT YOU SAY THERE WILL
BE I DON'T KNOW PERHAPS NOT --
EMPLOYEES WHO MOVE IN WHO MOVE
OUT OF THE DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN
BEFORE VESTING.
USED TO BE THEY HAD TO LEAVE THE
MONEY IN THE PLAN IS THAT STILL
THE CASE -- IT DEPENDS ON HOW
IT'S WORDED BUT IN ORANGE COUNTY
IF YOU WERE THERE FOR FIVE YEARS
OR LESS.
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD -- LOSE THE
CONTRIBUTION THAT WAS MADE BY
THE EMPLOYER BUT YOU WOULD BE
REIMBURSED FOR THE HIGH FISHING
YOU MADE SO YOU RUN OUT OF
POCKET RIGHT AND SO WITH A
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN.
IF EMPLOYEES MOVED TO THAT
INSTEAD OF A DEFINED BENEFIT
PLAN AND THEY LEAVE.
BEFORE THE NORMAL FASTING YOU
LOSE THAT COMPONENT OF THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN THAT'S LEFT
IN THE PLAN.
THAT WOULD BE AN ACTUARIAL RIGHT
I'M XIN CÃM THAT'S WHY WE
LET'S.
THAT'S WHERE WHO HOW MANY PEOPLE
LEAVE BEFORE THE FIVE YEARS.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S WHY WE'RE
CALLING FOR NATURAL NOTICES.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
THIS IS WHAT CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE IS ALL ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
ISSUE.
TWENTY SEVEN YES WITH MACE.
I SUIT THE ENJOYED THIS DIALOGUE
A LITTLE BIT ACTUALLY REMINDED
ME OF WHEN I WAS THE CHIEF OF
STAFF TO COUNTY SUPERVISOR
SUPERVISOR SAM YOU KNOW COUNTY.
THAT WE WANTED TO GO THE LEARN
FROM THE LEGEND WHO'S WHO'S NOW
AT THE TIME WAS A SUPERVISOR
DOWN IN ORANGE COUNTY I DON'T
THINK WE IN A SETTING UP THAT
MEETING BUT ANYWAY JUST FROM.
REMEMBER THAT BECAUSE CENTER
MORE LOCK WAS IT AN EXPERT -- IN
IN THESE MATTERS.
IT'S INTERESTING THOUGH I'VE
GOTTEN AT THE TIME I WAS
ACTUALLY I WAS A FINANCIAL
ADVISER ONE POINT TIME IN MY
LIFE I'M A LITTLE RUSTY ON THAT.
ON THOSE THINGS NOW BY THE TIME
I WAS NOT A FAN OF THE DB PLAN
AT ALL -- IN FACT I WANTED ALL
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TO GO TO A TO
DC PLAN AND I REMEMBER -- SHUT
SHALL I DARE SAY THAT WHEN I WAS
CAMPAIGNING I WAS REMINDED OF
THAT -- FROM A FEW FROM A FEW
FOLKS INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
THOUGH I'M NOT OPPOSED TO A TO A
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN -- THE
SEMINAL COUNTY IS A THIRTY SEVEN
ACT COUNTY HAS -- SB SIR AND I
LEARNED IT OFF A LOT ABOUT DB
PLANS. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
I LEARNED AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S SOME
CLARIFICATION MAYBE YOU GUYS CAN
HELP ME BECAUSE ON THE SENATE
PROPOSALTHAT FIRST QUESTION
THAT'S THERE.
THAT SAYS TO SUBMIT AN ACTUARIAL
ANALYSIS VERIFYING THAT OFFERING
A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION OPTION
DOES NOT HAVE AN ADVERSE IMPACT
ON THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY THE
DEFINED.
BENEFIT PLAN.
AND I I THINK IF I IF I HEARD --
OUT MY MY THE THE LEGEND -- AT
TALK SAYING THAT -- THAT -- NEW
EMPLOYEES IT WOULDN'T IT
WOULDN'T BE HURTFUL BUT BUT IN
IT IN ACTUALITY WHEN WHEN A WHEN
THEY'RE WHEN A DEFINED BENEFIT
PLAN ISN'T PROPERLY FUNDED.
IN ESSENCE THE EXISTING
EMPLOYEES ARE ACTUALLY PAYING
FOR THE FOR THE FOR THE RETIREES
THE ONLY WAY.
I'M NOT SO I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE
HOW THIS WORKS BETWEEN BUT WITH
THIS NEW PROPOSAL THAT YOU SEE
HAS AND HOW YOU'RE MOVING PEOPLE
FROM A DB PLAN OVER TO DC PLAN.
THAT COULD END UP HAVING A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE DB PLAN
OUT OF YOU CAN CAN HELP ME WITH
THAT -- CAN SPEAK BRIEFLY TO
THAT -- FIRST -- WITH REGARDS TO
THE LEGEND -- I JUST SAY THAT
WHEN I WAS IN.
BUSINESS SCHOOL WE DIDN'T DO A
CASE STUDY ON SENATOR MORLOCK
BUT WE DID ONE ON HIS
PREDECESSOR.
IRAN AGAINST YES.
READ TO ME -- TO ON THE SPECIFIC
ISSUE I THINK THE POINT SENATOR
MORE LIKE IT'S MAKING IS WHEN A
DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN IS FUNDED
PROPERLY -- ANY BENEFIT THAT A
CRUISE IN THAT YEAR SHOULD BE
FUNDED IN THAT YEAR AND THEN
EVERYTHING ELSE BEYOND THAT
SHOULD BE THROUGH A VEST AND
RETURNS.
ON IN PRACTICE -- SOMETIMES WITH
THE SYSTEMS WE SEEN ON UNFUNDED
LIABILITY IN IN THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS AGO WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
OVER FUNDED IN THAT HAS
FLUCTUATED -- I GUESS I'LL MAKE
TWO POINTS THOUGH I THINK THE
FIRST IS THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO A SYSTEM THAT
IS UNFUNDED USUALLY IT'S THE
EMPLOYER THAT -- STEPS UP AND
FEELS THAT ACTUARIAL UNFUNDED
LIABILITY -- AND WE'RE SEEING
THAT IN THE DISCUSSION THAT WE
HAD I GUESS A COUPLE HOURS AGO
WHEN IT CAME TO SOME OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL CALPERS
CONTRIBUTIONS THOSE ARE COMING
FROM -- FUTURE EMPLOYEES THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY COMING FROM THE
STATE OR THE EMPLOYER IN THIS
CASE -- WHEN IT COMES MORE
SPECIFICALLY TO MONEY IN THE
SYSTEM AND WHETHER PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING IT THERE THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF THINGS WHERE THERE
MIGHT BE SOME FLUCTUATIONS BASED
ON WHETHER THE SYSTEM ALLOWS THE
MONEY TO BE WATCHED THEIR?
WHETHER PEOPLE TAKE THE MONEY
WITH THEM WHAT INTEREST RATE
YOU'RE SETTING ON PEOPLE WHO
HAVE INVESTED YET BUT I
CONTINUES TO ACCUMULATE IN THE
SYSTEM SO.
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT COULD BENEFIT FROM SOME
STUDY -- BUT THE BROADER POINT
AND I ENJOYED THIS DISCUSSION AS
WELL BUT FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
THIS TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WE THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
MAKE THIS CONTRIBUTION WITHOUT
WAITING INTO THIS WHOLE DEBATE.
MANAGER IF I CAN.
JUST DO USUALLY IN AGAIN I'M A
LITTLE RUSTY WITH THESE THINGS
BUT THERE'S THAT FIVE YEAR
AVERAGE -- AND YEAH WITH THE
DISCOUNT RATE IS IS DROPPED BY
THE SYSTEM USUALLY EMPLOYER
INCREASES THEIR THEIR AND CAUGHT
THE CONTRIBUTIONS BASED UPON.
THEM THE EXISTING EMPLOYEES THAT
THEY THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SO I
GUESS THAT WOULD BE TO ME ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT WOULD BE.
INTERESTING TO LOOK AT IS IS IS
WHAT THE THE IMPACT THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE A BY BY MOVING PEOPLE
OVER BETWEEN FROM THE DB PLAN
OVER OVER TO THE DC PLAN IS THAT
NOT IS THAT NOT TRUE.
SO I I THINK I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND SO I THINK
THERE'S TWO WAYS OF LOOKING AT
FIRST IS WHEN THERE IS AN
UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
THOSE ARE FOR YEARS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN WORKED RIGHT IN THE
PAST AND SO THE WAY THE SYSTEMS
OFTEN ACCOUNT FOR THAT IS BASED
ON THEIR PRESENT EMPLOYEES.
THEY SAID A RATE -- AND THEN THE
ALLOCATED ON AND YOU SEE THAT ON
YOUR PAGE ON YOUR PAYCHECK OR
YOUR PAYSTUB WHEN YOU GET IT.
BUT THE FACT IS IF YOU HAD FEWER
EMPLOYEES IT WOULD JUST BE
BIGGER PER EMPLOYEE SO THAT
RESPONSIBILITY IS STILL ON THE
EMPLOYER NO MATTER HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES THEY HAVE SO.
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING
THAT AMOUNT AND IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY FLUCTUATE AGAIN THESE
ARE ACCORDING TO PRINCIPLES IF
YOU KNOW FOR HOW THE PROGRAM
WORKS.
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
THE PROGRAM -- IT MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT FOR NEW EMPLOYEES FOR
OUT IT IS FOR THE STATE FOR
PEOPLE BEGUN AFTER TWENTY
THIRTEEN BECAUSE THEY'RE YOUR
NORMAL COST -- THE RATE IS NOT
SECTOR BARGAINING BUT FLUCTUATES
FOR BOTH THE EMPLOYER AND THE
EMPLOYEE SO -- IN THAT CASE WHEN
THE DISCOUNT RATE TO YOUR POINT
FLUCTUATES THAN BOTH PEOPLE'S
COST FLUCTUATE BUT THOSE ARE NOT
FOR THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY THOSE
ARE FOR BENEFITS THAT ACCRUE.
IN THE PRESENT HERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU BASICALLY HAVE TO FUND OF
THE BENEFIT TOUCH ISN'T THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING CORRECT YES.
IT'S A DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN SO
YOU GUARANTEE A BENEFIT TO
SOMEBODY.
BASED ON YEARS OF SERVICE AT THE
END OF THE RAINBOW YES AND YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY.
IN THE BUCKET TO PAY THOSEBENEFITS YES SO YOU FUND TO THE
BENEFIT.
SO THAT'S WHY IF THE MARKET
TANKS.
IF YOU THE EMPLOYER.
YOU GET YOUR CHECKBOOK OUT.
AND FUNDED THE BENEFIT.
NOW I'M NOT THE CPA NOR MY AN
ACTUARY BUT THERE THERE'S A WAY
THEY CALCULATE THAT.
AND THAT'S HOW IT WORKS RIGHT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
NO THAT'S THAT THAT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING BUT THAT'S NOT BUT
I THOUGHT I HEARD SO WHAT AT
THIS.
SENATOR ROBB I THINK ACTUALLY --
IF IF WHAT HE JUST SAID IS
ACCURATE THEN YES WE'VE ANSWERED
MY QUESTION THIS MY
UNDERSTANDING THANK YOU.
THE FRONT YOU PAY YOU PAY THE
BENEFIT OUT THE BENEFIT I A
DEFINED BENEFIT SO WHATEVER IS
HAPPENING IN THE ECONOMY UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW IS PRESENTLY
INTERPRETED THAT IS.
THAT BENEFIT IS PAID OUT TO BE
READ TO THE RETIREE I THINK
YOU'RE MAKING AT SOME A
DIFFERENT POINT ALSO WHICH IS
THAT.
IT'S ALL BEING PAID OUT OF THAT
YOU KNOW CALPERS HAS THREE
HUNDRED AND SOME ODD BILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT LEVEL WAS
FLUCTUATING BASED ON THE MARKET.
IT'S ALSO FLUCTUATING BASED ON
HOW MANY PEOPLE AE PAYING AND
PAYING OUT SO THERE ARE
DIFFERENT WAYS OF LOOKING AT IT
SO. TO THE EXTENT THAT MORE
PEOPLE ARE PAYING INTO CALPERS
THAN YOU ARE RIGHT THAT THERE IS
MORE MONEY IN THAT FUND AND SO
MONIES GOING OUT IN MONIES GOING
AND BUT SENATOR MORE LIKE IS
ALSO.
CORRECT THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PAYING AND MONEY IF THE DISCOUNT
RATE IS SET APPROPRIATELY THEY
ARE FINDING THEIR OWN RETIREMENT
AND NOT NECESSARILY OTHERS
RETIREMENT.
MADAM CHAIR IF I CAN ASK THIS
ONE OF COURSE THE CURRENT FUNDED --
RATIO FOR THE UC SYSTEM.
EACH OF OCT WE HAVE THESE.
KURT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
THE UC INDICATES OF ITS MOST
RECENT REPORT FROM JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT THEY WERE IT 85%
FUNDED.
WHICH IS GOOD LEAVING AT TEN
BILLION DOLLAR OF TAX LIABILITY
FAIRLY GOOD.
LIKE THAT THANK.
BUT THE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
WRITTEN FROM HEARD BY THE THE
PRIOR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE STATED
THAT THERE WAS A NINETEEN
BILLION DOLLAR UNFUNDED RETIREE
MEDICAL SOLIDS.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
TACKLED.
JUST JUST HURRY UP.
CERTAINLY AND I JUST KNOW THAT
THAT'S A REGION TOLD YOU KNOW
DISCUSSION.
ON HEALTHCARE BENEFITS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE.
WHEN THE EIGHT ANOTHER BIGGIE
SEISMIC RETROFIT?
HELLO.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS AN
ASSEMBLY ACTION TO PROVIDE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR A PILOT TO PROVIDE
SEISMIC RENOVATIONS AT THE UC.
ALL THE WAY THIS WOULD WORK IS --
THE CAMPUS AT CAMPUSES RIVER
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THERE
WOULD BE AN EXPECTATION OF A OF
A MATCH WITH NON STATE FUNDING --
THAT ACCORDING TO STAFFTHE
INTENTION OF THE PROPOSAL IS --
TO INCENTIVIZE MORE PRIVATE GIFT
GIVING OFFER PROJECTS LIKE
SEISMIC OF RENOVATIONS.
WE WOULD NOTE HERE THAT -- SO
IT'S A GREAT EVASIONS ARE
REASONABLE USE OF ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT SAID WE RAISE TWO
ISSUES FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER IS IT'S WEIGHING THIS
PROPOSAL AGAINST OTHER ONE TIME
OPTIONS.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE STATE HAS --
PROCESSES IN PLACE AT THE MOMENT
TO FIND YOU SEE FACILITY
PROJECTS.
INCLUDING RENOVATION PROJECTS.
NOWADAYS WE TYPICALLY DO IT
THROUGH BY UNIVERSITY BONDS THAT
FINANCE OF THE PROJECTS WE PAID
BACK THE ASSOCIATED UP THE
GENERAL FUND.
ON TO THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO UNDERSTAND HOW HOW THIS NEW
PILOT WOULD INTERACT WITH THOSE
EXISTING PROCESSES.
AND SECOND WE KNOW THAT AND SOME
CASES CAMPUSES DO ALREADY MATCH
STATE FUNDING WITH NON STATE
FUNDING TYPICALLY THIS NON STATE
FUNDING INCLUDES THINGS LIKE --
OVERHEAD ON FEDERAL RESEARCH
GRANTS -- INVESTMENT RETURNS IN
CERTAIN -- MONEY ACCOUNTS AND
THIS OCCURS SOMETIMES EVEN FOR
SEISMIC RENOVATIONS SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN THIS YEAR THE STATE
DID APPROVE -- RENOVATION
PROJECT AT UC BERKELEY ABOUT
ALONE MORE THAN HALF OF THAT
PROJECT WOULD BE FUNDED WITH IN
THIS EXISTING PRACTICE FROM A
LEGIT LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER WHAT ADDITIONAL.
ON THINGS IS HOPING TO LEARN AS
A RESULT OF THE PILOT.
THANK YOU.
FINANCE.
SO WE THIS CALL IS A LAUDABLE
GOAL WE BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD
BE SUPPORTED TO LA OWES --
COMMENT AT THROUGH THE UC BUDGET.
THANK YOU ARE TO THE LA -- WHAT
DETERMINES ELIGIBILITY?
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE PROGRAM ELIGIBLE
CAMPUSES -- YOU KNOW I I HAVEN'T
SEEN THETRAILER LEGISLATION YET
SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO ALL THE
SPECIFICS BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS IT WILL.
PRIMARILY BE BASED ON HOW WHAT
WHAT NON STATE FUNDS THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO MATCH WITH THE STATE
FUNDING I CAN'T COMMENT MUCH
MORE THAT SINGS SECIFIC
LANGUAGE.
WE GONNA COME IN THIS MCCARTY AT
THE NOTION WAS TO ALL UC
CAMPUSES.
THANK YOU WHO COULD WHO COULD
HAVE THE MATCHING FUNDS THOSE
WHO COULD.
PUT UP [inaudible]
SKINNER.
ON OTHER CAMPUSES HAVE ANYWAY --
DE.
WHEN ELLIE -- RESPONSE THAT THE
STATE HAS MECHANISMS FOR FINDING
THESE NEEDS -- DO I DON'T HAVE
THE DATA BEFORE ME BUT LAST I
CHECKED.
THE IT.
SEISMIC NEED THE NEED THE COST.
TO GET.
THE UC BUILDINGS THAT ARE NOT UP
TO ASSIST THE THE SEISMIC CODE
THAT WE WOULD EXPECT TODAY -- IS
BEYOND ANYTHING THAT WE EITHER
HAVE BONDS OR CAPITAL AT LEE AND
IN FACT THE AS A LEGISLATURE WE
HAVE NOT PROVIDED YOU SEE VERY
MUCH CAPITAL MONIES -- SO I MEAN
IT.
YEAH WE MAY HAVE SOME MECHANISMS
BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVEN'T BEEN.
FINDING ANY OF THE CAPUSES OR
THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE FOR
CAPITAL NEEDS AT ANY RATE THAT
IS NEEDED. FOR YEARS AND FOR THE
SEISMIC NEED -- WE HAVE I'M SURE
MOST OF MY COLLEAGUES KNOW
CAMPUSES THAT ARE DIRECTLY ON
FAULTS I MEAN LITERALLY THE
HAYWARD FAULT RUNS THROUGH THE
UC BERKELEY CAMPUS IT ISOUR
OLDEST CAMPUS IT HAS QUITE A FEW.
BUILDINGS.
THAT -- PROVIDE ACTIVE
INSTRUCTION EVERYDAY BUT ARE NOT
UP TO THE SEISMIC CODE UCLA IS
IF IT IS NOT DIRECTLY ON A FAULT
IT IS IN CLOSE CLOSE PROXIMITY.
AND SURE RIVERSIDE SIMILARLY AND
MANY OF OUR OTHER UC CAMPUSES --
SO -- I I SUPPOSE I WOULD -- IF
WE WERE NOT.
TO ACT ON THE ASSEMBLY TO
REQUEST I WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT WOULD BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SOME FUNDING FOR
SEISMIC RETROFIT BECAUSE IT IS A
VERY SERIOUS NEED.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
I MIGHT HAVE SOME MINUTES
EARLIER MISSION JUST TO HELP --
YEAH SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED THE FIRST WITH
QUESTION WAS JUST ON GENERAL
NEED.
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU THINK OF
THIS I I DON'T I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE LANGUAGE -- BUT IF IT'S IF
THAT'S ASSUMING THERE'S A ONE TO
ONE MATCH YOU'RE LOOKING AT
MAYBE A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN TOTAL THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE.
FOR SEISMIC RENOVATIONS NOT
GETTING ABOUT IT'S ABOUT FIVE TO
MAYBE TEN PROJECTS -- IN THE
UNIVERSITIES CURRENTLY STUDYING
AT SEISMIC NEEDS ITS
IMPLEMENTING KIND OF A A STUDY
THAT IT'S ABOUT 70% DONE WITH
AND SO ONCE IT'S COME CONCLUDED
WITH THAT STUDY WOULD MIGHT AND
WE MAY HAVE A KIND OF BROADER
SENSE OF THE OVERALL NEED ACROSS
THE SYSTEM.
BOTH HOUSES ALSO ADOPT
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD HAVE A REQUIRE UNIT
YOU UNIVERSITY TO STUDY AT
SEISMIC NEEDS SO THE LEGISLATURE
IS EXPECTING THE UNIVERSITY TO
COME BACK WITH THE FULLER
ASSESSMENT OF THOSE NEEDS ACROSS
THE SYSTEM.
AND THEN JUST TO THAT A SECOND
QUESTION ABOUT THE EXISTING
PROCESS THE WITH EXISTING
PROCESS WORKS AS THE UNIVERSITY
RAISES BONTA USES THE GENERAL
FUND TO PAY BACK THE ASSOCIATED
DEBT.
ON THE UNIVERSITY CURRENTLY USES
THOSE BONDS FOR WRITING PROJECTS
INCLUDE NEW BUILDINGS AND THEY
ALSO INCLUDE SEISMIC RENOVATIONS%
ANOTHER SORT OF SORTS OF THINGS
LIKE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR
EXAMPLE. ONE ISSUE THAT -- IT IS
RAISED EACH YEAR IS HOW THE
UNIVERSITY PRIORITIZES ALL THESE
DIFFERENT NEEDS AND ROMAN GROWTH
SEISMIC NEEDS -- AND UNIVERSITY
RIGHT NOW TRIES TO WORK WITH THE
CAMPUS IS TO IDENTIFY THEIR
HIGHEST NEEDS AND SOMETIMES THAT
MEANS THAT.
THEY FIND ENROLLMENT GROWTH
ANOTHER YEARS IT WILL PROJECTS
THAT SUPPORTED WOMAN GROWTH A
NEW FACILITY SOMETIMES THAT
MEANS THERE SEISMIC RENOVATIONS
IT KIND OF VARIES BY CAMPUS SO
THERE HAVE BEEN.
A SOME SEISMIC PROJECTS OVERALL
BUT THERE IT'S UNLIKELY THAT
THEY'VE ADDRESSED -- THAT FULLY
MEDIA ESPECIALLY IN OLDER
CAMPUSES WERE YOU HAVE -- OLDER
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROBB.
WELL I JUST WANNA MAKE THE POINT
I MEAN WE HEARD.
WE HAD A GREAT DEAL OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND AS I RECALL IN
THE UC SYSTEM IT'S ABOUT A
LITTLE OVER FOUR BILLION OR
SOMETHING IN THE CSU SYSTEM IT'S
A LITTLE BIT OF A LITTLE OVER
FOUR BILLION SO IT'S TOTAL
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN EIGHT AND NINE
BILLION DOLLARS. FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND WHEN I ASKED THE
QUESTION.
AS TO WHETHER SEISMIC WAS
INCLUDED IN THAT -- AS I RECALL
THE ANSWER WAS NOT -- HENCE THE
NEED FOR THE STUDY IN MY
REQUESTED.
TO INSTEAD OF TWENTY THIRTY THAT
IT SPEED UP A LITTLE BIT AND WE
GET AN IDEA AND A HANDLE ON WHAT
THE TOTAL SEISMIC NEED IS SO WE
CAN ADD THAT TO THE EIGHT OR
NINE BILLION AND THEN FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO FUND IT.
AS A STATE SO THIS SOUNDS LIKE
THIS IS A PRETTY OOD START BUT
WE'VE GOT A LONG WAY TO GO WHEN
IT COMES.
TO SEISMIC RETROFIT IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
UP AND DOWN THE STATE THAT
PHILANTHROPY PROBABLY WON'T
TOTALLY ADDRESS.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT THANKS FOR THE
EFFORT.
THANK YOU MOVING ON TO ISSUE
TWENTY NINE VERY FEW SEE
ADJUSTMENTS LA -- SO THE ITEM
BEFORE YOU PRESENTS A SERIES OF
DIFFERENT CONFERENCE ISSUES
RELATED TO THE UC BUDGET FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME ALL ADDRESS JUST
THE THE OF THE LARGEST ISSUE FOR
EACH HOUSE -- ON THE SENATE SIDE
THE LARGEST ISSUE HERE IS
FUNDING FOR THE UC RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
THE OVERARCHING OBJECTIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL IS TO PROVIDE MORE
STATE SUPPORT PER STUDENT AT THE
SCHOOL AND ALSO EXPAND THE
SCHOOLS ENROLLMENT CURRENTLY THE
SCHOOL SERVES ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY STUDENTS IN THE OVER
ARCHING OBJECTIVE IS.
TO ROUGHLY DOUBLE THAT TO ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS -- THE
FUNDING WOULD THE WANT THERE'S
ONE TIME AND I'M GOING FUNDING
THERE THE ONE TIME FUNDING WOULD
BE TO FIND ANEW -- FACILITY FOR
THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE -- AND
THEN THE ONGOING FUNDING WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL STATE SUPPORT
CURRENTLY THE SCHOOL RECEIVES
FIFTEEN MILLION AND STATE
SUPPORT -- SO THIS WOULD
INCREASE IT AT ANOTHER TWENTY
FIVE FOR FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN TOTAL GENERAL GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT DIRECTLY TO THE SCHOOL.
THE LARGEST INITIATIVE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE IS TO PROVIDE.
A NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FNDING -- THAT'S
LARGELY UNRESTRICTED THE OVER
THE OBJECTIVE OF THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING IS TO CARRY OVER OUR
EARTH TO SUSTAIN ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ARE THE
UNIVERSITY RECEIVED A LARGE
AMOUNT OF UNRESTRICTED ONE TIME
FUNDS IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
SAYS THAT IT USE THOSE FUNDS --
FOR LARGELY ON GOING PURPOSES
THINGS LIKE HIRING MORE FACULTY
PROVIDING OR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES -- IN THE IT DIDN'T
INTEND HERE'S ASSISTING THOSE
ACTIVITIES FOR AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR.
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED IN
PROVIDING A MORE ONE TIME
FUNDING TO UNIVERSITY. TO
CONSIDER WAYS -- TO BUT PROVIDE
MORE CLARITY ON WHAT SCHOOLS ARE
FOR THE ONE TIME FUNDING AND
IDENTIFY -- POTENTIALLY ONE TIME
USES SO THAT THE UNIVERSITY
SPEND THEM ON ONE TIME PURPOSES
AND DOESN'T CREATE A COST
PRESSURE FOR THE STATE -- IN THE
FOLLOWING FISCAL YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE SO WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE YOU SEE
DYSLEXIA CENTER OF FUNDING THESE
ITEMS ARE NOT IN OUR BUDGET.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MR MAYES.
I JUST HAVE TO TO JUMP IN HERE --
JUST TO TALK ABOUT THE UC
RIVERSIDE MEDICAL SCHOOL -- BUT
THIS IS A A HUGE WAS A HUGE WIN
FOR THE INLAND EMPIRE THE TWO
COUNTIES -- IT NEEDS TO BE FULLY
FUNDED -- BUT I KNOW -- THE MY
COLLEAGUE -- WHO I THINK DO YOU
REPRESENT -- BUT THE UC ARE I DO
NOT -- BUT I I DO KNOW THAT THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
FACT INCREDIBLY SIGNIFICANT --
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE WE DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH PROVIDERS IN THE
TO COUNTY A REGION -- AND IT IS --
AND ONE OF THOSE THINGS IF WE
CAN GET SOME FOLKS TRAINED THERE
GET THEM TO LOVE THE OTHER
COMMUNITY HOPEFULLY THEY WILL
END UP -- END UP DOING A
RESIDENCY CLOSE BY AND THEN AND
THEN STAYING THERE SO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF RESPONSIBILITY.
THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
I LOVE THIS IS GONNA BE A UC
RIVERSIDE MINUTES WHO LOVE FEST
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
IT REALLY IS GOOD FOR THE WHOLE
STATE IS WE'VE NOT EXPANDED MED
SCHOOL PUBLICLY FUNDED MET
SCHOOLS IN.
GENERATIONS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON ISSUE.
TWENTY NINE RESIST THE URGE TO
CLOSE OUT ON THAT ONE RIGHT NOW --
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE THIRTY
NEW CAMPUS STUDY WE MAKE TO THIS
EARLIER EL AL AS FULL HOUSES
PROVIDE THE SAME AMOUNT FOR THIS
ISSUE THE HOUSES DO DIFFER
SOMEWHAT.
ON THE SPECIFIC REGIONS OR
CITIES FOR THE CSU CHANCES
OFFICE TO STUDY WHETHER NEEDEXISTS FOR A NEW CAMPUS THERE.
OF JUST WANTED TO NOTE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THAT AN
ALTERNATIVE APPROACH TO
SELECTING REGION'S LARGEST STUDY
WOULD BE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
AGREE ON FACTORS. TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT IN ASSESSING WHETHER A
NEED EXISTS FOR A NEW CAMPUS FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
LOOK AT FACTORS SUCH AS LOW
COLLEGE GOING RATES IN AN AREA.
FOR LONG COMMUTING DISTANCE TO A
FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY.
AS FACTORS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
THEN DIRECT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO LOOK AT ALL AREAS OF
THE STATE AND SEE WHICH ONES
MEET THOSE CRITERIA -- AND
INVEST MAY WARRANT TO NEW CAMPUS.
OUR LIST OF WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES TO GO WITH
THE REGIONAL STUDY APPROACH --
STATEWIDE APPROACH WE WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT EVEN ONE CAMPUS WOULD
INCREASE CONSIDERABLY BE OUT
YOUR COSTS ARE YOU HAPPY. ONE
TIME CAPITAL COSTS AND OF COSTS
TO OPERATE A CAMPUS WHICH ARE
QUITE A BIT HIGHER -- FOR YOU
CAMPUS AS OPPOSED -- TO EXISTING
CAMPUSES AND AND IN RETURN THE
STATE'S WAS CLOUT OUTLOOK WOULD
BE IMPACTED WHEN YOU HAVE THESE
ARE POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
HIGHER COSTS RIGHT NO QUESTION.
FINANCE.
THEY SAY THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
FOCUSES ON SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
THERE ARE A LOT OF LOCAL LEADERS
IN THE STOCKTON AREA WHO ARE
REALLY INVESTED.
IN THIS STUDY AND SO THE
GOVERNOR WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT DOES HAVE AN EMPHASIS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR MORE LOT.
MANAGER -- SINCE WE MENTION
ORANGE COUNTY -- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE INITIATED
SUBSEQUENT TO THE BANKRUPTCY
FILING WAS A TEN YEAR STRATEGIC
FINANCIAL PLAN.
SO WE COULD SEE WERE GOING WHAT
WHAT WHAT A DECISION TODAY.
HOW WOULD IT IMPACT IS TEN YEARS
OUT?
AND SO.
I'VE BEEN I SERVED ON SUB ONE
FOR THE FIRST FOUR YEARS.
AND I ASKED FOR A TEN YEAR PLAN
FROM.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND I WAS TOLD NO.
ARE NOT GONNA DO THAT FOR YOU.
SO IT'S A LITTLE INTERESTING
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA LOOK
AT A NEW CAMPUS BUT WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE A TEN YEAR.
STRATEGIC FINANCIAL PLAN. FOR
THE CURRENT.
CAMPUSES IN HOW ARE WE GONNA DIG
OUT IN AND IMPROVE OUR BALANCE
SHEET -- BEFORE WE ADD ANOTHER.
CAMPUS I'M NOT SAYING DON'T
BUILDING CAMPUS OR DON'T DO THE
RESEARCH UNDERSTAND.
MAYBE THAT THE STUDY SHOULD E A
LITTLE MORE -- BROUGHT IT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THE THE BIG
PICTURE HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
SUSTAIN THIS.
OTHERWISE WE'RE LOOKING AT
MASSIVE TUITION INCREASES RIGHT
WHICH ARE UNTENABLE SO I'M.
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
WILL BALANCE AS WE PURSUE THIS.
IT IN A MY QUESTION FOR YOU THAT
YOU ASKED THEM FOR TEN YEAR
FINANCIAL PLAN OR A TEN YEAR
STRATEGIC PLAN IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY INTEND.
TO EDUCATE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
KIDS FINANCIAL PLAN JUST TEN
COLUMNS IN AN EXCEL SPREADSHEET.
AND AND BASS BUT REALLY WAS
FINANCIAL NOT IN TERMS OF THEIR
STRATEGY ABOUT GROWTH AND
EXPANSION PROGRAM I WANT TO KNOW
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO PAY FOR
EVERYTHING AS IT GOES -- YOU
KNOW PUT JUST HOUSE THE HOUSE
AGO HOW ARE YOU GOING TO REDUCE.
YOUR UNFUNDED LIABILITIES JUST
CHECK OUT WHAT.
WHAT'S THE TEN YEAR PLAN IS NOT
THAT LONG -- IN IN SO -- BUT I
JUST WANT TO PUT ON THE RECORD
THAT WE NEED TO START DOING A
LITTLE MORE.
THINKING AHEAD ON HOW IT ALL
FITS IN AND SO WE DON'T LEAVE A
MESS TO THOSE TO SUCCEED IS
[inaudible]
MR MAYES.
REALLY LOVE THE ASSEMBLY MAP OF
A PLAN -- HERE COULD BE -- THAT
THERE IS A THE PALM DESERT IS IN
HERE -- I DO KNOW ON OUR SIDE
THERE'S A HANDFUL OF US MEMBERS --
WHO HAVE THIS AMBITION OF HAVING
FULL FLEDGED CAMPUSES?
BUT TO CENTER MORE LOCKS POINT
WE REALLY DO NEED TO HAVE THIS --
THIS GOAL IN THIS PLAN FOR ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA WE HAVE FOUR AND
A HALF MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
WE DO HAVE ARE YOU SEE WE ALSO
HAVE CAL STATE MAKES SENSE FOR
THERE TO BE ONE AND IN PALM
DESERT YET IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
SHOULD NOT BE WANTED TO THIS --
NOT ONE IN SAN MATEO COUNTY OF
COURSE THE ONE THAT I KNOW THAT --
DOCTOR AGAIN IS LOOKING -- FOR
IN IN IN STOCKTON AND SO THIS
IDEA OF DOING A COMPREHENSIVE A
PLAN OF WHERE THOSE NEXT --
BUSINESS NEXT THE FULL
INDEPENDENT ACCOUNT STATES ARE
GOING TO BE I THINK MAKES AN
AWFUL LOT AS A LOT OF SENSE.
THE REASON IM I LIKE THE
SPELLING OUT WHERE THE BOAT
WE'RE GONNA DO THE STUDYING IS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE CAL
STATE SYSTEM HAS THEIR OWN
CONSTITUENCY.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN POLITICAL
DYNAMICS AND AND THEY THEY
OFTENTIMES WANT TO KEEP
EVERYTHING ON THEIR CAR WHERE
THEIR CURRENT CAMPUSES ARE OUT
THEY DON'T WANT EXPAND JUST FOR
THOSE REASONS THEY GOT LIMITED
RESOURCES THEY GOT BIG AMBITIONS.
TO TO SPEND MONEY THERE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT TO LIST THESE AND I
THINK IT MAKES SENSE. FOR US TO
CONSIDER THOSE FOUR SITES THANK
YOU BACK TO WHEREVER I WAS -- IT
OUGHT. TO LIVE THIS IS DOWN
THERE BECAUSE THEY THEY'VE GIVEN
THE GAS ALMOST. THREE HUNDRED
THREE HUNDRED BEGIN ACRES OF
LAND TO BUILD THE CAMPUS FREE TO
STATE SO ANALYSTS AT BEAUTIFUL
AND IN FACT.
BUT THE ARE CHALLENGES CONTINUES
TO BE IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
PLAN.
AND WE DON'T AND SO THERE FOR
EVERYBODY WHO WANTS SOMETHING
HAS A TENDENCY TO THROW IN TO
TRY TO GET IT AND AND TO KIND OF
PUSH FOURTH.
WE NEED A HIGHER IT COMMISSION
THAT LIKE WE USED TO HAVE THAT
WOULD DEAL WITH THE SOMETIMES
THE PLANET MASS THAT WOULD WRITE
THE MASTER PLAN TO DEAL WITH AND
ROLL MY CHANGES AND ALL THE
STUFF WE TRIED WE TRIED IT FOR
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS.
AND IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A PROPOSAL
TO HAD TO DO SEE PACKING YET AND
BOB PAST GOVERNOR ALWAYS VETOED
IT BECAUSE HE GOT RID OF IT AND
DIDN'T WANT TO COME BACK.
BUT I THINK THERE MAY BE ONE OR
TWO PIECES OF LEGISLATION
FLOATING AROUND NOW HOPEFULLY
THAT MAKE IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK THAT MAY ONCE AGAIN
ESTABLISHED THIS HIGHER IT
COMMISSION.
THAT WHOSE JOB WOULD BE TO DO
THAT AND THEREFORE YOU TAKE A
LOT OF THE POLITICS OUT OF IT.
BECAUSE THEY WOULD BE LOOKING AT
ENROLLMENT TRANS CURRICULUM WHAT
KINDS OF DEGREES UNNECESSARY SO
FORTH AND SO ON WERE YOU GOING
TO FIND IT WHERE YOU LOCATED AND
THAT'S HOW YOU.
YOU DEVELOP A PLAN THAT'S HOW
YOU GET ON THE LIST BUT TEN
YEARS TO GET SAN MARCOS SO WHERE
PEOPLE OR WHEREVER YOU'RE GOING
TO BE BUT IT JUST TAKES A
POLITICS OUT OF IT AND AS A
RESULT IT FOCUSES ON WHERE THE
NEEDS ARE.
WITH THE ENROLLMENT IS YOU KNOW
WITH THE GROWTH MAY BE IN EVEN
IN AREAS WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A
CAMPUS LIKE -- IN COACHELLA YOU
KNOW THAT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT THE DATA SHOW THAT PROBABLY
THERE'S NOT POPULATION ENOUGH TO
TO HAVE A CAMPUS -- THEY DO NEED
TO COMMUNICATE ALLEGE THAT THEY
DO NEED SOME OTHER KINDS OF
THEORIES SAID THIS SO.
YOU KNOW BUT I JUST THINK --
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET SOMETHING
THAT WILL GIVE US MORE THAN JUST
EVERY NOW AND THEN WE CAN GET
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A BILL STUDY
TOGETHER.
AND AND THEN MAKE A DECISION
MAYBE -- THAT SOMETHING MIGHT
HAPPEN -- BUT WE NEED AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION WE HAVE A HUGE SYSTEM.
ABOUT COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
ISSUE WHEN YOU SEE THAT REALLY
NEEDS THAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN FROM A
CITIZEN COMMISSION THAT WOULD
REALLY BE LOOKING AT THE TRANS.
I JUST NEED TO TO TO MAKE SURE
TO CORRECT WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE --
BUT CAL STATE WE HAVE A CAMPUS
OF COUSE EXAMINED YOU KNOW IN
PALM DESERT THERE ARE FOUR OR
FIVE BEAUTIFUL BUILDINGS THAT
ARE THERE.
IN TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF A
RESOURCES THAT THE COMMUNITIES
JUST WANTS TO BE ABLE TO GIVE TO
BE ABLE TO TO BEGIN TO TO THE
BILL THAT OUT.
THEY NEED A PLAN -- AND IT ALSO
NEED TO BE PART OF THE OVERALL
SYSTEM WHICH IS WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO TO DO
THIS WORK AND AGAIN IT'S NOT
FAIR TO SAY YEAH I JUST NEED TO
GO DOWN.
AT THE PALM DESERT TO SERVE THE
FOLKS IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
THIS NEEDS.
TO DO NEEDS BECAUSE STATEWIDE --
WHICH IS WHY I THINK THESE SITES
ARE SO IMPORTANT [inaudible]
IRAQ.
BUT IT'S ONE OF SAY YOU KNOW I
YOU ACTUALLY SUPPORT LISTINGS
VARIOUS LOCATIONS I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE.
AMERICA VALLEY -- SUPPORTS AND I
DO TOO WHEN WE HEARD THIS AND IN
PARTICULAR WITH RESPECT TO CHULA
VISTA I WAS ASKING MY COLLEAGUES
WHO WAS THE PROPONENT OF THIS.
DO YOU NEED TO CAMPUS OR DO NEED
TO A BRANCH OF THE CAMPUS AND I
THINK THOSE CONVERSATIONS NEED
TO OCCUR WITH RESPECT.
TO PALM DESERT DO YOU DO WE NEED
OF ON HOOVER BRANCH OR DO WE
NEED A SEPARATE COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY.
BECAUSE WITH UNIVERSITIES COME
THE SAME BUREAUCRACY ISSUES IS
FOR A THAT I MENTIONED WITH
ONLINE -- DO WE NEED THAT
SOMETIMES YOU DO SOMETIMES YOU
DON'T BUT I DO SUPPORT.
A STUDY I SUPPORT A MASTER PLAN
I SUPPORT LOOKING AT THESE
VARIOUS LOCATIONS. TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE ENTITY IS
THAT WE SITE THERE WHETHER IT'S
A BRANCH CAMPUS OR WHETHER IT'S
A STAND UP STAND ALONE
UNIVERSITY JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT POINT IN.
AND I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
YOUR POINTS.
ANY FURTHER CONVERSATION
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MOVING ON TO THE ISSUE.
THIRTY ONE THE NEW THAT RIGHT
YEAH ISSUE.
THIRTY ONE THIS IS VERY IFFY
ISSUE ADJUSTMENTS ELIA.
THIS ITEM CONSISTS OF FOUR
ISSUES RELATED TO CSU TWO OF THE
ISSUES ARE SENATE PRIORITIES TO
THE ISSUES ARE ASSEMBLY
PRIORITIES.
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU
THAT ONE HOUSE PROVIDES A COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR THE
CAPITAL FELLOWS PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
FELLOWS.
AND THE HOUSE ALSO PROVIDES
TARGETED ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING FOR A PROGRAM THAT
PREPARES SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGISTS TO WORK IN K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS IN OTHER SETTINGS.
AND WE FIND THAT BOTH OF THESE
AUGMENTATIONS HAVE MERIT I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT ANY OF THE FOUR
ISSUES AND THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
AB QUESTIONS.
FINANCING THE COMMENT.
THANK YOU.
WITH A STATUS CHECK FOR MY
FELLOW.
GIVE ME FOR MONEY AB FAB AND
WE'VE BEEN WE OWE SOME FORMER
DOUBLES.
SERVING ALL RIGHT ISSUE THIRTY
TWO ACADEMIC QUALITY IN
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
SO THIS ITEM CONTAINS ONE YOU
SEE ISSUE AND ONE CSU ISSUE
REGARDING STUDENT SUCCESS
INITIATIVES.
THE HOUSE IS DIFFERENT MORE ON
THE UC ISSUE WITH THE SENATE
ADOPTING THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDING WITH
A FOCUS ON YOU SEE CLOSING.
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AT CAMPUSES.
THE ASSEMBLY REJECTED THE
PROPOSAL IN THE ASSEMBLY ACTION
RECOGNIZE UC'S RELATIVELY HIGH
GRADUATION RATES AND INSTEAD
CHOSE.
TO TARGET ONGOING FUNDS FOR
OTHERHIGH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES IN PARTICULAR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
THE HOUSES ARE MUCH CLOSER ON
THE CSU ISSUE BOTH PROVIDE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS MORE
FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR BUT THE
SENATE PROVIDES THE FUNDING ON
AN ONGOING BASIS.
WHILE THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES THE
FUNDING ONE TIME.
BETWEEN THE HOUSES WE RECOMMEND
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
PROVIDING THE FUNDING ON A ONE
TIME BASIS WOULD LIMIT -- THE
STATE'S OUT YOUR SPENDING
COMMITMENTS AND STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S RESERVES IN THE EVENT OF
A FUTURE RECESSION AND WE WOULD
KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY WAYS
CAMPUSES COULD USE ONE TIME
FUNDING.
EFFECTIVELY SUCH AS REDESIGNING
AT HIRING FACULTY TO OFFER MORE
COURSES IN HIGH DEMAND.
PROGRAMS IN HIGH DEMAND AREAS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE RIGHT OVER TO
MICHAEL GREAT CERTAINLY I THINK
ON THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
AUGMENTATIONS -- CERTAINLY
THEY'RE NOT REFLECTED IN OUR
BUDGET I THINK WE'D HAVE A
CONCERNED ABOUT THE THE LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY OF SOME OF
THOSE -- INVESTMENTS WE ALSO
NOTE -- ON THE REJECTION OF THE
STUDENT SUCCESS -- INITIATIVE IT
AT YOU SEE -- WE WOULD NOTE THA
THERE ARE STILL GAPS IN STUDENT
SUCCESS AMONG -- UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS OF STUDENTS
LOW INCOME STUDENTS SHOWING
THANK WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO CAREFULLY BALANCE
STUDENT SUCCESS WITH THE OTHER --
MEASURES THAT THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE TO PUT IN PLACE --
PARTICULARLY ACCESS -- SO WE
CERTAINLY AREN'T IN A POSITION
TO SUPPORT THESE THESE
DIFFERENCES TODAY BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A AREFUL
BALANCE THE NEEDS TO BE CRAFTED.
THANK YOU COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
MR MCCARTY YEAH I JUST --
BRIEFLY ON THE ON THE UC ITEM.
IT THE TICKET CAME DOWN -- TO
PRIORITIES AGAIN AND TOP ISSUE
WE HEAR FROM OUR MEMBERS
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS IS
ACCESS TO THE GREAT UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HOW THEIR NEIGHBOR
OR THEIR NEPHEW THEIR FRIENDS.
HAS A FOUR POINT THREE IN A
PLAID IRVINE DAVIS IN LA AND
GREAT SAT SCORE THEY CAN'T GET
IN.
AND SO THE THE QUALITY PIECE WAS
A REALLY COOKED IN THERE REALLY
ISN'T A HUGE. FOR YOUR
GRADUATION CRISIS THAT YOU SEE
LIKE THERE IS CSU SO WE THOUGHT
THE HIGHEST AND BEST SE THAT
FIFTY MILLION WAS TO ENROLL.
OR CALIFORNIANS THANKS
[inaudible]
WITH SKINNER.
WE ARE HAVING DISCUSSION ON THE
ROLE MAKE PEACE SUBSEQUENT
CRITICS NAY ITS NECK I THINK SHE
THIRD BY WILL SAVE MY COMMENT I
APPRECIATE THAT.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS ON ITEM
THIRTY TWO WERE COMMENTS
[inaudible] THREE NINE THE SHOE
THIRTY THREE LA JOH WELCOME TO
YOU FIRST MR.
BELIAU.
GREAT SO AS NOTED THAT THE ISSUE
BEFORE YOU INVOLVES ENROLLMENT.
YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
PIECES IN THIS ITEM SO I'M I'M
GONNA BREAK IT OUT INTO THREE
KEY ISSUES FOR YOU TO CONSIDER.
THE FIRST ISSUE HERE REPORT
PERTAINS TO UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT AT CSU AND YOU SEE.
FOR CSU THE SENATE PROVIDED MORE
THAN THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THE ASSEMBLY
ADOPTED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
LEVEL OF ENROLLMENT GROWTH. FOR
YOU SEE.
THEY BOTH HOUSES PROVIDED MORE
MOMENT GROSS THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED WITH THE
ASSEMBLY PROVIDING MORE THAN THE
SENATE.
WITH REGARD TO UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WE ARE GOING
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT COMMENTS
THAT WE'VE MADE THROUGHOUT THE
THE BUDGET PROCESS AS YOU THINK
ABOUT ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
ON THE ONE HAND -- IF YOU LOOK
AT TWO FIFTY FACTORS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HISTORICALLY HAS
LOOKED AT TO DETERMINE
ENROLLMENT LEVELS -- HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES ARE PROJECTED TO
DECLINE VERY SLIGHTLY ON THE
UPCOMING YEAR.
AND BOTH -- SYSTEMS ARE DRAWING
FROM BEYOND THEIR TRADITIONAL
FRESHMAN ELIGIBILITY POOLS.
THOSE TWO FACTORS MIGHT SUGGEST
THAT YOU COULD GO WITH THE LOWER
AMOUNTS BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES.
ON THE OTHER HAND BOB STUDENTS
AT BOTH SEGMENTS -- ARE MADE
MANY ELIGIBLE STUDENTS ARE NOT.
ACCOMMODATED TO THEIR CAMPUS A
CHOICE AND IN A CASE OF YOU SEE
ARE REDIRECTED TO CAMPUS IS LIKE
YOU SEE MERCED END UP NOT A
ROLLING BECAUSE IT WASN'T THE
CAMPUS THAT THEY PREFER TO GO.
TO PROVIDING MORE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH COULD ACCOMMODATE SOME OF
THOSE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS AND IF
THE FOR THAT WERE HIGH PRIORITY
YOU COULD GO WITH THE HIGHER
AMOUNTS SO IT'S GOING TO FALL
DOWN TO WHAT YOUR GOALS ARE FOR
A MOMENT AT THE TWO SYSTEMS.
AT LEAST IN THE CASE OF
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT.
REGARDING GRADUATE ENROLLMENT OF
THIS CITY THE SECOND ISSUE IS
FOR GRADUATE ROLE MEANT THE
SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T
PROVIDE FUNDING EXPLICITLY FOR
GRADUATE ROMAN GROSS THE
ASSEMBLY DID.
AND HERE WE WILL KNOW THAT THE
STATE DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME KIND
OF LONG STANDING UP POLICY
GUIDELINES DRIVING GRADUATE
MOMENT THAT IT DOES
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT.
ON THE UNIVERSITY HAS.
LONG ARGUED THAT IT I WOULD LIKE
TO GROW GRADUATE MOMENT IN
CONCERT WITH UNDERGRADUATE REAL
MEN AND THE OBJECTIVE THERE IS
TO IT ADD MORE DISCUSSION
SESSIONS AND AND ADD MORE T.
A.'S.
AYE TO ACCOMMODATE THE SORT OF
HIGHER LEVEL OF ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
I'M THE ROUGH RULE OF THUMB THE
UNIVERSITY RULES ABOUT FOR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS FOR EVERY
GRADUATE STUDENT SO IF YOU
WANTED TO KEEP THE PROPORTION
ROUGHLY THE SAME AS IT IS IN IN
THE CURRENT YEAR.
ARE YOU COULD USE THAT ROUGH
RULE OF THUMB SO FOR EXAMPLE
UNDER THE SENATE PROPOSAL OF
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
THAT WOULD BE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
GRADUATE STUDENTS.
AND OTHERS UNDER THE I'M SORRY
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY UNDER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY UNDER THE
SENATE PACKAGE ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE GRADUATE STUDENTS
UNDER THE ASSEMBLY PACKAGE
EXCUSE ME THERE.
AND FINALLY THE THIRD ISSUE FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER IS THE PER
STUDENT FUNDING RATE -- THAT YOU
SEE BETWEEN THE HOUSES THE HOUSE
IS DIFFERENT HERE WITH THE
SENATE PROVIDING A LOWER RATE
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY PROVIDING A
HIGHER RATE ELEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE DOLLARS PER
STUDENT.
AFFECTED LEE THE FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE HERE IS THAT THE
SENATE OF FOCUSES ON
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT THE
ASSEMBLY PROVIDES GROWTH FOR
BOTH UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
ENROLLMENT UNDERGRADUATE MOMENT
LIKELY.
IS LESS EXPENSIVE THAN GRADUATE
ENROLLMENT AND SO THAT IS THAT
THE FACTOR BEHIND THE TWO
DIFFERENT RATES THERE WE THINK
IT'S REASONABLE THAT IF YOU JUST
FOCUS ON UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
YOU COULD GO WITH A A SENATE
RATE.
IF YOU WANT TO PROVIDE GROWTH
FOR BOTH UNDERGRADUATE AND
GRADUATE ROLE THAT YOU COULD GO
WITH THE ASSEMBLY RATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE FINANCE. TO
CERTAINLY ON NEITHER OF THESE
TWO AUGMENTATIONS FOR ENROLLMENT
IN TWO YEARS YOU ARE YOU SEE --
THAT BOTH HOUSES HAVE CONSIDERED --
WERE INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET WHAT WE
WOULD SAY AND I THINK I ALLUDED
TO THIS MY PREVIOUS COMMENT IS
WE RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO BALANCE
THE STUDENT SUCCESS ASPECTS WITH.
ENROLLMENT AND ACCESS FUNDING AS
WELL AND WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF ON
THAT BALANCE.
THANK YOU MISS SKINNER.
THANK YOU ARMS.
I WANTED TO ECHO -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY SCUM IT'S ON THE
PREVIOUS DISCUSSION.
WE ARE -- WHILE I FEEL THAT WE
COULD EVEN EXPAND CSU'S
ENROLLMENT IN TERMS OF THE
DEMAND IN THE NEED ACROSS OUR
STATE.
WE HAVE AS A LEGISLATURE DONE
BETTER IN TERMS OF FINDING CSU
TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT CALF E
COMPARE AS COMPARED TO THE UC
SYSTEM.
AND I WILL NOTE THAT -- FOR THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FALL.
THERE WERE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND APPLICANTS HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO UCLA OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO UC BERKELEY I DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBERS OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD TO THE OTHER%
INSTITUTIONS.
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT WERE
ACTUALLY ENROLLED IN THE
FRESHMAN CLASS OF EACH OF THOSE
UC'S WAS IN THE ORDER OF SIXTY
THREE HUNDRED SO SIX THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED STUDENTS GUARDIAN
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPLICANTS.
NOW OF THAT HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPLICANTS THEY WERE NOT ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS NO BUT I
WOULD.
AND I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS AND
DIRECTLY IN FRONT OF ME BUT I
CAN PRETTY MUCH VENTURE TO SAY
THERE WAS AT LEAST FIFTY
THOUSAND OF THEM AT LEAST HALF
WERE.
SO WE KNOW THAT THE DESIRE BY
OUR FAMILIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE TO HAVE THE LEGISLATURE
FULFILL OUR MASTER PLAN PROMISE.
IS REALLY GREAT IN OUR
POPULATION HAS EXPANDED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND ONLY CAMPUS WE
HAVE ADDED SINCE I WENT TO
COLLEGE AND I'M NOT GONNA SAY
HOW OLD I AM.
YEARS AGO YEAH JUST A COUPLE
YEARS AGO -- IS MERCED.
AND NUMBER SAID IS THE ONLY ONE
OF THE UC CAMPUSES THAT I'M
AWARE OF THAT.
THAT -- IT.
IS IN FACT UNDER ENROLLED -- AND
MAYBE IT'S NOT IN THIS MAYBE
THIS YEAR IT WASN'T BUT I'M VERY
HAPPY TO SEE.
MERCED GROWING AND FOR MORE
PEOPLE TO APPRECIATE THAT IT
REALLY IS AN EXCELLENT
INSTITUTION.
BUT I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY DO OUR BEST TO FIND
INCREASE ENROLLMENT THAT ARE YOU
SEE SYSTEM IS THE LEAST WE CAN
DO.
FOR THESE -- FOR THE RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA AND I JUST ECHO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY SEE
CONCERNS.
I CERTAINLY DORSEN SUPPORT THE
UC ENROLLMENT.
BUT NOT AT THE EXCLUSION OF CSU
[inaudible]
BOTH.
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS BENEFIT.
BY BEING ABLE TO MEET.
THE REQUIREMENTS OR THE HOAX IF
YOU WILL OF THE MASTER PLAN OF
HIGHER EDUCATION.
MOSTLY IT WOULD BE OUR STUDENTS
[inaudible]
THE DESERVE.
THE HOPE IN THE PROMISE AND THE
REALIZATION OF THAT SO AS WE
BALANCES OUT I WOULD ARGUE THAT
WE SHOULD ATTEND TO GROWTH IN
CENTER OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR BOTH
SEE ISSUE AND UC.
CETERA [inaudible]
BINGO.
I THINK WE'VE DONE A PRETTY GOOD
JOB THE BY YOU SEE ISSUE THIS
YEAR IN THE BUDGET I THINK -- AS
WE TALK ABOUT IT IN AS I LOOK AT
IT WE MAY HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
SHORT ON UC'S SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING A CONTINUED
CONVERSATION WITH MIKE.
COLLEAGUES FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
HOW WE CAN -- HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
THAT -- IN THE FINAL PRODUCT
THAT WE WORK ON HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. FOR THE QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT LEAVE THAT ITEM OPEN
CALLING FOR THE OUR OF FIVE
O'CLOCK HAVING ARRIVED.
I'M GOING -- TO THE GERMAN FOR
THE EVENING -- WE ALL HAVE --
BRIEFING [inaudible]
IF.
THAT IS TRUE BUT THERE ARE A
COUPLE THAT ARE STICKY WICKETS --
YEAH.
YOUR GAS -- YOU'RE OUT OF GAS
[inaudible]
SOME ARGUE -- IT IF YOU WOULD
ALLOW ME DOCTOR WEBER TO READ
THE TEA LEAVES -- BOUGHT IN THE
AGENDA.
AND STOP NOW WE HAVE TO BE
BRIEFED -- WE WILL RECONVENE
TOMORROW MORNING AT TEN AM AND
IT IS MY OPTIMISTIC GOAL.
THAT WE WILL FINISH ITEMS FOUR
FORTY ONE IN EDUCATION.
AND COMPLETE RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION RECOGNIZING FOR
TOMORROW WE OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
A HARD STOP AT APPROXIMATELY.
ONE THIRTY THAT WOULD BE PM I'M
SHARING THAT FOR ALL OF US IN
FOR STAFF AND FOR ELLIE ALSO
EVERYONE CAN KNOW THE PLAN FOR
TOMORROW. TEN AM START GOAL IS
TO GET THROUGH RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION.
DAY ONE DOWN THANK YOU ALL WE'LL
SEE YOU AGAIN TOMORROW -- JR